this course from Harvard University
explores the concepts and algorithms at
the foundation of modern artificial
intelligence diving into the ideas that
give rise to Technologies like game
playing engines handwriting recognition
and machine translation you'll gain
exposure to the theory behind Graph
Search algorithms classification
optimization reinforcement learning and
other topics in artificial intelligence
and machine learning Brian Yu teaches
this course
thank you
[Music]
hello world this is cs50 and this is an
introduction to artificial intelligence
with python with cs50's own Brian Yu
this course picks up where cs50 itself
leaves off and explores the concepts and
algorithms at the foundation of modern
AI we'll start with a look at how AI can
search for solutions to problems whether
those problems are learning how to play
a game or trying to find driving
directions to a destination we'll then
look at how AI can represent information
both knowledge that our AI is certain
about but also information and events
about which our AI might be uncertain
learning how to represent that
information but more importantly how to
use that information to draw inferences
and new conclusions as well we'll
explore how AI can solve various types
of optimization problems trying to
maximize profits or minimize cost or
satisfy some other constraints before
turning our attention to the fast
growing field of machine learning where
we won't tell our AI exactly how to
solve a problem but instead give our AI
access to data and experiences so that
our AI can learn on its own how to
perform these
in particular we'll look at neural
networks one of the most popular tools
in modern machine learning inspired by
the way that human brains learn and
reason as well before finally taking a
look at the world of natural language
processing so that it's not just us
humans learning to learn how artificial
intelligence is able to speak but also
AI learning how to understand and
interpret human language as well we'll
explore these ideas and algorithms and
along the way give you the opportunity
to build your own AI programs to
implement all of this and more this is
cs50
[Music]
um
all right welcome everyone to an
introduction to artificial intelligence
with python my name is Brian Yu and in
this class we'll explore some of the
ideas and techniques and algorithms that
are at the foundation of artificial
intelligence now artificial intelligence
covers a wide variety of types of
techniques anytime you see a computer do
something that appears to be intelligent
or rational in some way like recognizing
someone's face in a photo or being able
to play a game better than people can or
being able to understand human language
when we talk to our phones and they
understand what we mean and are able to
respond back to us these are all
examples of AI or artificial
intelligence and in this class we'll
explore some of the ideas that make that
AI possible so we'll begin our
conversations with search the problem of
we have an AI and we would like the AI
to be able to search for solutions to
some kind of problem no matter what that
problem might be whether it's trying to
get driving directions from point A to
point B or trying to figure out how to
play a game given a tic-tac-toe game for
example figuring out what move it ought
to make after that we'll take a look at
knowledge ideally we want our AI to be
able to know information to be able to
represent that information and more
importantly to be able to draw
inferences from that information to be
able to use the information it knows and
draw additional conclusions so we'll
talk about how AI can be programmed in
order to do just that then we'll explore
the topic of uncertainty talking about
ideas of what happens if a computer
isn't sure about a fact but maybe is
only sure with a certain probability so
we'll talk about some of the ideas
behind probability and how computers can
begin to deal with uncertain events in
order to be a little bit more
intelligent in that sense as well
after that we'll turn our attention to
optimization problems of when the
computer is trying to optimize for some
sort of goal especially in a situation
where there might be multiple ways that
a computer might solve a problem but
we're looking for a better way or
potentially the best way if that's at
all possible
then we'll take a look at machine
learning we're learning more generally
and looking at how when we have access
to data our computers can be programmed
to be quite intelligent by learning from
data and learning from experience being
able to perform a task better and better
based on greater access to data so your
email for example where your email inbox
somehow knows which of your emails are
good emails and which of your emails are
spam these are all examples of computers
being able to learn from past
experiences and past data we'll take a
look too at how computers are able to
draw inspiration from Human intelligence
looking at the structure of the human
brain and how neural networks can be a
computer analog to that sort of idea and
how by taking advantage of a certain
type of structure of a computer program
we can write neural networks that are
able to perform tasks very very
effectively and then finally we'll turn
our attention to language not
programming languages but human
languages that we speak every day and
taking a look at the challenges that
come about as a computer tries to
understand natural language and how it
is some of the natural language
processing that occurs in modern
artificial intelligence can actually
work
but today we'll begin our conversation
with search this problem of trying to
figure out what to do when we have some
sort of situation that the computer is
in some sort of environment that an
agent is in so to speak and we would
like for that agent to be able to
somehow look for a solution to that
problem
now these problems can come in any
number of different types of formats one
example for instance might be something
like this classic 15 puzzle with the
sliding tiles that you might have seen
where you're trying to slide the tiles
in order to make sure that all the
numbers line up in order this is an
example of what you might call a search
Problem the 15 puzzle begins in an
initially mixed up mixed up State and we
need some way of finding moves to make
in order to return the puzzle to its
solved state but there are similar
problems that you can frame in other
ways trying to find your way through a
maze for example is another example of a
search problem you begin in one place
you have some goal of where you're
trying to get to and you need to figure
out the correct sequence of actions that
will take you from that initial state to
the goal and while this is a little bit
abstract anytime we talk about maze
solving in this class you can translate
it to something a little more real world
something like driving directions if you
ever wonder how Google Maps was able to
figure out what is the best way for you
to get from point A to point B and what
turns to make it what time depending on
traffic for example it's often some sort
of search algorithm you have an AI that
is trying to get from an initial
position to some sort of goal by taking
some sequence of actions so we'll start
our conversations today by thinking
about these types of search problems and
what goes in to solving a search problem
like this in order for an AI to be able
to find a good solution
in order to do so though we're going to
need to introduce a little bit of
terminology some of which I've already
used but the first term we'll need to
think about is an agent an agent is just
some entity that perceives its
environment it somehow is able to
perceive the things around it and act on
that environment in some way so in the
case of the driving directions your
agent might be some representation of a
car that is trying to figure out what
actions to take in order to arrive at a
destination in the case of the 15 puzzle
with the sliding tiles the agent might
be the AI or the person that is trying
to solve that puzzle to try and figure
out what tiles to move in order to get
to that solution
next we introduce the idea of a state a
state is just some configuration of the
agent in its environment so in the 15
puzzle for example any state might be
any one of these three for example a
state is just some configuration of the
tiles and each of these states is
different and is going to require a
slightly different solution a different
sequence of actions will be needed in
each one of these in order to get from
this initial state to the goal which is
where we're trying to get so the initial
State then what is that the initial
state is just the state where the agent
begins it is one such state where we're
going to start from and this is going to
be the starting point for our search
algorithm so to speak we're going to
begin with this initial State and then
start to reason about it to think about
what actions might we apply to that
initial state in order to figure out how
to get from the beginning to the end
from the initial position to whatever
our goal happens to be
and how do we make our way from that
initial position to the goal well
ultimately it's via taking actions
actions are just choices that we can
make in any given State and in AI we're
always going to try to formalize these
ideas a little bit more precisely such
that we could program them a little bit
more mathematically so to speak so this
will be a recurring theme and we can
more precisely Define actions as a
function we're going to effectively
Define a function called actions that
takes an input s where s is going to be
some state that exists inside of our
environment and actions of s is going to
take the state as input and return as
output the set of all actions that can
be executed in that state and so it's
possible that some actions are only
valid in certain States and not in other
states and we'll see examples of that
soon too
so in the case of the 15 puzzle for
example there are generally going to be
four possible actions that we can do
most of the time we can slide a tile to
the right slide a tile to the left
slider tile up or slide a tile down for
example and those are going to be the
actions that are available to us
so somehow our AI our program needs some
encoding of the state which is often
going to be in some numerical format and
some encoding of these actions but it
also needs some encoding of the
relationship between these things how do
the states in actions relate to one
another
and in order to do that we'll introduce
to our AI a transition model which would
be a description of what state we get
after we perform some available action
in some other state and again we can be
a little bit more precise about this
Define this transition model a little
bit more formally again as a function
the function is going to be a function
called result that this time takes two
inputs input number one is s some State
and input number two is a some action
and the output of this function result
is it is going to give us the state that
we get after we perform action a in
state s
so let's take a look at an example to
see more precisely what this actually
means here's an example of a state of
the 15 puzzle for example and here's an
example of an action sliding a tile to
the right what happens if we pass these
as inputs to the result function again
the result function takes this board
this state as its first input and it
takes an action as a second input and of
course here I'm describing things
visually so that you can see visually
what the state is and what the action is
in a computer you might represent one of
these actions as just some number that
represents the action or if you're
familiar with enums that allow you to
enumerate multiple possibilities it
might be something like that and the
state might just be represented as an
array or two-dimensional array of all of
these numbers that exist but here we're
going to show it visually just so you
can see it but when we take this state
and this action pass it into the result
function the output is a new state the
state we get after we take a tile and
slide it to the right and this is the
state we get as a result if we had a
different action and the different
estate for example and pass that into
the result function we'd get a different
answer altogether so the result function
needs to take care of figuring out how
to take a state and take an action and
get what results and this is going to be
our transition model that describes how
it is that states and actions are
related to each other
if we take this transition model and
think about it more generally and across
the entire problem we can form what we
might call a state space the set of all
of the states we can get from the
initial State via any sequence of
actions by taking 0 or 1 or 2 or more
actions in addition to that so we could
draw a diagram that looks something like
this where every state is represented
here by a game board
and there are arrows that connect every
state to every other state we can get to
from that state and these State space is
much larger than what you see just here
this is just a sample of what the state
space might actually look like
and in general across many search
problems whether they're this particular
15 puzzle or driving directions or
something else the state space is going
to look something like this we have
individual states and arrows that are
connecting them
and oftentimes just for Simplicity will
simplify our representation of this
entire thing as a graph some sequence of
nodes
and edges that connect nodes but you can
think of this more abstract
representation as the exact same idea
each of these little circles or nodes is
going to represent one of the states
inside of our problem and the arrows
here represent the actions that we can
take in any particular State taking us
from one particular state to another
state for example
all right so now we have this idea of
nodes that are representing these states
actions that can take us from one state
to another and a transition model that
defines what happens after we take a
particular action so the next step we
need to figure out is how we know when
the AI is done solving the problem the
AI needs some way to know when it gets
to the goal that it's found the goal so
the next thing we'll need to encode into
our artificial intelligence is a gold
test some way to determine whether a
given state is a goal state
in the case of something like driving
directions it might be pretty easy if
you're in a state that corresponds to
whatever the user typed in as their
intended destination well then you know
you're in a goal state in the 15 puzzle
it might be checking the numbers to make
sure they're all in ascending order but
the AI needs some way to encode whether
or not any state they happen to be in is
a goal and some problems might have one
goal like a maze where you have one
initial position and one ending position
and that's the goal in other more
complex problems you might imagine that
there are multiple possible goals there
are multiple ways to solve a problem and
we might not care which one the computer
finds as long as it does find a
particular goal
however sometimes the computer doesn't
just care about finding a goal but
finding a goal well or one with a low
cost and it's for that reason that the
last piece of terminology that we use to
define these search problems is
something called a path cost you might
imagine that in the case of driving
directions it would be pretty annoying
if I said I wanted directions from point
A to point B and the route that Google
Maps gave me was a long route with lots
of detours that were unnecessary that
took longer than it should have for me
to get to that destination and it's for
that reason that when we're formulating
search problems we'll often give every
path some sort of numerical cost some
number telling us how expensive it is to
take this particular option and then
tell our AI that instead of just finding
a solution some way of getting from the
initial state to the goal we'd really
like to find one that minimizes this
path cost that is less expensive or
takes less time or minimizes some other
numerical value
we can represent this graphically if we
take a look at this graph again and
imagine that each of these arrows each
of these actions that we can take from
one state to another state has some sort
of number associated with it that number
being the path cost of this particular
action where some of the costs for any
particular action might be more
expensive than the cost for some other
action for example although this will
only happen in some sorts of problems in
other problems we can simplify the
diagram and just assume that the cost of
any particular action is the same and
this is probably the case in something
like the 15 puzzles for example where it
doesn't really make a difference whether
I'm moving right or moving left the only
thing that matters is the total number
of steps that I have to take to get from
point A to point B and each of those
steps is of equal cost we can just
assume it's of some constant cost like
one
and so this now forms the basis for what
we might consider to be a search problem
a search problem has some sort of
initial State some place where we begin
some sort of action that we can take or
multiple actions that we can take in any
given State and it has a transition
model some way of defining what happens
when we go from one state and take one
action what state do we end up with as a
result in addition to that we need some
goal test to know whether or not we've
reached a goal and then we need a path
cost function that tells us for any
particular path by following some
sequence of actions how expensive is
that path what is its cost in terms of
money or time or some other resource
that we are trying to minimize our usage
of
and the goal ultimately is to find a
solution where a solution in this case
is just some sequence of actions that
will take us from the initial state to
the goal State and ideally we'd like to
find not just any solution but the
optimal solution which is a solution
that has the lowest path cost among all
of the possible solutions and in some
cases there might be multiple Optimal
Solutions but an optimal solution just
means that there is no way that we could
have done better in terms of finding
that solution
so now we've defined the problem and now
we begin need to begin to figure out how
it is that we're going to solve this
kind of search problem and in order to
do so you'll probably imagine that our
computer is going to need to represent a
whole bunch of data about this
particular problem we need to represent
data about where we are in the problem
and we might need to be considering
multiple different options at once and
oftentimes when we're trying to package
a whole bunch of data related to a state
together we'll do so using a data
structure that we're going to call a
node a node is a data structure that is
just going to keep track of a variety of
different values and specifically in the
case of a search problem it's going to
keep track of these four values in
particular every node is going to keep
track of estate the state we're
currently on and every node is also
going to keep track of apparent a parent
being the state before us or the node
that we used in order to get to this
current state and this is going to be
relevant because eventually once we
reach the goal node once we get to the
end we want to know what sequence of
actions we use in order to get to that
goal and the way we'll know that is by
looking at these parents to keep track
of what led us to the goal and what led
us to that state and what led us to the
state before that so on and so forth
backtracking our way to the beginning so
that we know the entire sequence of
actions we needed in order to get from
the beginning to the end
the node is also going to keep track of
what action we took in order to get from
the parent to the current state and the
node is also going to keep track of a
path cost in other words it's going to
keep track of the number that represents
how long it took to get from the initial
state to the state that we currently
happen to be at and we'll see why this
is relevant as we start to talk about
some of the optimizations that we can
make in terms of these search problems
more generally
so this is the data structure that we're
going to use in order to solve the
problem and now let's talk about the
approach how might we actually begin
to solve the problem well as you might
imagine what we're going to do is we're
going to start at one particular State
and we're just going to explore from
there the intuition is that from a given
State we have multiple options that we
could take and we're going to explore
those options and once we explore those
options we'll find that more options
than that are going to make themselves
available and we're going to consider
all of the available options to be
stored inside of a single data structure
that we'll call the frontier the
frontier is going to represent all of
the things that we could explore next
that we haven't yet explored or visited
so in our approach we're going to begin
the search algorithm by starting with a
frontier that just contains one state
the frontier is going to contain the
initial State because at the beginning
that's the only state we know about that
is the only state that exists
and then our search algorithm is
effectively going to follow a loop we're
going to repeat some process again and
again and again
the first thing we're going to do is if
the frontier is empty then there's no
solution and we can report that there is
no way to get to the goal and that's
certainly possible there are certain
types of problems that an AI might try
to explore and realize that there is no
way to solve that problem and that's
useful information for humans to know as
well so if ever the frontier is empty
that means there's nothing left to
explore and we haven't yet found a
solution so there is no solution if
there's nothing left to explore
otherwise what we'll do is we'll remove
a node from the frontier so our right
now at the beginning the frontier just
contains one node representing the
initial state but over time the frontier
might grow it might contain multiple
States and so here we're just going to
remove a single node from that Frontier
if that node happens to be a goal then
we found a solution so we remove a node
from the front here and ask ourselves is
this the goal and we do that by applying
the gold test that we talked about
earlier asking if we're at the
destination or asking if all the numbers
of the 15 puzzle happen to be in order
so if the node contains the goal we
found a solution great we're done
and otherwise what we'll need to do is
we'll need to expand the node and this
is a term of Art in artificial
intelligence to expand the node just
means to look at all of the neighbors of
that node in other words consider all of
the possible actions that I could take
from the state that this node is
representing and what nodes could I get
to from there we're going to take all of
those nodes the next nodes that I can
get to from this current one I'm looking
at and add those to the frontier
and then we'll repeat this process
so at a very high level the idea is we
start with the frontier that contains
the initial State and we're constantly
removing a node from the frontier
looking at where we can get to next and
adding those nodes to the frontier
repeating this process over and over
until either we remove a node from the
frontier and it contains a goal meaning
we've solved the problem or we run into
a situation where the frontier is empty
at which point we're left with no
solution
so let's actually try and take the
pseudocode put it into practice by
taking a look at an example of a sample
search Problem
so right here I have a sample graph a is
connected to B via this action B is
connected to node C and D is C is
connected e d is connected to F and what
I'd like to do is have my AI find a path
from a to e we want to get from this
initial state to this goal state
so how are we going to do that well
we're going to start with the frontier
that contains the initial State this is
going to represent our Frontier so our
Frontier initially will just contain a
that initial state where we're going to
begin and now we'll repeat this process
if the frontier is empty no solution
that's not a problem because the
Frontiers are not empty so we'll remove
a node from the frontier as the one to
consider next there's only one node in
the frontier so we'll go ahead and
remove it from the frontier but now a
this initial node this is the node we're
currently considering
we follow the next step we ask ourselves
is this node the goal no it's not a is
not the goal e is the goal so we don't
return the solution so instead we go to
this last step expand the node and add
the resulting nodes to the frontier
what does that mean well it means take
this state a and consider where we could
get to next and after a what we could
get to next is only B so that's what we
get when we expand a we find B and we
add B to the frontier and now B is in
the frontier and we repeat the process
again we say all right the frontier is
not empty so let's remove B from the
frontier B is now the node that we're
considering we ask ourselves is be the
goal no it's not so we go ahead and
expand B and add its resulting nodes to
the frontier
what happens when we expand B in other
words what nodes can we get to from B
well we can get to C and D so we'll go
ahead and add C and D from the frontier
and now we have two nodes in the front
here c and d and we repeat the process
again we remove a node from the frontier
for now I'll do so arbitrarily just by
picking C we'll see why later how
choosing which node you remove from the
frontier is actually quite an important
part of the algorithm but for now I'll
arbitrarily remove theme say it's not
the goal so we'll add e the next one to
the frontier then let's say I remove E
from the frontier and now I check I'm
currently looking at State e is it a
goal state it is because I'm trying to
find a path from a to e so I would
return the goal and that now would be
the solution that I'm now able to return
the solution and I found a path from a
to E
so this is the general idea the general
approach of the search algorithm to
follow these steps constantly removing
nodes from the frontier until we're able
to find a solution
so the next question you might
reasonably ask is what could go wrong
here what are the potential problems
with an approach like this and here's
one example of a problem that could
arise from this sort of approach imagine
this same graph same as before with one
change the change being now instead of
just an arrow from A to B we also have
an arrow from B to a meaning we can go
in both directions and this is true in
something like the 15 puzzle where when
I slide a tile to the right I could then
slide a tile to the left to get back to
the original position I could go back
and forth between a and b and that's
what these double arrows symbolize the
idea that from one state I can get to
another and then I can get back and
that's true in many search problems
what's going to happen if I try to apply
the same approach now well I'll begin
with a same as before and I'll remove a
from the frontier and then I'll consider
where I can get 2 from a and after a the
only place I can get to is B so B goes
into the frontier
then I'll say all right let's take a
look at B that's the only thing left in
the frontier where can I get 2 from B
before it was just C and D but now
because of that reverse Arrow I can get
to a or C or D so all three a c and d
all of those now go into the frontier
they are places I can get to from B and
now I remove one from the frontier and
you know maybe I'm unlucky and maybe I
pick a and now I'm looking at a again
and I consider where can I get you from
a and from a well I can get to B and now
we start to see the problem but if I'm
not careful I go from A to B and then
back to a and then to B again and I
could be going in this infinite Loop
where I never make any progress because
I'm constantly just going back and forth
between two states that I've already
seen
so what is the solution to this we need
some way to deal with this problem and
the way that we can deal with this
problem is by somehow keeping track of
what we've already explored and the
logic is going to be well if we've
already explored the state there's no
reason to go back to it once we've
explored a state don't go back to it
don't bother adding it to the frontier
there's no need to
so here's going to be our revised
approach a better way to approach this
sort of search problem and it's going to
look very similar just with a couple of
modifications
we'll start with a frontier that
contains the initial State same as
before but now we'll start with another
data structure which will just be a set
of nodes that we've already explored so
what are the states we've explored
initially it's empty we have an empty
explored set
and now we repeat
if the frontier is empty no solution
same as before we remove a node from the
frontier we check to see if it's a goal
State return the solution none of this
is any different so far but now what
we're going to do is we're going to add
the node to the explored state
so if it happens to be the case that we
remove a node from the frontier and it's
not the goal we'll add it to the
explored set so that we know we've
already explored it we don't need to go
back to it again if it happens to come
up later
and then the final step we expand the
node and we add the resulting nodes to
the frontier but before we just always
added the resulting nodes to the
frontier we're going to be a little
clever about it this time we're only
going to add the nodes to the frontier
if they aren't already in the frontier
and if they aren't already in the
explored set
so we'll check both the frontier and the
explored set make sure that the node
isn't already in one of those two and so
long as it isn't then we'll go ahead and
add it to the frontier but not otherwise
and so that revised approach is
ultimately what's going to help make
sure that we don't go back and forth
between two nodes
now the one point that I've kind of
glossed over here so far is this step
here removing a node from the frontier
before I just chose arbitrarily like
let's just remove a node and that's it
but it turns out it's actually quite
important how we decide to structure our
Frontier how we add them and how we
remove our nodes the frontier is the
data structure and we need to make a
choice about in what order are we going
to be removing elements
and one of the simplest data structures
for adding and removing elements is
something called a stack and a stack is
a data structure that is a last in first
out data type which means the last thing
that I add to the frontier is going to
be the first thing that I remove from
the frontier so the most recent thing to
go into the stack or the frontier in
this case is going to be the node that I
explore
so let's see what happens if I apply
this stack based approach to something
like this problem finding a path from a
to e what's going to happen well again
we'll start with a and we'll say all
right let's go ahead and look at a first
and then notice this time we've added a
to the explored set a is something we've
now explored we have this data structure
that's keeping track
we then say from a we can get to B
and all right from B what can we do well
from B we can explore B and get to both
C and D so we added C and then d
so now when we explore a node we're
going to treat the frontier as a stack
last in first out D was the last one to
come in so we'll go ahead and explore
that next and say all right where can we
get you from D well we can get to f
and so all right we'll explore it put F
into the frontier and now because the
frontier is a stack f is the most recent
thing that's gone in the stack so f is
what we'll explore next we'll explore F
and say all right where can we get you
from F Well we can't get anywhere so
nothing gets added to the frontier
so now what was the new most recent
thing added to the frontier well it's
now C the only thing left in the front
here we'll explore that from which we
can see all right from C we can get to e
so e goes into the frontier and then we
say all right let's look at e and e is
now the solution and now we've solved
the problem
so when we treat the frontier like a
stack a last in first out data structure
that's the result we get we go from A to
B to D to f
and then we sort of backed up and went
down to C and then e and it's important
to get a visual sense for how this
algorithm is working we went very deep
in this search tree so to speak all the
way until the bottom where we hit a dead
end and then we effectively backed up
and explored this other route that we
didn't try before and it's this going
very deep in the search tree idea this
way the algorithm ends up working when
we use a stack that we call this version
of the algorithm depth first search
depth first search is the search
algorithm where we always explore the
deepest node in the frontier we keep
going deeper and deeper through our
search tree and then if we hit a dead
end we back up and we try something else
instead
but depth for search is just one of the
possible search options that we could
use it turns out that there's another
algorithm called breadth first search
which behaves very similarly to depth
first search with one difference instead
of always exploring the deepest node in
the search tree the way the depth first
search does breadth first search is
always going to explore the shallowest
node in the frontier
so what does that mean well it means
that instead of using a stack which
depth for search or DFS used where the
most recent item added to the frontier
is the one we'll explore next in breadth
first search or BFS we'll instead use a
q where a q is a first in first out data
type where the very first thing we add
to the frontier is the first one we'll
explore and they effectively form a line
or a queue where the earlier you arrive
in the frontier the earlier you get
explored
so what would that mean for the same
exact problem finding a path from a to E
well we start with a same as before
then we'll go ahead and have explored a
and say where can we get you from a well
from a we can get to B same as before
from B same as before we can get to C
and D so C and D get added to the
frontier this time though we added C to
the frontier before D so we'll explore C
first
so C gets explored and from C where can
we get to well we can get to e so e gets
added to the frontier but because D was
explored before E we'll look at D next
so we'll explore D and say where can we
get you from D we can get to F and only
then we say all right now we can get to
E
and so what breadth first search or BFS
did is we started here we looked at both
c and d and then we looked at e
effectively we're looking at things one
away from the initial State then two
away from the initial State and only
then things that are three away from the
initial State unlike depth first search
which just went as deep as possible into
the search tree until it hit a dead end
and then ultimately had to back up
so these now are two different search
algorithms that we could apply in order
to try and solve a problem and let's
take a look at how these would actually
work in practice with something like
maze solving for example so here's an
example of a maze these empty cells
represent places where our agent can
move these darkened gray cells represent
walls that the agent can't pass through
and ultimately our agent our AI is going
to try to find a way to get from
position a to position B via some
sequence of actions where those actions
are left right up and down
what will depth first search do in this
case well depth first search we'll just
follow One path if it reaches a fork in
the road where it has multiple different
options depth first search is just in
this case going to choose one it has no
real preference but it's going to keep
following one until it hits a dead end
and when it hits a dead end depth first
search effectively goes back to the last
decision point and tries the other path
fully exhausting this entire path and
when it realizes that okay the goal is
not here then it turns its attention to
this path it goes as deep as possible
when it hits a dead end it backs up and
then tries this other path
keeps going as deep as possible down one
particular path and when it realizes
that that's a dead end then it'll back
up
and then ultimately find its way to the
goal and maybe you got lucky and maybe
you made a different Choice earlier on
but ultimately this is how depth first
search is going to work it's going to
keep following until it hits a dead end
and when it hits a dead end it backs up
and looks for a different solution and
so one thing you might reasonably ask is
is this algorithm always going to work
will it always actually find a way to
get from the initial state to the goal
and it turns out that as long as our
maze is finite as long as they're only
finitely many spaces where we can travel
then yes depth first search is going to
find a solution because eventually it'll
just explore everything if the maze
happens to be infinite and there's an
infinite State space which does exist in
certain types of problems then it's a
slightly different story but as long as
our maze has finitely many squares we're
going to find a solution
the next question though that we want to
ask is is it going to be a good solution
is it the optimal solution that we can
find and the answer there is not
necessarily and let's take a look at an
example of that in this maze for example
we're again trying to find our way from
A to B and you notice here there are
multiple possible solutions we could go
this way or we could go up in order to
make our way from A to B now if we're
lucky depth first search will choose
this way and get to B but there's no
reason necessarily why depth first
search would choose between going up or
going to the right it's sort of an
arbitrary decision point because both
are going to be added to the frontier
and ultimately if we get unlucky depth
first search might choose to explore
this path first because it's just a
random choice at this point it'll
explore explore explore and it'll
eventually find the goal this particular
path when in actuality there was a
better path there was a more optimal
solution that used fewer steps assuming
we're measuring the cost of a solution
based on the number of steps that we
need to take so depth for search if
we're unlucky might end up not finding
the best solution when a better solution
is available
so if that's DFS depth first search how
does BFS or breadth first search compare
how would it work in this particular
situation well the algorithm is going to
look very different visually in terms of
how BFS explores because BFS looks at
shallower nodes first the idea is going
to be BFS will first look at all of the
nodes that are one away from the initial
State look here and look here for
example just at the two nodes that are
immediately next to this initial state
then it'll explore nodes that are
two-way looking at this state and that
state for example then it'll explore
nodes that are three away this state and
that state whereas depth first search
just picked one path and kept following
it breadth first search on the other
hand is taking the option of exploring
all of the possible paths kind of at the
same time bouncing back between them
looking deeper and deeper at each one
but making sure to explore the shallower
ones or the ones that are closer to the
initial State earlier
so we'll keep following this pattern
looking at things that are far away
looking at things that are five away
looking at things that are six away
until eventually we make our way to the
goal and in this case it's true we had
to explore some states that ultimately
didn't lead us anywhere but the path
that we found to the goal was the
optimal path this is the shortest way
that we could get to the goal
and so what might happen then in a
larger maze well let's take a look at
something like this and how breadth
first search is going to behave well
breadth first search again we'll just
keep following the states until it
receives a decision point it could go
either left or right and while DFS just
picked one and kept following that until
it hit a dead end BFS on the other hand
will explore both it'll say look at this
node then this node and it'll look at
this node then that node so on and so
forth and when it hits a decision Point
here rather than pick one left or two
right and explore that path it'll again
explore both alternating between them
going deeper and deeper we'll explore
here and then maybe here and here and
then keep going explore here and slowly
make our way you can visually see
further and further out once we get to
this decision point we'll explore both
up and down
until ultimately
we make our way to the goal
and what you'll notice is yes breadth
first search did find our way from A to
B by following this particular path but
it needed to explore a lot of states in
order to do so and so we see some
trade-offs here between DFS and BFS that
in DFS there may be some cases where
there is some memory savings as compared
to a breadth first approach where
breadth first search in this case had to
explore a lot of States but maybe that
won't always be the case
so now let's actually turn our attention
to some code and look at the code that
we could actually write in order to
implement something like depth first
search or breadth first search in the
context of solving a maze for example
so I'll go ahead and go into my terminal
and what I have here inside of maze.pi
is an implementation of the same idea of
maze solving I've defined a class called
node
that in this case is keeping track of
the state the parent in other words the
state before the state and the action in
this case we're not keeping track of the
path cost because we can calculate the
cost of the path at the end after we
found our way from the initial state to
the goal
in addition to this I've defined a class
called a stack Frontier and if
unfamiliar with a Class A Class is a way
for me to define a way to generate
objects in Python it's referred us to an
idea of object oriented programming
where the idea here is that I would like
to create an object that is able to
store all of my Frontier data and I
would like to have functions otherwise
known as methods on that object that I
can use to manipulate the object and so
what's going on here if I'm familiar
with the syntax
is I have a function that initially
creates a frontier that I'm going to
represent using a list and initially my
Frontier is represented by the empty
list there's nothing in my Frontier to
begin with
I have an add function that adds
something to the frontier as by
appending it to the end of the list
I have a function that checks if the
frontier contains a particular State I
have an empty function that checks if
the frontier is empty if the frontier is
empty that just means the length of the
frontier is zero
and then I have a function for removing
something from the frontier I can't
remove something from the front here if
the frontier is empty so I check for
that first but otherwise if the frontier
isn't empty
recall that I'm implementing this
Frontier as a stack a last in first out
data structure which means the last
thing I add to the frontier in other
words the last thing in the list is the
item that I should remove from this
Frontier
so what you'll see here
is I have removed the last item of a
list and if you index into a python list
with negative one that gets you the last
item in the list since 0 is the first
item negative one kind of wraps around
and gets you to the last item in the
list
so we give that the node we call that
node we update the frontier here on line
28 to say go ahead and remove that node
that you just removed from the frontier
and then we return the node as a result
so this class here effectively
implements the idea of a frontier it
gives me a way to add something to a
frontier and a way to remove something
from the frontier as a stack
I've also just for good measure
implemented an alternative version of
the same thing called a queue Frontier
which in parentheses you'll see here it
inherits from a stack frontier meaning
it's going to do all the same things
that the stack Frontier did except the
way we remove a node from the frontier
is going to be slightly different
instead of removing from the end of the
list the way we would in a stack we're
instead going to remove from the
beginning of the list self.frontier zero
will get me the first node in the
frontier the first one that was added
and that is going to be the one that we
return in the case of a queue
then under here I have a definition of a
class called maze this is going to
handle the process of taking a sequence
a maze like text file and figuring out
how to solve it so it will take as input
a text file that looks something like
this for example where we see hash marks
that are here representing walls and I
have the character a representing the
starting position and the character B
representing the ending position
and you can take a look at the code for
parsing this text file right now that's
the less interesting part the more
interesting part is this solve function
here where the solve function is going
to figure out how to actually get from
point A to point B and here we see an
implementation of the exact same idea we
saw from a moment ago we're going to
keep track of how many states we've
explored just so we can report that data
later
but I start with a node that represents
just the start state
and I start with a frontier that in this
case is a stack Frontier and given that
I'm treating my Frontier as a stack you
might imagine that the algorithm I'm
using here is now depth first search
because depth first search or DFS uses a
stack as its data structure and
initially this Frontier is just going to
contain the start state
we initialize an explored set that
initially is empty there's nothing we've
explored so far and now here's our Loop
that notion of repeating something again
and again
first we check if the frontier is empty
by calling that empty function that we
saw the implementation of a moment ago
and if the frontier is indeed empty
we'll go ahead and raise an exception or
a python error to say sorry there is no
solution to this problem
otherwise we'll go ahead and remove a
node from the frontier as by calling
Frontier dot remove and update the
number of states we've explored because
now we've explored one additional state
so we say self.numexplored plus equals
one adding one to the number of states
we've explored
once we remove a node from the frontier
recall that the next step is to see
whether or not it's the goal the goal
test and in the case of the maze the
goal is pretty easy I check to see
whether the state of the node is equal
to the goal initially when I set up the
maze I set up this value called goal
which is a property of the maze so I can
just check to see if the node is
actually the goal
and if it is the goal then what I want
to do is backtrack my way towards
figuring out what actions I took in
order to get to this goal and how do I
do that we'll recall that every node
stores its parent the node that came
before it that we use to get to this
node and also the action used in order
to get there so I can create this Loop
where I'm constantly just looking at the
parent of every node and keeping track
for all of the parents what action I
took to get from the parent to this
current node so this Loop is going to
keep repeating this process of looking
through all of the parent nodes until we
get back to the initial state which has
no parent where node.parent is going to
be equal to none
as I do so I'm going to be building up
the list of all of the actions that I'm
following and the list of all the cells
that are part of the solution but I'll
reverse them because when I build it up
going from the goal back to the initial
State and building the sequence of
actions from the goal to the initial
state but I want to reverse them in
order to get the sequence of actions
from the initial state to the goal
and that is ultimately going to be the
solution
so all of that happens if the current
state is equal to the goal
and otherwise if it's not the goal well
then I'll go ahead and add this state to
the explored set to say I've explored
the state now no need to go back to it
if I come across it in the future
and then this logic here implements the
idea of adding neighbors to the frontier
I'm saying look at all of my neighbors
and I implemented a function called
Neighbors that you can take a look at
and for each of those neighbors I'm
going to check is the state already in
the frontier is the state already in the
explored set and if it's not in either
of those then I'll go ahead and add this
new child node this new node to the
frontier
so there's a fair amount of syntax here
but the key here is not to understand
all the nuances of the syntax so feel
free to take a closer look at this file
on your own to get a sense for how it is
working but the key is to see how this
is an implementation of the same
pseudocode the same idea that we were
describing a moment ago on the screen
when we were looking at the steps that
we might follow in order to solve this
kind of search Problem
so now let's actually see the connection
I'll go ahead and run
maze.pi on maze one dot text for example
and what we'll see is here we have a
printout of what the maze initially
looked like and then here down below is
after we've solved it we had to explore
11 states in order to do it and we found
a path from A to B and in this program I
just happened to generate a graphical
representation of this as well so I can
open up maze.png which is generated by
this program that shows you where in
dark the darker color here are the walls
red is the initial State green is the
goal and yellow is the path that was
followed we found a path from the
initial state to the goal
but now let's take a look at a more
sophisticated maze to see what might
happen instead let's look now at maze 2
dot text we're now here we have a much
larger maze again we're trying to find
our way from point A to point B but now
you'll imagine that depth first search
might not be so lucky it might not get
the goal on the first try it might have
to follow One path then backtrack and
explore something else a little bit
later
so let's try this we'll run python
maze.pi of maze2.text this time trying
on this other Maze and now depth first
search is able to find a solution here
as indicated by the stars is a way to
get from A to B and we can represent
this visually by opening up this maze
here's what that maze looks like and
highlighted in yellow is the path that
was found from the initial state to the
goal but how many states do we have to
explore before we found that path well
recall that in my program I was keeping
track of the number of states that we've
explored so far
and so I can go back to the terminal and
see that all right in order to solve
this problem we had to explore
399 different states and in fact if I
make one small modification of the
program and tell the program at the end
when we output this image I added an
argument called show explored and if I
set show explored equal to true
and rerun this program
python maze.pi running it on maze 2 and
then I open the maze what you'll see
here is highlighted in red are all of
the states that had to be explored to
get from the initial state to the goal
depth for search or DFS didn't find its
way to the goal right away it made a
choice to First explore this direction
and when it explored this direction it
had to follow every conceivable path all
the way to the very end even this long
and winding one in order to realize that
you know what that's a dead end and
instead the program needed to backtrack
after going this direction it must have
gone this direction it got lucky here by
just not choosing this path but it got
unlucky here exploring this direction
exploring a bunch of states that didn't
need to and then likewise exploring all
this top part of the graph when it
probably didn't need to do that either
so all in all depth first search here
really not performing optimally or
probably exploring more seats than it
needs to it finds an optimal solution
the best path to the goal but the number
of states needed to explore in order to
do so the number of steps I had to take
that was much higher
so let's compare how would breadth first
search or BFS do on this exact same maze
instead and in order to do so it's a
very easy change the algorithm for DFS
and BFS is identical with the exception
of what data structure we use to
represent the frontier
that in DFS I used a stack Frontier last
in first out whereas in BFS I'm going to
use a q Frontier first in first out
where the first thing I add to the
frontier is the first thing that I
remove so
I'll go back to the terminal rerun this
program on the same Maze and now you'll
see that the number of states we had to
explore was only 77 as compared to
almost 400 when we used depth for search
and we can see exactly why we can see
what happened if we open up maze.png now
and take a look again yellow highlight
is the solution that breadth first
search found which incidentally is the
same solution the depth research found
they're both finding the best solution
but notice all the white unexplored
cells there was much fewer states that
needed to be explored in order to make
our way to the goal because breadth
first search operates a little more
shallowly it's exploring things that are
close to the initial State without
exploring things that are further away
so if the goal is not too far away then
breadth first search can actually behave
quite effectively on a maze that looks a
little something like this
now in this case both BFS and DFS ended
up finding the same solution but that
won't always be the case and in fact
let's take a look at one more example
for instance maze 3.text
in maze 3.text notice that here there
are multiple ways that you could get
from A to B it's a relatively small maze
but let's look at what happens if I use
and I'll go ahead and turn off show
explored so we just see the solution
if I use BFS breadth first search to
solve maze 3.txt
well then we find a solution and if I
open up the maze here is the solution
that we found it is the optimal one with
just four steps we can get from the
initial state to what the goal happens
to be
but what happens if we tried to use
depth first search or DFS instead well
again I'll go back up to my cue Frontier
where Q Frontier means that we're using
breadth first search and I'll change it
to a stack Frontier
which means that now we'll be using
depth first search
I'll rerun pythonmaze.pi
and now you'll see that we find a
solution but it is not the optimal
solution this instead is what our
algorithm finds and maybe depth first
search would have found the solution
it's possible but it's not guaranteed
that if we just happen to be unlucky if
that we choose this state instead of
that state then depth first search might
find a longer route to get from the
initial state to the goal so we do see
some trade-offs here where depth for
search might not find the optimal
solution so at that point it seems like
breadth search is pretty good is that
the best we can do where it's going to
find us the optimal solution and we
don't have to worry about situations
where we might end up finding a longer
path to the solution than what actually
exists where the goal is far away from
the initial State and we might have to
take lots of steps in order to get from
the initial state to the goal what ended
up happening is that this algorithm BFS
ended up exploring basically the entire
graph having to go through the entire
maze in order to find its way from the
initial state to the goal State what
we'd ultimately like is for our
algorithm to be a little bit more
intelligent and now what would it mean
for our algorithm to be a little bit
more intelligent in this case
well let's look back to where breadth
first search might have been able to
make a different decision and consider
human intuition in this process as well
like what might a human do when solving
this maze that is different than what
BFS ultimately chose to do well the very
first decision point that BFFs made up
was right here when it made five steps
and ended up in a position where it had
a fork in the road it could either go
left or it could go right in these
initial couple steps there was no choice
there was only one action that could be
taken from each of those States and so
the search algorithm did the only thing
that any search algorithm could do which
is keep following that state after the
next state
but this decision point is where things
get a little bit interesting depth first
search that very first search algorithm
we looked at chose to say let's pick one
path and exhaust that path see if
anything that way has the goal and if
not then let's try the other way breadth
first search took the alternative
approach of saying you know what let's
explore things that are shallow close to
us first look left and right then back
left and back right so on and so forth
alternating between our options in the
hopes of finding something nearby
But ultimately what might a human do if
confronted with a situation like this of
go left or go right well a human might
visually see that all right I'm trying
to get to State B which is way up there
and going right just feels like it's
closer to the goal like it feels like
going right should be better than going
left because I'm making progress towards
getting to that goal now of course there
are a couple of assumptions that I'm
making here I'm making the assumption
that we can represent this grid as like
a two-dimensional grid where I know the
coordinates of everything I know that a
is in coordinate 0 0 and B is in some
other coordinate pair and I know what
coordinate I'm at now so I can calculate
but yeah going this way that is closer
to the goal and that might be a
reasonable assumption for some types of
search problems but maybe not in others
but for now
we'll go ahead and assume that that I
know what my current coordinate pair is
and I know the coordinate X Y of the
goal that I'm trying to get to and in
this situation I'd like an algorithm
that is a little bit more intelligent
that somehow knows that I should be
making progress towards the goal and
this is probably the way to do that
because in a maze moving in the
coordinate direction of the goal is
usually though not always a good thing
and so here we draw a distinction
between two different types of search
algorithms uninformed search and
informed search uninformed search
algorithms are algorithms like DFS and
BFS the two algorithms that we just
looked at which are search strategies
that don't use any problem-specific
knowledge to be able to solve the
problem
DFS and BFS didn't really care about the
structure of the maze or anything about
the way that a maze is in order to solve
the problem they just look at the
actions available and choose from those
actions and it doesn't matter whether
it's a maze or some other problem the
solution or the way that it tries to
solve the problem is really
fundamentally going to be the same
what we're going to take a look at now
is an improvement upon uninformed search
we're going to take a look at informed
search informed search are going to be
search strategies that use knowledge
specific to the problem to be able to
better find a solution and in the case
of a maze this like problem-specific
knowledge is something like if I'm in a
square that is geographically closer to
the goal that is better than being in a
square that is geographically further
away
and this is something we can only know
by thinking about this problem and
reasoning about what knowledge might be
helpful for our AI agent to know a
little something about
there are a number of different types of
informed search specifically first we're
going to look at a particular type of
search algorithm called greedy best
first search
greedy best first search often
abbreviated G BFS is a search algorithm
that instead of expanding the deepest
node like DFS or the shallowest node
like BFS this algorithm is always going
to expand the node that it thinks is
closest to the goal
now the search algorithm isn't going to
know for sure whether it is the closest
thing to the goal because if we knew
what was closest to the goal all the
time then we would already have a
solution like the knowledge of what is
close to the goal we could just follow
those steps in order to get from the
initial position to the solution but if
we don't know the solution meaning we
don't know exactly what's closest to the
goal instead we can use an estimate of
what's closest to the goal otherwise
known as a heuristic just some way of
estimating whether or not we're close to
the goal and we'll do so using a
heuristic function conventionally called
h of n that takes a status input and
returns our estimate of how close we are
to the goal
so what might this heuristic function
actually look like in the case of a maze
solving algorithm where we're trying to
solve a maze what does the heuristic
look like
well the heuristic needs to answer a
question like between these two cells C
and D which one is better which one
would I rather be in if I'm trying to
find my way to the goal well any human
could probably look at this and tell you
you know what d looks like it's better
even if the maze is a convoluted and you
haven't thought about all the walls D is
probably better and Y is D better well
because if you ignore the wall so let's
just pretend the walls don't exist for a
moment and relax the problem so to speak
D just in terms of like coordinate pairs
is closer to this goal it's fewer steps
that I wouldn't take to get to the goal
as compared to C even if you ignore the
walls if you just know the x y
coordinate of c and the x y coordinate
of the goal and likewise you know the x
y coordinate of D you can calculate the
D just geographically ignoring the walls
looks like it's better
and so this is the heuristic function
that we're going to use and it's
something called The Manhattan distance
one specific type of heuristic where the
heuristic is how many squares vertically
and horizontally and then left to right
so not allowing myself to go diagonally
just either up or right or left or down
how many steps do I need to take to get
from each of these cells to the goal
well if it turns out D is much closer
there are fewer steps it only needs to
take six steps in order to get to that
goal again here ignoring the walls we've
relaxed the problem a little bit we're
just concerned with if you do the math
to subtract the X values from each other
and the Y values from each other what is
our estimate of how far we are away we
can estimate that D is closer to the
goal than C is
and so now we have an approach we have a
way of picking which node to remove from
the frontier and at each stage in our
algorithm we're going to remove a node
from the frontier we're going to explore
the node if it has the smallest value
for this heuristic function if it has
the smallest Manhattan distance to the
goal
and so what would this actually look
like well let me first label this graph
label this maze with a number
representing the value of this heuristic
function the value of the Manhattan
distance from any of these cells so from
this cell for example we're one away
from the goal from this cell we're two
away from the goal three away four away
here we're five away because we have to
go one to the right and then four up
from somewhere like here the Manhattan
distance is 2 where only two squares
away from the goal geographically even
though in practices we're going to have
to take a longer path but we don't know
that yet the heuristic is just some easy
way to estimate how far we are away from
the goal and maybe our heuristic is
overly optimistic it thinks that yeah
we're only two steps away when in
practice when you consider the walls it
might be more steps
so the important thing here is that the
heuristic isn't a guarantee of how many
steps it's going to take it is
estimating it's an attempt at trying to
approximate and it does seem generally
the case that the squares that look
closer to the goal have smaller values
for the heuristic function than squares
that are further away
so now using greedy best for search what
might this algorithm actually do
well again for these first five steps
there's not much of a choice we started
this initial State a and we say all
right we have to explore these five
states but now we have a decision point
now we have a choice between going left
and going right and before when DFS and
BFS would just pick arbitrarily because
it just depends on the order you throw
these two nodes into the frontier and we
didn't specify what order you put them
into the frontier only the order you
take them out
here we can look at 13 and 11 and say
that all right this square is a distance
of 11 away from the goal according to
our heuristic according to our estimate
and this one we estimate to be 13 away
from the goal
so between those two options between
these two choices I'd rather have the
11. I'd rather be 11 steps away from the
goal so I'll go to the right we're able
to make an informed decision because we
know a little something more about this
problem so then we keep following 10 9 8
between the two sevens we don't really
have much of a way to know between those
so then we do just have to make an
arbitrary choice and you know what maybe
we choose wrong but that's okay because
now we can still say
all right let's try this seven we say
seven six we have to make this Choice
even though it increases the value of
the heuristic function but now we have
another decision point between six and
eight and between those two and really
we're also considering this 13 but
that's much higher between 6 8 and 13
well the six is the smallest value so
we'd rather take the six we're able to
make an informed decision that going
this way to the right is probably better
than going down so we turn this way we
go to five and now we find a decision
point where we'll actually make a
decision that we might not want to make
but there's unfortunately not too much
of a way around this we see four and six
four looks closer to the goal right it's
going up and the goal is further up
so we end up taking that route which
ultimately leads us to a dead end but
that's okay because we can still say all
right now let's try the six and now
follow this route that will ultimately
lead us to the goal
and so this now is how greedy best first
search might try to approach this
problem by saying whenever we have a
decision between multiple nodes that we
could explore let's explore the node
that has the smallest value of H of n
this heuristic function that is
estimating how far I have to go
and it just so happens that in this case
we end up doing better in terms of the
number of states we needed to explore
then BFFs needed to BFFs explored all of
this section and all of that section but
we were able to eliminate that by taking
advantage of this heuristic this
knowledge about how close we are to the
goal or some estimate of that idea
so this seems much better so wouldn't we
always prefer an algorithm like this
over an algorithm like breadth first
search well maybe one thing to take into
consideration is that we need to come up
with a good heuristic how good the
heuristic is is going to affect how good
this algorithm is and coming up with a
good heuristic can oftentimes be
challenging
but the other thing to consider is to
ask the question just as we did with the
prior to algorithms is this algorithm
optimal will it always find the shortest
path from the initial state to the goal
and to answer that question let's take a
look at this example for a moment take a
look at this example again we're trying
to get from A to B and again I've
labeled each of the cells with their
Manhattan distance from the goal the
number of squares up and to the right
you would need to travel in order to get
from that square to the goal
and let's think about would greedy best
for search that always picks the
smallest number end up finding the
optimal solution
what is the shortest solution and would
this algorithm find it
and the important thing to realize is
that right here is the decision point
where estimated to be 12 away from the
goal and we have two choices we can go
to the left which we estimate to be 13
away from the goal or we can go up where
we estimate it to be 11 away from the
goal and between those two greedy best
for search is going to say the 11 looks
better than the 13. and in doing so
greedy best first search will end up
finding this path to the goal but it
turns out this path is not optimal there
is a way to get to the goal using fewer
steps and it's actually this way this
way then ultimately involved fewer steps
even though it meant at this moment
choosing the worst option between the
two or what we estimated to be the worst
option based on the heuristics and so
this is what we mean by this is a greedy
algorithm it's making the best decision
locally at this decision point it looks
like it's better to go here than it is
to go to the 13 but in the big picture
it's not necessarily optimal that it
might find a solution when in actuality
there was a better solution available
so we want like we would like some way
to solve this problem we like the idea
of this heuristic of being able to
estimate the path the distance between
us and the goal and that helps us to be
able to make better decisions and to
eliminate having to search through
entire parts of this state space But we
would like to modify the algorithm so
that we can achieve optimality so that
it can be optimal and what is the way to
do this what is the intuition here
well let's take a look at this problem
in this initial problem greedy best
research found us this solution here
this long path and the reason why it
wasn't great is because yes the
heuristic numbers went down pretty low
but later on they started to build back
up they built back 8 9 10 11 all the way
up to 12 in this case
and so how might we go about trying to
improve this algorithm well one thing
that we might realize is that you know
if we go all the way through this
algorithm through this path and we end
up going to the 12
and we've had to take this many steps
like who knows how many steps that is
just to get to this 12.
we could have also as an alternative
taken much fewer steps just six steps
and ended up at this 13 here and yes 13
is more than 12 so it looks like it's
not as good but it required far fewer
steps right it only took six steps to
get to this 13 versus many more steps to
get to this 12 and while greedy best
first search says oh well 12 is better
than 13 so pick the 12 we might more
intelligently say I'd rather be
somewhere that heuristically looks like
it takes slightly longer if I can get
there much more quickly and we're going
to encode that idea this general idea
into a more formal algorithm known as a
star search a star search is going to
solve this problem by instead of just
considering the heuristic also
considering how long it took us to get
to any particular state so the
distinction is greedy best for search if
I am in a state right now the only thing
I care about is what is the estimated
distance the heuristic value between me
and the goal whereas a star search will
take into consideration two pieces of
information it'll take into
consideration how far do I estimate I am
from the goal but also how far did I
have to travel in order to get here
because that is relevant too
so we'll search algorithms by expanding
the node with the lowest value of G of n
plus h of n h of n is that same
heuristic that we were talking about a
moment ago that's going to vary based on
the problem but G of n is going to be
the cost to reach the node how many
steps I had to take in this case to get
to my current position
so what is that search algorithm look
like in practice well let's take a look
again we've got the same Maze and again
I've labeled them with their Manhattan
distance this value is the H of n value
the heuristic estimate of how far each
of these squares is away from the goal
but now as we begin to explore States We
Care not just about this heuristic value
but also about G of n the number of
steps I had to take in order to get
there and I care about summing those two
numbers together
so what does that look like on this very
first step I have taken one step
and now I am estimated to be 16 steps
away from the goal so the total value
here is 17.
then I take one more step I've now taken
two steps and I estimate myself to be 15
away from the goal again a total value
of 17. now I've taken three steps and
I'm estimated to be 14 away from the
goal so on and so forth four steps an
estimate of 13 five steps estimate of 12
and now here's a decision point
I could either be six steps away from
the goal with a heuristic of 13 for a
total of 19 or I could be six steps away
from the goal with a heuristic of 11
with an estimate of 17 for the total so
between 19 and 17 I'd rather take the 17
the 6 Plus 11. so so far no different
than what we saw before we're still
taking this option because it appears to
be better and I keep taking this option
because it appears to be better but it's
right about here
that things get a little bit different
now I could be 15 steps away from the
goal with an estimated distance of six
so 15 plus 6 total value of 21.
alternatively I could be six steps away
from the goal because this is five steps
away so this is six steps away with a
total value of 13 as my estimate so 6
plus 13 that's 19. so here we would
evaluate G of n plus h of n to be 19 6
plus 13 whereas here we would be 15 plus
6 or 21. and so the intuition is 19 less
than 21 pick here but the idea is
ultimately I'd rather be having taken
fewer steps get to a 13 than having
taken 15 Steps and be at a six because
it means I've had to take more steps in
order to get there maybe there's a
better path this way
so instead we'll explore this route
now if we go one more this is seven
steps plus 14 is 21 so between those two
it's sort of a toss-up we might end up
exploring that one anyways but after
that as these numbers start to get
bigger and the heuristic values and
these heuristic values start to get
smaller you'll find that we'll actually
keep exploring down this path and you
can do the math to see that at every
decision point a star search is going to
make a choice based on the sum of how
many steps it took me to get to my
current position and then how far I
estimate I am from the goal
so while we did have to explore some of
these states the ultimate solution we
found was in fact an optimal solution it
did find us the quickest possible way to
get from the initial state to the goal
and it turns out that a star is an
optimal search algorithm under certain
conditions so the conditions are h of n
my heuristic needs to be admissible what
does it mean for a heuristic to be
admissible well a heuristic is
admissible if it never overestimates the
true cost h of n always needs to either
get it exactly right in terms of how far
away I am or it needs to underestimate
so we saw an example from before where
the heuristic value was much smaller
than the actual cost it would take
that's totally fine but the heuristic
value should never overestimate it
should never think that I'm further away
from the goal than I actually am
and meanwhile to make a stronger
statement h of n also needs to be
consistent and what does it mean for it
to be consistent mathematically it means
that for every node which we'll call n
and successor the node after me then
I'll call n Prime where it takes a cost
of C to make that step
the heuristic value of n needs to be
less than or equal to the heuristic
value of n prime plus the cost so it's a
lot of math but in words what that
ultimately means is that if I am here at
this state right now
the heuristic value from me to the goal
shouldn't be more than the heuristic
value of my successor the next place I
could go to plus however much it would
cost me to just make that step from one
step to the next step and so this is
just making sure that my heuristic is
consistent between all of these steps
that I might take so as long as this is
true then a star search is going to find
me an optimal solution and this is where
much of the challenge of solving these
search problems can sometimes come in
that a star search is an algorithm that
is known and you could write the code
fairly easily but it's choosing the
heuristic that can be the interesting
challenge the better the heuristic is
the better I'll be able to solve the
problem in the fewer states that I'll
have to explore and I need to make sure
that the heuristic satisfies these
particular constraints
so all in all these are some of the
examples of search algorithms that might
work and certainly there are many more
than just this a star for example does
have a tendency to use quite a bit of
memory so there are alternative
approaches to a star
that ultimately use less memory than
this version of a star happens to use
and there are other search algorithms
that are optimized for other cases as
well
but now so far we've only been looking
at search algorithms where there's one
agent like I am trying to find a
solution to a problem I am trying to
navigate my way through a maze I am
trying to solve a 15 puzzle I am trying
to find driving directions from point A
to point B
sometimes in search situations though
we'll enter an adversarial situation
where I am an agent trying to make
Intelligent Decisions and there's
someone else who is fighting against me
so to speak that has opposite objectives
someone where I am trying to succeed
someone else that wants me to fail and
this is most popular in something like a
game a game like tic-tac-toe where we've
got this three by three grid and x and O
take turns either writing an X or an o
in any one of these squares and the goal
is to get three x's in a row if you're
the X player or three O's in a row if
you're the O player and computers have
gotten quite good at playing games
tic-tac-toe very easily but even more
complex games and so you might imagine
what does an intelligent decision in a
game look like so maybe X makes an
initial move in the middle and O plays
up here like what does an intelligent
move for X now become like where should
you move if you were X and it turns out
there are a couple of possibilities but
if an AI is playing this game optimally
then the AI might play somewhere like
the upper right
where in this situation o has the
opposite objective of x x is trying to
win the game to get three in a row
diagonally here and O is trying to stop
that objective opposite of the objective
and so o is going to place here to try
to block
but now X has a pretty clever move X can
make a move like this
where now X has two possible ways that X
can win the game X could win the game by
getting three in a row across here or X
could win the game by getting three in a
row vertically this way so it doesn't
matter where o makes their next move o
could play Here For example blocking the
three in a row horizontally but then X
is going to win the game by getting a
three in a row vertically
and so there's a fair amount of
reasoning that's going on here in order
for the computer to be able to solve a
problem and it's similar in spirit to
the problems we've looked at so far
right there actions there's some sort of
state of the board and some transition
from one action to the next but it's
different in the sense that this is now
not just a classical search problem but
an adversarial search problem that I am
the X player trying to find the best
moves to make but I know that there's
some adversary that is trying to stop me
so we need some sort of algorithm to
deal with these adversarial type of
search situations
and the algorithm we're going to take a
look at is an algorithm called Minimax
which works very well for these
deterministic games where there are two
players it can work for other types of
games as well but we'll look right now
at games where I make a move then my
opponent makes a move and I am trying to
win and my opponent is trying to win
also or in other words my opponent is
trying to get me to lose
and so what do we need in order to make
this algorithm work well anytime we try
and translate this human concept of like
playing a game winning and losing to a
computer we want to translate it in
terms that the computer can understand
and ultimately the computer really just
understands numbers and so we want some
way of translating a game of X's and O's
on a grid to something numerical
something the computer can understand
the computer doesn't normally understand
Notions of like win or lose but it does
understand the concept of like bigger
and smaller
and so we might not do is we might take
each of the possible ways that a
tic-tac-toe game can unfold and assign a
value or a utility to each one of those
possible ways and in a tic-tac-toe game
and in many types of games there are
three possible outcomes the outcomes are
Owens X wins or nobody wins so player
one wins player two wins or nobody wins
and for now let's go ahead and assign
each of these possible outcomes a
different value we'll say oh winning
that'll have a value of negative one
nobody winning they don't have a value
of zero and X winning that will have a
value of one so we've just assigned
numbers to each of these three possible
outcomes and now we have two players we
have the X player and the O player
and we're going to go ahead and call the
X player the max player and we'll call
the O player the Min player and the
reason why is because in the Minimax
algorithm the max player which in this
case is X is aiming to maximize the
score right these are the possible
options for the score negative one zero
and One X wants to maximize the score
meaning if at all possible X would like
this situation where X wins the game and
we give it a score of one but if this
isn't possible if x needs to choose
between these two options negative one
meaning o winning or zero meaning nobody
winning X would rather that nobody wins
score of zero then a score of negative
one a winning
so this notion of winning and losing and
tying has been reduced mathematically to
just this idea of try and maximize the
score the X player always wants the
score to be bigger and on the flip side
the Min player in this case o is aiming
to minimize the score the O player wants
the score to be as small as possible
so now we've taken this game of x's and
o's and winning and losing and turned it
into something mathematical something
where X is trying to maximize the score
o is trying to minimize the score let's
now look at all the parts of the game
that we need in order to encode it in an
AI so that an AI can play a game like
tic-tac-toe
so the game is going to need a couple of
things we'll need some sort of initial
state that will in this case call s0
that which is how the game begins like
an empty tic-tac-toe board for example
we'll also need a function called player
where the player function is going to
take as input a state here represented
by S and the output of the player
function is going to be which player's
turn is it right we need to be able to
give a tic-tac-toe board to the computer
run it through a function and that
function tells us whose turn it is
we'll need some notion of actions that
we can take we'll see examples of that
in just a moment we need some notion of
a transition model same as before if I
have a state and I take an action I need
to know what results as a consequence of
it I need some way of knowing when the
game is over so this is equivalent to
kind of like a goal test but I need some
terminal test some way to check to see
if a state is a terminal state where a
terminal State means the game is over in
a classic game of tic-tac-toe a terminal
State means either someone has gotten
three in a row or all of the squares of
the tic-tac-toe board are filled either
of those conditions make it a terminal
state in a game of chess it might be
something like when there is Checkmate
or if Checkmate is no longer possible
that that becomes a terminal state
and then finally we'll need a utility
function a function that takes a state
and gives us a numerical value for that
terminal State some way of saying if x
wins the game that has a value of one if
o has won the game that has a value of
negative one if nobody has won the game
that has a value of zero
so let's take a look at each of these in
turn
the initial State we can just represent
in tic-tac-toe as the empty game board
this is where we begin it's the place
from which we begin this search and
again I'll be representing these things
visually but you can imagine this really
just being like an array or a
two-dimensional array of all of these
possible squares
then we need the player function that
again takes a state and tells us whose
turn it is assuming X makes the first
move if I have an empty game board then
my player function is going to return X
and if I have a game board where X is
made a move then my player function is
going to return o the player function
takes the tic-tac-toe game board and
tells us whose turn it is
next up we'll consider the actions
function the action function much like
it did in classical search takes a state
and gives us the set of all of the
possible actions we can take in that
state
so let's imagine
it's always turn to move in a game board
that looks like this what happens when
we pass it into the actions function so
the actions function takes this state of
the game as input and the output is a
set of possible actions it's a set of I
could move in the upper left or I could
move in the bottom middle those are the
two possible action choices that I have
when I begin in this particular state
now just as before when we had States
and actions we need some sort of
transition model to tell us when we take
this action in the state what is the new
state that we get and here we Define
that using the result function that
takes a state as input as well as an
action
and when we apply the result function to
this state saying that let's let o move
in this upper left corner the new state
we get is this resulting state where o
is in the upper left corner and now this
seems obvious to someone who knows how
to play Tic-Tac-Toe like of course you
play in the upper left corner that's the
board you get but all of this
information needs to be encoded into the
AI the AI doesn't know how to play
Tic-Tac-Toe until you tell the AI how
the rules of tic-tac-toe work and this
function defining this function here
allows us to tell the AI how this game
actually works and how actions actually
affect the outcome of the game
so the AI needs to know how the game
works the AI also needs to know when the
game is over as by defining a function
called terminal that takes us input a
state s such that if we take a game that
is not yet over pass it into the
terminal function the output is false
the game is not over but if we take a
game that is over because X has gotten
three in a row along that diagonal pass
that into the terminal function then the
output is going to be true because the
game now is in fact over
and finally we've told the AI how the
game works in terms of what moves can be
made and what happens when you make
those moves we've told the AI when the
game is over now we need to tell the AI
what the value of each of those States
is and we do that by defining this
utility function that takes a state s
and tells us the score or the utility of
that state so again we said that if x
wins the game that utility is a value of
one whereas if o wins the game then the
utility of that is negative one and the
AI needs to know for each of these
terminal states where the game is over
what is the utility of that state
so like if I give you a game board like
this where the game is in fact over and
I ask the AI to tell me what the value
of that state is it could do so the
value of the state is one
where things get interesting though is
if the game is not yet over let's
imagine a game board like this we're in
the middle of the game it's O's turn to
make a move
so how do we know it's always tournament
can move we can calculate that using the
player function we can say player of s
pass in the state o is the answer so we
know it's O's turn to move and now what
is the value of this board and what
action should o take well that's going
to depend we have to do some calculation
here and this is where the Minimax
algorithm really comes in recall that X
is trying to maximize the score which
means that o is trying to minimize the
score o would like for the to minimize
the total value that we get at the end
of the game and because this game isn't
over yet we don't really know just yet
what the value of this game board is we
have to do some calculation in order to
figure that out
and so how do we do that kind of
calculation well in order to do so we're
going to consider just as we might in a
classical search situation what actions
could happen next and what states will
that take us to and it turns out that in
this position there are only two open
squares which means there are only two
open places where o can make a move
oh could either make a move in the upper
left
or o could make a move in the bottom
middle
and Minimax doesn't know right out of
the box which of those moves is going to
be better so it's going to consider both
but now we sort of run into the same
situation now I have two more game
boards neither of which is over what
happens next
and now it's in this sense that Minimax
is what we'll call a recursive algorithm
it's going to now repeat the exact same
process although now considering it from
the opposite perspective it's as if I am
now going to put myself if I am the O
player I'm going to put myself in my
opponent's shoes my opponent as the X
player and consider what would my
opponent do if they were in this
position what would my opponent do the X
player if they were in that position
and what would then happen well the
other player my opponent the X player is
trying to maximize the score whereas I
am trying to minimize the score as the O
player so X is trying to find the
maximum possible value that they can get
and so what's going to happen
well from this board position X only has
one choice X is going to play here and
they're going to get three in a row and
we know that that board X winning that
has a value of one if x wins the game
the value of that game board is one
and so from this position
if this state can only ever lead to the
state it's the only possible option and
this state has a value of one then the
maximum possible value that the X player
can get from this game board is also one
from here the only place we can get is
to a game with a value of one so this
game board also has a value of one
now we consider this one over here
what's going to happen now well X needs
to make a move the only move X can make
is in the upper left so X will go there
and in this game no one wins the game
nobody has three in a row so the value
of that game board is zero nobody's one
and so again by the same logic if from
this board position the only place we
can get to is a board where the value is
zero then this state must also have a
value of zero
and now here comes the choice part the
idea of Trying to minimize I as the O
player now know that if I make this
Choice moving in the upper left that is
going to result in a game with a value
of one assuming everyone plays optimally
and if I instead play in the lower
middle choose this fork in the road that
is going to result in a game board with
a value of zero I have two options I
have a one and a zero to choose from and
I need to pick and as the Min player I
would rather choose the option with the
minimum value so whenever a player has
multiple choices the Min player will
choose the option with the smallest
value the max player will choose the
option with the largest value between
the one and the zero the zero is smaller
meaning I'd rather tie the game than
lose the game and so this game board
will say also has a value of zero
because if I am playing optimally
I will pick this fork in the road I'll
place my o here to block X's three in a
row X will move in the upper left and
the game will be over and no one will
have won the game
so this is now the logic of Minimax to
consider all of the possible options
that I can take all of the actions that
I can take and then to put myself in my
opponent's shoes I decide what move I'm
going to make Now by considering what
move my opponent will make on the next
turn and to do that I consider what move
I would make on the turn after that so
on and so forth until I get all the way
down to the end of the game to one of
these so-called terminal States in fact
this very decision point where I am
trying to decide is the O player what to
make a decision about might have just
been a part of the logic that the X
player my opponent was using the move
before me this might be part of some
larger tree where X is trying to make a
move in this situation and needs to pick
between three different options in order
to make a decision about what to happen
and the further and further away we are
from the end of the game the deeper this
tree has to go because every level in
this tree is going to correspond to one
move one move or action that I take one
move or action that my opponent takes in
in order to decide what happens and in
fact it turns out that if I am the X
player in this position and I
recursively do the logic and see I have
a choice three choices in fact one of
which leads to a value of zero if I play
here then if everyone plays optimally
the game will be a tie if I play here
then o is going to win and I'll lose
playing optimally or here where I the X
player can win well between a score of
zero and negative one and one I'd rather
pick the board with a value of one
because that's the maximum value I can
get and so this board would also have a
maximum value of one
and so this tree can get very very deep
especially as the game starts to have
more and more moves and this logic works
not just for Tic-tac-toe but any of
these sorts of games where I make a move
my opponent makes a move and ultimately
we have these adversarial objectives and
we can simplify the diagram into a
diagram that looks like this this is a
more abstract version of the Minimax
tree where these are each States but I'm
no longer representing them as exactly
like tic-tac-toe boards this is just
representing some generic game that
might be tic-tac-toe might be some other
game altogether
any of these green arrows that are
pointing up that represents a maximizing
State I would like the score to be as
big as possible and any of these red
arrows pointing down those are
minimizing states where the player is
the Min player and they are trying to
make the score as small as possible
so if you imagine in this situation I am
the maximizing player this player here
and I have three choices one choice
gives me a score of five one choice
gives me a score of three and one choice
gives me a score of nine well then
between those three choices my best
option is to choose this nine over here
the score that maximizes my options out
of all the three options and so I can
give this state a value of nine because
among my three options that is the best
choice that I have available to me
so that's my decision now you imagine
it's like one move away from the end of
the game
but then you could also ask a reasonable
question what might my opponent do two
moves away from the end of the game my
opponent is the minimizing player they
are trying to make the score as small as
possible imagine what would have
happened if they had to pick which
choice to make one choice leads us to
this state where I the maximizing player
I'm going to opt for nine the biggest
score that I can get
and one
leads to this state where I the
maximizing player would choose eight
which is then the largest score that I
can get now the minimizing player forced
to choose between a nine or an eight is
going to choose the smallest possible
score which in this case is an eight and
that is then how this process would
unfold that the minimizing player in
this case considers both of their
options and then all of the options that
would happen as a result of that
so this now is a general picture of what
the Minimax algorithm looks like let's
now try to formalize it using a little
bit of pseudocode so what exactly is
happening in the Minimax algorithm well
given a state s we need to decide what
to happen the max player if it's Maxis
player's turn then Max is going to pick
an action a in actions of s recall that
actions as a function that takes a state
and gives me back all of the possible
actions that I can take it tells me all
of the moves that are possible
the max player is going to specifically
pick an action a in the set of actions
that gives me the highest value of Min
value of result of sna so what does that
mean well it means that I want to make
the option that gives me the highest
score of all of the actions a but what
score is that going to have to calculate
that I need to know what my opponent the
Min player is going to do if they try to
minimize the value of the state that
results
so we say what state results after I
take this action and what happens when
the Min player tries to minimize the
value of that state I consider that for
all of my possible options and after
I've considered that for all of my
possible options I pick the action a
that has the highest value
likewise the Min player is going to do
the same thing but backwards they're
also going to consider what are all of
the possible actions they can take if
it's their turn and they're going to
pick the action a that has the smallest
possible value of all the options and
the way they know what the smallest
possible value of all the options is is
by considering what the max player is
going to do by saying what's the result
of applying this action to the current
state
and then what would the max player try
to do what value would the max player
calculate for that particular state so
everyone makes their decision based on
trying to estimate what the other person
would do
and now we need to turn our attention to
these two functions max value and Min
value how do you actually calculate the
value of a state if you're trying to
maximize its value and how do you
calculate the value of a state if you're
trying to minimize the value if you can
do that then we have an entire
implementation of this Minimax algorithm
so let's try it let's try and implement
this max value function that takes a
state and returns as output the value of
that state if I'm trying to maximize the
value of the state
well the first thing I can check for is
to see if the game is over because if
the game is over in other words if the
state is a terminal State then this is
easy I already have this utility
function that tells me what the value of
the board is if the game is over I just
check like did xwind and Owen is it a
tie and this utility function just knows
what the value of the state is
what's trickier is if the game isn't
over because then I need to do this
recursive reasoning about thinking what
is my opponent going to do on the next
move
and I want to calculate the value of
this state and I want the value of the
state to be as high as possible and I'll
keep track of that value in a variable
called V and if I want the value to be
as high as possible I need to give V an
initial value and initially I'll just go
ahead and set it to be as low as
possible because I don't know what
options that are available to me yet so
initially I'll set V equal to negative
Infinity which seems a little bit
strange but the idea here is I want the
value initially to be low as low as
possible because as I consider my
actions I'm always going to try and do
better than V and if I set V to negative
Infinity I know I can always do better
than that
so now I consider my actions and this is
going to be some kind of loop where for
every action in actions of State recall
actions as a function that takes my
state and gives me all the possible
actions that I can use in that state so
for each one of those actions I want to
compare it to V and say all right V is
going to be equal to the maximum of v
and this expression so what is this
expression
well first it is get the result of
taking the action in the state
and then get the Min value of that in
other words let's say
I want to find out from that state what
is the best that the Min player can do
because they're going to try and
minimize the score so whatever the
resulting score is of the Min value of
that state compare it to my current best
value and just pick the maximum of those
two because I am trying to maximize the
value in short with these three lines of
code are doing are going through all of
my possible actions and asking the
question how do I maximize the score
given what my opponent is going to try
to do after this entire loop I can just
return V and that is now the value of
that particular state
and for the Min player it's the exact
opposite of this the same logic just
backwards to calculate the minimum value
of a state first we check if it's a
terminal state if it is we return its
utility
otherwise we're going to now try to
minimize the value of the state given
all of my possible actions so I need an
initial value for V the value of the
state and initially I'll set it to
Infinity because I know I can always get
something less than infinity so by
starting with v equals infinity I make
sure that the very first action I find
that will be less than this value of V
and then I do the same thing Loop over
all of my possible actions and for each
of the results that we could get when
the max player makes their decision
let's take the minimum of that and the
current value of V so after all is said
and done I get the smallest possible
value of V that I then return back to
the user
so that in effect is the pseudocode for
Minimax that is how we take a gain and
figure out what the best move to make is
by recursively using these max value and
Min value functions where max value
calls Min value Min value calls max
value back and forth all the way until
we reach a terminal State at which point
our algorithm can simply return the
utility of that particular state
but what you might imagine is that this
is going to start to be a long process
especially as games start to get more
complex as we start to add more moves
and more possible options and games that
might last quite a bit longer so the
next question to ask is what sort of
optimizations can we make here how can
we do better in order to use less space
or take less time to be able to solve
this kind of problem
and we'll take a look at a couple of
possible optimizations but for one we'll
take a look at this example again
returning to these up arrows and down
arrows let's imagine that I now am the
max player this green arrow I am trying
to make this score as high as possible
and this is an easy game where there are
just two moves I make a move one of
these three options and then my opponent
makes a move one of these three options
based on what move I make and as a
result we get some value
let's look at the order in which I do
these calculations and figure out if
there are any optimizations I might be
able to make to this calculation process
I'm going to have to look at these
states one at a time so let's say I
start here on the left and say all right
now I'm going to consider what will the
Min player my opponent try to do here
well the Min player is going to look at
all three of their possible actions and
look at their value because these are
terminal States they're the end of the
game and so they'll see all right this
node is a value of four value of 8 value
of five
and the Min player is going to say well
all right between these three options
four eight and five I'll take the
smallest one I'll take the four so this
state now has a value of four
then I is the max player say all right
if I take this action it will have a
value of four that's the best that I can
do because Min player is going to try
and minimize my score
so now what if I take this option we'll
explore this next and now explore what
the Min player would do if I choose this
action and the Min player is going to
say all right what are the three options
the Min player has options between nine
three and seven
and so three is the smallest among nine
three and seven so we'll go ahead and
say this state has a value of 3. so now
I is the max player I have now explored
two of my three options I know that one
of my options will guarantee me a score
of four at least and one of my options
will guarantee me a score of three
and now I consider my third option and
say all right what happens here same
exact Logic the Min player is going to
look at these three states two four and
six say the minimum possible option is
two so the Min player wants the two
now I as the max player have calculated
all of the information by looking two
layers deep by looking at all of these
nodes and I can now say between the four
the three and the two you know what I'd
rather take the four because if I choose
this option if my opponent plays
optimally they will try and get me to
the four but that's the best I can do I
can't guarantee a higher score because
if I pick either of these two options I
might get a three or I might get a two
and it's true that you know down here is
a nine and that's the highest score out
of any of the scores so I might be
tempted to say you know what maybe I
should take this option because I might
get the nine
but if the Min player is playing
intelligently if they're making the best
move that each possible option they have
when they get to make a choice I'll be
left with the three whereas I could
better playing optimally have guaranteed
that I would get the four
so that doesn't affect the logic that I
would use as a Minimax player trying to
maximize my score from that node there
but it turns out they took quite a bit
of computation for me to figure that out
I had to reason through all of these
nodes in order to draw this conclusion
and this is for a pretty simple game
where I have three choices my opponent
has three choices and then the game's
over
so what I'd like to do is come up with
some way to optimize this maybe I don't
need to do all of this calculation to
still reach the conclusion that you know
what this action to the left that's the
best that I could do
let's go ahead and try again and try to
be a little more intelligent about how I
go about doing this
so first I start the exact same way I
don't know what to do initially so I
just have to consider one of the options
and consider what the Min player might
do Min has three options four eight and
five and between those three options Min
says four is the best they can do
because they want to try to minimize the
score
now I the max player will consider my
second option making this move here and
considering what my opponent would do in
response what will the Min player do
well the Min player is going to from
that state look at their options and I
would say all right 9 is an option 3 is
an option and if I am doing the math
from this initial State doing all this
calculation when I see a 3 that should
immediately be a red flag for me
because when I see a three down here at
this state I know that the value of this
state is going to be at most three
it's going to be three or something less
than three even though I haven't yet
looked at this last action or even few
further actions if there were more
actions that could be taken here
how do I know that well I know that the
Min player is going to try to minimize
my score
and if they see a three the only way
this could be something other than a
three is if this remaining thing that I
haven't yet looked at is less than three
which means there's no way for this
value to be anything more than three
because the Min player can already
guarantee a three and they are trying to
minimize my score
so what does that tell me Well it tells
me that if I choose this action my score
is going to be three or maybe even less
than three if I'm unlucky
but I already know that this action will
guarantee me a four
and so given that I know that this
action guarantees me a score of four and
this action means I can't do better than
three if I'm trying to maximize my
options there is no need for me to
consider this triangle here there is no
value no number that could go here that
would change my mind between these two
options I'm always going to opt for this
path that gets me a 4 as opposed to this
path where the best I can do with the
three if my opponent plays optimally
and this is going to be true for all of
the future states that I look at too but
if I look over here at what Min player
might do over here if I see that this
state is a 2 I know that this state is
at most a two because the only way this
value could be something let other than
two is if one of these remaining States
is less than the two and so the Min
player would opt for that instead so
even without looking at these remaining
States I is the maximizing player
can know that choosing this path to the
left is going to be better than choosing
either of those two paths to the right
because this one can't be better than
three this one can't be better than two
and so four in this case is the best
that I can do
so in order to do this cut and I can say
now that this state has a value of 4.
so in order to do this type of
calculation I was doing a little bit
more bookkeeping keeping track of things
keeping track all the time of what is
the best that I can do what is the worst
that I can do and for each of these
states saying all right well if I
already know that I can get a 4 then if
the best I can do it this state is a
three no reason for me to consider it I
can effectively prune this leaf and
anything below it from the tree and it's
for that reason this approach this
optimization to Minimax is called Alpha
Beta pruning Alpha and beta stand for
these two values and you'll have to keep
track of of the best you can do so far
and the worst you can do so far and
pruning is the idea of if I have a big
long deep search tree
I might be able to search it more
efficiently if I don't need to search
through everything if I can remove some
of the nodes to try and optimize the way
that I look through this entire search
space
so Alpha Beta pruning can definitely
save us a lot of time as we go about the
search process by making our searches
more efficient but even then it's still
not great as games get more complex
tic-tac-toe fortunately is a relatively
simple game and we might reasonably ask
a question like
how many total possible tic-tac-toe
games are there you can think about it
you can try and estimate you know how
many moves are there at any given point
how many moves long can the game last it
turns out
there are about
255 000 possible tic-tac-toe games that
can be played
but compare that to a more complex game
something like a game of chess for
example far more pieces far more moves
games that last much longer how many
total possible chess games could there
be
it turns out that after just four moves
each four moves by the white player four
moves by the black player that there are
288 billion possible chess games that
can result from that situation after
just four moves each and going even
further if you look at entire chess
games and how many possible chess games
there could be as a result there they're
more than 10 to the 29 000 possible
chess games far more chess games than
could ever be considered and this is a
pretty big problem for the Minimax
algorithm because the Minimax algorithm
starts with an initial State considers
all the possible actions and all the
possible actions after that
all the way until we get to the end of
the game
and that's going to be a problem if the
computer is going to need to look
through this many states which is far
more than any computer could ever do in
any reasonable amount of time
so what do we do in order to solve this
problem instead of looking through all
these states which is totally
intractable for a computer we need some
better approach and it turns out that
better approach generally takes the form
of something called depth limited
Minimax where normally Minimax is depth
unlimited we just keep going layer after
layer move after move until we get to
the end of the game depth limited
Minimax is instead going to say you know
what after a certain number of moves
maybe I'll look 10 moves ahead maybe
I'll look 12 moves ahead but after that
point I'm going to stop and not consider
additional moves that might come after
that just because it would be
computationally intractable to consider
all of those possible options
but what do we do after we get 10 or 12
moves deep and we arrive at a situation
where the game's not over Minimax still
needs a way to assign a score to that
game board or game state to figure out
what its current value is which is easy
to do if the game is over but not so
easy to do if the game is not yet over
so in order to do that we need to add
one additional feature to depth limited
Minimax called an evaluation function
which is just some function that is
going to estimate the expected utility
of a game from a given state
so in a game like chess if you imagine
that a game value of 1 means white wins
negative one means black wins zero means
it's a draw
then you might imagine that a score of
like 0.8 means white is very likely to
win they'll certainly not guaranteed and
you would have an evaluation function
that estimates how good the game State
happens to be and depending on how good
that evaluation function is that is
ultimately what's going to constrain how
good the AI is the better the AI is at
estimating how good or how bad any
particular game state is the better the
AI is going to be able to play that game
if the evaluation function is worse and
not as good as estimating what the
expected utility is then it's going to
be a whole lot harder and you can
imagine trying to come up with these
evaluation functions in chess for
example you might write an evaluation
function based on how many pieces you
have as compared to how many pieces your
opponent has because each one has a
value and your evaluation function
function probably needs to be a little
bit more complicated than that to
consider other possible situations that
might arise as well and there are many
other variants on Minimax that
additional features in order to help it
perform better under these larger more
computationally untractable situations
where we couldn't possibly explore all
of the possible moves so we need to
figure out how to use evaluation
functions and other techniques to be
able to play these games ultimately
better but this now with a look at this
kind of adversarial search these search
problems where we have situations where
I am trying to play against some sort of
opponent and these search problems show
up all over the place throughout
artificial intelligence we've been
talking a lot today about more classical
search problems like trying to find
directions from one location to another
but anytime an AI is faced with trying
to make a decision like what do I do now
in order to do something that is
rational or do something that is
intelligent or trying to play a game
like figuring out what move to make
these sort of algorithms can really come
in handy it turns out that for
Tic-tac-toe the solution is pretty
simple because it's a small game XKCD is
famously put together a webcomic where
he will tell you exactly what move to
make as the optimal move to make no
matter what your opponent happens to do
this type of thing is not quite as
possible for a much larger game like
Checkers or chess for example where
chess is totally computationally
untractable for most computers to be
able to explore all the possible States
so we really need our AI to be far more
intelligent about how they go about
trying to deal with these problems and
how they go about taking this
environment that they find themselves in
and ultimately searching for one of
these Solutions so this then was a look
at search in artificial intelligence
next time we'll take a look at knowledge
thinking about how it is that our AIS
are able to know information reason
about that information and draw
conclusions all in our look at Ai and
the principles behind it we'll see you
next time
thank you
[Music]
all right welcome back everyone to an
introduction to artificial intelligence
with python last time we took to look at
search problems in particular where we
have ai agents that are trying to solve
some sort of Problem by taking actions
in some sort of environment whether that
environment is trying to take actions by
playing moves in a game or whether those
actions are something like trying to
figure out where to make turns in order
to get driving directions from point A
to point B this time we're going to turn
our attention more generally to just
this idea of knowledge the idea that a
lot of intelligence is based on
knowledge especially if we think about
human intelligence people know
information we know facts about the
world and using that information that we
know we're able to draw conclusions
reason about the information that we
know in order to figure out how to do
something or figure out some other piece
of information that we conclude based on
the information we already have
available to us what we'd like to focus
on now is the ability to take this idea
of knowledge and being able to reason
based on knowledge and apply those ideas
to artificial intelligence in particular
we're going to be building what are
known as knowledge based agents agents
that are able to reason and act by
representing knowledge internally is
somehow inside of our AI they have some
understanding of what it means to know
something and ideally they have some
algorithms or some techniques they can
use based on that knowledge that they
know in order to figure out the solution
to a problem or figure out some
additional piece of information that can
be helpful in some sense so what do we
mean by reasoning based on knowledge to
be able to draw conclusions well let's
look at a simple example drawn from the
World of Harry Potter we take one
sentence that we know to be true imagine
if it didn't if it didn't rain then
Harry visited Hagrid today so one fact
that we might know about the world and
then we take another fact Harry visited
Hagrid or Dumbledore today but not both
so it tells us something about the world
that Harry either visited Hagrid but not
Dumbledore or Harry visited Dumbledore
but not Hagrid and now we have a third
piece of information about the world
that Harry visited Dumbledore today so
we now have three pieces of information
now three facts inside of a knowledge
base so to speak information that we
know and now we as humans can try and
reason about this and figure out based
on this information what additional
information can we begin to conclude and
well looking at these last two
statements Harry either visited Hagrid
or Dumbledore but not both and we know
that Harry visited Dumbledore today well
then it's pretty reasonable that we
could draw the conclusion that you know
what Harry must not have visited Hagrid
today because based on a combination of
these two statements we can draw this
inference so to speak a conclusion that
Harry did not visit Hagrid today
but it turns out we can even do a little
bit better than that get some more
information by taking a look at this
first statement and reasoning about that
this first statement says if it didn't
rain then Harry visited Hagrid today
so what does that mean in all cases
where it didn't rain then we know that
Harry visited Hagrid but if we also know
now that Harry did not visit Hagrid then
that tells us something about our
initial premise that we were thinking
about in particular it tells us that it
did rain today because we can reason if
it didn't rain then Harry would have
visited Hagrid but we know for a fact
that Harry did not visit Hagrid today
so it's this kind of reasoning this sort
of logical reasoning where we use logic
based on the information that we know in
order to take information and reach
conclusions that is going to be the
focus of what we're going to be talking
about today how can we make our
artificial intelligence logical so that
they can perform the same kinds of
deduction the same kinds of reasoning
that we've been doing so far
of course humans reason about logic
generally in terms of human language
that I just now was speaking in English
talking in English about these sentences
and trying to reason through how it is
that they relate to one another we're
going to need to be a little bit more
formal when we turn our attention to
computers and being able to encode this
notion of logic and Truth hood and
falsehood inside of a machine so we're
going to need to introduce a few more
terms and a few symbols that'll help us
reason through this idea of logic inside
of an artificial intelligence and we'll
begin with the idea of a sentence now a
sentence in a natural language like
English is just something that I'm
saying like what I'm saying right now in
the context of AI though a sentence is
just an assertion about the world in
what we're going to call a knowledge
representation language some way of
representing knowledge inside of our
computers and the way that we're going
to spend most of today reasoning about
knowledge is through a type of logic
known as propositional logic there are a
number of different types of Logics some
of which we'll touch on but
propositional logic is based on a logic
of propositions or just statements about
the world and so we begin in
propositional logic with a notion of
propositional symbols we will have
certain symbols that are oftentimes just
letters something like P or Q or R where
each of those symbols is going to
represent some fact or sentence about
the world so P for example might
represent the fact that it is raining
and so p is going to represent be a
symbol that represents that idea and Q
for example might represent Harry
visited Hagrid today each of these
propositional symbols represents some
sentence or some fact about the world
but in addition to just having
individual facts about the world we want
some way to connect these propositional
symbols together in order to reason more
complexly about other facts that might
exist inside of the world in which we're
reasoning so in order to do that we'll
need to introduce some additional
symbols that are known as logical
connectives now there are a number of
these logical connectives but five of
the most important and the ones we're
going to focus on today are these five
up here each represented biological
symbol not is represented by this symbol
here and is represented as sort of an
upside down V or is represented by a V
shape implication and we'll talk about
what that means in just a moment is
represented by an arrow and
biconditional again we'll talk about
what that means in a moment is
represented by these double arrows but
these five logical connectives are the
main ones we're going to be focusing on
in terms of thinking about how it is
that a computer can reason about facts
and draw conclusions based on the facts
that it knows
but in order to get there we need to
take a look at each of these logical
connectives and build up an
understanding for what it is that they
actually mean so let's go ahead and
begin with the not symbol so this not
symbol here and what we're going to show
for each of these logical connectives is
what we're going to call a truth table a
table that demonstrates what this word
not means when we attach it to a
propositional symbol or any sentence
inside of our logical language and so
the pro the truth table for naught is
shown right here if P some propositional
symbol or some other sentence even is
false then not p is true
and if p is true then not p is false so
you can imagine that placing this not
symbol in front of some sentence of
propositional logic just says the
opposite of that so if for example P
represented it is raining then not P
would represent the idea that it is not
raining and as you might expect if p is
false meaning if the sentence it is
raining is false well then the sentence
not P must be true the sentence that it
is not raining is therefore true so not
you can imagine just takes whatever is
in p and it inverts it turns false into
true and true into false much
analogously to what the English word not
means just taking whatever comes after
it and inverting it to mean the opposite
next up and also very english-like is
this idea of and represented by this
upside down V shape or this point shape
and as opposed to just taking a single
argument the way not does we have p and
we have not p and is going to combine
two different sentences in propositional
logic together so I might have one
sentence p and another sentence q and I
want to combine them together to say p
and Q and the general Logic for what p
and Q means is it means that both of its
operands are true p is true and also Q
is true and so here's what that truth
table looks like this time we have two
variables p and Q and when we have two
variables Each of which can be in two
possible states true or false that leads
to 2 squared or four possible
combinations of Truth and falsehood so
we have p is false and Q is false we
have p is false and Q is true p is true
and Q is false and then p and Q both are
true and those are the only four
possibilities for what p and Q could
mean and in each of those situations
this third column here p and Q is
telling us a little bit about what it
actually means for p and Q to be true
and we see that the only case where p
and Q is true is in this fourth row here
where P happens to be true Q also
happens to be true and in all other
situations p and Q is going to evaluate
to false so this again is much in line
with what our intuition of and might
mean if I say p and Q I probably mean
that I expect both p and Q to be true
next up also potentially consistent with
what we mean is this word or represented
by this V shape sort of an upside down
and symbol and or as the name might
suggest is true if either of its
arguments are true as long as p is true
or Q is true then P or Q is going to be
true which means the only time that P or
Q is false is if both of its operands
are false if p is false and Q is false
then P or Q is going to be false but in
all other cases at least one of the
operands is true maybe they're both true
in which case P or Q is going to
evaluate to true
now this is mostly consistent with the
way that most people might use the word
or in the sense of speaking the word or
in normal English though there is
sometimes when we might say or where we
mean p or q but not both or we mean sort
of it can only be one or the other it's
important to note that this symbol here
this or means P or Q or both that those
are totally okay as long as either or
both of them are true then the or is
going to evaluate to be true as well
it's only in the case where all of the
operands are false that P or Q
ultimately evaluates to false as well in
logic there's a number another symbol
known as The Exclusive or which encodes
this idea of exclusivity of like one or
the other but not both but we're not
going to be focusing on that today
whenever we talk about or we're always
talking about either or both in this
case as represented by this truth table
here
so that now is not an and an or and next
up is what we might call implication as
denoted by this arrow symbol so we have
p and Q and this sentence here will
generally read as P implies Q
and what P implies Q means is that if p
is true then Q is also true so I might
say something like if it is raining then
I will be indoors meaning it is raining
implies I will be indoors as The Logical
sentence that I'm saying there and the
truth table for this can sometimes be a
little bit tricky so obviously if p is
true and Q is true then P implies Q
that's true that definitely makes sense
and it should also stand to reason that
when p is true and Q is false then P
implies Q is false because if I said to
you if it is raining then I will be out
indoors and it is raining but I'm not
indoors well then it would seem to be
that my original statement was not true
P implies Q means that if p is true then
Q also needs to be true and if it's not
well then the statement is false
what's also worth noting though is what
happens when p is false when p is false
the implication makes no claim at all if
I say something like if it is raining
then I will be indoors and it turns out
it's not raining then in that case I am
not making any statement as to whether
or not I will be indoors or not P
implies Q just means that if p is True Q
must be true but if p is not true then
we make no Claim about whether or not Q
is true at all so in either case if p is
false it doesn't matter what Q is
whether it's false or true we're not
making any Claim about Q whatsoever we
can still evaluate the implication to
true the only way that the implication
is ever false is if our premise p is
true but the conclusion that we're
drawing Q happens to be false so in that
case we would say p does not imply Q in
that case
finally the last connective that we'll
discuss is this biconditional you can
think of a biconditional as a condition
that goes in both directions so
originally when I said something like if
it is raining then I will be indoors I
didn't say what would happen if it
wasn't written maybe I'll be indoors
maybe I'll be outdoors this
biconditional you can read as an if and
only if so I can say if it is I will be
indoors if and only if it is raining
meaning if it is raining then I will be
indoors and if I am indoors it's
reasonable to conclude that it is also
raining so this biconditional is only
true when p and Q are the same so if p
is true and Q is true then this
biconditional is also true P implies q
but also the reverse is True Q also
implies P so if p and Q both happen to
be false we would still say it's true
but in any of these other two situations
this P if and only if Q is going to
ultimately evaluate to false so I'll a
lot of truths and falses going on there
but these five basic logical connectives
are going to form the core of the
language of propositional logic the
language that we're going to use in
order to describe ideas and the language
that we're going to use in order to
reason about those ideas in order to
draw conclusions
so let's now take a look at some of the
additional terms that we'll need to know
about in order to go about trying to
form this language of propositional
logic and writing AI that's actually
able to understand this sort of logic
the next thing we're going to need is
the notion of what is actually true
about the world we have a whole bunch of
propositional symbols p and Q and R and
maybe others but we need some way of
knowing like what actually is true in
the world is p true or false is Q true
or false so on and so forth and to do
that we'll introduce the notion of a
Model A model just assigns a truth value
or a truth value is either true or false
to every propositional symbol in other
words it's creating what we might call a
possible world so let me give an example
if for example I have two propositional
symbols p is it is raining and Q is it
is a Tuesday a model just takes each of
these two symbols and assigns a truth
value to them either true or false so
here's a sample model in this model in
other words in this possible world it is
possible that P is true meaning it is
raining and Q is false meaning it is not
a Tuesday but there are other possible
worlds or other models as well there is
some model where both of these variables
are true some model where both of these
variables are false in fact if there are
n variables that are propositional
symbols like this that are either true
or false then the number of possible
models is 2 to the N because each of
these possible models possible variables
within my model could be set to either
true or false if I don't know any
information about it
so now that I have the the symbols and
the symbols and the connectives that I'm
going to need in order to construct
these parts of knowledge we need some
way to represent that knowledge and to
do so we're going to allow our AI access
to what we'll call a knowledge base and
our knowledge base is really just a set
of sentences that our AI knows to be
true some set of sentences in
propositional logic that are things that
our AI knows about the world
and so we might tell our AI some
information information about a
situation that it finds itself in or
situation about a problem that it
happens to be trying to solve and we
would give that information to the AI
that the AI would store inside of its
knowledge base and what happens next is
the AI would like to use that
information in the knowledge base to be
able to draw conclusions about the rest
of the world and what do those
conclusions look like well to understand
those conclusions we'll need to
introduce one more idea one more symbol
and that is the notion of entailment
so this sentence here with this double
Turn Style in these Greek letters this
is the Greek letter Alpha and the Greek
letter beta and we read this as Alpha
entails beta and Alpha and beta here are
just sentences in propositional logic
and what this means is that Alpha
entails beta means that in every model
in other words in every possible World
in which sentence a is true or a
sentence Alpha is true then sentence
beta is also true so if something
entails something else if Alpha entails
beta it means that if I know Alpha to be
true then beta must therefore also be
true so if my Alpha is something like I
know that it is a Tuesday in January
then a reasonable beta might be
something like I know that it is January
because in all worlds where it is a
Tuesday in January I know for sure that
it must be January just by definition
this first statement or sentence about
the world entails the second statement
and we can reasonably use deduction
based on that first sentence to figure
out that the second sentence is in fact
true as well and ultimately it's this
idea of entailment that we're going to
try and encode into our compute we want
our AI agent to be able to figure out
what the possible entailments are we
want our AI to be able to take these
three sentences sentences like if it
didn't rain Harry visited Hagrid that
Harry visited Hagrid or Dumbledore but
not both and that Harry visited
Dumbledore and just using that
information we'd like our AI to be able
to infer or figure out that using these
three sentences inside of a knowledge
base we can draw some conclusions in
particular we can draw the conclusions
here that one Harry did not visit Hagrid
today and we can draw the entailment too
that it did in fact rain today and this
process is known as inference and that's
what we're going to be focusing on today
this process of deriving new sentences
from old ones that I give you these
three sentences you put them in the
knowledge base inside the IAAI and the
AI is able to use some sort of inference
algorithm to figure out that these two
sentences must also be true and that is
how we Define inference
so let's take a look at an inference
example to see how we might actually go
about inferring things in a human sense
before we take a more algorithmic
approach to see how we could encode this
idea of inference in Ai and we'll see
there are a number of ways that we can
actually achieve this so again we'll
deal with a couple of propositional
symbols we'll deal with p q and r p is
it is a Tuesday Q is it is raining and R
is Harry will go for a run three
propositional symbols that we are just
defining to mean this we're not saying
anything yet about whether they're true
or false we're just defining what they
are
now we'll give ourselves or an AI access
to a knowledge base abbreviated to KB
the knowledge that we know about the
world we know this statement all right
so let's try to parse it the parentheses
here are just used for precedence so we
can see what associates with what but
you would read this as p and not Q
implies r
all right so what does that mean let's
put it be piece by piece p is it is a
Tuesday
Q is it is raining so not Q is it is not
raining
and implies R is Harry will go for a run
so the way to read this entire sentence
in human natural language at least is a
if it is a Tuesday
and it is not raining then Harry will go
for a run
so if it is a Tuesday and it is not
raining then Harry will go for a run and
that is now inside of our knowledge base
and let's now imagine that our knowledge
base has two other pieces of information
as well it has information that P is
true
that it is a Tuesday
and we also have the information not q
that it is not rated that this sentence
Q it is raining happens to be false and
those are the three sentences that we
have access to p and not Q implies r p
and not Q
using that information we should be able
to draw some inferences p and not Q is
only true if both p and not Q are true
well all right we know that P is true
and we know that not Q is true so we
know that this whole expression is true
and the definition of implication is if
this whole thing on the left is true
then this thing on the right must also
be true so if we know that P and not Q
is true then R must be true as well so
the inference we should be able to draw
from all of this is that R is true and
we know that Harry will go for a run by
taking this knowledge inside of our
knowledge base and being able to reason
based on that idea
and so this ultimately is the beginning
of what we might consider to be some
sort of inference algorithm some process
that we can use to try and figure out
whether or not we can draw some
conclusion and ultimately what these
inference algorithms are going to answer
is the central question about entailment
given some query about the world
something we're wondering about the
world and we'll call that query Alpha
the question we want to ask using these
inference algorithms is a does KB that
are knowledge base entail Alpha in other
words using only the information we know
inside of our knowledge base the
knowledge that we have access to can we
conclude that this sentence Alpha is
true and that's ultimately what we would
like to do
so how can we do that how can we go
about writing an algorithm that can look
at this knowledge base and figure out
whether or not this query Alpha is
actually true well it turns out there
are a couple of different algorithms for
doing so and one of the simplest perhaps
is known as model checking now remember
that a model is just some assignment of
all of the propositional symbols inside
of our language to a truth value true or
false and you can think of a model as a
possible world that there are many
possible worlds where different things
might be true or false and we can
enumerate all of them and the model
checking algorithm does exactly that
so what does our model tracking
algorithm do well if we wanted to
determine if our knowledge base entails
some query Alpha then we are going to
enumerate all possible models in other
words consider all possible values of
true and false for our variables all
possible States in which our world can
be in
and if in every model where our
knowledge base is true Alpha is also
true then we know that the knowledge
base entails Alpha so take a closer look
at that sentence and try and figure out
what it actually means if we know that
in every model in other words in every
possible world no matter what assignment
of true and false to variables you give
if we know that whenever our knowledge
is true what we know to be true is true
that this query Alpha is also true well
then it stands to reason that as long as
our knowledge base is true then Alpha
must also be true
and so this is going to form the
foundation of our model checking
algorithm we're going to enumerate all
of the possible worlds and ask ourselves
whenever the knowledge base is true is
Alpha true and if it's that's the case
then we know Alpha to be true and
otherwise there is no entailment our
knowledge base does not entail Alpha
all right so this is a little bit
abstract but let's take a look at an
example to try and put real
propositional symbols to this idea so
again we'll work with the same example p
is it is a Tuesday Q is it is raining R
is Harry will go for a run our knowledge
base contains these pieces of
information p and not Q implies R we
also know P it is a Tuesday and not Q it
is not raining and our query our Alpha
in this case the thing we want to ask is
R we want to know is it guaranteed is it
entailed that Harry will go for a run
so the first step is to enumerate all of
the possible models we have three
propositional symbols here PQ and R
which means we have two to the third
power or eight possible models all false
false false true false true false false
true true
Etc eight possible ways you could assign
true and false to all of these models
and we might ask in each one of them is
the knowledge base true here are the set
of things that we know in which of these
worlds could this knowledge base
possibly apply to and which world is
this knowledge base true well in the
knowledge base for example we know P
like we know it is a Tuesday which means
we know that these four first four rows
where p is false none of those are going
to be true or going to work for this
particular knowledge base our knowledge
base is not true in those worlds
likewise we also know not Q we know that
it is not raining so any of these models
where Q is true like these two and these
two here those aren't going to work
either because we know that Q is not
true
and finally we also know that P and not
Q implies R which means that when p is
true where p is true here and Q is false
Q is false and these two then R must be
true and if ever p is True Q is false
but R is also false well that doesn't
satisfy this implication here that
implication does not hold true under
those situations so we could say that
for our knowledge base we can conclude
under which of these possible worlds is
our knowledge base true and under which
of the possible worlds is our knowledge
base false and it turns out there is
only one possible world where our
knowledge base is actually true in some
cases there might be multiple possible
worlds where the knowledge base is true
but in this case it just so happens that
there's only one one possible world
where we can definitively say something
about our knowledge base and in this
case we would look at the query
the query of R is R true R is true and
so as a result we can draw that
conclusion
and so this is this idea of model
checking enumerate all the possible
models and look in those possible models
to see whether or not if our knowledge
base is true is the query in question
true as well
so let's now take a look at how we might
actually go about writing this in a
programming language like python take a
look at some actual code that would
encode this notion of propositional
symbols and logic and these connectives
like and and or and not an implication
and so forth and see what that code
might actually look like so I've written
in advance a logic Library that's more
detailed than we need to worry about
entirely today but the important thing
is that we have one class for every type
of logical symbol or connective that we
might have so we just have one class for
logical symbols for example where every
symbol is going to represent and store
some name for that particular symbol and
we also have a class for not that takes
an operand so we might say not one
symbol to say something is not true or
some other sentence is not true we have
one for and one for or so on and so
forth and I'll just demonstrate how this
works and you can take a look at the
actual logic.pi later on but I'll go
ahead and call this file
harry.pi we're going to store
information about
In This World of Harry Potter for
example so I'll go ahead and import from
my logic module I'll import everything
and in this library in order to create a
symbol you use capital S symbol and I'll
create a symbol for rain to mean it is
raining for example and I'll create a
symbol for Hagrid to mean Harry visited
Hagrid is what the symbol is going to
mean so this symbol means it is raining
this symbol means Harry visited Hagrid
and I'll add another symbol called
Dumbledore
for Harry visited
now I'd like to save these symbols so
that I can use them later as I do some
logical analysis so I'll go ahead and
save each one of them inside of a
variable so like rain Hagrid and
Dumbledore
that you could call the variables
anything
and now that I have these logical
symbols I can use logical connectives to
combine them together so for example if
I have a sentence like and
rain and Hagrid for example which is not
necessarily true but just for
demonstration
I can now try and print out sentence dot
formula which is a function I wrote that
takes a sentence in propositional logic
and just prints it out so that we the
programmers can now see this in order to
get an understanding for how it actually
works so if I run python harry.pi
what we'll see is this sentence in
propositional logic Reign and Hagrid
this is The Logical representation of
what we have here in our Python program
of saying and whose arguments are Reign
and Hagrid so we're saying rain and
Hagrid by encoding that idea and this is
quite common in Python object-oriented
programming where you have a number of
different classes and you pass arguments
into them in order to create a new and
object for example in order to represent
this idea
but now what I'd like to do is somehow
encode the knowledge that I have about
the world in order to solve that problem
from the beginning of class where we
talked about trying to figure out who
Harry visited and trying to figure out
if it's raining or if it's not raining
and so what knowledge do I have
I'll go ahead and create a new variable
called knowledge and what do I know well
I know the very first sentence that we
talked about was the idea that if it is
not raining then Harry will visit hygrid
so all right how do I encode the idea
that it is not raining well I can use
not and then the rain symbol so here's
me saying that it is not raining and now
the implication is that if it is not
raining then Harry visited Hagrid
so I'll wrap this inside of an
implication
to say if it is not raining this first
argument to the implication will then
Harry visited Hagrid
so I'm saying implication the premise is
that it's not raining and if it is not
raining then Harry visited Hagrid and I
can print out knowledge.formula to see
The Logical formula equivalent of that
same idea so I run python of harry.pi
and this is The Logical formula that we
see as a result which is a text-based
version of what we were looking at
before that if it is not raining then
that implies that Harry visited Hagrid
but there was additional information
that we had access to as well in this
case we had access to the fact that
Harry visited either Hagrid or
Dumbledore so how do I encode that well
this means that in my knowledge I've
really got multiple pieces of knowledge
going on I know one thing and another
thing and another thing so I'll go ahead
and wrap all of my knowledge inside of
an and I'll move things on a new lines
just for good measure but I know
multiple things so I'm saying knowledge
is an and of multiple different
sentences I know multiple different
sentences to be true one such sentence
that I know to be true is this
implication that if it is not raining
then Harry visited Hagrid another such
sentence that I know to be true is or
Hagrid
Dumbledore in other words either so
Hagrid or Dumbledore is true because I
know that Harry visited Hagrid or
Dumbledore
but I know more than that actually that
initial sentence from before said that
Harry visited Hagrid or Dumbledore but
not both so now I want a sentence
that'll encode the idea that Harry
didn't visit both Hagrid and Dumbledore
well the notion of Harry visiting Hagrid
and Dumbledore would be represented like
this and of Hagrid and Dumbledore
and if that is not true if I want to say
not that then I'll just wrap this whole
thing inside of a knot
so now these three lines line eight says
that if it is not raining then Harry
visited Hagrid line 9 says Harry visited
Hagrid or Dumbledore and line 10 says
Hagrid didn't or Harry didn't visit both
Hagrid and Dumbledore that it is not
true that both the Hagrid symbol and the
Dumbledore symbol are true only one of
them can be true
and finally the last piece of
information that I knew was the fact
that Harry visited Dumbledore
so these now are the pieces of knowledge
that I know one sentence and another
sentence and another and another and I
can print out what I know just to see it
a little bit more visually and here now
is a logical representation of the
information that my computer is now
internally representing using these
various different python objects and
again take a look at logic.pi if you
want to take a look at how exactly it's
implementing this but no need to worry
too much about all of the details there
we're here saying that if it is not
raining then Harry visited Hagrid we're
saying that Hagrid or Dumbledore is true
and we're saying it is not the case that
Hagrid and Dumbledore is true that
they're not both true and we also know
that Dumbledore is true so this long
logical sentence represents our
knowledge base it is the thing that we
know
and now what we'd like to do is we'd
like to use model checking to ask a
query to ask a question like based on
this information do I know whether or
not it's raining and we as humans were
able to logic our way through it and
figure out that all right based on these
sentences we can conclude this and that
to figure out that yes it must have been
raining but now we'd like for the
computer to do that as well
so let's take a look at the model
checking algorithm that is going to
follow that same pattern that we drew
out in pseudocode a moment ago so I've
defined a function here in logic.pi that
you can take a look at called Model
check model check takes two arguments
the knowledge that I already know and
the query
and the idea is in order to do model
checking I need to enumerate all of the
possible models and for each of the
possible models I need to ask myself is
the knowledge base true and is the query
true so the first thing I need to do is
somehow enumerate all of the possible
models meaning for all possible symbols
that exist I need to assign true and
false to each one of them and see
whether or not it's still true
and so here is the way we're going to do
that
we're going to start so I've defined
another helper function internally that
we'll get to in just a moment but this
function starts by getting all of the
symbols in both the knowledge and the
query by figuring out what symbols am I
dealing with in this case the symbols
I'm dealing with are rain and Hagrid and
Dumbledore but there might be other
symbols depending on the problem and
we'll take a look soon at some examples
of situations where ultimately we're
going to need some additional symbols in
order to represent the problem
and then we're going to run this check
all function which is a helper function
that's basically going to recursively
call itself checking every possible
configuration of propositional symbols
so we start out
by looking at this check all function
and what do we do so if not symbols
means if we finish assigning all of the
symbols we've assigned every symbol of
value so far we haven't done that but if
we ever do then we check
in this model is the knowledge true
that's what this line is saying if we
evaluate the knowledge propositional
logic formula using the model's
assignment of truth values is the
knowledge true if the knowledge is true
then we should return true only if the
query is true because if the knowledge
is true we want the query to be true as
well in order for there to be entailment
otherwise we don't know that there
otherwise there won't be an entailment
if there's ever a situation where what
we know in our knowledge is true but the
query the thing we're asking happens to
be false so this line here is checking
that same idea that in all worlds where
the knowledge is true the query must
also be true
otherwise we can just return true
because if the knowledge isn't true then
we don't care this is equivalent to when
we were enumerating this table from a
moment ago in all situations where the
knowledge base wasn't true all of these
seven rows here we didn't care whether
or not our query was true or not we only
care to check whether the query is true
when the knowledge base is actually true
which was just this green highlighted
row right there
so that logic is encoded using that
statement there
and otherwise if we haven't assigned
symbols yet which we haven't seen
anything yet then the first thing we do
is pop one of the symbols I make a copy
of the symbols first just to save an
existing copy but I pop one symbol off
of the remaining symbol so that I just
pick one symbol at random and I create
one copy of the model where that symbol
is true
and I create a second copy of the model
where that symbol is false
so I now have two copies of the model
one where the symbol is true and one
where the symbol is false and I need to
make sure that this entailment holds in
both of those models so I recursively
check all on the model where the
statement is true and check all on the
model where the statement is false
so again you can take a look at that
function to try to get a sense for how
exactly this logic is working but in
effect what it's doing is recursively
calling this check-off function again
and again and again and on every level
of the recursion we're saying let's pick
a new uh symbol that we haven't yet
assigned assign it to true and assign it
to false and then check to make sure
that the entailment holds in both cases
because ultimately I need to check every
possible world I need to take every
combination of symbols and try every
combination of true and false in order
to figure out whether the entailment
relation actually holds
so that function we've written for you
but in order to use that function inside
of harry.pi what I'll write is something
like this I would like to model check
based on the knowledge and then I
provide as a second argument what the
query is what the thing I want to ask is
and what I want to ask in this case is
is it rating
so model check again takes two arguments
the first argument is the information
that I know this knowledge which in this
case is this information that was given
to me at the beginning
and the second argument Reign is
encoding the idea of the query what am I
asking I would like to ask based on this
knowledge do I know for sure that it is
rated
and I can try and print out the result
of that
and when I run this program
I see that the answer is true that based
on this information I can conclusively
say that it is rating because using this
model checking algorithm we were able to
check that in every world where this
knowledge is true it is raining in other
words there is no world where this
knowledge is true and it is not written
so you can conclude that it is in fact
written
and this sort of logic can be applied to
a number of different types of problems
that if confronted with a problem where
some sort of logical deduction can be
used in order to try to solve it you
might try thinking about what
propositional symbols you might need in
order to represent that information and
what statements and propositional logic
you might use in order to encode that
information which you know and this
process of trying to take a problem and
figure out what propositional symbols to
use in order to encode that idea or how
to represent it logically is known as
knowledge engineering that software
engineers and AI Engineers will take a
problem and try and figure out how to
distill it down into knowledge that is
representable by a computer and if we
can take any general purpose problem
some problem that we find in the human
world and turn it into a problem that
computers know how to solve as by using
any number of different variables well
then we can take a computer that is able
to do something like model checking or
some other inference algorithm and
actually figure out how to solve that
problem
so now we'll take a look at two or three
examples of knowledge engineering and
practice of taking some problem and
figuring out how we can apply logical
symbols and use logical formulas to be
able to encode that idea and we'll start
with a very popular board game in the US
and the UK known as clue now in the game
of Clue there's a number of different
factors that are going on but the basic
premise of the game if you've never
played it before is that there are a
number of different people for now we'll
just use three Colonel Mustard Professor
Plum and Miss Scarlett there are a
number of different rooms like a
ballroom a kitchen and a library and
there are a number of different weapons
a knife a revolver and a wrench and
three of these one person one room and
one weapon is the solution to the the
mystery the the murderer and what room
they were in and what weapon they happen
to use and what happens at the beginning
of the game is that all these cards are
randomly shuffled together and three of
them one person one room and one weapon
are placed into a sealed envelope that
we don't know and we would like to
figure out using some sort of logical
process what's inside the envelope which
person which room and which weapon and
we do so by looking at some but not all
of these cards here by looking at these
cards to try and figure out what might
be going on
and so this is a very popular game but
let's now try and formalize it and see
if we could train a computer to be able
to play this game by reasoning through
it logically
so in order to do this we'll Begin by
thinking about what propositional
symbols we're ultimately going to need
remember again that propositional
symbols are just some symbol some
variable that can be either true or
false in the world
and so in this case the propositional
symbols are really just going to
correspond to each of the
possible things that could be inside the
envelope mustard is a propositional
symbol then in this case will just be
true if kernel mustard is inside the
envelope if he is the murderer and false
otherwise and likewise for Plum for
Professor Plum and Scarlet for Miss
scarlet and likewise for each of the
rooms and for each of the weapons we
have one propositional symbol for each
of these ideas
then using those propositional symbols
we can begin to create logical sentences
create knowledge that we know about the
world so for example we know that
someone is the murderer that one of the
three people is in fact the murderer and
how would we encode that well we don't
know for sure who the murderer is but we
know it is one person or the second
person or the third person
so I could say something like this
mustard or Plum or scarlet and this
piece of knowledge encodes that one of
these three people is the murder we
don't know which but one of these three
things must be true
what other information do we know well
we know that for example one of the
rooms must have been the room in the
envelope the the crime was committed
either in the ballroom or the kitchen or
the library again right now we don't
know which but this is knowledge we know
at the outfit knowledge that one of
these three must be inside the envelope
and likewise we can say the same thing
about the weapon that it was either the
knife or the revolver or the wrench that
one of those weapons must have been the
weapon of choice and therefore the
weapon in the envelope
and then as the game progresses the
gameplay works by people get various
different cards and using those cards
you can deduce information that if
someone gives you a card for example I
have the professor Plum card in my hand
then I know the professor Plum card
can't be inside the envelope I know that
Professor Plum is not the criminal
so I know a piece of information like
not Plum for example I know that
Professor plum it has to be false this
propositional symbol is not true
and sometimes I might not know for sure
that a particular card is not in the
middle but sometimes someone make a
guess and I'll know that one of three
possibilities is not true like someone
will guess Colonel Mustard in the
library with the revolver or something
to that effect and in that case a card
might be revealed that I don't see but
if it is a card and it is either Colonel
Mustard or the revolver or the library
then I know that at least one of them
can't be in the middle so I know
something like it is either not mustard
or it is not the library or it is not
the revolver now maybe multiple of these
are not true but I know that at least
one of mustard library and revolver must
in fact be false
and so this now is a propositional logic
representation of this game of Clue a
way of encoding the knowledge that we
know inside this game using
propositional logic that a computer
algorithm something like model checking
that we saw a moment ago can actually
look at and understand
so let's now take a look at some code to
see how this algorithm might actually
work in practice
all right so I'm now going to open up a
file called clue.pi which I've started
already and what we'll see here is I've
defined a couple of things I've defined
some symbols initially notice I have a
symbol for kernel mustard a symbol for
Professor Plum a symbol for Miss Scarlet
all of which I've put inside of this
list of characters I have a symbol for
ballroom and kitchen and library inside
of a list of rooms and then I have
symbols for knife and revolver and
wrench these are my weapons and so all
of these characters and rooms and
weapons all together those are my
symbols
and now I also have this check knowledge
function and what the check knowledge
function does is it takes my knowledge
and it's going to try and draw
conclusions about what I know
so for example we'll Loop over all of
the possible symbols and we'll check do
I know that that symbol is true and a
symbol is going to be something like
Professor Plum or the knife or the
library and if I know that it is true in
other words I know that it must be the
card in the envelope then I'm going to
print out using a function called C
print which prints things in color I'm
going to print out the word yes and I'm
going to print that in green just to
make it very clear to us
and if we're not sure that the symbol is
true maybe I can check to see if I'm
sure that the symbol is not true like if
I know for sure that it is not Professor
Plum for example and I do that by
running model check again this time
checking if my knowledge is not the
symbol if I know for sure that the
symbol is not true
and if I don't know for sure that the
symbol is not true because I say l if
not model check meaning I'm not sure
that the symbol is false well then I'll
go ahead and print out maybe next to the
symbol because maybe the symbol is true
maybe it's not I don't actually know
so what knowledge do you actually have
well let's try and represent my
knowledge now so my knowledge is I know
a couple of things so I'll put them in
an and
I know that one of the three people must
be the criminal so I know or mustard
Plum Scarlet this is my way of encoding
that it is either Colonel Mustard or
Professor Plum or Miss Scarlett I know
that it must have happened in one of the
rooms so I know or Ballroom kitchen
library for example and I know that one
of the weapons must have been used as
well so I know or knife revolver wrench
so that might be my initial knowledge
that I know that it must have been one
of the people I know it must have been
in one of the rooms and I know that it
must have been one of the weapons and I
can see what that knowledge looks like
as a formula by printing out knowledge
dot formula
so I'll run Python clue.pi and here now
is the information that I know in
logical format I know that it is Kernel
mustard or Professor Plum or Miss
Scarlett and I know that it is the
ballroom the kitchen or the library and
I know that it is the knife the revolver
or the wrench but I don't know much more
than that I can't really draw any firm
conclusions and in fact we can see that
if I try and do let me go ahead and run
my knowledge check function on my
knowledge now let's check is this
function that I or check knowledge
rather
is this function that I just wrote that
looks over all of the symbols and tries
to see what conclusions I can actually
draw about any of the symbols so I'll go
ahead and run uh clue.pi and see what it
is that I know and it seems that I don't
really know anything for sure I have all
three people or maybes all three of the
rooms are maybes all three of the
weapons are maybes I don't really know
anything for certain just yet but now
let me try and add some additional
information and see if additional
information additional knowledge can
help us to logically reason our way
through this process and we are just
going to provide the information our AI
is going to take care of doing the
inference and figuring out what
conclusions it's able to draw
so I start with some cards and those
cards tell me something so if I have the
kernel mustard card for example I know
that the mustard symbol must be false in
other words mustard is not the one in
the envelope is not the criminal so I
can say knowledge supports something
called every and in this Library
supports dot add which is a way of
adding knowledge or adding an additional
logical sentence to an and Clause so I
can say knowledge.add not mustard
right I happen to know because I have
the mustard card that kernel mustard is
not the suspect and maybe have a couple
of other cards too maybe I also have a
card for the kitchen so I know it's not
the kitchen and maybe I have another car
that says that it is not the revolver
so I have three cards Colonel Mustard
the kitchen and the revolver and I
encode that into my AI this way by
saying it's not kernel mustard it's not
the kitchen and it's not the revolver
and I know those to be true
so now when I rerun clue.pi we'll see
that I've been able to eliminate some
possibilities before I wasn't sure if it
was the knife or the revolver or the
wrench a knife with maybe a revolver
with maybe wrenches maybe now I'm down
to just the knife and the wrench between
those two I don't know which one it is
they're both maybes but I've been able
to eliminate the revolver which is one
that I know to be false because I have
the revolver card
and so additional information might be
acquired over the course of this gain
and we would represent that just by
adding knowledge to our knowledge set
our knowledge base that we've been
building here so if for example We
additionally got the information that
someone made a guess someone guessed
like uh Miss Scarlett in the library
with the wrench and we know that that a
card was revealed which means that one
of those three cards either Miss Scarlet
or the library or the wrench one of
those at minimum must not be inside of
the envelope so I could add some
knowledge say knowledge.add and I'm
going to add an or Clause because I I
don't know for sure which one it's not
but I know one of them is not in the
envelope so it's either not Scarlet or
it's not the library and or supports
multiple arguments I can say it's also
or not the wrench so at least one of
those needs Scarlet library and wrench
at least one of those needs to be false
I don't know which though maybe it's
multiple maybe it's just one but at
least one I know needs to hold
and so now if I rerun clue.pi I don't
actually have any additional information
just yet nothing I can say conclusively
I still know that maybe it's Professor
Plum maybe it's Miss Scarlet I haven't
eliminated any options but let's imagine
that I get some more information which
someone shows me the professor Plum card
for example so I say all right let's go
back here knowledge dot add not
plum
so I didn't have the professor Plum card
I know that Professor Plum is not in the
middle I rerun clue.pi and or right now
I'm able to draw some conclusions now
I've been able to eliminate Professor
Plum and the only person that could left
remaining be is Miss Scarlett so I know
yes Miss Scarlett this variable must be
true and I've been able to infer that
based on the information I already had
now between the ballroom and the library
and the knife and the wrench for those
two I'm still not sure so let's add one
more piece of information
let's say that I know that it's not the
ballroom someone has shown me the
ballroom card so I know it's not the
ballroom which means at this point I
should be able to conclude that it's the
library let's see I'll say knowledge dot
add not
the ballroom
and we'll go ahead and run that
and it turns out that after all of this
not only can I conclude that I know that
it's the library but I also know that
the weapon was the knife and that might
have been an inference that was a little
bit trickier something I wouldn't have
realized immediately but the AI via this
model checking algorithm is able to draw
that conclusion that we know for sure
that it must be Miss Scarlet in the
library with the knife and how did we
know that well we know it
from this or Clause up here that we know
that it's either not Scarlet or it's not
the library or it's not the wrench and
given that we know that it is Miss
scarlet and we know that it is the
library then the only remaining option
for the weapon is that it is not the
wrench which means that it must be the
knife so we as humans now can go back
and reason through that even though it
might not have been immediately clear
and that's one of the advantages of
using an AI or some sort of algorithm in
order to do this is that the computer
can exhaust all of these possibilities
and try and figure out what the solution
actually should be
and so for that reason it's often
helpful to be able to represent
knowledge in this way knowledge
engineering some situation where we can
use a computer to be able to represent
knowledge and draw conclusions based on
that knowledge and anytime we can
translate something into propositional
logic symbols like this this type of
approach can be useful so you might be
familiar with logic puzzles where you
have to puzzle your way through trying
to figure something out this is what a
classic logic puzzle might look like
something like gilderoy Minerva Pomona
and Horus each belong to a different one
of the four houses Gryffindor Hufflepuff
Ravenclaw and Slytherin and then we have
some information the gilderoy belongs to
Gryffindor or Ravenclaw Pomona does not
belong in Slytherin and Minerva does
belong to Gryffindor so we have a couple
pieces of information and using that
information we need to be able to draw
some conclusions about which person
should be assigned to which house and
again we can use the exact same idea to
try and implement this notion so we need
some propositional symbols and in this
case the propositional symbols are going
to get a little more complex although
we'll see ways to make this a little bit
cleaner later on but we'll need 16
propositional symbols one for each
person and house so we need to say
remember every propositional symbol is
either true or false so gilderoy
Gryffindor is either true or false
either he's in Gryffindor or he is not
likewise gilderoy Hufflepuff also true
or false either it is true or it's false
and that's true for every combination of
person and house that we could come up
with we have some sort of propositional
symbol for each one of those
using this type of knowledge we can then
begin to think about what types of
logical sentences we can say about the
puzzle that if we know before we even
think about the information we were
given we can think about the premise of
the problem that every person is
assigned to a different house
so what does that tell us well it tells
us sentences like this it tells us like
Pomona Slytherin implies not Pomona
Hufflepuff something like if Pomona is
in Slytherin then we know that Pomona is
not in Hufflepuff and we know this for
all four people and for all combinations
of houses that no matter what person you
pick if they're in one house then
they're not in some other house so I'll
probably have a whole bunch of knowledge
statements that are of this form that if
we know pomonas and Slytherin then we
know Pomona is not in Hufflepuff we were
also given the information that each
person is in a different house so I also
have pieces of knowledge that look
something like this Minerva Ravenclaw
implies not gilderoy Ravenclaw if
they're all in different houses than if
Minerva is in Ravenclaw then we know the
guild Roy is not in Ravenclaw as well
and I have a whole bunch of similar
sentences like this that are expressing
that idea for other people and other
houses as well and so in addition to
sentences of these form I also have the
knowledge that was given to me
information like gilderoy was in
Gryffindor or in Ravenclaw that would be
represented like this Gilroy Gryffindor
or gilderoy Ravenclaw and then using
these sorts of sentences I can begin to
draw some conclusions about the world
so let's see an example of this we'll go
ahead and actually try and implement
this logic puzzle to see if we can
figure out what the answer is
I'll go ahead and open up puzzle.pi
where I've already started to implement
this sort of idea I've defined a list of
people and a list of houses and I've so
far created one symbol for every person
and for every house that's what this
double for Loop is doing looping over
all people looping over all houses
creating a new symbol for each of them
and then I've added some information I
know that every person belongs to a
house so I've added the information for
every person
that person Gryffindor or person
Hufflepuff or person Ravenclaw or person
Slytherin that one of those four things
must be true every person belongs to a
house what other information do I know I
also know that only one house per person
so no person belongs to multiple houses
so how does this work well this is going
to be true for all people so I'll Loop
over every person
and then I need to Loop over all
different pairs of houses the idea is I
want to encode the idea that if Minerva
is in Gryffindor then Minerva can't be
in Ravenclaw so I'll Loop over all
houses each one and I'll Loop over all
houses again H2
and as long as they're different H1 not
equal to H2
then I'll add to my knowledge base this
piece of information that implication in
other words an if then if the person is
in H1 then I know that they are not
in-house H2
so these lines here are encoding the
notion that for every person if they
belong to house one then they are not in
house two
and the other piece of logic we need to
encode is the idea that every house can
only have one person in other words if
Pomona is in Hufflepuff then nobody else
is allowed to be in Hufflepuff either
and that's the same logic but sort of
backwards I Loop over all of the houses
and loop over all different pairs of
people so I Loop over people once Loop
over people again and only do this when
the people are different P1 not equal to
P2
and I add the knowledge that if as given
by the implication
if person one belongs to the house then
it is not the case that person two
belongs to the same house
so here I'm just encoding the knowledge
that represents the problem's
constraints I know that everyone's in a
different house I know that any person
can only belong to one house and I can
now take my knowledge and try and print
out the information that I happen to
know so I'll go ahead and print out
knowledge.formula just to see this in
action and I'll go ahead and skip this
for now but we'll come back to this in a
second
let's print out the knowledge that I
know by running python puzzle.pi it's a
lot of information a lot that I have to
scroll through because there's 16
different variables all going on but the
basic idea if we scroll up to the very
top is I see my initial information
gilderoy is either in Gryffindor or
gilderoy is in Hufflepuff or gilduroys
and Ravenclaw or gilderoyes and
Slytherin and and then way more
information as well so this is quite
messy more than we really want to be
looking at and soon too we'll see ways
of representing this a little bit more
nicely using logic but for now we can
just say these are the variables that
we're dealing with and now we'd like to
add some information
so the information we're going to add is
gilderoy is in Gryffindor or he is in
Ravenclaw so that knowledge was given to
us so I'll go ahead and say knowledge
dot add
and I know that either or
gilderoy Gryffindor
or
gilderoy Ravenclaw one of those two
things must be true
I also know that Pomona was not in
Slytherin so I can say knowledge.add not
this symbol not the Pomona Slytherin
symbol and then I can add the knowledge
that Minerva is in Gryffindor by adding
the symbol Minerva Gryffindor
so those are the pieces of knowledge
that I know and this Loop here at the
bottom just Loops over all of my symbols
checks to see if the knowledge entails
that symbol by calling this model check
function again
and if it does if we know the symbol is
true we print out the symbol
so now I can run Python puzzle.pi and
python is going to solve this puzzle for
me we're able to conclude that gilderoy
belongs to Ravenclaw Pomona belongs to
Hufflepuff Minerva to Gryffindor and
Horus to Slytherin just by encoding this
knowledge inside the computer although
it was quite tedious to do in this case
and as a result we were able to get the
conclusion from that as well
and you can imagine this being applied
to many sorts of different deductive
situations so not only these situations
where we're trying to deal with Harry
Potter characters in this puzzle but if
you've ever played games like Mastermind
where you're trying to figure out which
order different colors go in and trying
to make predictions about it I could
tell you for example let's play a
simplified version of Mastermind where
there are four colors red blue green and
yellow and they're in some order but I'm
not telling you what order you just have
to make a guess and I'll tell you of red
blue green and yellow how many of the
four you got in the right position so a
simplified version of this game you
might make a guess like red blue green
yellow and I would tell you something
like two of those four are in the
correct position but the other two are
not
then you could reasonably make a guess
and say all right let's try this blue
red green yellow try switching two of
them around and this time maybe I tell
you you know what none of those are in
the correct position
and the question then is all right what
is the correct order of these four
colors and we as humans could begin to
reason this through all right well if
none of these were correct but two of
these were correct well it must have
been because I switched the red and the
blue which means red and blue here must
be correct which means green and yellow
are probably not correct you can begin
to do this sort of deductive reasoning
we can also equivalently try and take
this and encode it inside of our
computer as well and it's going to be
very similar to the logic puzzle that we
just did a moment ago so I won't spend
too much time on this code because it is
fairly similar but again we have a whole
bunch of colors and four different
positions in which those colors can be
and then we have some additional
knowledge and I encode all of that
knowledge and you can take a look at
this code on your own time but I just
want to demonstrate that when we run
this code run python
mastermind.pi and run and see what we
get we ultimately are able to compute
red 0 in the zero position blue in the
one position yellow in the two position
and green in the three position as The
Ordering of those symbols now ultimately
what you might have noticed is this
process was taking quite a long time and
in fact model checking is not a
particularly efficient algorithm right
what I need to do in order to model
check is take all of my possible
different variables and enumerate all of
the possibilities that they could be it
if I have n variables I have 2 to the N
possible worlds that I need to be
looking through in order to perform this
model checking algorithm and this is
probably not tractable especially as we
start to get to much larger and larger
sets of data we have many many more
variables that are at play right here we
only have a relatively small number of
variables so this sort of approach can
actually work but as the number of
variables increases model checking
becomes less and less good of a way of
trying to solve these sorts of problems
so while it might have been okay for
something like Mastermind to conclude
that this is indeed the correct sequence
where all four are in the correct
position what we'd like to do is come up
with some better ways to be able to make
inferences rather than just enumerate
all of the possibilities and to do so
what we'll transition to next is the
idea of inference rules some sort of
rules that we can apply to take
knowledge that already exists and
translate it into new forms of knowledge
and the general way will structure an
inference rule is by having a horizontal
line here anything above the line is
going to represent a premise something
that we know to be true
and then anything below the line will be
the conclusion that we can arrive at
after we apply the logic or from the
inference rule that we're going to
demonstrate so we'll do some of these
inference rules is by demonstrating them
in English first but then translating
them into the world of propositional
logic so you can see what those
inference rules actually look like
so for example let's imagine that I have
access to two pieces of information I
know for example that if it is raining
then Harry is inside for example and
let's say I also know it is rating
then most of us could reasonably then
look at this information and conclude
that all right Harry must be inside
this inference rule is known as modus
ponens and it's phrased more formally in
logic as this if we know that Alpha
implies beta in other words if Alpha
then beta and we also know that Alpha is
true
then we should be able to conclude that
beta is also true we can apply this
inference rule to take these two pieces
of information and generate this new
piece of information notice that this is
a totally different approach from the
model checking approach where the
approach was look at all of the possible
worlds and see what's true in each of
these worlds here we're not dealing with
any specific World we're just dealing
with the knowledge that we know and what
conclusions we can arrive at based on
that knowledge that I know that a
implies B and I know a and the
conclusion is B and this should seem
like a relatively obvious rule but of
course if Alpha then beta and we know
Alpha then we should be able to conclude
that beta is also true and that's going
to be true for many but maybe even all
of the inference rules that we'll take a
look at you should be able to look at
them and say yeah of course that's going
to be true but it's putting these all
together figuring out the right
combination of inference rules that can
be applied that ultimately is going to
allow us to will generate interesting
knowledge inside of our AI so that's
modus ponens's application of
implication that if we know Alpha and we
know that Alpha implies beta then we can
conclude beta
let's take a look at another example
fairly straightforward something like
Harry is friends with Ron and Hermione
based on that information we can
reasonably conclude Harry is friends
with Hermione that must also be true
and this inference rule is known as and
elimination in the what and elimination
says is that if we have a situation
where Alpha and beta are both true I
have information Alpha and beta will
then
just Alpha is true or likewise just beta
is true that if I know that both parts
are true then one of those parts must
also be true again something obvious
from the point of view of human
intuition but a computer needs to be
told this kind of information to be able
to apply the inference rule we need to
tell the computer that this is an
inference rule that you can apply so the
computer has access to it and is able to
use it in order to translate information
from one form to another
in addition to that let's take a look at
another example of an inference rule
something like it is not true that Harry
did not pass the test
bit of a tricky sentence to parcel read
it again it is not true or it is false
that Harry did not pass the test well if
it is false that Harry did not pass the
test then the only reasonable conclusion
is that Harry did pass the test
and so this instead of being and
elimination is what we call Double
negation elimination that if we have two
negatives inside of our premise then we
can just remove them all together they
cancel each other out one turns true to
false and the other one turns false back
into true phrased a little bit more
formally we say that if the premise is
not not Alpha then the conclusion we can
draw is just Alpha we can say that Alpha
is true
we'll take a look at a couple more of
these if I have it is raining then Harry
is inside
how do I reframe this well this one is a
little bit trickier but if I know if it
is raining then Harry is inside then I
conclude one of two things must be true
either it is not raining or Harry is
inside now this one's trickier so let's
think about it a little bit this first
premise here if it is raining then Harry
is inside is saying that if I know that
it is raining then Harry must be inside
so what is the other possible case well
if Harry is not inside then I know that
it must not be raining so one of those
two situations must be true either it's
not raining or it is raining in which
case Harry is inside so the conclusion I
can draw is either it is not written
or it is raining so therefore Harry is
inside and so this is a way to translate
if then statements into or statements
and this is known as implication
elimination and this is similar to what
we actually did in the beginning when we
were first looking at those very first
sentences about Harry and Hagrid and
Dumbledore and phrased a little bit more
formally this says that if I have the
implication Alpha implies beta that I
can draw the conclusion that either not
alpha or beta because there are only two
possibilities either Alpha is true or
Alpha is not true so one of those
possibilities is Alpha is not true but
if Alpha is true well then we can draw
the conclusion that beta must be true so
either Alpha is not true
or Alpha is true in which case beta is
also true so this is one way to turn an
implication into just a statement about
or in addition to eliminating
implications we can also eliminate
biconditionals as well so let's take an
English example something like it is
raining if and only if Harry is inside
and this if and only if really sounds
like that biconditional that double
arrow sign that we saw in propositional
logic not too long ago and what does
this actually mean if we were to
translate this well this means that if
it is raining then Harry is inside and
if Harry is inside then it is raining
that this implication goes both ways and
this is what we would call biconditional
elimination that I can take a
biconditional a if and only if B and
translate that into something like this
a implies B and B implies a so many of
these inference rules are taking logic
that uses certain symbols and turning
them into different symbols taking an
implication and turning it into an or or
taking a biconditional and turning it
into implication and another example of
it would be something like this it is
not true that both Harry and Ron passed
the test
well all right how do we translate that
what does that mean well if it is not
true that both of them pass the test
well then the reasonable conclusion we
might draw is that at least one of them
didn't pass the test so the conclusion
is either Harry did not pass the test or
Ron did not pass the test or both this
is not an exclusive or but if it is true
that it is not true that both Harry and
Ron passed the test will then either
Harry didn't pass the test or wrong
didn't pass the test
and this type of law is one of De
Morgan's laws quite famous in logic
where the idea is that we can turn an
and into an or we can say we can take
this and that both Harry and Ron passed
the test and turn it into an or by
moving the knot around so if it is not
true that Harry and Ron passed the test
well then either Harry did not pass the
test or Ron did not pass the test either
and the way we frame that more formally
using logic is to say this if it is not
true that Alpha and beta well then
either not alpha or not beta
the way I like to think about this is
that if you have a negation in front of
an and expression you move the negation
inwards so to speak moving the negation
into each of these individual sentences
and then flip the and into an or for the
negation move inwards and the and flips
into an or so I go from Not A and B to
not a or not b
and there's actually a reverse of De
Morgan's law that goes in the other
direction for something like this if I
say it is not true that Harry or Ron
passed the test meaning neither of them
passed the test well the conclusion I
can draw is that Harry did not pass the
test and Ron did not pass the test so in
this case instead of turning an and into
an or we're turning an or into an and
but the idea is the same and this again
is another example of De Morgan's laws
and the way that works is that if I have
not a or b this time the same logic is
going to apply I'm going to move the
negation inwards and I'm going to flip
this time flip the or into an and so if
not a or b meaning it is not true that a
or b or alpha or beta then I can say not
Alpha and not beta moving the negation
inwards in order to make that conclusion
so those are de Morgan's laws and a
couple other inference rules that are
worth just taking a look at one is the
distributive law that works this way so
if I have Alpha and beta or gamma
well then much in the same way that you
can use in math use distributive laws to
distribute operands like addition and
multiplication I can do a similar thing
here where I can say if Alpha and beta
or gamma then I can say something like
Alpha and beta or Alpha and Gamma that
I've been able to distribute this and
sign throughout this expression so this
is an example of the distributive
property or the distributive law as
applied to logic in much the same way
that you would distribute like a
multiplication over the addition of
something for example
this works the other way too so if for
example I have alpha or beta and gamma I
can distribute the or throughout the
expression I can say alpha or beta and
Alpha or gamma so the distributive law
Works in that way too and it's helpful
if I want to take an or and move it into
the expression and we'll see an example
soon of why it is that we might actually
care to do something like that
all right so now we've seen a lot of
different inference rules and the
question now is how can we use those
inference rules to actually try and draw
some conclusions to actually try and
prove something about entailment proving
that given some initial knowledge base
we would like to find some way to prove
that a query is true
well one way to think about it is
actually to think back to what we talked
about last time when we talked about
search problems recall again that search
problems have some sort of initial State
they have actions that you can take from
one state to another as defined by a
transition model that tells you how to
get from one state to another we talked
about testing to see if you're at a goal
and then some path cost function to see
you know how many steps did you have to
take or how costly was the solution that
you found
now that we have these inference rules
that take some set of sentences and
propositional logic and get us some new
set of sentences in propositional logic
we can actually treat those sentences or
those sets of sentences as States inside
of a search problem so if we want to
prove that some query is true prove that
some logical theorem is true we can
treat theorem proving as a form of a
search problem I can say that we begin
in some initial state where that initial
state is the knowledge base that I begin
with the set of all of the sentences
that I know to be true
what actions are available to me well
the actions are any of the inference
rules that I can apply at any given time
the transition model just tells me after
I apply the inference rule here is the
new set of all of the knowledge that I
have which will be the old set of
knowledge plus some additional inference
that I've been able to draw much as in
the same way we saw what we got when we
applied those inference rules and got
some sort of conclusion that conclusion
gets added to our knowledge base and our
transition model we'll encode that
what is the goal test well our goal test
is you know checking to see if we have
proved the statement we're trying to
prove if the thing we're trying to prove
is inside of our knowledge base
and the path cost function the thing
we're trying to minimize is maybe the
number of inference rules that we needed
to use the number of steps so to speak
inside of our proof
and so here we've been able to apply the
same types of ideas that we saw last
time with search problems to something
like trying to prove something about
knowledge by taking our knowledge and
framing it in terms that we can
understand as a search problem with an
initial state with actions with a
transition model so this shows up a
couple of things one being how versatile
search problems are that they can be the
same types of algorithms that we use to
solve a maze or figure out how to get
from point A to point B inside of
driving directions for example can also
be used as a theorem proving method of
taking some sort of starting knowledge
base and trying to prove something about
that knowledge
so this yet again is a second way in
addition to model checking to try and
prove that certain statements are true
but it turns out there's yet another way
that we can try and apply inference and
we'll talk about this now which is not
the only way but certainly one of the
most common which is known as resolution
and resolution is based on another
inference rule that we'll take a look at
now quite a powerful inference rule that
will let us prove anything that can be
proven about a knowledge base and it's
based on this basic idea let's say I
know that either Ron is in the great
hall or Hermione is in the library
and let's say I also know that Ron is
not in the Great Hall
based on those two pieces of information
what can I conclude
well I could pretty reasonably conclude
that Hermione must be in the library how
do I know that well it's because these
two statements these two what we'll call
complementary literals literals that
complement each other they're opposites
of each other
seem to conflict with each other this
sentence tells us that either Ron is in
the great hall or Hermione is in the
library
so if we know that Ron is not in the
Great Hall that conflicts with this one
which means Hermione must be in the
library
and this we can frame as a more general
rule known as the unit resolution rule a
rule that says that if we have P or Q
and we also know not p
well then from that we can reasonably
conclude q that if P or Q are true and
we know that P is not true the only
possibility is for Q to then be true
and this it turns out is quite a
powerful inference rule in terms of what
it can do in part because we can quickly
start to generalize this rule this Q
right here doesn't need to just be a
single propositional symbol it could be
multiple all chained together in a
single Clause as we'll call it so if I
had something like P or q1 or Q2 or Q3
so on and so forth up until qn so I had
n different other variables and I have
not p
well then what happens when these two
complement each other is that these two
Clauses resolve so to speak to produce a
new Clause that is just q1 or Q2 all the
way up to qn and in an or the order of
the arguments in the order doesn't
actually matter the P doesn't need to be
the first thing it could have been in
the middle but the idea here is that if
I have p in one clause and not p in the
other Clause well then I know that one
of these remaining things must be true
I've resolved them in order to produce a
new clause
but it turns out we can generalize this
idea even further in fact and display
even more power that we can have with
this resolution rule so let's take
another example
let's say for instance that I know the
same piece of information that either
Ron is in the great hall or Hermione is
in the library
and the second piece of information I
know is that Ron is not in the great
hall or Harry is sleeping
so it's not just a single piece of
information I have two different Clauses
and we'll Define Clauses more precisely
in just a moment
what do I know here well again for any
propositional symbol like Ron is in the
Great Hall there are only two
possibilities either Ron is in the Great
Hall in which case based on resolution
we know that Harry must be sleeping
or Ron is not in the Great Hall
in which case we know based on the same
rule that Hermione must be in the
library
based on those two things in combination
I can say based on these two premises
that I can conclude that either Hermione
is in the library or Harry is leaving
so again because these two conflict with
each other I know that one of these two
must be true and you can take a closer
look and try and reason through that
logic make sure you convince yourself
that you believe this conclusion stated
more generally we can name this
resolution rule by saying that if we
know P or Q is true
and we also know that not P or R is true
we resolve these two Clauses together to
get a new Clause Q or r that either Q or
R must be true
and again much as in the last case Q and
R don't need to just be single
propositional symbols it could be
multiple symbols so if I had a rule that
had a p or q1 or Q2 or Q3 so on and so
forth up until qn where n is just some
number and likewise
I had not P or R1 or R2 so on and so
forth up until RM where M again
is just some other number I can resolve
these two Clauses together to get one of
these must be true q1 or Q2 up until qn
or R1 or R2 up until RM and this is just
a generalization of that same rule we
saw before
each of these things here are we're
going to call a clause where a clause is
formally defined as a disjunction of
literals where a disjunction means it's
a bunch of things that are connected
with or disjunction means things
connected with or conjunction meanwhile
as things connected with and and a
literal is either a propositional symbol
or the opposite of a propositional
symbol so it's something like P or Q or
not P or not Q those are all
propositional symbols or not of the
propositional symbols and we call those
literals
so a clause is just something like this
P or Q or R for example
meanwhile what this gives us an ability
to do is it gives us an ability to turn
logic any logical sentence into
something called conjunctive normal form
a conjunctive normal form sentence is a
logical sentence that is a conjunction
of Clauses recall again conjunction
means things are connected to one
another using and and so a conjunction
of Clauses means it is an and of
individual Clauses Each of which has
ores in it so something like this A or B
or C and D or not e and f or G
everything in parentheses is one Clause
all of the Clauses are connected to each
other using an and everything in the
Clause is separated using an or
and this is just a standard form that we
can translate a logical sentence into
that just makes it easy to work with and
easy to manipulate and it turns out that
we can take any sentence in logic and
turn it into conjunctive normal form
just by applying some inference rules
and transformations to it so we'll take
a look at how we can actually do that
so what is the process for taking a
logical formula and converting it into
conjunctive normal form otherwise known
as CNF well the process looks a little
something like this we need to take all
of the symbols that are not part of
conjunctive normal form the
biconditionals and the implications and
so forth and turn them into something
that is more closely like conjunctive
normal form so the first step will be to
eliminate biconditionals those if and
only if double arrows and we know how to
eliminate biconditionals because we saw
there was an inference rule to do just
that anytime I have an expression like
Alpha if and only if beta I can turn
that into Alpha implies beta and beta
implies Alpha based on that inference
rule we saw before
likewise in addition to eliminating
biconditionals I can eliminate
implications as well the if then arrows
and I can do that using the same
inference rule we saw before too taking
Alpha implies beta and turning that into
not alpha or beta because that is a
logically equivalent to this first thing
here
then we can move knots inwards because
we don't want knots on the outsides of
our Expressions conjunctive normal form
requires that it's just Claws and Claws
and Claws and Claws any knots need to be
immediately next to propositional
symbols but we can move those knots
around using de Morgan's laws by taking
something like not a and b and turn it
into not a or not B for example using
Morgan's laws to manipulate that and
after that all we'll be left with are
ands and ORS and those are easy to deal
with we can use the distributive law to
distribute the ORS so that the ores end
up on the inside of the expression so to
speak and the ands end up on the outside
so this is the general pattern for how
we'll take a formula and convert it into
conjunctive normal form and let's now
take a look at an example of how we
would do this and explore then why it is
that we would want to do something like
this
here's how we can do it let's take this
formula for example P or Q implies R and
I'd like to convert this into
conjunctive normal form where it's all
ands of Clauses and every Clause is a
disjunctive clause it's ores together
so what's the first thing I need to do
well this is an implication so let me go
ahead and remove that implication using
the implication inference rule I can
turn P or Q into a p or Q implies R into
not P or Q or r
so that's the first step I've gotten rid
of the implication
and next I can get rid of the knot on
the outside of this expression too I can
move the knots inwards so they're closer
to the literals
themselves by using de Morgan's laws and
de Morgan's law says that not P or Q is
equivalent to not p and not Q again here
just applying the inference rules that
we've already seen in order to translate
these statements
and now I have two things that are
separated by an or where this thing on
the inside is an and what I'd really
like to move the ore so the oars are on
the inside because conjunctive normal
form means I need clause and clause and
clause and Claws and so to do that I can
use the distributive law if I have not p
and not Q or r i can distribute the or R
to both of these to get not P or R and
not Q or R using the distributive law
and this now here at the bottom is in
conjunctive normal form it is a
conjunction an and of disjunctions of
Clauses that just are separated by ores
so this process can be used by any
formula to take a logical sentence and
turn it into this conjunctive normal
form where I have claws and Claws and
Claws and Claws and Claws and so on
so why is this helpful why do we even
care about taking all these sentences
and converting them into this form it's
because once they're in this form where
we have these Clauses these Clauses are
the inputs to the resolution inference
rule that we saw a moment ago that if I
have two Clauses where there's something
that conflicts or something
complementary between those two clauses
I can resolve them to get a new Clause
to draw a new conclusion and we call
this process inference by resolution
using the resolution rule to draw some
sort of inference and it's based on the
same idea that if I have P or Q This
clause and I have not P or r that I can
resolve these two Clauses together to
get Q or r as the resulting Clause a new
piece of information that I didn't have
before
now a couple of key points that are
worth noting about this before we talk
about the actual algorithm one thing is
that let's imagine we have P or Q or S
and I also have not P or r or S the
resolution rule says that because this P
conflicts with this not P we would
resolve to put everything else together
to get Q or s or r or s
but it turns out that this double s is
redundant or S here and or S there it
doesn't change the meaning of the
sentence so in resolution when we do
this resolution process we'll usually
also do a process known as factoring
where we take any duplicate variables
that show up and just eliminate them so
Q or s or r or S just becomes Q or r or
S the S only needs to appear once no
need to include it multiple times
now one final question worth considering
is what happens if I try to resolve p
and not P together if I know that P is
true and I know that not p is true well
resolution says I can merge these
Clauses together and look at everything
else well in this case there is nothing
else so I'm left with what we might call
the empty Clause I'm left with nothing
and the empty Clause is always false the
empty Clause is equivalent to just being
false and that's pretty reasonable
because it's impossible for both p and
not P to both hold at the same time p is
either true or it's not true which means
that if p is true then this must be
false and if this is true then this must
be false there's no way for both of
these to hold at the same time so if
ever I try and resolve these two it's a
contradiction and I'll end up getting
this empty Clause where the empty Clause
I can call equivalent to false
and this idea that if I resolve these
two contradictory terms I get the empty
Clause this is the basis for our
inference by resolution algorithm here's
how we're going to perform inference by
resolution at a very high level
we want to prove that our knowledge base
entails some query Alpha that based on
the knowledge we have we can prove
conclusively that Alpha is going to be
true
how are we going to do that well in
order to do that we're going to try to
prove that if we know the knowledge and
not Alpha that that would be a
contradiction and this is a common
technique in computer science more
generally this idea of proving something
by contradiction if I want to prove that
something is true I can do so by first
assuming that it is false and showing
that it would be contradictory showing
that it leads to some contradiction and
if the thing I'm trying to prove if when
I assume it's false leads to a
contradiction then it must be true and
that's the logical approach or the idea
behind a proof by contradiction and
that's what we're going to do here we
want to prove that this query Alpha is
true so we're going to assume that it's
not true we're going to assume not Alpha
and we're going to try and prove that
it's a contradiction
if we do get a contradiction well then
we know that our knowledge entails the
query Alpha if we don't get a
contradiction there is no entailment
this is this idea of a proof by
contradiction of assuming the opposite
of what you're trying to prove and if
you can demonstrate that that's a
contradiction then what you're proving
must be true
but more formally how do we actually do
this how do we check that knowledge base
and not Alpha is going to lead to a
contradiction well here is where
resolution comes into play
to determine if our knowledge base
entails some query Alpha we're going to
convert knowledge base and not Alpha to
conjunctive normal form that form where
we have a whole bunch of Clauses that
are all ended together
and when we have these individual
Clauses now we can keep checking to see
if we can use resolution to produce a
new Clause right we can take any pair of
Clauses and check is there some literal
that is the opposite of each other or
complementary to each other in both of
them for example I have a p in one
clause and a not p in another clause or
an r in one clause and a not R in
another Clause If Ever I have that
situation where once I convert to
conjunctive normal form and I have a
whole bunch of clauses I see two Clauses
that I can resolve to produce a new
Clause then I'll do so this process
occurs in a loop I'm going to keep
checking to see if I can use resolution
to produce a new clause and keep using
those new Clauses to try to generate
more new Clauses after that
now a dress so may happen that
eventually we may produce the empty
Clause the Clause we were talking about
before if I resolve p and not P together
that produces the empty clause and the
empty Clause we know to be false because
we know that there's no way for both p
and not P to both simultaneously be true
so if ever we produce the empty Clause
then we have a contradiction
and if we have a contradiction that's
exactly what we were trying to do in a
fruit by contradiction if we have a
contradiction then we know that our
knowledge base must entail this query
Alpha we know that Alpha must be true
and it turns out and we won't go into
the proof here but you can show that
otherwise if you don't produce the empty
Clause then there is no entailment if we
run into a situation where there are no
more new Clauses to add we've done all
the resolution that we can do and yet we
still haven't produced The Empty Clause
then there is no entailment in this case
and this now is the resolution algorithm
and it's very abstract looking
especially this idea of like what does
it even mean to have the empty Clause so
let's take a look at an example actually
try and prove some entailment by using
this inference by resolution process
so here's our question we have this
knowledge base here's the knowledge that
we know A or B and not b or c and not C
and we want to know if all of this
entails a
so this is our knowledge base here this
whole long thing in our query Alpha is
just this propositional symbol a
so what do we do well first we want to
prove by contradiction so we want to
First assume that a is false and see if
that leads to some sort of contradiction
so here's what we're going to start with
A or B and not b or c and not C this is
our knowledge base
and we're going to assume not a we're
going to assume that the thing we're
trying to prove is in fact false
and so this is now in conjunctive normal
form and I have four different clauses I
have a or b I have not b or c I have not
C and I have not a
and now I can begin to just pick two
Clauses that I can resolve and apply the
resolution rule to them
and so looking at these four clauses I
see all right
these two Clauses are ones I can resolve
I can resolve them because there are
complementary literals that show up in
them there's a c here and a not C here
so just looking at these two Clauses if
I know that not b or c is true
and I know that c is not true
well then I can resolve these two
Clauses to say all right not B that must
be true I can generate this new Clause
as a new piece of information that I now
know to be true
and all right now I can repeat this
process do the process again can I use
resolution again to get some new
conclusion well it turns out I can I can
use that new Clause I just generated
along with this one here there are
complementary literals this B is
complementary to or conflicts with this
not B over here and so if I know that A
or B is true
and I know that b is not true well then
the only remaining possibility is that a
must be true so now we have a that is a
new Clause that I've been able to
generate
and now I can do this one more time I'm
looking for two Clauses that can be
resolved and you might programmatically
do this by just looping over all
possible pairs of Clauses and checking
for complementary literals in each and
here I can say all right I found two
Clauses not a an a that conflict with
each other
and when I resolve these two together
well this is the same as when we're
resolving p and not P from before when I
resolve these two Clauses together I get
rid of the A's and I'm left with the
empty clause and the empty Clause we
know to be false which means we have a
contradiction which means we can safely
say that this whole knowledge base does
entail a that if this sentence is true
that we know that a for sure is also
true
so this now using inference by
resolution is an entirely different way
to take some statement and try and prove
that it is in fact true instead of
enumerating all of the possible worlds
that we might be in in order to try to
figure out in which cases is the
knowledge base true and in which case is
our query true instead we use this
resolution algorithm to say let's keep
trying to figure out what conclusions we
can draw and see if we reach a
contradiction and if we reach a
contradiction and that tells us
something about whether our knowledge
actually entails the query or not and it
turns out there are many different
algorithms that can be used for
Instagram inference what we've just
looked at here are just a couple of them
and in fact all of this is just based on
one particular type of logic it's based
on propositional logic where we have
these individual symbols and we connect
them using and and or and not and
implies and by conditionals but
propositional logic is not the only kind
of logic that exists and in fact we see
that there are limitations that exist in
propositional logic especially as we saw
thought in examples like with the
Mastermind example or with the example
with the logic puzzle where we had
different uh Hogwarts house people that
belong to different houses and we were
trying to figure out who belonged to
which houses there were a lot of
different propositional symbols that we
needed in order to represent some fairly
basic ideas so now as a final topic that
we'll take a look at just before we end
class today is one final type of logic
different from propositional logic known
as first order logic which is a little
bit more powerful than propositional
logic and is going to make it easier for
us to express certain types of ideas in
propositional logic if we think back to
that puzzle with the people in the
Hogwarts houses we had a whole bunch of
symbols and every symbol could only be
true or false right we had a symbol for
Minerva Gryffindor which was either true
if Minerva was in Gryffindor and false
otherwise and likewise for Minerva
Hufflepuff and Minerva Ravenclaw and
Minerva Slytherin and so forth
but this was starting to get quite
redundant that we wanted some way to be
able to express that there's a
relationship between these propositional
symbols that Minerva shows up in all of
them and also I would have liked to have
not have had so many different symbols
to represent what really was a fairly
straightforward problem
so first order logic will give us a
different way of trying to deal with
this idea by giving us two different
types of symbols we're going to have
constant symbols that are going to
represent objects like people or houses
and then predicate symbols
which you can think of as relations or
functions that take an input and
evaluate them to like true or false for
example that tell us whether or not some
property of some constant or some pair
of constants or multiple constants
actually holds so we'll see an example
of that in just a moment but for now in
this same problem are constant symbols
might be objects things like people or
houses some Minerva Pomona Horus
gilderoy those are all constant symbols
as are my four houses Gryffindor
Hufflepuff Ravenclaw and Slytherin
predicates meanwhile these predicate
symbols are going to be properties that
might hold true or false of these
individual constants so person might
hold true of Minerva but it would be
false for Gryffindor because Gryffindor
is not a person and house which is going
to hold true for Ravenclaw but it's not
going to hold true for Horus for example
because Horus is a person
and belongs to Meanwhile is going to be
some relation that is going to relate
people to their houses it's going to
only tell me when someone belongs to a
house or does not
so let's take a look at some examples of
what a sentence in first order logic
might actually look like a sentence
might look like something like this
person Minerva with Minerva in
parentheses and person being a predicate
symbol Minerva being a constant symbol
this sentence in first order logic
effectively means Minerva is a person or
the person property applies to the
Minerva object so if I want to say
something like Minerva as a person here
is how I express that idea using first
order logic
meanwhile I can say something like house
Gryffindor to likewise express the idea
that Gryffindor is a house I can do that
this way and all of the same logical
connectives we saw in propositional
logic those are going to work here too
so and or implication biconditional not
in fact I can use not to say something
like not house Minerva and this sentence
in first order logic means something
like Minerva is not a house it is not
true that the house property applies to
Minerva
meanwhile in addition to some of these
predicate symbols that just take a
single argument some of our predicate
symbols are going to express binary
relations relations between two of its
arguments so I could say something like
belongs to and then two inputs Minerva
and Gryffindor to express the idea that
Minerva belongs to Gryffindor and so now
here's the key difference or one of the
key differences between this and
propositional logic in propositional
logic I needed one symbol for Minerva
Gryffindor and one symbol for Minerva
Hufflepuff and one symbol for all the
other people's Gryffindor and Hufflepuff
variables in this case I just need one
symbol for each of my people and one
symbol for each of my houses
and then I can express as a predicate
something like belongs to and say
belongs to Minerva Gryffindor to express
the idea that Minerva belongs to
Gryffindor House so already we can see
that first order logic is quite
expressive in being able to express
these sorts of sentences using the
existing constant symbols and predicates
that already exist while minimizing the
number of new symbols that I need to
create I can just use eight symbols for
people for houses instead of 16 symbols
for every possible combination of each
but first order logic gives us a couple
of additional features that we can use
to express even more complex ideas and
these morphe additional features are
generally known as quantifiers and there
are two main quantifiers in first order
Logic the first of which is universal
quantification Universal quantification
lets me Express an idea like something
is going to be true for all values of a
variable like for all values of X some
statement is going to hold true
so what made a sentence in Universal
quantification look like well we're
going to use this upside down a to mean
for all so upside down ax means for all
values of X where X is any object this
is going to hold true
belongs to X Gryffindor implies not
belongs to X Hufflepuff
so let's try and parse this out this
means that for all values of x if this
holds true if x belongs to Gryffindor
then this does not hold true X does not
belong to Hufflepuff
so translated into English this sentence
is saying something like for all objects
x if x belongs to Gryffindor then X does
not belong to Hufflepuff for example or
a phrase even more simply anyone in
Gryffindor is not in Hufflepuff
simplified way of saying the same thing
so this Universal quantification lets us
express an idea like something is going
to hold true for all values of a
particular variable
in addition to Universal quantification
though we also have existential
quantification
whereas Universal quantification said
that something is going to be true for
all values of a variable existential
quantification says that some expression
is going to be true for some value of a
variable at least one value of the
variable so let's take a look at a
sample sentence using existential
quantification one such sentence looks
like this there exists an X this
backwards e stands for exists and here
we're saying there exists an X such that
house X and belongs to Minerva X in
other words there exists some object X
where X is a house and Minerva belongs
to X or phrased a little more succinctly
in English I'm here just saying Minerva
belongs to a house there's some object
that is a house and Minerva belongs to a
house and combining this Universal and
existential quantification we can create
far more sophisticated logical
statements than we were able to just
using propositional logic I could
combine these to say something like this
for all X person X implies there exists
a y such that house Y and belongs to X Y
all right so a lot of stuff going on
there a lot of symbols let's try and
parse it out and just understand what
it's saying here we're saying that for
all values of x if x is a person then
this is true
so in other words I'm saying for all
people and we call that person X this
statement is going to be true what
statement is true of all people well
there exists a why that is a house so
there exists some house
and X belongs to y
in other words I'm saying that for all
people out there there exists some house
such that X the person belongs to why
the house
so spray is more succinctly I'm saying
that every person belongs to a house
that for all x if x is a person then
there exists a house that X belongs to
and so we can now Express a lot more
powerful ideas using this idea now A
first order logic and it turns out there
are many other kinds of logic out there
there's second order logic and other
higher order logic Each of which allows
us to express more and more complex
ideas but all of it in this case is
really in pursuit of the same goal which
is the representation of knowledge we
want our AI agents to be able to know
information to represent that
information whether that's using
propositional logic or first order logic
or some other logic and then be able to
reason based on that to be able to draw
conclusions make inferences figure out
whether there's some sort of entailment
relationship as by using some sort of
inference algorithm something like
inference by resolution or model
checking or any number of these other
algorithms that we can use in order to
take information that we know and
translate it to additional conclusions
so all of this has helped us to create
AI that is able to represent information
about what it knows and what it doesn't
know
next time though we'll take a look at
how we can make our AI even more
powerful by not just encoding
information that we know for sure to be
true and not to be true but also to take
a look at uncertainty to look at what
happens if AI thinks that something
might be probable or maybe not very
probable or somewhere in between those
two extremes all in the pursuit of
trying to build our intelligent systems
to be even more intelligent we'll see
you next time
good
[Music]
all right welcome back everyone to an
introduction to artificial intelligence
with python and last time we took a look
at how it is that AI inside of our
computers can represent knowledge we
represented that knowledge in the form
of logical sentences in a variety of
different logical languages and the idea
was we wanted our AI to be able to
represent knowledge or information and
somehow use those pieces of information
to be able to derive New pieces of
information via inference to be able to
take some information and deduce some
additional conclusions based on the
information that it already knew for
sure but in reality when we think about
computers and we think about AI very
rarely are our machines going to be able
to know things for sure oftentimes
there's going to be some amount of
uncertainty in the information that our
AIS or our computers are dealing with
where it might believe something with
some probability as we'll soon discuss
what probability is all about and what
it means but not entirely for certain
and we want to use the information that
it has some knowledge about even if it
doesn't have perfect knowledge to still
be able to make inferences still be able
to draw conclusions so you might imagine
for example in the context of a robot
that has some sensors and is exploring
some environment it might not know
exactly where it is or exactly what's
around it but it does have access to
some data that can allow it to draw
inferences with some probability there's
some likelihood that one thing is true
or another or you can imagine in context
where there is a little bit more
Randomness and uncertainty something
like predicting the weather where you
might not be able to know for sure what
tomorrow's weather is with a hundred
percent certainty but you can probably
infer with some probability what
tomorrow's weather is going to be based
on maybe today's weather in yesterday's
weather and other data that you might
have access to as well and so oftentimes
we can distill this in terms of just
possible events that might happen and
what the likelihood of those events are
this comes a lot in games for example
where there's an element of chance
inside of those games so you imagine
rolling a dice you're not sure exactly
what the die roll is going to be but you
know it's going to be one of these
possibilities from one to six for
example
and so here now we introduce the idea of
probability Theory and what we'll take a
look at today is beginning by looking at
the mathematical foundations of
probability Theory getting a
understanding for some of the key
Concepts within probability and then
diving into how we can use probability
and the ideas that we look at
mathematically to represent some ideas
in terms of models that we can put into
our computers in order to program an AI
that is able to use information about
probability to draw inferences to make
some judgments about the world with some
probability or likelihood of being true
so probability ultimately boils down to
this idea that there are possible worlds
that we're here representing using this
little Greek letter Omega and the idea
of a possible world is that you know
when I roll a die there are six possible
worlds that could result from it I can
roll a one or a two or a three or a four
or a five or a six and each of those are
a possible world and each of those
possible worlds has some probability of
being true the probability that I do
roll a one or a two or a three or
something else and we represent that
probability like this using the capital
letter P and then in parentheses what it
is that we want the probability of so
this right here would be the probability
of some possible world as represented by
the little letter Omega now there are a
couple of basic axioms of probability
that become relevant as we consider how
we deal with probability and how we
think about it first and foremost every
probability value must range between 0
and 1 inclusive so the smallest value
any probability can have is the number
zero which is an impossible event
something like I roll a die and the die
is a seven is the role that I get if the
die only has numbers one through six the
event that I roll a seven is impossible
so it would have probability zero and on
the other end of the spectrum
probability can range all the way up to
the positive number one meaning an event
is certain to happen that I roll a die
and the number is less than 10 for
example that is an event that is
guaranteed to happen if the only sides
on my die are one through six for
instance and then there can range
through any real number in between these
two values we're generally speaking a
higher value for the probability means
an event is more likely to take place
and a lower value for the probability
means the event is less likely to take
place
and the other key rule for probability
looks a little bit like this this Sigma
notation if you haven't seen it before
refers to summation the idea that we're
going to be adding up a whole sequence
of values and the sigma donation is
going to come up a couple of times today
because as we deal with probability
oftentimes we're adding up a whole bunch
of individual values or individual
probabilities to get some other value so
we'll see this come up a couple of times
but what this notation means is that if
I sum up all of the possible worlds
Omega that are in big Omega which
represents the set of all the possible
worlds meaning I take for all of the
worlds in the set of possible worlds and
add up all of their probabilities
what I ultimately get is the number one
so if I take all the possible worlds add
up what each of their probabilities is I
should get the number one at the end
meaning all probabilities just need to
sum for to one so for example if I take
dice for example if you imagine I have a
fair die with numbers one through six
and I roll the die each one of these
rolls has an equal probability of taking
place and the probability is one over
six for example so each of these
probabilities is between zero and one
zero meaning impossible and one meaning
for certain and if you add up all of
these probabilities for all of the
possible worlds you get the number one
and we can represent any one of those
probabilities like this the probability
that we roll the number two for example
is just one over six every six times we
roll the die we'd expect that one time
for instance that I might come up as a
two its probability is not certain but
it's a little more than nothing for
instance
and so this is all fairly
straightforward for just a single dot
but things get more interesting as our
models of the world get a little bit
more complex let's imagine now that
we're not just dealing with a single die
but we have two dice for example I have
a red dye here and a blue dye there and
I care not just about what the
individual role is but I care about the
sum of the two rules in this case the
sum of the two roles is the number three
how do I begin to now reason about like
what does the probability look like if
instead of having one die I now have two
dice well what we might imagine is that
we could first consider what are all of
the possible worlds and in this case all
of the possible worlds are just every
combination of the red and blue dye that
I could come up with for the red dye it
could be a one or a two or a three or a
four or a five or a six and for each of
those possibilities the blue dye
likewise could also be either one or two
or three or four or five or six
and it just so happens that in this
particular case each of these possible
combinations is equally likely equally
likely are all of these various
different possible worlds that's not
always going to be the case if you
imagine more complex models that we
could try to build and things that we
could try to represent in the real world
it's probably not going to be the case
that every single possible world is
always equally likely but in the case of
fair dice where in any given die roll
any one number has just as good a chance
of coming up as any other number we can
consider all of these possible worlds to
be equally likely
but even though all of the possible
worlds are equally likely that doesn't
necessarily mean that their sums are
equally likely so if we consider what
the sum is of all of these two so one
plus one that's a two two plus one is a
three and consider for each of these
possible pairs of numbers what their sum
ultimately is we can notice that there
are some patterns here where it's not
entirely the case that every number
comes up equally likely if you consider
seven for example what's the probability
that when I roll two dice their sum is
seven there are several ways this can
happen there are you know six possible
worlds where the sum is seven it could
be a one and a six or a two and a five
or a three and a four a four and a three
and so forth
but if you instead consider you know
what's the probability that I roll two
dice and the sum of those two die rolls
is 12 for example well looking at this
diagram there's only one possible World
in which that can happen and that's the
possible world where both the red dye
and the blue dye both come up as sixes
to give us a sum total of 12. So based
on just taking a look at this diagram we
see that some of these probabilities are
likely different the probability that
the sum is a 7 must be greater than the
probability that the sum is a 12. and we
can represent that even more formally by
saying okay the probability that we sum
to 12 is 1 out of 36. out of the 36
equally likely probable possible worlds
six squared because we have six options
for the red die and six options for the
blue die out of those 36 options only
one of them sums to 12. whereas on the
other hand the probability that if we
take two dice rolls and they sum up to
the number seven well out of those 36
possible worlds there were six worlds
where the sum was seven and so we get 6
over 36 which we can simplify as a
fraction to just one over six
so here now we're able to represent
these different ideas of probability
representing some events that might be
more likely and then other events that
are less likely as well
and these sorts of judgments where we're
figuring out just in the abstract what
is the probability that this thing takes
place are generally known as
unconditional probabilities some degree
of belief we have in some proposition
some fact about the world in the absence
of any other evidence without knowing
any additional information if I roll a
die what's the chance it comes up as a
two or if I roll two dice what's the
chance that the sum of those two die
rolls is a seven
but usually when we're thinking about
probability especially when we're
thinking about training in AI to
intelligently be able to know something
about the world and make predictions
based on that information it's not
unconditional probability that our AI is
dealing with but rather conditional
probability probability where rather
than having no original knowledge we
have some initial knowledge about the
world and how the world actually works
so conditional probability is the degree
of belief in a proposition given some
evidence that has already been revealed
to us
so what does this look like well it
looks like this in terms of notation
we're going to represent conditional
probability as probability of a and then
this vertical bar and then B and the way
to read this is the thing on the left
hand side of the vertical bar is what we
want the probability of here now I want
the probability that a is true that it
is a real world that it is the event
that actually does take place
and then on the right side of the
vertical bar is our evidence the
information that we already know for
certain about the world for example that
b is true so the way to read this entire
expression is what is the probability of
a given B the probability that a is true
given that we already know that b is
true and this type of judgment
conditional probability the probability
of one thing given some other fact comes
up quite a lot when we think about the
types of calculations we might want our
AI to be able to do for example we might
care about the probability of rain today
given that we know that it rained
yesterday we could think about the
probability of rain today just in the
abstract what is the chance that today
it rains but usually we have some
additional evidence I know for certain
that it rained yesterday and so I would
like to calculate the probability that
it rains today given that I know that it
rained yesterday or you might imagine
that I want to know the probability that
my optimal route to my destination
changes given the current traffic
conditions so whether or not traffic
conditions change that might change the
probability that this route is actually
the optimal route or you might imagine
in a medical context I want to know the
probability that a patient has a
particular disease given some results of
some tests that have been performed on
that patient and I have some evidence
the results of that test and I would
like to know the probability that a
patient has a particular disease so this
notion of conditional probability comes
up everywhere as we begin to think about
what we would like to reason about but
being able to reason a little more
intelligently by taking into account
evidence that we already have we're more
able to get an accurate result for what
is the likelihood that someone has this
disease if we know this evidence the
results of the test as opposed to if we
were just calculating the unconditional
probability of saying what is the
probability they have the disease
without any evidence to try and back up
our result one way or the other
so now that we've got this idea of what
conditional probability is the next
question we have to ask is all right how
do we calculate conditional probability
how do we figure out mathematically if I
have an expression like this how do I
get a number from that what does
conditional probability actually mean
well the formula for conditional
probability looks a little something
like this the probability of a given B
the probability that a is true given
that we know that b is true is equal to
this fraction the probability that A and
B are true divided by just the
probability that b is true and the way
to intuitively try to think about this
is that if I want to know the
probability that a is true given that b
is true well I want to consider all the
ways they could both be true out of the
only worlds that I care about are the
words where B is already true I can sort
of ignore all the cases where B isn't
true because those aren't relevant to my
ultimate computation they're not
relevant to what it is that I want to
get information about
so let's take a look at an example let's
take go back to that example of rolling
two dice and the idea that those two
dice might sum up to the number 12. we
discussed earlier that the unconditional
probability that if I roll two dice and
they sum to 12 is 1 out of 36 because
out of the 36 possible worlds that I
might care about in only one of them is
the sum of those two dice 12. it's only
when red is six and blue is also six
but let's say now that I have some
additional information I now want to
know what is the probability that the
two dice sum to 12 given that I know
that the red dye was a fix so I already
have some evidence I already know the
red dies of six I don't know what the
blue dye is that information isn't given
to me in this expression but given the
fact that I know that the red die rolled
a fix what is the probability that we
sum to 12.
so we can begin to do the math using
that expression from before here again
are all of the possibilities all of the
possible combinations of red dye being
one through six and blue dye being one
through six
and I might consider first all right
what is the probability of my evidence
my B variable where I want to know what
is the probability that the red die is a
six well the probability that the red
dies of six is just one out of six so
these one out of six options are really
the only worlds that I care about here
now all the rest of them are irrelevant
to my calculation because I already have
this evidence that the red diode was a
fix so I don't need to care about all
the other possibilities that could
result
so now in addition to the fact that the
red dye were old as a six and the
probability of that the other piece of
information I need to know in order to
calculate this conditional probability
is the probability that both of my
variables A and B are true the
probability that both the red die is a
six and they all sum to 12. so what is
the probability that both of these
things happen well it only happens in
one possible case in one out of these 36
cases and it's the case where both the
red and the blue dye are equal to six
there's an information piece of
information that we already knew and so
this probability is equal to one over
thirty six and so to get the conditional
probability that the sum is 12 given
that I know that the red dice is equal
to six well I just divide these two
values together and 1 over 36 divided by
1 over 6 gives us this probability of
one over six given that I know that the
red die rolled a value of six the
probability that the sum of the two dice
is 12 is also 1 over 6. and that
probably makes intuitive sense to you
too because if the red die is a six the
only way for me to get to a 12 is if the
blue die also rolls a six and we know
that the probability of the blue die
rolling a six is whatever six so in this
case the conditional probability seems
fairly straightforward but this idea of
calculating a conditional probability by
looking at the probability that both of
these events take place is an idea
that's going to come up again and again
this is the definition now of
conditional probability and we're going
to use that definition as we think about
probability more generally to be able to
draw conclusions about the world this
again is that formula the probability of
a given B is equal to the probability
that A and B take place divided by the
probability of B and you'll see this
formula sometimes written in a couple of
different ways you could imagine
algebraically multiplying both sides of
this equation by probability of B to get
rid of the fraction and you'll get an
expression like this the probability of
A and B which is this expression over
here here is just the probability of B
times the probability of a given b or
you could represent this equivalently
since A and B in this expression are
interchangeable A and B is the same
thing as b and a you could imagine also
representing the probability of A and B
as the probability of a times the
probability of B given a just switching
all of the A's and B's these three are
all equivalent ways of trying to
represent what joint probability means
and so you'll sometimes see all of these
equations and they might be useful to
you as you begin to reason about
probability and to think about what
values might be taking place in the real
world
now sometimes when we deal with
probability we don't just care about a
Boolean event like did this happen or
did this not happen sometimes we might
want the ability to represent like
variable values in a probability space
where some variable might take on
multiple different possible values and
in probability we call a variable in
probability Theory a random variable a
random variable in probability is just
some variable and probability theory
that has some domain of values that it
can take on so what do I mean by this
what I mean is I might have a random
variable that is just called roll for
example that has six possible values
roll is my variable and the possible
values the domain of values that it can
take on are one two three four five and
six and I might like to know the
probability of each in this case they
happen to all be the same but in other
very random variables that might not be
the case for example I might have a
random variable to represent the weather
for example where the domain of values
it could take on are things like sun or
cloudy or rainy or windy or snowy and
each of those might have a different
probability and I care about knowing
what is the probability that the weather
equals Sun or the weather equals clouds
for instance and I might like to do some
mathematical calculations based on that
information other random variables might
be something like traffic what are the
odds that there is no traffic or light
traffic or heavy traffic traffic in this
case is my random variable and the
values that that random variable can
take on are here it's either none or
light or heavy and I the person doing
these calculations I the person encoding
these random variables into my computer
need to make the decision as to what
these possible values actually are you
might imagine for example for a flight
if I care about whether or not I make it
or to a flight on time my flight has a
couple of possible values that I could
take on my flight could be on time my
flight could be delayed my flight could
be canceled so flight in this case is my
random variable and these are the values
that it can take on and often I want to
know something about the probability
that my random variable takes on each of
those possible values and this is what
we then call a probability distribution
a probability distribution takes a
random variable and gives me the
probability ability for each of the
possible values in its domain so in the
case of this flight for example my
probability distribution might look
something like this my probability
distribution says the probability that
the random variable flight is equal to
the value on time is 0.6 or otherwise
put into more English human friendly
terms the likelihood that my flight is
on time is 60 for example and in this
case the probability that my flight is
delayed is 30 percent the probability
that my flight is canceled is 10 or 0.1
and if you sum up all of these possible
values the sum is going to be one right
if you take all of the possible worlds
here are my three possible worlds for
the value of the random variable flight
add them all up together the result
needs to be the number one per that
Axiom of probability theory that we've
discussed before
so this now is one way of representing
this probability distribution for the
random variable flight sometimes you'll
see it represented a little bit more
concisely that this is pretty verbose
for really just trying to express three
possible values and so often you'll
instead see the same notation
representing using a vector and all a
vector is is a sequence of values as
opposed to just a single value I might
have multiple values and so I could
extend instead represent this idea this
way bold P so a larger P generally
meaning the probability distribution of
this variable flight is equal to this
Vector represented at angle brackets the
probability distribution is 0.6 0.3 and
0.1 and I would just have to know that
this probability distribution is in
order of on time or delayed and canceled
to know how to interpret this Vector to
mean the first value in the vector is
the probability that my flight is on
time the second value in the vector is
the probability that my flight is
delayed and the third value in the
Vector is the probability that my flight
is canceled and so this is just an
alternate way of representing this idea
a little more verbosely but oftentimes
you'll see us just talk about a
probability distribution over a random
variable and whenever we talk about that
what we're really doing is trying to
figure out the probabilities of each of
the possible values that that random
variable can take on but this notation
is just a little bit more succinct even
though it can sometimes be a little
confusing depending on the context in
which you see it so we'll start to look
at examples where we use this sort of
notation to describe probability and to
describe events that might take place
a couple of other important ideas to
know with regards to probability Theory
one is this idea of Independence and
Independence refers to the idea that the
knowledge of one event doesn't influence
the probability of another event so for
example in the context of my two dice
rolls where I had the red dye and the
blue dye the probability that I roll the
red dye and the blue dye those two
events red dye and blue diamond are
independent knowing the result of the
red dye doesn't change the probabilities
for the blue dye it doesn't give me any
additional information about what the
value of the blue dye is ultimately
going to be but that's not always going
to be the case you might imagine that in
the case of weather something like
clouds and Rain those are probably not
independent that if it is cloudy that
might increase the probability that
later in the day it's going to rain so
some information informs some other
event or some other random variable so
Independence refers to the idea that one
event doesn't influence the other and if
they're not independent then there might
be some relationship
so mathematically formally what does
independence actually mean well recall
this formula from before that the
probability of A and B is the
probability of a times the probability
of B given a and the more intuitive way
to think about this is that to know how
likely it is that a and b happen well
let's first figure out the likelihood
that a happens and then given that we
know that a happens let's figure out the
likelihood that b happens and multiply
those two things together
but if a and b were independent meaning
knowing a doesn't change anything about
the likelihood that b is true well then
the probability of B given a meaning the
probability that b is true given that I
know a is true well then I know a is
true shouldn't really make a difference
if these two things are independent but
a shouldn't influence B at all so the
probability of B given a is really just
the probability of B if it is true that
A and B are independent and so this
right here is one example of a
definition for what it means for A and B
to be independent the probability of A
and B is just the probability of a times
the probability of B anytime you find
two events A and B where this
relationship holds them then you can say
that A and B are independent
so an example of that might be the dice
that we were taking a look at before
here if I wanted the probability of red
being a 6 and blue being a six well
that's just the probability that red is
a 6 multiplied by the probability that
blue is a thick because both equal to 1
over 36. so I can say that these two
events are independent
what wouldn't be independent for example
would be an example so this for example
has a probability of 1 over 36 as we
talked about before but what wouldn't be
independent would be a case like this
the probability that the red die rolls a
fix and the red die rolls a four
if you just naively took okay red dye
six red dye four well if I'm only
rolling the die once you might imagine
that naive approaches to say well each
of these has a probability of one over
six so multiply them together and the
probability is 1 over 36 but of course
if you're only rolling the red die once
there's no way you could get two
different values for the red dye it
couldn't both be a six and a four so the
probability should be zero but if you
were to multiply probability of red six
times probability of red four well that
would equal 1 over 36 but of course
that's not true because we know that
there is no way probability zero that
when we roll the red die once we get
both a six and a four because only one
of those possibilities can actually be
the result
and so we can say that the event that
red roll a six and the event that red
roll is for those two events are not
independent if I know that the red role
of a fix I know that the red role cannot
possibly be a four so these things are
not independent and instead if I wanted
to calculate the probability I would
need to use this conditional probability
as is the regular definition of the
probability of two events taking place
and the probability of this now well the
probability of the red role being a six
that's one over six but what's the
probability that the roles are four
given that the roll is a six well this
is just zero because there's no way for
the prob for the red rule to be a four
given that we already know the red role
of the fix and so the value if we do add
all that multiplication is we get the
number zero
so this idea of conditional probability
is going to come up again and again
especially as we begin to reason about
multiple different random variables that
might be interacting with each other in
some way and this gets us to one of the
most important rules in probability
Theory which is known as Bayes Rule and
it turns out that just using the
information we've already learned about
probability and just applying a little
bit of algebra we can actually derive
Bayes rule for ourselves but it's a very
important rule when it comes to
inference and thinking about probability
in the context of what it is that a
computer can do or what a mathematician
could do by having access to
informations about probability so let's
go back to these equations to be able to
derive Bayes rule ourselves we know the
probability of A and B the likelihood
that A and B take place is the
likelihood of B and then the likelihood
of a given that we know that b is
already true
and likewise the probability of a given
a and b is the probability of a times
the probability of B given that we know
that a is already true this is sort of a
symmetric relationship where it doesn't
matter the order of A and B and B and a
mean the same thing and so in these
equations we can just swap out A and B
to be able to represent the exact same
idea so we know that these two equations
are already true we've seen that already
and now let's just do a little bit of
algebraic manipulation of this stuff
both of these Expressions on the right
hand side are equal to the probability
of A and B so what I can do is take
these two expressions on the right hand
side and just set them equal to each
other right if they're both equal to the
probability of A and B then they both
must be equal to each other so
probability of a times probability of B
given a is equal to the probability of B
times the probability of a given B
and now all we're going to do is do a
little bit of division I'm going to
divide both sides by P of a and now I
get what if Bayes rule the probability
of B given a is equal to the probability
of B times the probability of a given B
divided by the probability of a and
sometimes in Bayes rule you'll see the
order of these two arguments switched so
instead of B times a given B it'll be a
given B times B that ultimately doesn't
matter because in multiplication you can
switch the order of the two things
you're multiplying and it doesn't change
the result but this here right now is
the most common formulation of Bayes
rule the probability of B given a is
equal to the probability of a given B
times the probability of B divided by
the probability of a and this rule it
turns out is really important when it
comes to trying to infer things about
the world because it means you can
express one conditional probability the
conditional probability of B given a
using knowledge about the probability of
a given B using the result reverse of
that conditional probability so let's
first do a little bit of an example with
this just to see how we might use it and
then explore what this means a little
bit more generally so we're going to
construct a situation where I have some
information there are two events that I
care about the idea that it's cloudy in
the morning and the idea that it is
rainy in the afternoon those are two
different possible events that could
take place cloudy in the morning or the
am rainy in the PM and what I care about
is given clouds in the morning what is
the probability of rain in the afternoon
a reasonable question I might ask in the
morning I look outside or an ai's camera
looks outside and sees that there are
clouds in the morning and we want to
conclude we want to figure out what is
the probability that in the afternoon
there is going to be rain
of course in the abstract we don't have
access to this kind of information but
we can use data to begin to try and
figure this out so let's imagine now
that I have access to some pieces of
information I have access to the idea
that 80 of rainy afternoons start out
with a cloudy morning and you might
imagine that I could have gathered this
data just by looking at data over a
sequence of time but I know that 80 of
the time when it's raining in the
afternoon it was cloudy that morning
I also know that 40 of days have cloudy
mornings
and I also know that 10 of days have
rainy afternoons
and now using this information I would
like to figure out
given clouds in the morning what is the
probability that it rains in the
afternoon I want to know the probability
of afternoon rain given morning clouds
and I can do that in particular using
this fact the probability of uh so if I
know that 80 of rainy afternoons start
with cloudy mornings then I know the
probability of Cloudy mornings given
rainy afternoon so using sort of the
reverse conditional probability I can
figure that out expressed in terms of
Bayes rule this is what that would look
like probability of rain given clouds is
the probability of clouds given rain
times the probability of rain divided by
the probability of clouds here I'm just
substituting in for the values of A and
B from that equation of Bayes rule from
before and then I can just do the math I
have this information I know that 80 of
the time if it was raining then there
were clouds in the morning so 0.8 here
the probability of rain is 0.1 because
10 percent of days were raining and 40
percent of days were cloudy I do the
math and I can figure out the answer is
0.2 so the problem ability that it rains
in the afternoon given that it was
cloudy in the morning is 0.2 in this
case
and this now is an application of Bayes
rule the idea that using one conditional
probability we can get the reverse
conditional probability and this is
often useful when one of the conditional
probabilities might be easier for us to
know about or easier for us to have data
about and using that information we can
calculate the other conditional
probability so what does this look like
well it means that knowing the
probability of Cloudy mornings given
rainy afternoons we can calculate the
probability of rainy afternoons given
cloudy mornings or for example more
generally if we know the probability of
some visible effect some effect that we
can see and observe given some unknown
cause that we're not sure about
well then we can calculate the
probability of that unknown unknown
cause given the visible effect so what
might that look like
well in the context of medicine for
example I might know the probability of
some medical test result given a disease
like I know that if someone has a
disease then X percent of the time the
medical test result will show up as this
for instance and using that information
then I can calculate all right what is
the probability that given I know the
medical test result what is the
likelihood that someone has the disease
this is the piece of information that is
usually easier to know easier to
immediately have access to data for and
this is the information that I actually
want to calculate or I might want to
know for example if I know that what Pro
some probability of counterfeit bills
have like Blurry text around the edges
because counterfeit printers aren't
nearly as good at printing text
precisely so I have some information
about given something as a counterfeit
Bill like X percent of counterfeit bills
have blurry text for example and using
that information then I can calculate
some piece of information that I might
want to know like given that I know
there's blurry text on a bill what is
the probability ability that that bill
is counterfeit so given one conditional
probability I can calculate the other
conditional probability as well
and so now we've taken a look at a
couple of different types of probability
we've looked at unconditional
probability where I just look at what is
the probability of this event occurring
given no additional evidence that I
might have access to and we've also
looked at conditional probability where
I have some sort of evidence and I would
like to using that evidence be able to
calculate some other probability as well
the other kind of probability that will
be important for us to think about is
joint probability and this is when we're
considering the likelihood of multiple
different events simultaneously and so
what do we mean by this well for example
I might have probability distributions
that look a little something like this
like oh I want to know the probability
distribution of clouds in the morning
and that distribution looks like this
forty percent of the time C which is my
random variable here is equal to it's
cloudy and sixty percent of the time
it's not cloudy so here's just a simple
probability distribution that is
effectively telling me that 40 of the
time it's cloudy
I might also have a probability
distribution for rain in the afternoon
where 10 of the time or with probability
0.1 it is raining in the afternoon and
with probability 0.9 it is not raining
in the afternoon and using just these
two pieces of information I don't
actually have a whole lot of information
about how these two variables relate to
each other but I could if I had access
to their joint probability meaning for
every combination of these two things
meaning morning cloudy and afternoon
rain morning cloudy and afternoon not
rain morning not cloudy and afternoon
rain and morning not cloudy and
afternoon not raining if I had access to
values for each of those four I'd have
more information so information that'd
be organized in a table like this and
this rather than just a probability
distribution is a joint probability
distribution it tells me the probability
distribution of each of the possible
combinations of values that these random
variables can take on
so if I want to know what is the
probability that on any given day it is
both cloudy and rainy well I would say
all right we're looking at cases where
it is cloudy and cases where it is
raining and the intersection of those
two that Row in that column is 0.08 so
that is the probability that it is both
cloudy and rainy using that information
and using this conditional probability
table or using this joint probability
table I can begin to draw other pieces
of information about things like
conditional probability so I might ask a
question like what is the probability
distribution of clouds given that I know
that it is raining meaning I know for
sure that it's raining that it's raining
tell me the probability distribution
over whether it's cloudy or not given
that I know already that it is in fact
raining and here I'm using C to stand
for that random variable I'm looking for
a distribution meaning the answer to
this is not going to be a single value
it's going to be two values a vector of
two values where the first value is
probability of clouds the second value
is probability that it is not cloudy but
the sum of those two values is going to
be one because when you add up the
probabilities of all of the possible
Worlds the result that you get must be
the number one
and well what do we know about how to
calculate a conditional probability well
we know that the probability of a given
B is the probability of A and B divided
by the probability of B
so what does this mean well it means
that I can calculate the probability of
clouds given that it's raining as the
probability of clouds and raining
divided by the probability of rain and
this comma here for for the probability
distribution of clouds and rain this
comma sort of stands in for the word and
you'll sort of see in The Logical
operator and and the comma used
interchangeably this means the
probability distribution over the clouds
and knowing the fact that it is raining
divided by the probability of rain
and the interesting thing to note here
and what we'll often do in order to
simplify our mathematics is that
dividing by the probability of rain the
probability of rain here is just some
numerical constant it is some number
dividing by probability of rain is just
dividing by some constant or in other
words multiplying by the inverse of that
constant and it turns out oftentimes we
can just not worry about what the exact
value of this is and just know that it
is in fact a constant value and we'll
see why in a moment so instead of
expressing this as this joint
probability divided by the probability
of rain sometimes we'll just represent
it as Alpha times the numerator here the
probability distribution of C this
variable and that we know that it is
raining for instance so all we've done
here is that this value of 1 over the
probability of rain that's really just a
constant we're going to divide by or
equivalently multiply by the inverse of
at the end we'll just call it Alpha for
now and deal with it a little bit later
but the key idea here now and this is an
idea that's going to come up again is
that the conditional distribution of C
given rain is proportional to meaning
just some Factor multiplied by The Joint
probability of c and Rain being true and
so how do we figure this out well this
is going to be the probability that it
is cloudy given that it's raining which
is 0.08 and the probability that it's
not cloudy given that it's rainy which
is 0.02 and so we get Alpha times here
now is that probability distribution
0.08 is clouds and Rain 0.02 is not
cloudy and rain
but of course 0.08 and 0.02 don't sum up
to the number one and we know that in a
probability distribution if you consider
all of the possible values they must sum
up to a probability of one and so we
know that we just need to figure out
some constant to normalize so to speak
these values something we can multiply
or divide by to get it so that all these
probabilities sum up to one and it turns
out that if we multiply both numbers by
10 then we can get that result of 0.8
and 0.2 the proportions are still
equivalent but now 0.8 plus 0.2 those
sum up to the number one
so take a look at this and see if you
can understand step by step how it is
we're getting from one point to another
but the key idea here is that by using
the joint probabilities these
probabilities that it is both cloudy and
rainy and that it is not cloudy and
rainy I can take that information and
figure out the conditional probability
given that it's raining what is the
chance that it's cloudy versus not
cloudy just by multiplying by some
normalization constant so to speak and
this is what a computer can begin to use
to be able to interact with these
various different types of probabilities
and it turns out there are a number of
other probability rules that are going
to be useful to us as we begin to
explore how we can actually use this
information to encode into our
computerism some more complex analysis
that we might want to do about
probability and distributions and random
variables that we might be interacting
with so here are a couple of those
important probability rules one of the
simplest rules is just this negation
rule what is the probability of not
event a so a is an event that has some
probability and I would like to know
what is the probability that a does not
occur and it turns out it's just 1 minus
P of a which makes sense because if
those are the two possible cases either
a happens or a doesn't happen then when
you add up those two cases you must get
one which means
P of not a must just be 1 minus P of a
because P of A and P of not a must sum
up to the number one they must include
all of the possible cases
we've seen an expression for calculating
the probability of A and B we might also
reasonably want to calculate the
probability of A or B what is the
probability that one thing happens or
another thing happens so for example I
might want to calculate what is the
probability that if I roll two dice a
red dye and a blue die what is the
likelihood that a is a 6 or B is a six
like one or the other and what you might
imagine you could do and the wrong way
to approach it would be just to say all
right well a comes up as a 6 with the
red die comes up as a six with
probability one over six the same for
the blue diets also one over six add
them together and you get two over six
otherwise known as one-third but this
does It suffers from a problem of over
counting that we've double counted the
case where both A and B both the red dye
and the blue dye both come up as a sixth
Rule and I've counted that instance
twice so to resolve this the actual
expression for calculating the
probability of A or B uses what we call
the inclusion exclusion formula so I
take the probability of a add it to the
probability of B that's all same as
before but then I need to exclude the
cases that I've double counted so I
subtract from that the probability of A
and B and that gets me the result for A
or B I consider all the cases where a is
true and all the cases where B is true
and if you imagine this is like a Venn
diagram of cases where a is true cases
where B is true I just need to subtract
out the middle to get rid of the cases
that I have over counted by double
counting them inside of both of these
individual expressions
one other rule that's going to be quite
helpful is a rule called marginalization
so marginalization is answering the
question of how do I figure out the
probability of a using some other
variable that I might have access to
like B even if I don't know additional
information about it I know that b some
event can have two possible States
either B happens or B doesn't happen
assuming it's a Boolean true or false
and well what that means is that for me
to be able to calculate the probability
of a there are only two cases either a
happens and B happens or a happens and B
doesn't happen and those are two
disjoint meaning they can't both happen
together either B happens or B doesn't
happen they're disjoint or separate
cases and so I can figure out the
probability of a just by adding up those
two cases the probability that a is true
is the probability that A and B is true
plus the probability that a is true and
B isn't true so by marginalizing I've
looked at the two possible cases that
might take place either B happens or B
doesn't happen and in either of those
cases I look at what's the probability
that a happens and if I add those
together well then I get the probability
that a happens as a whole
so take a look look at that rule it
doesn't matter what B is or how it's
related to a so long as I know these
joint distributions I can figure out the
overall probability of a and this can be
a useful way if I have a joint
distribution like the joint distribution
of A and B to just figure out some
unconditional probability like the
probability of a and we'll see examples
of this soon as well now sometimes these
might not just be random might not just
be variables that are events that are
like they happened or they didn't happen
like B is here they might be some
broader probability distribution where
there are multiple possible values and
so here in order to use this
marginalization rule I need to sum up
not just over B and not B but for all of
the possible values that the other
random variable could take on and so
here we'll see a version of this rule
for random variables and it's going to
include that summation notation to
indicate that I'm summing up adding up a
whole bunch of individual values
so here's the rule looks a lot more
complicated but it's actually the
equivalent exactly the same rule what
I'm saying here is that if I have two
random variables one called X and one
called y
well the probability that X is equal to
some value x sub I this is just some
value that this variable takes on how do
I figure it out well I'm going to sum up
over J where J is going to range over
all of the possible values that y can
take on well let's look at the
probability that x equals x i and y
equals YJ so the exact same rule the
only difference here is now I'm summing
up over all of the possible values that
y can take on saying let's add up all of
those possible cases and look at this
joint distribution this joint
probability that X takes on the value I
care about given all of the possible
values for y and if I add all those up
then I can get this unconditional
probability of what x is equal to
whether or not X is equal to some value
x sub I so let's take a look at this
rule because it does look a little bit
complicated let's try and put a concrete
example to it here again is that same
joint distribution from before I have
Cloud not cloudy rainy not rainy and
maybe I want to access some variable I
want to know what is the probability
that it is cloudy will marginalization
says that if I have this joint
distribution and I want to know like
what is the probability that it is
cloudy well I need to consider the other
variable the variable that's not here
the idea that it's rainy and I
considered the two cases either it's
raining or it's not raining and I just
sum up the values for each of those
possibilities
in other words the probability that it
is cloudy is equal to the sum
of the probability that it's cloudy and
it's rainy
and the probability that it's cloudy and
it is not
raining
and so these now are values that I have
access to these are values that are just
inside of this joint probability table
what is the probability that it is both
cloudy and rainy well it's just the
intersection of these two here which is
.08 and the probability that it's cloudy
and not raining is all right here's
cloudy here's not raining it's 0.32 so
it's .08 plus 0.32 which just gives us
equal to 0.4 that is the unconditional
probability that it is in fact cloudy
and so marginalization gives us a way to
go from these joint distributions to
just some individual probability that I
might care about and you'll see a little
bit later why it is that we care about
that and why that's actually useful to
us as we begin doing some of these
calculations
last rule we'll take a look at before
transitioning something a little bit
different is this rule of conditioning
very similar to the marginalization rule
but it says that again if I have two
events A and B but instead of having
access to their joint probabilities I
have access to their conditional
probabilities how they relate to each
other well again if I want to know the
probability that a happens and I know
that there's some other variable B
either B happens or B doesn't happen and
so I can say that the probability of a
is the probability of a given B times
the probability of B meaning B happened
and given that I know B happen what's
the likelihood that a happened and then
I consider the other case that b didn't
happen so here's the probability that b
didn't happen and here's the probability
that a happens given that I know that b
didn't happen and this is really the
equivalent rule just using conditional
probability instead of joint probability
where I'm saying let's look at both of
these two cases and condition on B look
at the case where B happens and look at
the case where B doesn't happen and look
at what probabilities I get as a result
and just as in the case of
marginalization where there was an
equivalent rule for random variables
that could take on multiple possible
values in a domain of possible values
here too conditioning has the same
equivalent rule again there's a
summation to mean I'm summing over all
of the possible values that some random
variable y could take on but if I want
to know what is the probability that X
takes on this value then I'm going to
sum up over all the values of J that y
could take on and say all right what's
the chance that y takes on that value YJ
and multiply it by the conditional
probability that X takes on this value
given that y took on that value YJ so
equivalent rule just using conditional
probabilities instead of joint
probabilities and using the equation we
know about joint probabilities we can
translate between these two
so all right we've seen a whole lot of
mathematics and we've just sort of laid
the foundation for mathematics and no
need to worry if you haven't seen
probability in too much detail up until
this point these are sort of the
foundations of the ideas that are going
to come up as we begin to explore how we
can now take these ideas from
probability and begin to apply them to
represent something inside of our
computer something inside of the AI
agent we're trying to design that is
able to represent information and
probabilities and the likelihoods
between various different events so
there are a number of different
probabilistic models that we can
generate but the first of the models
we're going to talk about are what are
known as Bayesian networks and a
Bayesian Network is just going to be
some network of random variables
connected random variables that are
going to represent the dependence
between these random variables the odds
are most random variables in this world
are not independent from each other that
there's some relationship between things
that are happening that we care about if
it is raining today you know that might
increase the likelihood that my flight
or my train gets delay played for
example there's some dependence between
these random variables and a Bayesian
Network is going to be able to capture
those dependencies
so what is a Bayesian Network what is
its actual structure and how does it
work well a Bayesian Network is going to
be a directed graph and again we've seen
directed graphs before they are
individual nodes with arrows or edges
that connect one node to another node
and pointing in a particular direction
and so this directed graph is going to
have nodes as well where each node in
this directed graph is going to
represent a random variable something
like the weather or something like
whether my train was on time or delayed
and we're going to have an arrow from a
node X to a node y to mean that X is a
parent of Y so that'll be our notation
if there's an arrow from X to Y X is
going to be considered a parent of Y and
the reason that's important is because
each of these nodes is going to have a
probability distribution that we're
going to store along with it which is
the distribution of x given some
evidence given the parents of X so the
way to more intuitively think about this
is the parent seem to be thought of as
sort of causes for some effect that
we're going to observe
and so let's take a look at an actual
example of a Bayesian Network and think
about the types of logic that might be
involved in reasoning about that Network
let's imagine for a moment that I have
an appointment out of town and I need to
take a train in order to get to that
appointment so what are the things I
might care about well I care about you
know getting to my appointment on time
either I make it to my appointment and
I'm able to attend it or I miss the
appointment and you might imagine that
that's influenced by the train that the
train is either on time or it's delayed
for example
but that train itself is also influenced
whether the train is on time or not
depends maybe on the rain you know is
there no rain is it light rain is there
heavy rain and it might also be
influenced by other variables too it
might be influenced as well by whether
or not there's you know maintenance on
the train track for example if there is
maintenance on the train track that
probably increases the likelihood that
my train is delayed
um and so we can represent all of these
ideas using a Bayesian Network that
looks a little something like this here
I have four nodes representing four
random variables that I would like to
keep track of I have one random variable
called rain that can take on three
possible values in its domain either
none or light or heavy for no rain light
rain or heavy rain I have a variable
called maintenance for whether or not
there is maintenance on the train track
which it has two possible values just
either yes or no either there is
maintenance or there's no maintenance
happening on the track then I have a
random variable for the train indicating
whether or not the train was on time or
not that random variable has two
possible values in its domain the the
train is either on time or the train is
delayed
and then finally I have a random
variable for whether I make it to my
appointment for my appointment down here
I have a random variable called
appointment that itself has two possible
values attend and miss
and so here are the possible values here
are my four nodes Each of which
represents a random variable Each of
which has a domain of possible values
that it can take on and the arrows the
edges pointing from one node to another
encode some notion of dependence inside
of this graph that whether I make it to
my appointment or not is dependent upon
whether the train is on time or delayed
and whether the train is on time or
delayed is dependent on two things given
by the two arrows pointing at this node
it is dependent on whether or not there
was maintenance on the train track and
it is also dependent upon whether or not
it was raining or whether it is raining
and just to make things a little
complicated let's say as well that
whether or not there's maintenance on
the track this too might be influenced
by the rain that if there's heavier rain
well maybe it's less likely that it's
going to be maintenance on the train
track that day because they're more
likely to want to do maintenance on the
track on days when it's not raining for
example and so these nodes might have
different relationships between them but
the idea is that we can come up with a
probability distribution for any of
these nodes based only upon its parents
and so let's look node by node at what
this probability distribution might
actually look like and we'll go ahead
and begin with this root node this rain
node here which is at the top and has no
arrows pointing into it which means its
probability distribution is not going to
be a conditional distribution it's not
based on anything I just have some
probability distribution over the
possible values for the rain random
variable
and that distribution might look a
little something like this none light
and heavy each have a possible value
here I'm saying the likelihood of no
rain is 0.7 of light rain is 0.2 of
heavy rain is 0.1 for example so here is
a probability distribution for this root
node in this Bayesian Network
and let's now consider the next node in
the network maintenance track
maintenance is yes or no and the general
idea of what this distribution is going
to encode at least in this story is the
idea that the heavier the rain is the
less likely it is that there's going to
be maintenance on the track because the
people that are doing maintenance on the
track probably want to wait until a day
when it's not as rainy in order to do
the track maintenance for example and so
what might that probability distribution
look like well this now is going to be a
conditional probability distribution
that here the three possible values for
the rain random variable which I'm here
just going to abbreviate to R either no
rain light rain or heavy rain
and for each of those possible values
either there is yes track maintenance or
no track maintenance and those have
probabilities associated with them that
I can see here that if it is if it is
not raining then there is a probability
of 0.4 that there's track maintenance
and a probability of 0.6 that there
isn't but if there's Heavy Rain then
here the chance that there is track
maintenance of 0.1 and the chance that
there is not track maintenance is 0.9
each of these rows is going to sum up to
one because each of these represent
different values of whether or not it's
raining the three possible values of
that random variable can take on and
each is associated with its own
probability distribution that is
ultimately all going to add up to the
number one
so that there is our distribution for
this random variable called maintenance
about whether or not there is
maintenance on the train track
and now let's consider the next variable
here we have a node inside of our
Bayesian Network called train that has
two possible values on time and delayed
and this node is going to be dependent
upon the two nodes that are pointing
towards it that this whether or not the
train is on time or delayed depends on
whether or not there's track maintenance
and it depends on whether or not there's
rain that heavier rain probably means
more likely that my train is delayed
and if there is track maintenance that
also probably means it's more likely
that my train is delayed as well and so
you could construct a larger probability
distribution a conditional probability
distribution that instead of
conditioning on just one variable as was
the case here is now conditioning on two
variables conditioning both on rain
represented by R and on maintenance
represented by Yes again each of these
rows has two values that sum up to the
number one one for whether the train is
on time one for whether the train is
delayed
and here I can say something like all
right if I know there was light rain and
track maintenance well okay that would
be R is light and M is yes well then
there's a probability of 0.6 that my
train is on time and a probability of
0.4 the train is delayed and you can
imagine gathering this data just by
looking at real world data looking at
data about all right if I knew that it
was a light rain and there was track
maintenance how often was a train
delayed or not delayed and you could
begin to construct this thing but the
interesting thing is intelligently being
able to try to figure out how might you
go about ordering these things what
things might influence other nodes
inside of this Bayesian Network
and the last thing I care about is
whether or not I make it to my
appointment so did I attend or miss the
appointment and ultimately whether I
attend or missed the appointment you
know it is influenced by track
maintenance because it's indirectly this
idea that right if there is track
maintenance well then my train might
more likely be delayed and if my
training is more likely to be delayed
then I'm more likely to miss my
appointment but what we encode in this
Bayesian Network are just what we might
consider to be more direct relationships
so the train has a direct influence on
the appointment and given that I know
whether the train is on time or delayed
knowing whether there's track
maintenance isn't going to give me any
additional information that I didn't
already have that if I know train these
other nodes that are up above isn't
really going to influence the result
and so here we might represent it using
another conditional probability
distribution that looks a little
something like this the train can take
on two possible values either my train
is on time or my train is delayed and
for each of those two possible values I
have a distribution for what are the
odds that I'm able to attend the meeting
and what are the odds that I miss the
meeting and obviously if my train is on
time I'm much more likely to be able to
attend the meeting than if my train is
delayed in which case I'm more likely to
miss that meeting
so all of these nodes put all together
here represent this Bayesian Network
this network of random variables whose
values I ultimately care about and that
have some sort of relationship between
them some sort of dependence where these
arrows from one node to another indicate
some dependence that I can calculate the
probability of some node given the
parents that happen to exist there so
now that we've been able to describe the
structure of this Bayesian Network and
the relationships between each of these
nodes by associating each of the nodes
in the network with a probability
distribution whether that's an
unconditional probability distribution
in the case of this root node here like
rain and a conditional probability
distribution in the case of all of the
other nodes whose probabilities are
dependent upon the values of their
parents we can begin to do some
computation and calculation using the
information inside of that table so
let's imagine for example but I just
wanted to compute something simple like
the probability of light rain how would
I get the probability of light rain well
light rain rain here is a root node and
so if I wanted to calculate that
probability I could just look at the
probability distribution for rain and
extract from it the probability of light
rains just a single value that I already
have access to
but we could also Imagine wanting to
compute more complex joint probabilities
like the probability that there is light
rain and also no track maintenance this
is a joint probability of two values
light rain and no track maintenance and
the way I might do that is first by
starting by saying all right well let me
get the probability of light rain but
now I also want the probability of no
track maintenance but of course this
node is dependent upon the value of rain
so what I really want is the probability
of no track maintenance given that I
know that there was light rain and so
the expression for calculating this this
idea that the probability of light rain
and no track maintenance is really just
the probability of light rain and the
probability that there's no track
maintenance given that I know that there
already is light rain so I take the
unconditional probability of light rain
multiply it by the conditional
probability of no track maintenance
given that they know there's light rain
and you can continue to do this again
and again for every variable that you
want to add into this joint probability
that I might want to calculate if I
wanted to know the probability of light
rain and no track maintenance and a
delayed train well that's going to be
the probability of light rain multiplied
by the probability of no track
maintenance given light rain multiplied
by the probability of a delayed train
given light rain and no track
maintenance because whether the train is
on time or delayed is dependent upon
both of these other two variables and so
I have two pieces of evidence that go
into the calculation of that conditional
probability and each of these three
values is just a value that I can look
up by looking at one of these individual
probability distributions that is
encoded into my Bayesian Network
and if I wanted a joint probability over
all four of the variables something like
the probability of light rain and no
track maintenance and a delayed train
and I miss my appointment well that's
going to be multiplying four different
values one from each of these individual
nodes it's going to be the probability
of light rain then if no track
maintenance given light rain then have a
delayed train given light rain and no
track maintenance and then finally for
this node here for whether I make it to
my appointment or not it's not dependent
upon these two variables given that I
know whether or not the train is on time
I only need to care about the
conditional probability that I miss my
train or did I miss my appointment given
that the train happens to be delayed and
so that's represented here by four
probabilities Each of which is located
inside of one of these probability
distributions for each of the nodes all
multiplied together
and so I can take a variable like that
and figure out what the joint
probability is by multiplying a whole
bunch of these individual probabilities
from the Bayesian Network
but of course just as with last time
where what I really wanted to do was to
be able to get new pieces of information
here too this is what we're going to
want to do with our Bayesian Network in
the context of knowledge we talked about
the problem of inference given things
that I know to be true can I draw
conclusions make deductions about other
facts about the world that I also know
to be true and what we're going to do
now is apply the same sort of idea to
probability using information about
which I have some knowledge whether some
evidence or some probabilities can I
figure out not other variables for
certain but can I figure out the
probabilities of other variables taking
on particular values and so here we
introduce the problem of inference in a
probabilistic setting in a case where
variables might not necessarily be true
for sure but they might be random
variables that take on different values
with some probability
so how do we formally Define what
exactly this inference problem actually
is well the inference problem have a
couple of parts to it we have some query
some variable X that we want to compute
the distribution for maybe I want the
probability that I miss my train or I
want the probability that the there is
track maintenance something that I want
information about
and then I have some evidence variables
maybe it's just one piece of evidence
maybe it's multiple pieces of evidence
but I've observed certain variables for
some sort of event so for example I
might have observed that it is raining
this is evidence that I have I know that
there is light rate or I know that there
is heavy rain and that is evidence I
have and using that evidence I want to
know what is the probability that my
train is delayed for example
and that is a query that I might want to
ask based on this evidence so I have a
query some variable evidence which are
some other variables that I have
observed inside of my Bayesian Network
and of course that does leave some
hidden variables why these are variables
that are not evidence variables and not
query variables so you might imagine in
the case where I know whether or not
it's raining and I want to know whether
my train is going to be delayed or not
the hidden variable the thing I don't
have access to is something like is
there maintenance on the track or am I
going to make or not make my appointment
for example these are variables that I
don't have access to they're hidden
because they're not things I observed
and they're also not the query the thing
that I'm asking and so ultimately what
we want to calculate
because I want to know the probability
distribution of x given e the event that
I observed so given that I observed some
event I observe that it is raining I
would like to know what is the
distribution over the possible values of
the train random variable is it on time
is it delayed what's the likelihood
that's going to be there and it turns
out we can do this calculation just
using a lot of the probability rules
that we've already seen in action and
ultimately we're going to take a look at
the math on a little bit of a high level
at an abstract level but ultimately we
can allow computers and programming
libraries that already exist to begin to
do some of this math for us but it's
good to get a general sense for what's
actually happening when this inference
process takes place let's imagine for
example that I want to compute the
probability distribution of the
appointment random variable given some
evidence given that I know that there
was light rain and no track maintenance
so there's my evidence these two
variables that I observe the values of I
observe the value of rain I know there's
light rain and I know that there is no
track maintenance going on today and
what I care about knowing my query is
this random variable appointment I want
to know the distribution of this random
variable appointment like what is the
chance that I'm able to attend my
appointment what is the chance that I
miss my appointment given this evidence
and the hidden variable the information
that I don't have access to is this
variable train this is information that
is not part of the evidence that I see
not something that I observe but it is
also not the query that I'm asking for
and so what might this inference
procedure look like well if you recall
back from when we were defining
conditional probability and doing math
with conditional probabilities we know
that a conditional probability is
proportional to the Joint probability
and we remember this by recalling that
the probability of a given B is just
some constant Factor Alpha multiplied by
the probability of A and B that constant
Factor Alpha turns out to be like
dividing over the probability of B but
the important thing is that it's just
some constant multiplied by The Joint
distribution the probability that all of
these individual things happen so in
this case I can take the probability of
the appointment random variable given
light rain and no track maintenance and
say that is just going to be
proportional some constant Alpha
multiplied by The Joint probability the
probability of a particular value for
the appointment random variable and
light rain and no track maintenance
well all right how do I calculate this
probability of appointment and light
rain and no track maintenance when what
I really care about is knowing like I
need all four of these values to be able
to calculate a joint distribution across
everything
because in a particular appointment
depends upon the value of train
well in order to do that here I can
begin to use that marginalization trick
that there are only two ways I can get
any configuration of an appointment
light rain and no track maintenance
either this particular setting of
variables happens and the train is on
time or this particular setting of
variables happens and the train is
delayed those are two possible cases
that I would want to consider and if I
add those two cases up well then I get
the result just by adding up all of the
possibilities for the hidden variable or
variables if there are multiple but
since there's only one hidden variable
here train all I need to do is iterate
over all the possible values for that
hidden variable train and add up their
probabilities
so this probability expression here
becomes probability distribution over
appointment light no rain and training
is on time and the probability
distribution over the appointment light
rain no track maintenance and the train
is delayed for example so I take both of
the possible values for train go ahead
and add them up these are just joint
probabilities that we saw earlier how to
calculate just by going parent parent
parent and calculating those
probabilities and multiplying them
together and then you'll need to
normalize them at the end speaking at a
high level to make sure that everything
adds up to the number one
so the formula for how you do this in a
process known as inference by
enumeration looks a little bit
complicated but ultimately it looks like
this and let's now try to distill what
it is that all of these symbols actually
mean let's start here what I care about
knowing is the probability of X my query
variable given some sort of evidence
what do I know about conditional
probabilities will a conditional
probability is proportional to the Joint
probability so it's some Alpha some
normalizing constant multiplied by this
joint probability of X and evidence
and how do I calculate that well to do
that I'm going to marginalize over all
of the Hidden variables all the
variables that I don't directly observe
the values for I'm basically going to
iterate over all of the possibilities
that it could happen and just sum them
all up and so I can translate this into
a sum over all Y which ranges over all
the possible hidden variables and the
values that they could take on
and adds up all of those possible
individual probabilities and that is
going to allow me to do this process of
inference by enumeration now ultimately
it's pretty annoying if we as humans
have to do all this math for itself for
ourselves but turns out this is where
computers and AI can be particularly
helpful that we can program a computer
to understand a Bayesian Network to be
able to understand these inference
procedures and to be able to do these
calculations and using the information
you've seen here you could Implement a
Bayesian Network from scratch yourself
but turns out there are a lot of
libraries especially written in Python
that allow us to make it easier to do
the sort of probabilistic inference to
be able to take a Bayesian Network and
do these sorts of calculations so that
you don't need to know and understand
all of the underlying math though it's
helpful to have a general sense for how
it works but you just need to be able to
describe the structure of the network
and make queries in order to be able to
produce the result
and so let's take a look at an example
of that right now it turns out that
there are a lot of possible libraries
that exist in Python for doing the sort
of inference it doesn't matter too much
which specific Library you use they all
behave in Fairly similar ways but the
library I'm going to use here is one
known as pomegranate and here inside of
model.pi I have defined a Bayesian
Network just using the structure and the
syntax of the pomegranate Library
expects and what I'm effectively doing
is just in Python creating nodes to
represent each of the nodes of the
Bayesian Network that you saw me
describe a moment ago so here on line
four after I've imported pomegranate I'm
defining a variable called rain that is
going to represent a node inside of my
Bayesian Network it's going to be a node
that behave follows this distribution
where there are three possible values
none for no rain light for light rain
heavy for heavy rain and these are the
probabilities of each of those taking
place 0.7 is the likelihood of no rain
0.2 for light rain
0.1 for heavy Ray
then after that we go to the next
variable the variable for track
maintenance for example which is
dependent upon that rain variable and
this instead of being an unconditional
distribution is a conditional
distribution as indicated by a
conditional probability table here and
the idea is that I'm following this is
conditional on the distribution of rain
so if there is no rain then the chance
that there is yes track maintenance is
0.4 if there's no rain the chance that
there's no track maintenance of 0.6
likewise for light Ray and I have a
distribution for heavy rain I have a
distribution as well but I'm effectively
encoding the same information you saw
represented graphically a moment ago but
I'm telling this Python program that the
maintenance node obeys this particular
conditional probability distribution and
we do the same thing for the other
random variables as well
train was a node inside my distribution
that was a conditional probability table
with two parents it was dependent not
only on rain but also on track
maintenance and so here I'm saying
something like given that there is no
rain and yes track maintenance the
probability that my train is on time is
0.8 and the probability that it's
delayed is 0.2 and likewise I can do the
same thing for all of the other possible
values of the parents of the train node
inside of my Bayesian Network by saying
for all of those possible values here is
the distribution that the train node
should follow
and I do the same thing for an
appointment based on the distribution of
the variable train
then at the end what I do is actually
construct this network by describing
what the states of the network are and
by adding edges between the dependent
nodes so I create a new Bayesian Network
add states to it one for rain one for
maintenance one for the train one for
the appointment and then I add edges
connecting the related pieces rain has
an arrow to maintenance because rain
influences track maintenance rain also
influences the train maintenance also
influences the train and train
influences whether I make it to my
appointment and bake just finalizes the
model and does some additional
computation so the specific syntax of
this is not really the important part
pomegranate just happens to be one of
several different libraries that can all
be used for similar purposes and you
could describe describe and Define a
library for yourself that implemented
similar things but the key idea here is
that someone can design a library for a
general Bayesian Network that has nodes
that are based upon its parents and then
all a programmer needs to do using one
of those libraries is to Define what
those nodes and what those ability
distributions are and we can begin to do
some interesting logic based on it so
let's try doing that like conditional or
joint probability calculation that we
saw us do by hand before by going into
likelihood dot Pi where here I'm
importing the model that I just defined
a moment ago and here I'd just like to
calculate model.probability which
calculates the probability for a given
observation and I'd like to calculate
the probability of no rain no track
maintenance my train is on time and I'm
able to attend the meeting so sort of
the optimal scenario that there's no
rain and no maintenance on the track my
train is on time and I'm able to attend
the meeting what is the probability that
all of that actually happens and I can
calculate that using the library and
just print out its probability
and so I'll go ahead and run python of
likelihood.pi
and I see that okay the probability is
about 0.34 so about a third of the time
everything goes right for me in this
case no rain no track maintenance train
is on time and I'm able to attend the
meeting but I could experiment with this
try and calculate other probabilities as
well what's the probability that
everything goes right up until the train
but I still miss my meeting so no rain
no track maintenance train is on time
but I missed the appointment let's
calculate that probability and to write
that has a probability of about 0.04 so
about four percent of the time the train
will be on time there won't be any rain
no track maintenance and yet I'll still
miss the meeting
and so this is really just an
implementation of the calculation of the
joint probabilities that we did before
what this library is likely doing is
first figuring out the probability of no
rain then figuring out the probability
of no track maintenance given no rain
then the probability that my train is on
time given both of these values and then
the probability that I miss my
appointment given that I know that the
train was on time so this again is the
calculation of that joint probability
and turns out we can also begin to have
our computer solve inference problems as
well to begin to infer based on
information evidence that we see what is
the likelihood of other variables also
being true
so let's go into inference.pi for
example we're here I'm again importing
that exact same model from before
importing all the nodes and all the
edges and the probability distribution
that is encoded there as well and now
there's a function for doing some sort
of prediction and here into this model I
pass in the evidence that I observe so
here I've encoded into this Python
program the evidence that I have
observed I have observed the fact that
the train is delayed and that is the
value for one of the four random
variables inside of this Bayesian
Network and using that information I
would like to be able to draw in
inspiration and figure out inferences
about the values of the other random
variables that are inside of my Bayesian
Network I would like to make predictions
about everything else so all of the
actual computational logic is happening
in just these three lines where I'm
making this call to this prediction down
below I'm just iterating over all of the
states and all the predictions and just
printing them out so that we can
visually see what the results are but
let's find out given the train is
delayed what can I predict about the
values of the other random variables
let's go ahead and run python
inference.pi
I run that and all right here is the
result that I get given the fact that I
know that the train is delayed this is
evidence that I have observed well given
that there is a 45 chance or a 46 chance
that there was no rain a 31 chance there
was light rain or 23 chance it was Heavy
Rain I can see a probability
distribution over track maintenance and
a probability distribution over whether
I'm able to attend or miss my
appointment now we know that whether I
attend or miss the appointment that is
only dependent upon the train being
delayed or not delayed it shouldn't
depend on anything else so let's imagine
for example that I knew that there was
Heavy Rain that shouldn't affect the
distribution for making the appointment
and indeed if I go up here and add some
evidence say that I know that the value
of rain is heavy that is evidence that I
now have access to I now have two pieces
of evidence I know that the rain is
heavy and I know that my train is
delayed
I can calculate the probability by
running this inference procedure again
and seeing the result
I know that the rain is heavy I know my
train is delayed the probability
distribution for track maintenance
changed given that I know that there's
heavy rain now it's more likely that
there's no track maintenance 88 percent
as opposed to 64 from here before
and now what is the probability that I
make the appointment well that's the
same as before it's still going to be
attend the appointment with probability
0.6 missed the appointment with
probability 0.4 because it was only
dependent upon whether or not my train
was on time or delayed and so this here
is implementing that idea of that
inference algorithm to be able to figure
out based on the evidence that I have
what can we infer about the values of
the other variables that exist as well
so inference by enumeration is one way
of doing this inference procedure just
looping over all of the values the
hidden variables could take on and
figuring out what the probability is
now it turns out this is not
particularly efficient and there are
definitely optimizations you can make by
avoiding repeated work if you're
calculating the same sort of probability
multiple times there are ways of
optimizing the program to avoid having
to recalculate the same probabilities
again and again but even then as the
number of variables get large as the
number of possible values those
variables could take on get large we're
going to start to have to do a lot of
computation a lot of calculation to be
able to do this inference and at that
point it might start to get unreasonable
in terms of the amount of time that it
would take to be able to do this sort of
exact inference and it's for that reason
that oftentimes when it comes towards
probability and things we're not
entirely sure about we don't always care
about doing exact inference and knowing
exactly what the probability is but if
we can approximate the inference
procedure do some sort of approximate
inference that that can be pretty good
as well that if I don't know the exact
probability but I have a general sense
for the probability that I can get
increasingly accurate with more time
that that's probably pretty good
especially if I can get that to happen
even faster
so how could I do approximate inference
inside of a Bayesian Network well one
method is through a procedure known as
sampling in the process of sampling I'm
going to take a sample of all of the
variables inside of this Bayesian
Network here and how I'm going to sample
well I'm going to sample one of the
values from each of these nodes
according to their probability
distribution so how might I take a
sample of all these nodes well I'll
start at the root I'll start with rain
here's the distribution for rain and
I'll go ahead and using a random number
generator or something like it randomly
pick one of these three values I'll pick
none with probability 0.7 light with
probability 0.2 and heavy with
probability 0.1 so I'll randomly just
pick one of them according to that
distribution and maybe in this case I
pick none for example
then I do the same thing for the other
variable maintenance also has a
probability distribution and I'm going
to sample now there are three
probability distributions here but I'm
only going to sample from this first row
here because I've observed already in my
sample that the value of rain is none so
given that rain is none I'm going to
sample from this distribution to say all
right what should the value of
Maintenance be and in this case
maintenance is going to be let's just
say yes which happens forty percent of
the time in the event that there is no
rain for example
and we'll sample all the rest of the
nodes in this way as well that I want to
sample from the train distribution and
I'll sample from this first row here
where there is no rain but there is
track maintenance and I'll sample 80
percent of the time I'll say the train
is on time 20 of the time I'll say the
train is delayed and finally we'll do
the same thing for whether I make it to
my appointment or not did I attend or
miss the appointment we'll sample based
on this distribution and maybe say that
in this case I attend the appointment
which happens 90 of the time when the
train is actually on time
so by going through these nodes I can
very quickly just do some sampling and
get a sample of the possible values that
could come up from going through this
entire Bayesian Network according to
those probability distributions and
where this becomes powerful is if I do
this not once but I do this thousands or
tens of thousands of times and generate
a whole bunch of samples all using this
distribution I get different samples
maybe some of them are the same but I
get a value
for each of the possible variables that
could come up
and so then if I'm ever faced with a
question a question like what is the
probability that the train is on time
you could do an exact inference
procedure this is no different than the
inference problem we had before where I
could just marginalize look at all the
possible other values of the variables
and do the computation of inference by
enumeration to find out this probability
exactly
but I could also if I don't care about
the exact probability just sample it
approximate it to get close and this is
a powerful tool in AI where we don't
need to be right 100 of the time or we
don't need to be exactly right if we
just need to be right with some
probability we can often do so more
effectively more efficiently
and so here now are all of those
possible samples I'll sort of highlight
the ones where the train is on time I'm
ignoring the ones where the train is
delayed and you know in this case
there's like six out of eight of the
samples have the train is arriving on
time and so maybe in this case I can say
that in six out of eight cases that's
the likelihood that the train is on time
and with eight samples that might not be
a great prediction but if I had
thousands upon thousands of samples then
this could be a much better inference
procedure to be able to do these sorts
of calculations so this is a direct
sampling method to just do a bunch of
samples and then figure out what the
probability of some event is
now this from before was an
unconditional probability what is the
probability that the train is on time
and I did that by looking at all the
samples and figuring out right here are
the ones where the train is on time
but sometimes what I'll want to
calculate is not an unconditional
probability but rather a conditional
probability something like what is the
probability that there is light rain
given that the train is on time
something to that effect and to do that
kind of calculation well what I might do
is
here are all the samples that I have and
I want to calculate a probability
distribution given that I know that the
train is on time so to be able to do
that I can kind of look at the two cases
where the train was delayed in and
ignore or reject them sort of exclude
them from the possible samples that I'm
considering and now I want to look at
these remaining cases where the train is
on time here are the cases where there's
light rain and I say okay these are two
out of the six possible cases that can
give me an approximation for the
probability of light rain given the fact
that I know the train was on time and I
did that in almost exactly the same way
just by adding an additional step by
saying that all right when I take each
sample let me reject all of the samples
that don't match my evidence and only
consider the samples that do match what
it is that I have in my evidence
that I want to make some sort of
calculation about
and it turns out using the libraries
that we've had for Bayesian Networks
we can begin to implement the same sort
of idea like Implement rejection
sampling which is what this method is
called to be able to figure out some
probability not via direct inference but
instead by sampling so what I have here
is a program called sample.pi Imports
the exact same model and what I defined
first is a program to generate a sample
and the way I generate a sample is just
by looping over all of the states the
states need to be in some sort of order
to make sure I'm looping in the correct
order but effectively if it is a
conditional distribution I'm going to
sample based on the parents and
otherwise I'm just going to directly
sample the variable like rain which has
no parents it's just an unconditional
distribution and keep track of all those
parent samples and return the final
sample the exact syntax of this again
not particularly important it just
happens to be part of the implementation
details of this particular Library the
interesting logic is down below now that
I have the ability to generate a sample
if I want to know the distribution of
the appointment random variable given
that the train is delayed well then I
can begin to do calculations like this
let me take 10 000 samples and assemble
all my results in this list called Data
I'll go ahead and loop n times in this
case 10 000 times I'll generate a sample
and I want to know the distribution of
appointment given that the train is
delayed so according to rejection
sampling I'm only going to consider
samples where the train is delayed if
the Train's not delayed I'm not going to
consider those values at all so I'm
going to say all right if I take the
sample look at the value of the train
random variable if the train is delayed
well let me go ahead and add to my data
that I'm collecting the value of the
appointment random variable that took
that it took on in this particular
sample so I'm only considering the
samples where the train is delayed and
for each of those samples considering
what the value of appointment is and
then at the end I'm using a python class
called counter which quickly counts up
all the values inside of a data set so I
can take this list of data and figure
out how many times was my appointment
made and how many times was my
appointment missed
and so this here with just a couple
lines of code is an implementation of
rejection sampling and I can run it by
going ahead and running python sample.pi
and when I do that here's the result I
get this is the result of the counter
1251 times I was able to attend the
meeting and 856 times I was able to miss
the meeting and you can imagine by doing
more and more samples I'll be able to
get a better and better more accurate
result and this is a randomized process
it's going to be an approximation of the
probability if I run at a different time
you'll notice the numbers are similar
1272 and 905 but they're not identical
because there's some randomization some
likelihood that things might be higher
or lower and so this is why we generally
want to try and use more samples so that
we can have a greater amount of
confidence in our result be more sure
about the result that we're getting of
whether or not it accurately reflects or
represents the actual underlying
probabilities that are inherent inside
of this distribution
and so this then was an instance of
rejection sampling and it turns out
there are a number of other sampling
methods that you could use to begin to
try to sample one problem that rejection
sampling has is that if the evidence
you're looking for is a fairly unlikely
event well you're going to be rejecting
a lot of samples like if I'm looking for
the probability of x given some evidence
e if e is very unlikely to occur like
occurs maybe one every thousand times
then I'm only going to be considering
one out of every thousand samples that I
do which is a pretty inefficient method
for trying to do this sort of
calculation I'm throwing away a lot of
samples and it takes computational
effort to be able to generate those
samples so I'd like to not have to do
something like that so there are other
sampling methods that can try and
address this one such sampling method is
called likelihood weighting in
likelihood waiting we follow a slightly
different procedure and the goal is to
avoid needing to throw out samples that
didn't match the evidence and so what
we'll do is we'll start by fixing the
values for the evidence variables rather
than sample everything we're going to
fix the values of the evidence variables
and not sample those
then we're going to sample all the other
non-evidence variables in the same way
just using the Bayesian Network looking
at the probability distributions
sampling all the non-evidence variables
but then what we need to do is weight
each sample by its likelihood right if
our evidence is really unlikely we want
to make sure that we've taken into
account How likely was the evidence to
actually show up in the sample if I have
a sample where the evidence was much
more likely to show up than another
sample then I want to weight the more
likely one higher so we're going to
weight each sample by its likelihood
where likelihood is just defined as the
probability of all of the evidence given
all the evidence we have what is the
probability that it would happen in that
particular sample so before all of our
samples were weighted equally they all
had a weight of one when we were
calculating like the overall average in
this case we're going to weight each
sample multiply each sample by its
likelihood in order to get the more
accurate distribution
so what would this look like well if I
ask the same question what is the
probability of light rain given that the
train is on time when I do the sampling
procedure and start by trying to sample
I'm going to start by fixing the
evidence variable I'm already going to
have in my sample the train is on time
that way I don't have to throw out
anything I'm only sampling the things
where I know the value of the variables
that are my evidence are what I expect
them to be
so we'll go ahead and sample from rain
and maybe this time I sample light rain
instead of no rain then I'll sample from
track maintenance and say maybe yes
there's track maintenance then for Trane
well I've already fixed it in place
Trane was an Evidence variable so I'm
not going to bother sampling again I'll
just go ahead and move on I'll move on
to appointment and go ahead and sample
from appointment as well
so now I've generated a sample I've
generated a sample by fixing this
evidence variable and sampling the other
three
and the last step is now weighting the
sample like how much weight should it
have and the weight is based on like how
probable is it that the train was
actually on time this evidence actually
happened given the values of these other
variables light rain and the fact that
yes there was track maintenance
well to do that I can just go back to
the train variable and say all right if
there was light rain and track
maintenance the likelihood of my
evidence the likelihood that my train
was on time is 0.6 and so this train
this particular sample would have a
weight of 0.6 and I could repeat the
sampling procedure again and again each
time every sample would be given a
weight according to the probability of
the evidence that I see associated with
it
and there are other sampling methods
that exist as well but all of them are
designed to try and get it the same idea
to approximate the inference procedure
of figuring out the value of a variable
so we've now dealt with probability as
it pertains to particular variables that
have these discrete values but what we
haven't really considered is how values
might change over time that we've
considered something like a variable for
rain where rain can take on values of
none or light rain or heavy rain but in
practice usually when we consider values
for variables like rain we like to
consider it for over time how do the
values of these variables change what do
we do with when we're dealing with
uncertainty over a period of time which
can come up in the context of weather
for example if I have sunny days and I
have rainy days and I'd like to know not
just like what is the probability that
it's raining now
but what is the probability that it
rains tomorrow or the day after that or
the day after that and so to do this
we're going to introduce a slightly
different kind of model but here we're
going to have a random variable not just
one for the weather but for every
possible time step and you can Define
time step however you like a simple way
is just to use days as your time step
and so we can define a variable called x
sub T which is going to be the weather
at time T So X Sub 0 might be the
weather on day 0 x sub 1 might be the
weather on day one so on and so forth x
sub 2 is the weather on day two
but as you can imagine if we start to do
this over longer and longer periods of
time there's an incredible amount of
data that might go into this if you're
keeping track of data about the weather
for a year now suddenly you might be
trying to predict the weather tomorrow
given 365 days of previous pieces of
evidence and that's a lot of evidence to
have to deal with and manipulate and
calculate probably nobody knows what the
exact conditional probability
distribution is for all of those
combinations of variables and so when
we're trying to do this inference inside
of a computer when we're trying to
reasonably do this sort of analysis
it's helpful to make some simplifying
assumptions some assumptions about the
problem that we can just assume are true
to make our lives a little bit easier
even if they're not totally accurate
assumptions if they're close to Accurate
or approximate they're usually pretty
good and the Assumption we're going to
make is called the Markov assumption
which is the assumption that the current
state depends only on a finite fixed
number of previous dates so the current
day's weather depends not on all the
previous day's weather for the rest of
for all of history but the current days
whether I can predict just based on
yesterday's weather or just based in the
last two days whether or the last three
days weather but oftentimes we're going
to deal with like just the one previous
state helps to predict this current
state
and by putting a whole bunch of these
random variables together using this
markup assumption we can create what's
called a Markov chain where a Markov
chain is just some sequence of random
variables where each of the variable's
distribution follows that Markov
assumption and so we'll do an example of
this where the markup assumption is I
can predict the weather is it sunny or
rainy or and we'll just consider those
two possibilities for now even though
there are other types of weather but I
can predict each day's weather just on
the prior day's weather using today's
weather I can come up with a probability
distribution for tomorrow's weather
and here's what this weather might look
like it's formatted in terms of a matrix
as you might describe it as sort of rows
and Columns of values
where on the left hand side I have
today's weather represented by the
variable x sub T and over here in the
columns I have tomorrow's weather
represented by the variable x sub t plus
one t plus one days weather instead and
what this Matrix is saying is if today
is sunny well then you know it's more
likely than not that tomorrow is also
Sunny oftentimes the weather stays
consistent for multiple days in a row
and for example let's say that if today
is sunny our model says that tomorrow
with probability 0.8 it will also be
sunny and with probability point two
what will be raining
and likewise If Today is raining then
it's more likely than not that tomorrow
is also raining with probability 0.7 and
it'll be rating with probability 0.3 uh
it will be sunny so this Matrix this
description of how it is we transition
from one state to the next state is what
we're going to call the transition model
and using the transition model you can
begin to construct this Markov Chain by
just predicting you know given today's
weather what's the likelihood of
tomorrow's weather happening and you can
imagine doing a simpler similar sampling
procedure where you take this
information you sample what tomorrow's
weather is going to be using that you
sample the next day's weather and the
result of that is you can form this
Markov chain of like x0 Time and Time
Day Zero with sunny the next day is
sunny maybe the next day it changes to
raining then raining then raining and
the pattern that this Markov chain
follows given the distribution that we
had access to this transition model here
is that when it's sunny it tends to stay
sunny for a little while the next couple
days tend to be sunny too
and when it's raining it tends to be
raining as well and so you get a Markov
chain that looks like this and you can
do analysis on this you can say you know
given that today is raining what is the
probability that tomorrow is raining or
you can begin to ask probability
questions like what is the probability
of this sequence of five values Sun Sun
rain rain and answer those sorts of
questions too and it turns out there
again many python libraries for
interacting with models like this of
probabilities that have distributions
and random variables that are based on
previous variables according to this
Markov assumption
and pomegranate 2 has ways of dealing
with these sorts of variables so I'll go
ahead and go into
the Markov or the I'll go ahead and go
into the chain directory where I have
some information about Markov chains and
here I've defined a file called model.pi
where I've defined in a very similar
syntax and again the exact syntax
doesn't matter so much as the idea that
I'm encoding this information into a
Python program so that the program has
access to these distributions I've here
defined some starting distribution so
every Markov model begins at some point
in time and I need to give it some
starting distribution and so we'll just
say you know at the start you can pick
50 50 between sunny and rainy we'll say
it's sunny 50 of the time rainy 50 of
the time and then down below I've here
to find the transition model how it is
that I transition from one day to the
next and here I've encoded that exact
same Matrix from before that if it was
sunny today then with probability 0.8 it
will be sunny tomorrow and it'll be
rainy tomorrow with probability 0.2 and
I likewise have another distribution for
if it was raining today instead
and so that alone defines the Markov
model you can begin to answer questions
using that model but one thing I'll just
do is sample from the Markov chain it
turns out there's a method built into
this Markov chain library that allows me
to sample 50 seats from the chain
basically just simulating like 50
instances of weather
and so let me go ahead and run this
python model.pi
and when I run it what I get is that
it's going to sample from this Markov
chain 50 states 50 days worth of weather
that it's just going to randomly sample
and you can imagine sampling many times
to be able to get more data to be able
to do more analysis But Here For example
it's you know sunny today and days in a
row raining a whole bunch of days in a
row before it changes back to Sun and so
you get this model that follows the
distribution that we originally
described that follows the distribution
of sunny days tend to lead to more sunny
days rainy days tend to lead to more
rainy days
and that then is a Markov model and
Markov models rely on us knowing the
values of these individual states I know
that today is sunny or that today is
raining and using that information I can
draw some sort of inference about what
tomorrow is going to be like
but in practice this often isn't the
case it often isn't the case that I know
for certain what the exact state of the
world is oftentimes the state of the
world is exactly unknown but I'm able to
somehow sense some information about
that state that a robot or an AI doesn't
have exact knowledge about the world
around it but it has some sort of sensor
whether that sensor is a camera or like
sensors that detect distance or just a
microphone that is sensing audio for
example it is sensing data and using
that data that data is somehow related
to the state of the world even if it
doesn't actually know our AI doesn't
know what the underlying true state of
the world actually is
and for that we need to get into the
world of sensor models the way of
describing how it is that we translate
what the hidden State the underlying
true state of the world is with what the
observation what it is that the AI knows
or the AI has access to actually is and
so for example
a hidden State might be a robot's
position if a robot is exploring new
Uncharted Territory the robot likely
doesn't know exactly where it is but it
does have an observation it has Robot
sensor data where it can sense you know
how far away are possible obstacles
around it and using that information
using the observed information that it
has it can infer something about the
hidden State because what the true
hidden state is influences those
observations whatever the robot's true
position is and affects or has some
effect upon what the sensor data of the
robot is able to collect is even if the
robot doesn't actually know for certain
what its true position is
likewise if you think about a voice
recognition or a speech recognition
program that listens to you and is able
to respond to you something like Alexa
or your um or what Apple and Google are
doing with their voice recognition as
well that you might imagine that the
hidden State the underlying state is
what words are actually spoken the true
nature of the world contains you saying
a particular sequence of words but your
phone or your Home Smart Home device
doesn't know for sure exactly what words
you said the only observation that the
AI has access to is like some audio
waveforms and those audio waveforms are
of course dependent upon this hidden
State and you can infer based on those
audio waveforms what the word spoken
likely were
but you might not know with a hundred
percent certainty what that hidden State
actually is and it might be a task to
try and predict given this observation
given these audio waveforms can you
figure out what the actual word spoken
are
likewise you might imagine on a website
true user engagement might be
information you don't directly have
access to but you can observe data like
website or app analytics about how often
was this button clicked or how often are
people interacting with a page in a
particular way and you can use that to
infer things about your users as well so
this type of problem comes up all the
time when we're dealing with AI and
trying to infer things about the world
and often AI doesn't really know the
hidden true state of the world all the
AI has access to is some observation
that is related to the hidden true state
but it's not direct there might be some
noise there the audio waveform might
have some additional noise it might be
difficult to parse the sensor data might
not be exactly correct there's some
noise that might not allow you to
conclude with certainty what the hidden
state is but can allow you to infer what
it might be
and so the simple example we'll take a
look at here is Imagining the hidden
State as the weather whether it's sunny
or rainy or not and imagine you are
programming an AI inside of a building
that maybe has access to just a camera
to inside the building and all you have
access to is an observation
as to whether or not employees are
bringing an umbrella into the building
or not you can detect whether it's an
umbrella or not
and so you might have an observation as
to whether or not an umbrella is brought
into the building or not and using that
information you want to predict whether
it's sunny or rainy even if you don't
know what the underlying weather is so
the underlying weather might be sunny
uranium and if it's raining obviously
people are more likely to bring an
umbrella and so whether or not people
bring an umbrella your observation tells
you something about the hidden State and
of course this is a bit of a contrived
example but the idea here is to think
about this more broadly in terms of more
generally Anytime You observe something
it having to do with some underlying
hidden state
and so to try and model this type of
idea where we have these hidden States
and observations rather than just use a
Markov model which has state state state
Each of which is connected by that
transition Matrix that we described
before we're going to use what we call a
hidden Markov model very similar to a
Markov model but this is going to allow
us to Model A system that has hidden
states that we don't directly observe
along with some observed event that we
do actually see and so in addition to
that transition model that we still need
of saying you know given the underlying
state of the world if it's sunny or
rainy what's the probability of
tomorrow's weather we also need another
model that given some state is going to
give us an observation of like green yes
someone brings an umbrella into the
office or red no nobody brings umbrellas
into the office and so the observation
might be
that if it's sunny then odds are
nobody's going to bring an umbrella to
the office but maybe some people are
just being cautious and they do bring an
umbrella to the office anyways and if
it's raining then with much higher
probability then people are going to
bring umbrellas into the office but
maybe if the rain was unexpected people
didn't bring an umbrella and so they
might have some other probability as
well so using the observations you can
begin to predict with reasonable
likelihood what the underlying state is
even if you don't actually get to
observe the underlying state if you
don't get to see what the hidden state
is actually equal to this here we'll
often call the sensor model it's also
often called the emission probabilities
because the state the underlying State
emits some sort of emission that you
then observe and so that can be another
way of describing that same idea
and the sensor Markov assumption that
we're going to use is this an assumption
that the evidence variable the thing we
observe the emission that gets produced
depends only on the corresponding State
meaning I can predict whether or not
people will bring umbrellas or not
entirely dependent just on whether it is
sunny or rainy today of course again
this assumption might not hold in
practice that in practice it might
depend whether or not people bring
umbrellas might depend not just on
today's weather but also in yesterday's
weather and the day before but for
simplification purposes it can be
helpful to apply this sort of assumption
just to allow us to be able to reason
about these probabilities a little more
easily and if we're able to approximate
it we can still often get a very good
answer
and so what these hidden Markov models
end up looking like is a little
something like this where now rather
than just have one chain of States like
sun sun rain rain we instead have this
upper level which is the underlying
state of the world is it sunny or is it
rainy and those are connected by that
transition Matrix we described before
but each of these States produces an
emission produces an observation that I
see that on this day it was sunny and
people didn't bring umbrellas and on
this day it was sunny but people did
bring umbrellas and on this day it was
raining and people did bring umbrellas
and so on and so forth and so each of
these underlying States represented by x
sub t for x sub 1 0 1 2 so on and so
forth produces some sort of observation
or emission which is what the E stands
for E Sub Zero e sub 1 E sub 2 so on and
so forth and so this too is a way of
trying to represent this idea and what
you want to think about is that these
underlying states are the true nature of
the world the robot's position as it
moves over time and that produces some
sort of sensor data that might be
observed or what people are actually
saying and using the emission data of
what audio waveforms do you detect in
order to process that data and try and
figure it out and there are a number of
possible tasks that you might want to do
given this kind of information and one
of the simplest is trying to infer
something about the future or the past
or about these sort of hidden states
that might exist and so the tasks that
you'll often see and we're not going to
go into the mathematics of these tasks
but they're all based on the same idea
of conditional probabilities and using
the probability distributions we have to
draw these sorts of conclusions
one task is called filtering which is
given observations from the start until
now calculate the distribution for the
current state meaning you know given
information about from the beginning of
time until now on which days the people
bring an umbrella or not bring an
umbrella can I calculate the probability
of the current state that today is it
sunny or is it raining another task that
might be possible is prediction which is
looking towards the future given
observations about people bringing
umbrellas from the beginning of the when
we started accounting time until now can
I figure out the distribution that
tomorrow is it sunny or is it raining
and you can also go backwards as well by
a smoothing where I can say given
observations from start until now
calculate the distributions for some
past State like I know that today people
brought umbrellas and Tomorrow People
brought umbrellas and so given two days
worth of data of people bringing
umbrellas what's the probability that
yesterday it was raining and that I know
that people brought umbrellas today that
might inform that decision as well it
might influence those probabilities and
there's also
a most likely explanation task in
addition to other tasks that might exist
as well which is combining some of these
given observations from the start up
until now figuring out the most likely
sequence of states and this is what
we're going to take a look at now this
idea that if I have all these
observations umbrella no umbrella
umbrella no umbrella can I calculate the
most likely states of sun rain Sun rain
and whatnot that actually represented
the true weather that would produce
these observations and this is quite
common when you're trying to do
something like voice recognition for
example that you have these emissions of
these audio waveforms and you would like
to calculate based on all of the
observations that you have what is the
most likely sequence of actual words or
syllables or sounds that the user
actually made when they were speaking to
this particular device or other tasks
that might come up in that context as
well
and so we can try this out by going
ahead and going into the hmm directory
hmm for hidden Markov model
and here
what I've done is I've defined a model
where this model first defines my
possible State Sun and Rain along with
their emission probabilities the
observation model or the emission model
where here given that I know that it's
sunny the probability that I see people
bring an umbrella is 0.2 the probability
of no umbrella is 0.8 and likewise if
it's raining then people are more likely
to bring an umbrella umbrella has
probability 0.9 no umbrella has probably
0.1 so the actual underlying hidden
States those states are sun and rain but
the things that I observe the
observations that I can see are either
umbrella or no umbrella as the things
that I observe as a result
so this then I also need to add to it a
transition Matrix same as before saying
that if today is sunny then tomorrow is
more likely to be sunny and if today is
rainy then tomorrow is more likely to be
raining as with before I give it some
starting probabilities saying at first
you know 50 50 chance for whether it's
sunny or rainy and then I can create the
model based on that information again
the exact syntax of this is not so
important so much as it is the data that
I am now encoding into a program such
that now
I can begin to do some inference so I
can give my program for example a list
of observations you know umbrella
umbrella no umbrella umbrella umbrella
so on and so forth no umbrella no
umbrella and I would like to calculate I
would like to figure out the most likely
explanation for these observations what
is likely is is with the rain rain is
this rain or is it more likely that this
was actually sunny and then it switched
back to it being rainy and you know
that's an interesting question we might
not be sure because it might just be
that it just so happened on this rainy
day people decided not to bring an
umbrella or it could be that it switched
from rainy to Sunny back to rainy which
doesn't seem too likely but it certainly
could happen
and using the data we give to the hidden
Markov model our model can begin to
predict these answers and begin to
figure it out so we're going to go ahead
and just predict these observations and
then for each of those predictions go
ahead and print out what the prediction
is and this Library just so happens to
have a function called predict that does
this prediction process for me
so I run python sequence.pi
and the result I get is this this is the
prediction based on the observations of
what all of those states are likely to
be and it's likely to be rain and rain
in this case it thinks that will most
likely happen is that it was sunny for a
day and then went back to being rainy
but in different situations it was
raining for longer maybe or if the
probabilities were slightly different
you might imagine that it's more likely
that it was raining all the way through
and it just so happened on one rainy day
people decided not to bring umbrellas
and so here to python libraries can
begin to allow for the sort of inference
procedure and by taking what we know and
by putting it in terms of these tasks
that already exist these General tasks
that work with hidden Markov models then
anytime we can take an idea and
formulate it as a hidden Markov model
formulate it as something that has
hidden States and observed emissions
that result from those States then we
can take advantage of these algorithms
that are known to exist for trying to do
this sort of inference so now we've seen
a couple of ways that AI can begin to
deal with uncertainty we've taken a look
at probability and how we can use
probability to describe numerically
things that are likely or more likely or
less likely to happen than other events
or other variables and using that
information we can begin to construct
these standard types of models things
like Bayesian networks and Markov chains
and hidden Markov models that all allow
us to be able to describe how particular
events relate to other events or how the
values of particular variables relate to
other variables not for certain but with
some sort of probability distribution
and by formulating things in terms of
these models that already exist we can
take advantage of python libraries that
Implement these sort of models already
and allow us just to be able to use them
to produce some sort of resulting effect
so all of this then allows our AI to
begin to deal with these sort of
Uncertain problems so that our AI
doesn't need to know things for certain
but can infer based on information it
doesn't know next time we'll take a look
at additional types of problems that we
can solve by taking advantage of AI
related algorithms even beyond the world
of the types of problems we've already
explored we'll see you next time
[Music]
okay welcome back everyone to an
introduction to artificial intelligence
with python and now so far we've taken a
look at a couple of different types of
problems we've seen classical search
problems where we're trying to get from
an initial state to a goal by figuring
out some optimal path we've taken a look
at adversarial search where we have a
game playing Agent that is trying to
make the best move we've seen
knowledge-based problems where we're
trying to use logic and inference to be
able to figure out and draw some
additional conclusions and we've seen
some probabilistic models as well where
we might not have certain information
about the world but we want to use the
knowledge about probabilities that we do
have to be able to draw some conclusions
today we're going to turn our attention
to another category of problems
generally known as optimization problems
where optimization is really all about
choosing the best option from a set of
possible options and we've already seen
optimization in some contexts like game
playing where we're trying to create an
AI that chooses the best move out of a
set of possible moves but what we'll
take a look at today is a category of
types of problems and algorithms to
solve them that can be used in order to
deal with a broader range of potential
optimization problems and the first of
the algorithms that we'll take a look at
is known as a local search and local
search differs from search algorithms
we've seen before in the sense that the
search algorithms we've looked at so far
which are things like breadth first
search or a star search for example
generally maintain a whole bunch of
different paths that were simultaneously
exploring and we're looking at a bunch
of different paths at once trying to
find our way to the solution on the
other hand in local search this is going
to be a search algorithm that's really
just going to maintain a single node
looking at a single state and will
generally run this algorithm by
maintaining that single node and then
moving ourselves to one of the
neighboring nodes throughout this search
process and this is generally useful in
context not like these problems which
we've seen before like a maze solving
situation where we're trying to find our
way from the initial state to the goal
by following some path but local search
is most applicable when we really don't
care about the path at all and all we
care about is what the solution is and
in the case of a solving a maze the
solution was always obvious you could
point to the solution you know exactly
what the goal is and the real question
is what is the path to get there but
local search is going to come up in
cases where figuring out exactly what
the solution is exactly what the goal
looks like is actually the heart of the
challenge
and to give an example of one of these
kinds of problems we'll consider a
scenario where we have two types of
buildings for example we have houses and
hospitals and our goal might be in a
world that's formatted as this grid
where we have a whole bunch of houses a
house here house here two houses over
there maybe we want to try and find a
way to place two hospitals on this map
so maybe a hospital here and a hospital
there and the problem now is we want to
place two hospitals on the map but we
want to do so with some sort of
objective and our objective in this case
is to try and minimize the distance of
any of the houses from a hospital so you
might imagine all right what's the
distance from each of the houses to
their nearest hospital there are a
number of ways we could calculate that
distance but one way is using a heurist
if we've looked up before which is the
Manhattan distance this idea of how many
rows and columns would you have to move
inside of this grid layout in order to
get to a hospital for example and it
turns out if you take each of these four
houses and figure out all right how
close are they to their nearest hospital
you get something like this where this
house is 300 away from a hospital this
house is six away these two houses are
reached four away and if you add all
those numbers up together you get a
total cost of 17 for example so for this
particular configuration of hospitals a
hospital here and a hospital there that
state we might say has a cost of 17. and
the goal of this problem now that we
would like to apply a search algorithm
to figure out is can you solve this
problem to find a way to minimize that
cost minimize the total amount if you
sum up all of the distances from all the
houses to the nearest hospital how can
we minimize that final value
and if we think about this problem a
little bit more abstractly abstracting
away from this specific problem and
thinking more generally about problems
like it you can often formulate these
problems by thinking about them as a
state Space Landscape as we'll see them
call it here in this diagram of a state
Space Landscape each of these vertical
bars represents a particular state that
our world could be in so for example
each of these vertical bars represents a
particular configuration of two
hospitals and the height of this
vertical bar is generally going to
represent some function of that state
some value of that state so maybe in
this case the height of the vertical bar
represents what is the cost of this
particular configuration of hospitals in
terms of what is the sum total of all
the distances from all of the houses to
their nearest hospital
and generally speaking when we have a
state-space landscape we want to do one
of two things we might be trying to
maximize the value of this function
trying to find a global maximum so to
speak of this state-space landscape a
single state whose value is higher than
all of the other states that we could
possibly choose from and generally in
this case when we're trying to find a
global maximum we'll call the function
that we're trying to optimize them some
objective function some function that
measures for any given State how good is
that state such that we can take any
state pass it into the objective
function and get a value for how good
that state is and ultimately what our
goal is is to find one of these states
that has the highest possible value for
that objective function
an equivalent but reverse problem is the
problem of finding a global minimum some
state that has a value after you pass it
into this function that is lower than
all of the other possible values that we
might choose from and generally speaking
when we're trying to find a global
minimum we call the function that we're
calculating a cost function generally
each state has some sort of cost whether
that cost is a monetary cost or a Time
cost or in the case of the houses and
hospitals we've been looking at just now
a distance cost in terms of how far away
each of the houses is from a hospital
and we're trying to minimize the cost
find the state that has the lowest
possible value of that cost
so these are the general types of ideas
we might be trying to go for within a
state-space landscape trying to find a
global maximum or trying to find a
global minimum and how exactly do we do
that well recall that in local search we
generally operate this algorithm by
maintaining just a single state just
some current state represented inside of
some node maybe inside of a data
structure where we're keeping track of
where we are currently and then
ultimately what we're going to do is
from that state move to one of its
neighbor States so in this case
represented in this one-dimensional
space by just the state immediately to
the left or to the right of it but for
any different problem you might Define
what it means for there to be a neighbor
of a particular state in the case of a
hospitals for example that we were just
looking at a neighbor might be moving
One hospital one space to the left or to
the right or up or down some state that
is close to our current state but
slightly different and as a result might
have a slightly different value in terms
of its objective function or in terms of
its cost function
so this is going to be our general
strategy in local search to be able to
take a state maintaining some current
node and move where we're looking at in
the state Space Landscape in order to
try to find a global maximum or a global
minimum somehow and perhaps the simplest
of algorithms that we could use to
implement this idea of local search is
an algorithm known as Hill climate and
the basic idea of hill climbing is let's
say I'm trying to maximize the value of
my state I'm trying to figure out where
the global maximum is I'm going to start
at a state and generally what hill
climbing is going to do is it's going to
consider the neighbors of that state
that from this state you know all right
I could go left or I could go right and
this neighbor happens to be higher and
this neighbor happens to be lower and in
hill climbing if I'm trying to maximize
the value I'll generally pick the
highest when I can between the state to
the left and right of me this one is
higher so we'll go ahead and move myself
to consider that state instead and then
I'll repeat this process continually
looking at all of my neighbors and
picking the highest neighbor doing the
same thing looking at my neighbors
picking the highest of my neighbors
until I get to a point like right here
where I consider both of my neighbors
and both of my neighbors have a lower
value than I do this current state has a
value that is higher than any of its
neighbors and at that point the
algorithm terminates and I can say all
right here I have now found the solution
and the same thing works in exactly the
opposite way for trying to find a global
minimum but the algorithm is
fundamentally the same if I'm trying to
find a global minimum and say my current
state starts here I'll continually look
at my neighbors pick the lowest value
that I possibly can until I eventually
hopefully find that Global minimum a
point at which when I look at both of my
neighbors they each have a higher value
and I'm trying to minimize the total
score or cost or value that I get as a
result of calculating some sort of cost
function
so we can formulate this graphical idea
in terms of pseudocode and the pseudo
code for hill climbing might look like
this we Define some function called Hill
Climb that takes us input the problem
that we're trying to solve and generally
we're going to start in some sort of
initial state so I'll start with a
variable called current that is keeping
track of my initial State like an
initial configuration of hospitals and
maybe some problems lend themselves to
an initial State someplace where you
begin in other cases maybe not in which
case we might just randomly generate
some initial State just by choosing two
locations for hospitals at random for
example and figuring out from there how
we might be able to improve but that
initial State we're going to store
inside of current
and now here comes our Loop some
repetitive process we're going to do
again and again until the algorithm
terminates and what we're going to do
his first say let's figure out all of
the neighbors of the current state from
my state what are all of the neighboring
states for some definition of what it
means to be a neighbor and I'll go ahead
and choose the highest value of all of
those neighbors and save it inside of
this variable called Neighbor so keep
track of the highest valued neighbor
this is in the case where I'm trying to
maximize the value in the case where I'm
trying to minimize the value you might
imagine here you'll pick the neighbor
with the lowest possible value but these
ideas are really fundamentally
interchangeable and it's possible in
some cases there might be multiple
neighbors that each have an equally high
value or an equally low value in the
minimizing case and in that case we can
just choose randomly from among them
just choose one of them and save it
inside of this variable neighbor
and then the key question to ask is is
this neighbor better than my current
state
and if the neighbor the best neighbor
that I was able to find is not better
than my current state
well then the algorithm is over and I'll
just go ahead and return the current
state if none of my neighbors are better
then I may as well stay where I am is
the general logic of the hill climbing
algorithm but otherwise if the neighbor
is better then I may as well move to
that neighbor so you might imagine
setting current equal to neighbor where
the general idea is if I'm at a current
state and I see a neighbor that is
better than me then I'll go ahead and
move there and then I'll repeat the
process continually moving to a better
neighbor until I reach a point at which
none of my neighbors are better than I
am and at that point we'd say the
algorithm can just terminate there
so let's take a look at a real example
of this with these houses and hospitals
so we've seen now that if we put the
hospitals in these two locations that
has a total cost of 17 and now we need
to Define if we're going to implement
this hill climbing algorithm what it
means to take this particular
configuration of hospitals this
particular State and get a neighbor of
that state and a simple definition of
neighbor might be just let's pick one of
the hospitals and move it by one square
to the left or right or up or down for
example and that would mean we have six
possible Neighbors from this particular
configuration we could take this
hospital and move it to any of these
three possible squares or we take this
hospital and move it to any of those
three possible squares and each of those
would generate a neighbor
and what I might do is say all right
here's the locations and the distances
between each of the houses and their
nearest hospital let me consider all of
the neighbors and see if any of them can
do better than a cost of 17. and it
turns out there are a couple of ways
that we could do that and it doesn't
matter if we randomly choose among all
the ways that are the best but one such
possible way is by taking a look at this
hospital here and considering the
directions in which it might move if we
hold this Hospital constant if we take
this hospital and move it one square up
for example that doesn't really help us
it gets closer to the house up here but
it gets further away from the house down
here and it doesn't really change
anything for the two houses along the
left hand side
but if we take this Hospital on the
right and move it one square down it's
the opposite problem it gets further
away from the house up above and it gets
closer to the house down below the real
idea the goal should be to be able to
take this hospital and move it one
square to the left by moving at one
square to the left we move it closer to
both of these houses on the right
without changing anything about the
houses on the left for them this
hospital was still the closer one so
they aren't affected so we're able to
improve the situation by picking a
neighbor that results in a decrease in
our total cost and so we might do that
move ourselves from this current state
to a neighbor by just taking that
hospital and moving it
and at this point there's not a whole
lot that can be done with this hospital
but there's still other optimizations we
can make other neighbors we can move to
that are going to have a better value if
we consider this hospital for example we
might imagine that right now it's a bit
far up that both of these houses are a
little bit lower so we might be able to
do better by taking this hospital and
moving it one square down moving it down
so that now instead of a cost of 15
we're down to a cost of 13 for this
particular configuration and we can do
even better by taking the hospital and
moving it one square to the left now
instead of a cost of 13 we have a cost
of 11 because this house is one away
from the hospital this one is far away
this one is three away and this one is
also three away so we've been able to do
much better than that initial cost that
we had using the initial configuration
just by taking every state and asking
ourselves the question can we do better
by just making small incremental changes
moving to a neighbor moving to a
neighbor and moving to a neighbor after
that
and now at this point we can potentially
see that at this point the algorithm is
going to terminate there's actually no
neighbor we can move to that is going to
improve the situation get us a cost that
is less than 11. because if we take this
hospital and move it up or to the right
well that's going to make it further
away if we take it and move it down that
doesn't really change the situation it
gets further away from this house but
closer to that house and likewise the
same story was true for this Hospital
any neighbor we move it to up left down
or right is either going to make it
further away from the houses and
increase the cost or it's going to have
no effect on the cost whatsoever
and so the question we might now ask is
is this the best we could do is this the
best placement of the hospitals we could
possibly have and it turns out the
answer is no because there's a better
way that we could place these hospitals
and in particular there are a number of
ways you could do this but one of the
ways is by taking this hospital here and
moving it to this Square for example
moving it diagonally by one square which
was not part of our definition of
neighbor we could only move left right
up or down but this is in fact better it
has a total cost of nine it is now
closer to both of these houses and as a
result the total cost is less
but we weren't able to find it because
in order to get there we had to go
through a state that actually wasn't any
better than the current state that we
had been on previously and so this
appears to be a limitation or a concern
you might have as you go about trying to
implement a hill climbing algorithm is
that it might not always give you the
optimal solution
if we're trying to maximize the value of
any particular State we're trying to
find the global maximum a concern might
be that we could get stuck at one of the
local Maxima highlighted here in blue
where a local Maxima is any state whose
value is higher than any of its
neighbors if we ever find ourselves at
one of these two states when we're
trying to maximize the value of the
state we're not going to make any
changes we're not going to move left or
right we're not going to move left here
because those states are worse but yet
we haven't found the global Optimum we
haven't done as best as we could do and
likewise in the case of the hospitals
what we're ultimately trying to do is
find a global minimum find a value that
is lower than all of the others but we
have the potential to get stuck at one
of the local Minima any of these states
whose value is lower than all of its
neighbors but still not as low as the
local minimum and so the takeaway here
is that it's not always going to be the
case that when we run this naive hill
climbing algorithm that we're always
going to find the optimal solution there
are things that could go wrong if we
started here for example and tried to
maximize our value as much as possible
we might move to the highest possible
neighbor move to the highest possible
neighbor and stop and never realize that
there's actually a better State way over
there that we could have gone to instead
and other problems you might imagine
just by taking a look at the state Space
Landscape are these various different
types of plateaus something like this
flat local maximum here where all six of
these states each have the exact same
value and so in the case of the
algorithm we showed before none of the
neighbors are better so we might just
get stuck at this flat local maximum and
even if you allowed yourself to move to
one of the neighbors it wouldn't be
clear which neighbor you would
ultimately move to and you could get
stuck here as well and there's another
one over here this one is called a
shoulder it's not really a local maximum
because there's still places where we
can go higher not local minimum because
we can go lower so we can still make
progress but it's still this flat area
where if you have a local search
algorithm that is potential to get lost
here unable to make some upward or
downward progress depending on whether
we're trying to maximize or minimize it
and therefore another potential for us
to be able to find a solution that might
not actually be the optimal solution
and so because of this potential the
potential that hill climbing has to not
always find us the optimal result it
turns out there are a number of
different varieties and variations on
the hill climbing algorithm that help to
solve the problem better depending on
the context and depending on the
specific type of problem some of these
variants might be more applicable than
others what we've taken a look at so far
is a version of hill climbing generally
called steepest Ascent hill climbing
where the idea of steepest Ascent hill
climbing is we are going to choose the
highest valued Neighbor In the case
where we're trying to maximize or the
lowest valued neighbor in cases where
we're trying to minimize but generally
speaking if I have five neighbors and
they're all better than my current state
I will pick the best one of those five
now sometimes that might work pretty
well it's sort of a greedy approach of
trying to take the best operation at any
particular time step but it might not
always work there might be cases where
actually I want to choose an option that
is slightly better than me but maybe not
the best one because that later on might
lead to a better outcome ultimately so
there are other variants we might
consider of this space the kill climbing
algorithm one is known as stochastico
climbing and in this case we choose
randomly from all of our higher value
neighbors so if I'm at my current state
and there are five neighbors that are
all better than I am rather than
choosing the best one as steepest a
certain would do stochastic will just
choose randomly from one of them
thinking that if it's better then it's
better and maybe there's a potential to
make forward progress even if it is not
locally the best option I could possibly
choose
First Choice hill climbing ends up just
choosing the very first highest valued
neighbor that follows behaving on a
similar idea rather than consider all of
the neighbors as soon as we find a
neighbor that is better than our current
state we'll go ahead and move there so
maybe some efficiency improvements there
and maybe has the potential to find a
solution that the other strategies
weren't able to find and with all of
these variants we still suffer from the
same potential risk this risk that we
might end up at a local minimum or a
local maximum and we can reduce that
risk by repeating the process multiple
times so one variant of hill climbing is
random restart hill climbing where the
general idea is we'll conduct hill
climbing multiple times if we apply as
steepest descent hill climbing for
example we'll start at some random State
try and figure out how to solve the
problem and figure out what is the local
maximum or local minimum we get to and
then we'll just randomly restart and try
again choose a new starting
configuration try and figure out what
the local maximum or minimum is and do
this some number of times and then after
we've done it some number of times we
can pick the best one out of all of the
ones that we've taken a look at so
there's another option we have access to
as well and then although I said the
generally local search will usually just
keep track of a single node and then
move to one of its neighbors there are
variants of hill climbing that are known
as local beam searches where rather than
keep track of just one current best
state we're keeping track of K highest
valued neighbors such that rather than
starting at one random initial
configuration I might start with three
or four or five randomly generate all
the neighbors and then pick like the
three or four or five best of all of the
neighbors that I find and continually
repeat this process with the idea being
that now I have more options that I'm
considering more ways that I could
potentially navigate myself to the
optimal solution that might exist for a
particular problem
so let's now take a look at some actual
code that can Implement some of these
kinds of ideas something like steepest
Ascent hill climbing for example for
trying to solve this Hospital problem
so I'm going to go ahead and go into my
hospitals directory where I've actually
set up the basic framework for solving
this type of problem I'll go ahead and
go into hospitals.pi and we'll take a
look at the code we've created here I've
defined a class that is going to
represent the state space so the space
has a height and a width and also some
number of hospitals so you can configure
how big is your map how many hospitals
should go here
we have a function for adding a new
house to the state space and then some
functions that are going to get me all
of the available spaces for if I want to
like randomly Place hospitals in
particular locations and here now is the
hill climbing algorithm so what are we
going to do in the hill climbing
algorithm well we're going to start by
randomly initializing where the
hospitals are going to go we don't know
where the hospitals should actually be
so let's just randomly place them so
here I'm running a loop for each of the
hospitals that I have I'm going to go
ahead and add a new hospital at some
random location so I basically get all
of the available spaces and I randomly
choose one of them as where I would like
to add this particular Hospital
I have some logging output and
generating some images which we'll take
a look at a little bit later but here is
the key idea so I'm going to just keep
repeating this algorithm I could specify
a maximum of how many times I want it to
run or I could just run it up until it
hits local maximum or local minimum
and now we'll basically consider all of
the hospitals that could potentially
move so consider each of the two
hospitals or more hospitals if they're
more than that and consider all of the
places where that hospital could move to
some neighbor of that hospital that we
can move the neighbor to
and then see you know is this going to
be better than where we were currently
so if it is going to be better then
we'll go ahead and update our best
neighbor and keep track of this new best
neighbor that we found
and then afterwards we can ask ourselves
the question if best neighbor cost is
greater than or equal to the cost of the
current set of hospitals meaning if the
cost of our best neighbor is greater
than the current cost meaning our best
neighbor is worse than our current state
well then we shouldn't make any changes
at all and we should just go ahead and
return the current set of hospitals but
otherwise we can update our hospitals in
order to change them to one of the best
neighbors and if there are multiple that
are all equivalent I'm here using
random.choice to say go ahead and choose
one randomly so this is really just a
python implementation of that same idea
that we were just talking about this
idea of taking a current state some
current set of hospitals generating all
of the neighbors looking at all the ways
we could take one hospital and move it
one square to the left or right or up or
down and then figuring out based on all
of that information which is the best
neighbor or the set of all the best
neighbors and then choosing from one of
those
and each time we go ahead and generate
an image in order to do that
and so now what we're doing is if we
look down at the bottom I'm going to
randomly generate a space with height 10
and width 20 and I'll say go ahead and
put three hospitals somewhere in the
space I'll randomly generate 15 houses
that I just go ahead and add in random
locations and now I'm going to run this
hill climbing algorithm in order to try
and figure out where we should Place
those hospitals
so I'll go ahead and run this program by
running python hospitals
and we see that we started our initial
state had a cost of 72 but we were able
to continually find neighbors that were
able to decrease that cost decrease to
69 66 63 so on and so forth all the way
down to 53 as the best neighbor we were
able to ultimately find and we can take
a look at what that looked like by just
opening up these files so here for
example was the initial configuration we
randomly selected a location for each of
these 15 different houses and then
randomly selected locations for one two
three hospitals that were just located
somewhere inside of the state space and
if you add up all the distances from
each of the houses to their nearest
hospital you get a total cost of about
72. and so now the question is what
neighbors can we move to that improve
this situation and it looks like the
first one the algorithm found was by
taking this house that was over there on
the right and just moving it to the left
and that probably makes sense because if
you look at the houses in that general
area really these five houses look like
they're probably the ones that are going
to be close assist to this Hospital over
here moving it to the left decreases the
total distance at least to most of these
houses so it does increase that distance
for one of them and so we're able to
make these improvements to the situation
by continually finding ways that we can
move these hospitals around
until we eventually settle at this
particular state that has a cost of 53
where we figured out a position for each
of the hospitalism and now none of the
neighbors that we could move to are
actually going to improve the situation
we can take this hospital and this
hospital and that hospital and look at
each of the neighbors and none of those
are going to be better than this
particular configuration and again
that's not to say that this is the best
we could do there might be some other
configuration of hospitals that is a
global minimum and this might just be a
local minimum that is the best of all of
its neighbors but maybe not the best in
the entire possible State space and you
could search through the entire State
Space by considering all of the possible
configurations for hospitals But
ultimately that's going to be very time
intensive especially as our state space
gets bigger and there might be more and
more possible States it's going to take
quite a long time to look through all of
them and so being able to use these sort
of local search algorithms can often be
quite good for trying to find the best
solution we can do and especially if we
don't care about doing the best possible
and we just care about doing pretty good
and finding a pretty good placement of
those hospitals then these methods can
be particularly powerful
but of course we can try and mitigate
some of this concern by instead of using
hill climbing to use random restart this
idea of rather than just Hill Climb one
time we can Hill Climb multiple times
and say try hill climbing a whole bunch
of times on the exact same map and
figure out what is the best one that
we've been able to find and so I've here
implemented a function for random
restart that restarts some maximum
number of times
and what we're going to do is repeat
that number of times this process of
just go ahead and run the hill climbing
algorithm figure out what the cost is of
getting from all the houses to the
hospitals and then figure out is this
better than we've done so far so I can
try this exact same idea where instead
of running hill climbing I'll go ahead
and run random restart
and I'll randomly restart maybe 20 times
for example
and we'll go ahead and now I'll remove
all the images and then rerun the
program
and now we started by finding a original
state when we initially ran hill
climbing the best cost we were able to
find was 56 each of these iterations is
a different iteration of the hill
climbing algorithm we're running hill
climbing not one time but 20 times here
each time going until we find a local
minimum in this case and we look and see
each time did we do better than we did
the best time we've done so far so we
went from 56 to 46 this one was greater
so we ignored it this one was 41 which
was less so we went ahead and kept that
one and for all of the remaining 16
times that we tried to implement uh hill
climbing and we tried to run the hill
climbing algorithm we couldn't do any
better than that 41. again maybe there
is a way to do better that we just
didn't find but it looks like that way
ended up being a pretty good solution to
the problem that was attempt number
three starting from Counting at zero so
we can take a look at that open up
number three and this was the state that
happened to have a cost of 41 that after
running the hill climbing algorithm on
some particular random initial
configuration of hospitals this is what
we found was the local minimum in terms
of Trying to minimize the cost and it
looks like we did pretty well that this
hospital is pretty close to this region
this one is pretty close to these houses
here this Hospital looks about as good
as we can do for trying to capture those
houses over on that side and so these
sorts of algorithms can be quite useful
for trying to solve these problems
but the real problem with many of these
different types of hill climbing
steepest of some stochastic first choice
and so forth is that they never make a
move that makes our situation worse
right they're always going to take
ourselves in our current state look at
the neighbors and consider can we do
better than our current state and move
to one of those Neighbors which of those
neighbors we choose might vary among
these various different types of
algorithms but we never go from a
current position to a position that is
worse than our current position and
ultimately that's what we're going to
need to do if we want to be able to find
a global maximum or a global minimum
because sometimes if we get stuck we
want to find some way of dislodging
ourselves from our local maximum or
local minimum in order to find the
global maximum or the global minimum or
increase the probability that we do find
it and so the most popular technique for
trying to approach the problem from that
angle is a technique known as simulated
annealing simulated because it's
modeling after a real physical process
of annealing where you can think about
this in terms of physics a physical
situation where you have some system of
particles and you might imagine that
when you heat up a particular physical
system there's a lot of energy there
things are moving around quite randomly
but over time as the system cools down
it eventually settles into some final
position and that's going to be the
general idea of simulated annealing
we're going to simulate that process of
some high temperature system where
things are moving around randomly quite
frequently but over time decreasing that
temperature until we eventually settle
at our ultimate solution and the idea is
going to be if we have some state-spaced
landscape that looks like this and we
begin
at its initial State here if we're
looking for a global maximum and we're
trying to maximize the value of the
state our traditional hill climbing
algorithms would just take this state
and look at the two neighbor ones and
always pick the one that is going to
increase the value of the state but if
we want some chance of being able to
find the global maximum we can't always
make good moves
we have to sometimes make bad moves and
allow ourselves to make a move in a
Direction
that actually seems for now to make our
situation worse such that later we can
find our way up to
that Global maximum in terms of trying
to solve that problem of course once we
get up to this Global maximum once we've
done a whole lot of the searching then
we probably don't want to be moving to
states that are worse than our current
state and so this is where this metaphor
for annealing starts to come in where we
want to start making more random moves
and over time start to make fewer of
those random moves based on a particular
temperature schedule
so the basic outline looks something
like this early on in simulated
annealing we have a higher temperature
State and what we mean by a higher
temperature state is that we are more
likely to accept neighbors that are
worse than our current state we might
look at our neighbors and if one of our
neighbors is worse than the current
state especially if it's not all that
much worse if it's pretty close but just
slightly worse then we might be more
likely to accept that and go ahead and
move to that neighbor anyways
but later on as we run simulated
annealing we're going to decrease that
temperature and at a lower temperature
we're going to be less likely to accept
neighbors that are worse than our
current state
now to formalize this and put a little
bit of pseudocode to it here is what
that algorithm might look like we have a
function called simulated annealing that
takes us input the problem we're trying
to solve and also potentially some
maximum number of times we might want to
run the simulated annealing process how
many different neighbors are we going to
try and look for and that value is going
to vary based on the problem you're
trying to solve
we'll again start with some current
state that will be equal to the initial
state of the problem but now we need to
repeat this process over and over for
max number of times repeat some process
some number of times where we're first
going to calculate a temperature and
this temperature function takes the
current time T starting at 1 going all
the way up to Max and then gives us some
temperature that we can use in our
computation where the idea is that this
temperature is going to be higher early
on and it's going to be lower later on
so there are a number of ways this
temperature function could often work
one of the simplest ways is just to say
it is like the proportion of time that
we still have remaining out of like Max
units of time how much time do we have
remaining you start off with a lot of
that time remaining and as time goes on
the temperature is going to decrease
because you have less and less of that
remaining time still available to you
so we calculate a temperature for the
current time and then we pick a random
neighbor of the current state no longer
are we going to be picking the best
neighbor that we possibly can or just
one of the better neighbors that we can
we're going to pick a random neighbor it
might be better it might be worse but
we're going to calculate that we're
going to calculate Delta e e for energy
in this case which is just how much
better is the neighbor than the current
state so if Delta e is positive that
means the neighbor is better than our
current state if Delta e is negative
that means the neighbor is worse than
our current state and so we can then
have a condition that looks like this if
Delta e is greater than zero that means
the neighbor state is better than our
current state and if ever that situation
arises we'll just go ahead and update
current to be that neighbor same as
before move where we are currently to be
the neighbor because the neighbor is
better than our current state we'll go
ahead and accept that but now the
difference is that whereas before we
never ever wanted to take a move that
made our situation worse now we
sometimes want to make a move that is
actually going to make our situation
worse because sometimes we're going to
need to dislodge ourselves from a local
minimum or local maximum to increase the
probability that we're able to find the
global minimum or the global maximum a
little bit later
and so how do we do that how do we
decide to sometimes accept some state
that might actually be worse well we're
going to accept a worse state with some
probability and that probability needs
to be based on a couple of factors it
needs to be based in part on the
temperature where if the temperature is
higher we're more likely to move to a
worse neighbor and if the temperature is
lower we're less likely to move to a
worse neighbor but also to some degree
should be based on Delta e if the
neighbor is much worse than the current
state we probably want to be less likely
to choose that than if the neighbor is
just a little bit worse than the current
state
so again there are a couple of ways you
could calculate this but it turns out
one of the most popular is just to
calculate e to the power of Delta e over
T where e is just a constant Delta e
over T are based on Delta e and t here
we calculate that value and that'll be
some value between 0 and 1 and that is
the probability with which we should
just say all right let's go ahead and
move to that neighbor and it turns out
that if you do the math for this value
when Delta e is such that the neighbor
is not that much worse than the current
state that's going to be more likely
that we're going to go ahead and move to
that state and likewise when the
temperature is lower we're going to be
less likely to move to that neighboring
state as well
so now this is the big picture for
simulated and healing this process of
taking the problem and going ahead and
generating random neighbors will always
move to a neighbor if it's better than
our current state but even if the
neighbor is worse than our current state
will sometimes move there depending on
how much worse it is and also based on
the temperature and as a result the hope
the goal of this whole process is that
as we begin to try and find our way to
the local the global maximum or the
global minimum we can dislodge ourselves
if we ever get stuck at a local maximum
or local minimum in order to eventually
make our way to exploring the part of
the state space that is going to be the
best and then as the temperature
decreases eventually we settle there
without moving around too much from what
we've found to be the globally best
thing that we can do thus far so at the
very end we just return whatever the
current state happens to be and that is
the conclusion of this algorithm we've
been able to figure out what the
solution is
and these types of algorithms have a lot
of different applications anytime you
can take a problem and formulate it as
something where you can explore a
particular configuration and then ask
are any of the neighbors better than
this current configuration and have some
way of measuring that then there's an
applicable case for these hill climbing
simulated annealing types of algorithms
so sometimes it can be for facility
location type problems like for when
you're trying to plan a city and figure
out where the hospitals should be but
there are definitely other applications
as well and one of the most famous
problems in computer science is the
traveling salesman problem traveling
salesman problem generally is formulated
like this I have a whole bunch of cities
here indicated by these dots and what
I'd like to do is find some route that
takes me through all of the cities and
ends up back where I started so some
route that like starts here goes through
all these cities and ends up back where
I originally started and what I might
like to do is minimize the total
distance that I have to travel in order
or the total cost of taking this entire
path and you can imagine this is a
problem that's very applicable in
situations like uh when delivery
companies are trying to deliver things
to a whole bunch of different houses
they want to figure out how do I get
from the warehouse to all these various
different houses and get back again all
using as minimal time and distance and
energy as possible so you might want to
try to solve these sorts of problems but
it turns out that solving this
particular kind of problem is very
computationally difficult it's a very
computationally expensive task to be
able to figure it out this falls under
the category of what are known as NP
complete problems problems that there is
no known efficient way to try and solve
these sorts of problems and so what we
ultimately have to do is come up with
some approximation some ways of trying
to find a good solution even if we're
not going to find the globally best
solution that we possibly can at least
not in a feasible or tractable amount of
time
and so what we could do is take the
traveling salesman problem and try to
formulate it using local search and ask
a question like all right I can pick
some State some configuration some route
between all of these nodes and I can
measure the cost of that state figure
out what the distance is and I might now
want to try to minimize that cost as
much as possible
and then the only question now is what
does it mean to have a neighbor of the
state what does it mean to take this
particular route and have some
neighboring route that is close to it
but slightly different such that it
might have a different total distance
and there are a number of different
definitions for what a neighbor of a
traveling salesman configuration might
look like but one way is just to say a
neighbor is what happens if we pick two
of these edges between nodes and switch
them effectively
so for example I might pick these two
edges here these two that just happen to
cross this node goes here this node goes
there
and go ahead and switch them and what
that process will generally look like is
removing both of these edges from the
graph taking this node and connecting it
to the node it wasn't connected to so
connecting it up here instead we'll need
to take these arrows that were
originally going this way and reverse
them except move them going the other
way and then just fill in that last
remaining blank add an arrow that goes
in that direction instead so by taking
two edges and just switching them I have
been able to consider one possible
neighbor of this particular
configuration and it looks like this
neighbor is actually better it looks
like this probably travels a shorter
distance in order to get through all the
cities through this route than the
current state did and so you could
imagine implementing this idea inside of
a hill climbing or simulated annealing
algorithm where we repeat this process
to try and take a state of this
traveling salesman problem look at all
the neighbors and then move to the
neighbors if they're better or maybe
even move to the neighbors if they're
worse until we eventually settle upon
some best solution that we've been able
to find
and it turns out that these types of
approximation algorithms even if they
don't always find the very best solution
can often do pretty well at trying to
find solutions that are helpful too
so that then was a look at local search
particular category of algorithms that
can be used for solving a particular
type of problem where we don't really
care about the path to the solution I
didn't care about the steps I took to
decide where the hospital should go I
just cared about the solution itself I
just care about where the hospitals
should be or what the route through the
traveling salesman Journey really ought
to be
another type of algorithm that might
come up are known as these categories of
linear programming types of problems and
linear programming often comes up in the
context where we're trying to optimize
for some mathematical function but
oftentimes linear programming will come
up when we might have real real numbered
values that it's not just like discrete
fixed values that we might have but any
decimal values that we might want to be
able to calculate and so linear
programming is a is a family of types of
problems where we might have a situation
that looks like this where the goal of
linear programming is to minimize a cost
function and you can invert the numbers
and say try and maximize it but often
we'll frame it as Trying to minimize a
cost function
that has some number of variables X1 X2
X3 all the way up to xn so some number
of variables that are involved things
that I want to know the values to and
this cost function might have
coefficients in front of those variables
and this is what we would call like a
linear equation where we just have all
of these variables that might be
multiplied by a coefficient and then
added together we're not going to square
anything or cube anything because
that'll give us different types of
equations with linear programming we're
just dealing with linear equations in
addition to linear constraints where a
constraint is going to look something
like if we sum up this particular
equation that is just some linear
combination of all of these variables it
is less than or equal to some bound B
and we might have a whole number of
these various different constraints that
we might Place onto our linear
programming exercise
and likewise just as we can have
constraints that are saying this linear
equation is less than or equal to some
bound B it might also be equal to
something that if you want some sum of
some combination of variables to be
equal to a value you can specify that
and we can also maybe specify that each
variable has lower and upper bounds that
it needs to be a positive number for
example or it needs to be a number that
is less than 50 for example and there
are a number of other choices we can
make there for defining what the bounds
of a variable are but it turns out that
if you can take a problem and formulate
it in these terms formulate the problem
as your goal is to minimize a cost
function and you're minimizing that cost
function subject to particular
constraints subjects to equations that
are of the form like this of some
sequence of variables is less than a
bound or is equal to some particular
value then there are a number of
algorithms that already exist for
solving these sorts of problems
so let's go ahead and take a look at an
example here's an example of a problem
that might come up in the world of
linear programming often this is going
to come up when we're trying to optimize
for something and we want to be able to
do some calculations and we have
constraints on what we're trying to
optimize them and so it might be
something like this in the context of a
factory we have two machines X1 and X2
X1 costs fifty dollars an hour to run X2
costs eighty dollars an hour to run and
our goal what we're trying to do our
objective is to minimize the total cost
so that's what we'd like to do but we
need to do so subject to certain
constraints so there might be a labor
constraint that X1 requires five units
of labor per hour X2 requires two units
of labor per hour and we have a total of
20 units of Labor that we have to spend
so this is a constraint we have no more
than 20 units of Labor that we can spend
and we have to spend it across X1 and X2
Each of which requires a different
amount of Labor
and we might also have a constraint like
this that tells us X1 is going to
produce 10 units of output per hour X2
is going to produce 12 units of output
per hour and the company needs 90 units
of output so we have some goal something
we need to achieve we need to achieve 90
units of output but there are some
constraints that X1 can only produce 10
units of output per hour X2 produces 12
units of output per hour these types of
problems come up quite frequently and
you can start to notice patterns in
these types of problems problems where I
am trying to optimize for some goal
minimizing cost maximizing output
maximizing profits or something like
that and there are constraints that are
placed on that process and so now we
just need to formulate this problem in
terms of linear equations
so let's start with this first point two
machines X1 and X2 X costs fifty dollars
an hour X2 costs eighty dollars an hour
here we can come up with an objective
function that might look like this this
is our cost function rather 50 times X1
plus 80 times X2 where X1 is going to be
a variable representing how many hours
do we run machine x14 X2 is going to be
are we running machine X2 for and what
we're trying to minimize is this cost
function which is just how much it costs
to run each of these machines per hour
summed up this is an example of a linear
equation just some combination of these
variables plus coefficients that are
placed in front of them and I would like
to minimize that total value but I need
to do so subject to these constraints X1
requires 50 units of labor per hour X2
requires two and we have a total of 20
units of Labor to spend and so that
gives us a constraint of this form
5 times X1 plus 2 times X2 is less than
or equal to 20. 20 is the total number
of units of Labor we have to spend and
that's spent across X1 and X2 Each of
which requires a different number of
units of labor per hour for example and
finally we have this constraint here X1
produces 10 units of output per hour X2
produces 12 and we need 90 units of
output and so this might look something
like this
that 10x1 plus 12x2 this is the amount
of output per hour it needs to be at
least 90. if we can do better great but
it needs to be at least 90. and if you
recall from my formulation before I said
that generally speaking in linear
programming we deal with equals
constraints or less than or equal to
constraints so we have a greater than or
equal to sign here that's not a problem
whenever we have a greater than or equal
to sign we can just multiply the
equation by negative one and that'll
flip it around to a less than or equals
negative 90 for example instead of a
greater than or equal to 90 and that's
going to be an equivalent expression
that we can use to represent this
problem
so now that we have this cost function
and these constraints that it's subject
to it turns out there are a number of
algorithms that can be used in order to
solve these types of problems and these
problems go a little bit more into
geometry and linear algebra than we're
really going to get into but the most
popular of these types of algorithms are
Simplex which was one of the first
algorithms discovered for trying to
solve linear programs and later on a
class of interior Point algorithms can
be used to solve this type of problem as
well the key is not to understand
exactly how these algorithms work but to
realize that these algorithms exist for
efficiently finding Solutions anytime we
have a problem of this particular form
and so we can take a look for example
at
the production directory here
where here I have a file called
production.pi where here I'm using scipy
which was the library for a lot of
science related functions within Python
and I can go ahead and just run this
optimization function in order to run a
linear program dot linprog here is going
to try and solve this linear program for
me where I provide to this expression to
this function call all of the data about
my linear program so it needs to be in a
particular format which might be a
little confusing at first but this first
argument to scipy.optimize.lin
programming is the cost function which
is in this case just an array or a list
that has 50 and 80 because my original
cost function was 50 times X1 plus 80
times X2 so I just tell python 50 and 80
those are the coefficients that I am now
trying to optimize for
and then I provide all of the
constraints so the constraints and I
wrote them up above in comments is the
constraint one is 5x1 plus 2x2 is less
than or equal to 20 and constraint 2 is
negative 10x1 plus negative 12x2 is less
than or equal to negative 90.
and so scipy expects these constraints
to be in a particular format it first
expects me to provide all of the
coefficients for the upper bound
equations u b just sort for upper bound
where the coefficients of the first
equation are five and two because we
have 5x1 and 2x2 and the coefficients
for the second equation are negative 10
and negative 12 because I have negative
10x1 plus negative 12x2
and then here we provide it as a
separate argument just to keep things
separate what the actual bound is what
is the upper Bound for each of these
constraints well for the first
constraint the upper bound is 20 that
was constraint number one and then for
constraint number two the upper bound is
90. so a bit of a cryptic way of
representing it it's not quite as simple
as just writing the mathematical
equations what really is being expected
here are all of the coefficients and all
of the numbers that are in these
equations by first providing the
coefficients for the cost function then
providing all the coefficients for the
inequality constraints and then
providing all of the upper bounds for
those inequality constraints and once
all of that information is there then we
can run any of these interior Point
algorithms or the Simplex algorithm even
if you don't understand how it works you
can just run the function
and figure out what the result should be
and here I said if the result is a
success we were able to solve this
problem go ahead and print out
what the value of X1 and X2 should be
otherwise go ahead and print out no
solution and so if I run this program by
running python
production dot pi
it takes a second to calculate but then
we see here is what the optimal solution
should be X1 should run for 1.5 hours X2
should run for 6.25 hours and we were
able to do this by just formulating the
problem as a linear equation that we
were trying to optimize some cost that
we were trying to minimize them and then
some constraints that were placed on
that and many many problems fall into
this category of problems that you can
solve if you can just figure out how to
use equations and use these constraints
to represent that general idea and
that's a theme that's going to come up a
couple of times today where we want to
be able to take some problem and reduce
it down to some problem we know how to
solve in order to begin to
find a solution and to use existing
methods that we can use in order to find
a solution more effectively or more
efficiently
and it turns out that these types of
problems where we have constraints show
up in other ways too and there's an
entire class of problems that's more
generally just known as constraint
satisfaction problems and we're going to
now take a look at how you might
formulate a constraint satisfaction
problem and how you might go about
solving a constraint satisfaction
problem but the basic idea of a
constraint satisfaction problem is we
have some number of variables that need
to take on some values and we need to
figure out what values each of those
variables should take on but those
variables are subject to particular
constraints that are going to limit what
values those variables can actually take
on
so let's take a look at a real world
example for example let's look at exam
scheduling that I have four students
here students one two three and four
each of them is taking some number of
different classes classes here are going
to be represented by letters so student
one is enrolled in courses a b and c
student two is enrolled in courses b d
and e so on and so forth and now say
University for example is trying to
schedule exams for all of these courses
but there are only three exam slots on
Monday Tuesday and Wednesday and we have
to schedule an exam for each of these
courses but the constraint now the
constraint we have to deal with with the
scheduling is that we don't want anyone
to have to take two exams on the same
day we would like to try and minimize
that or eliminate it if at all possible
so how do we begin to represent this
idea how do we structure this in a way
that a computer with an AI algorithm can
begin to try and solve the problem well
let's in particular just look at these
classes that we might take and represent
each of the courses them as some node
inside of a graph and what we'll do is
we'll create an edge between two nodes
in this graph if there is a constraint
between those two nodes
so what does this mean well we can start
with student one who's enrolled in
courses a b and c what that means is
that a and b can't have an exam at the
same time A and C can't have an exam at
the same time and B and C also can't
have an exam at the same time and I can
represent that in this graph by just
drawing edges one Edge between A and B
one between B and C and then one between
C and A and that encodes now the idea
that between those nodes there is a
constraint and in particular the
constraint happens to be that these two
can't be equal to each other though
there are other types of constraints
that are possible depending on the type
of problem that you're trying to solve
and then we can do the same thing for
each of the other students so for
student two who's enrolled in courses b
d and e well that means b d and e those
all need to have edges that connect each
other as well student three is enrolled
in courses c e and f so we'll go ahead
and take c e and f and connect those by
drawing edges between them two and then
finally student four is enrolled in
courses e f and g and we can represent
that by drawing edges between e f and g
although E and F already had an edge
between them we don't need another one
because this constraint is just encoding
the idea that course e and course F
cannot have an exam on the same day so
this then is what we might call the
constraint graph there's some graphical
representation of all of my variables so
to speak and the constraints between
those possible variables where in this
particular case each of the constraints
represents an inequality constraint then
an edge between b and d means whatever
value the variable B takes on cannot be
the value that the variable D takes on
as well
so what then actually is a constraint
satisfaction problem well a constraint
satisfaction problem is just some set of
variables X1 all the way through xn
some set of domains for each of those
variables so every variable needs to
take on some values maybe every variable
has the same domain but maybe each
variable has a slightly different domain
and then there's a set of constraints so
we'll just call a set C that is some
constraints that are placed upon these
variables like X1 is not equal to X2 but
it could be of other forms too like
maybe X1 equals X2 plus one if you if
these variables are taking on numerical
values in their domain for example the
types of constraints are going to vary
based on the types of problems
and constraint satisfaction shows up all
over the place as well in any situation
where we have variables that are subject
to particular constraints so one popular
game is sudoku for example this 9x9 grid
where you need to fill in numbers into
each of these cells but you don't want
to make sure there's you want to make
sure there's never a duplicate number in
any row or in any column or in any grid
of three by three cells for example so
what might this look like as a
constraint satisfaction problem well my
variables are all of the empty squares
in the puzzle so represented here is
just like an X comma y coordinate for
example as all of the squares where I
need to plug in a value where I don't
know what value it should take on
the domain
is just going to be all the numbers from
one through nine any value that I could
fill in to one of these cells so that is
going to be the domain for each of these
variables and then the constraints are
going to be of the form like this cell
can't be equal to this cell can't be
equal to the cell can't be and all these
need to be different for example and
same for all of the rows and the columns
and the three by three squares as well
so those constraints are going to
enforce what values are actually allowed
and we can formulate the same idea in
the case of this exam scheduling problem
where the variables we have are the
different courses a up through G the
domain for each of these variables is
going to be Monday Tuesday and Wednesday
those are the possible values each of
the variables can take on that in this
case just represent when is the exam for
that class
and then the constraints are of this
form a is not equal to B A is not equal
to C meaning A and B can't have an exam
on the same day A and C can't have an
exam on the same day or more formally
these two variables cannot take on the
same value within their domain
so that then is this formulation of a
constraint satisfaction problem that we
can begin to use to try and solve this
problem and constraints can come in a
number of different forms there are hard
constraints which are constraints that
must be satisfied for a correct solution
to something like in the Sudoku puzzle
you cannot have this cell and this cell
that are in the same row take on the
same value that is a hard constraint but
problems can also have soft constraints
where these are constraints that express
some notion of preference that maybe A
and B can't have an exam on the same day
but maybe someone has a preference that
A's exam is earlier than B's exam
doesn't need to be the case but some
expression that some solution is better
than another solution and in that case
you might formulate the problem as
trying to optimize for maximizing
people's preferences you want people's
preferences to be satisfied as much as
possible
in this case though we'll mostly just
deal with hard constraints constraints
that must be met in order to have a
correct solution to the problem so we
want to figure out some assignment of of
these variables to their particular
values that is ultimately going to give
us a solution to the problem by allowing
us to assign someday to each of the
classes such that we don't have any
conflicts between classes
so it turns out that we can classify the
constraints in a constraint satisfaction
problem into a number of different
categories the first of those categories
are perhaps the simplest of the types of
constraints which are known as unary
constraints where unary constraint is a
constraint that just involves a single
variable for example a unitary
constraint might be something like a
does not equal Monday meaning course a
cannot have its exam on Monday if for
some reason the instructor for the
course isn't available on Monday you
might have a constraint in your problem
that looks like this something that just
has a single variable a in it and maybe
says a is not equal to Monday or a is
equal to something or in the case of
numbers greater than or less than
something a constraint that just has one
variable we consider to be a unary
constraint and this is in contrast to
something like a binary constraint which
is a constraint that involves two
variables for example so this would be a
constraint like the ones we were looking
at before something like a does not
equal B is an example of a binary
constraint because it is a constraint
that has two variables in involved in an
A and B and we represented that using
some Arc or some Edge that connects
variable a to variable B and using this
knowledge of okay what is a unitary
constraint what is the binary constraint
there are different types of things we
can say about a particular constraint
satisfaction problem and one thing we
can say is we can try and make the
problem node consistent so what does
node consistency mean node consistency
means that we have all of the values in
a variable's domain satisfying that
variable as a unary constraints so for
each of the variables inside of our
constraint satisfaction problem if all
of the values satisfy the unary
constraints for that particular variable
we can say that the entire problem is
node consistent or we can even say that
a particular variable is node consistent
if we just want to make one node
consistent within itself
so what does that actually look like
let's look at now a simplified example
where instead of having a whole bunch of
different classes we just have two
classes A and B Each of which has an
exam on either Monday or Tuesday or
Wednesday so this is the domain for the
variable a and this is the domain for
the variable B
and now let's imagine we have these
constraints a not equal to Monday B not
equal to Tuesday B not equal to Monday a
not equal to B so those are the
constraints that we have on this
particular problem
and what we can now try to do is enforce
node consistency and node consistency
just means we make sure that all of the
values for any variable's domain satisfy
its unary constraints and so we could
start by trying to make node a node
consistent like is it consistent does
every value inside of A's domain satisfy
its unary constraints well initially
we'll see that Monday does not satisfy
A's unary constraints because we have a
constraint a unary constraint here that
a is not equal to Monday but Monday is
still in A's domain and so this is
something that is not node consistent
because we have Monday in the domain but
this is not a valid value for this
particular node and so how do we make
this node consistent well to make the
node node consistent what we'll do is
we'll just go ahead and remove Monday
from the A's domain now a can only be on
Tuesday or Wednesday because we have
this constraint that a is not equal to
Monday
and at this point now a is node
consistent for each of the values that a
can take on Tuesday and Wednesday there
is no constraint that is a unary
constraint that conflicts with that idea
there is no constraint that says that a
can't be Tuesday there's no unary
constraint that says that a cannot be on
Wednesday and so now we can turn our
attention to b b also has a domain
Monday Tuesday and Wednesday and we can
begin to see whether those variables
satisfy the unary constraints as well
well here's a unary constraint B is not
equal to Tuesday and that does not
appear to be satisfied by this domain of
Monday Tuesday and Wednesday because
Tuesday this possible value that the
variable B could take on is not
consistent with this unary constraint
that b is not equal to Tuesday so to
solve that problem we'll go ahead and
remove Tuesday from B's domain now B's
domain only contains Monday and
Wednesday but as it turns out there's
yet another unary constraint that we
placed on the variable B which is here B
is not equal to Monday
and that means that this value Monday
inside of B's domain is not consistent
with B's unary constraints because we
have a constraint that says the B cannot
be Monday and so we can remove Monday
from B's domain and now we've made it
through all of the unary constraints
we've not yet considered this constraint
which is a binary constraint but we've
considered all of the unary constraints
all the constraints that involve just a
single variable and we've made sure that
every node is consistent with those
unary constraints we can say that now we
have enforced node consistency that for
each of these possible nodes we can pick
any of these values in the domain and
there won't be a unary constraint that
is violated as a result of it
so node consistency is fairly easy to
enforce we just take each node make sure
the value from the domain satisfy the
unary constraints where things get a
little bit more interesting is when we
consider different types of consistency
something like Arc consistency for
example an arc consistency refers to
when all the values in a variable's
domain satisfy the variable's binary
constraints so when we're looking at
trying to make a Arc consistent we're no
longer just considering the unary
constraints that are involve a we're
trying to consider all of the binary
constraints that involve a as well so
any Edge that connects a to another
variable inside of that constrained
graph that we were taking a look at
before
put a little bit more formally Arc
consistency and Arc really is just
another word for like an edge that
connects two of these nodes inside of
our constraint graph we can Define our
consistency a little more precisely like
this in order to make some variable X
Arc consistent with respect to some
other variable y we need to remove any
element from X's domain to make sure
that every choice for X every choice in
X's domain has a possible choice for y
so put another way if I have a variable
X and I want to make X an arc consistent
then I'm going to look at all of the
possible values that X can take on and
make sure that for all of those possible
values there is still some choice that I
can make for y if there's some Arc
between X and Y to make sure that y has
a possible option that I can choose as
well
so let's look at an example of that
going back to this example but from
before we enforced node consistency
already by saying that a can only be on
Tuesday or Wednesday because we knew
that a could not be on Monday and we
also said that b is only domain only
consists of Wednesday because we know
the B does not equal Tuesday and also B
does not equal Monday
so now let's begin to consider Arc
consistency let's try and make a Arc
consistent with b and what that means is
to make a art consistent with respect to
b means that for any choice we make in
A's domain there is some choice we can
make in B's domain that is going to be
consistent and we can try that for a we
can choose Tuesday as a possible value
for a if I choose Tuesday for a is there
a value for B that satisfies the binary
constraint well yes B Wednesday would
satisfy this constraint that a does not
equal B Because Tuesday does not equal
Wednesday
however if we chose Wednesday for a well
then there is no choice in B's domain
that satisfies this binary constraint
there is no way I can choose something
for B that satisfies a does not equal B
because I know B must be Wednesday
and so if ever I run into a situation
like this where I see that here is a
possible value for a
such that there is no choice of value
for B that satisfies the binary
constraint well then this is not art
consistent and to make it art consistent
I would need to take Wednesday and
remove it from A's domain because
Wednesday was not going to be a possible
choice I could make for a because it
wasn't consistent with this binary
constraint for B there was no way I
could choose Wednesday for a and still
have an available Solution by choosing
something for b as well
so here now I've been able to enforce
Arc consistency and in doing so I've
actually solved this entire problem that
given these constraints where A and B
can have exams on either Monday or
Tuesday or Wednesday the only solution
as it would appear is that A's exam must
be on Tuesday and B's exam must be on
Wednesday and that is the only option
available to me
so if we want to apply our consistency
to a larger graph not just looking at
one particular pair of our consistency
there are ways we can do that too and we
can begin to formalize what the pseudo
code would look like for trying to write
an algorithm that enforces art
consistency and we'll start by defining
a function called revise revise is going
to take as input a CSP otherwise known
as a constraint satisfaction problem and
also two variables X and Y and what
revise is going to do is it is going to
make X Arc consistent with respect to Y
meaning remove anything from X's domain
that doesn't allow for a possible option
for y
how does this work well we'll go ahead
and first keep track of whether or not
we've made a revision revised is
ultimately going to return true or false
in order to turn true in the event that
we did make a revision to access domain
it'll return false if we didn't make any
change to X's domain and we'll see in a
moment why that's going to be helpful
but we start by saying revised equals
false we haven't made any changes
then we'll say all right let's go ahead
and loop over all of the possible values
in X's domain so Loop over X's domain
for each little X in X's domain I want
to make sure that for each of those
choices I have some available choice in
y that satisfies the binary constraints
that are defined inside of my CSP inside
of my constraint satisfaction problem so
if ever it's the case that there is no
value Y in y's domain that satisfies the
constraint for X and Y
well if that's the case that means that
this value X shouldn't be in X's domain
so I'll go ahead and delete X from X's
domain and I'll set revised equal to
true because I did change X's domain I
changed X's domain by removing Little X
and I removed Little X because it wasn't
art consistent and there was no way I
could choose a value for y that would
satisfy this X Y constraint
so in this case we'll go ahead and set
revised equal true and we'll do this
again and again for every value in X's
domain sometimes it might be fine in
other cases it might not allow for a
possible choice for y in which case we
need to remove this value from X's
domain and at the end we just return
revised to indicate whether or not we
actually made a change
so this function then this revised
function is effectively an
implementation of what you saw me do
graphically a moment ago and it makes
one variable X Arc consistent with
another variable in this case y
but generally speaking when we want to
enforce our consistency we'll often want
to enforce our consistency not just for
a single Arc but for the entire
constraint satisfaction problem and it
turns out there's an algorithm to do
that as well and that algorithm is known
as AC3 AC3 takes a constraint
satisfaction problem and it enforces art
consistency across the entire problem
how does it do that well it's going to
basically maintain a q or basically just
a line of all of the arcs that it needs
to make consistent and over time we
might remove things from that queue as
we begin dealing with art consistency
and we might need to add things to that
queue as well if there are more things
we need to make Arc consistent
so we'll go ahead and start with a cue
that contains all of the arcs in the
constraint satisfaction problem all of
the edges that connect to nodes that
have some sort of binary constraint
between them and now as long as the Q is
non-empty there is work to be done the
queue is all of the things that we need
to make are consistent so as long as the
queue is not empty there's still things
we have to do what do we have to do
well we'll start by dequeuing from the
queue remove something from the queue
and strictly speaking it doesn't need to
be a cube but a q is a traditional way
of doing this we'll DQ from the queue
and that'll give us an arc X and Y these
two variables where I would like to make
X are consistent with y
so how do we make X Art consistent with
Y well we can go ahead and just use that
revise function we talked about a moment
ago we called the revised function
passing as input the constraint
satisfaction problem and also these
variables X and Y because I want to make
X Arc consistent with Y in other words
remove any values from X's domain that
don't leave an available option for y
and recall what does revised return well
it returns true if we actually made a
change if we removed something from X's
domain because there wasn't an available
option for y for example and it returns
false if we didn't make any change to
X's domain at all and it turns out if
revise returns false if we didn't make
any changes well then there's not a
whole lot more work to be done here for
this Arc we can just move ahead to the
next Arc that's in the queue
but if we did make a change if we did
reduce X's domain by removing values
from X's domain well then what we might
realize is that this creates potential
problems later on that it might mean
that some Arc that was Arc consistent
with X that node might no longer be Arc
consistent with X because while there
used to be an option that we could
choose for X now there might not be
because now we might have removed
something from X that was necessary for
some other Arc to be Arc consistent and
so if ever we did revise X's domain
we're going to need to add some things
to the queue some additional arcs that
we might want to check how do we do that
well first thing we want to check is to
make sure that X's domain is not zero if
X's domain is zero that means there are
no available options for X at all and
that means that there's no way you can
solve the constraint and satisfaction
problem if we've removed everything from
X's domain we'll go ahead and just
return false here to indicate there's no
way to solve the problem because there's
nothing left in X's domain but otherwise
if there are things left in X's domain
but fewer things than before well then
what we'll do is we'll Loop over each
variable Z that is in all of x's and
neighbors except for y why we already
handled but we'll consider all of x's
others neighbors and ask ourselves all
right well that Arc from each of those
Z's to X that Arc might no longer be Arc
consistent because well for each Z there
might have been a possible option we
could choose for X to correspond with
each of these possible values now there
might not be because we removed some
elements from X's domain and so what
we'll do here is we'll go ahead and
enqueue adding something to the queue
this Arc ZX for all of those neighbors Z
so we need to add back some arcs to the
Q in order to continue to enforce our
consistency
at the very end if we make it through
all this process then we can return true
but this now is AC3 this algorithm for
enforcing Arc consistency on a
constraint satisfaction problem and the
big idea is really just keep track of
all of the arcs that we might need to
make art consistent make it art
consistent by calling the revised
function and if we did revise it then
there are some new arcs that might need
to be added to the queue in order to
make sure that everything is still are
consistent even after we've removed some
of the elements from a particular
variables domain
so what then would happen if we tried to
enforce our consistency on a graph like
this on a graph where each of these
variables has a domain of Monday Tuesday
and Wednesday well it turns out that by
enforcing art consistency on this graph
well it can solve some types of problems
nothing actually changes here for any
particular Arc just considering two
variables there's always a way for me to
just for any of the choices I make for
one of them make a choice for the other
one because there are three options and
I just need the two to be different from
each other so this is actually quite
easy to just take an arc and just
declare that it is Art consistent
because if I pick you know Monday for D
then I just pick something that isn't
Monday for B in art consistency we only
consider consistency between a binary
constraint between two nodes and we're
not really considering all of the rest
of the nodes yet
so just using AC3 the enforcement of art
consistency that can sometimes have the
effect of reducing domains to make it
easier to find Solutions but it will not
always actually solve the problem we
might still need to somehow search to
try and find a solution and we can use
classical traditional search algorithms
to try to do so you'll recall that a
search problem generally consists of
these parts we have some initial State
some actions a transition model that
takes me from one state to another state
a goal test to tell me have I satisfied
my objective correctly and then some
path cost function because in the case
of like maze solving I was trying to get
to my goal as quickly as possible
so you could formulate a CSP or a
constraint satisfaction problem as one
of these types of search problems the
initial state will just be an empty
assignment where an assignment is just a
way for me to assign any particular
variable to any particular value so if
an empty assignment is no variables are
assigned to any values yet
then the action I can take is adding
some new variable equals value pair to
that assignment saying for this
assignment let me add a new value for
this variable
and the transition model just defines
what happens when you take that action
you get a new assignment that has that
variable equal to that value inside of
it the gold test is just checking to
make sure all the variables have been
assigned and making sure all the
constraints have been satisfied and the
path cost function sort of irrelevant I
don't really care about what the path
really is I just care about finding some
assignment that actually satisfies all
of the constraints so really all the
paths have the same cost I don't really
care about the path to the goal I just
care about the solution itself much as
we've talked about now before
the problem here though is that if we
just implement this naive search
algorithm just by implementing like
breadth first search or depth first
search this is going to be very very
inefficient and there are ways we can
take advantage of efficiencies in the
structure of a constraint satisfaction
problem itself and one of the key ideas
is that we can really just order these
variables and it doesn't matter what
order we assign variables in the
assignment a equals 2 and then b equals
eight is identical to the assignment of
b equals eight and then a equals two
switching the order doesn't really
change anything about the fundamental
nature of that assignment
and so there are some ways that we can
try and revise this idea of a search
algorithm to apply it specifically for a
problem like a constraint satisfaction
problem and it turns out the search
algorithm will generally use when
talking about constraint satisfaction
problems is something known as
backtracking search and the big idea of
backtracking search is we'll go ahead
and make assignments from variables to
values and if ever we get stuck we
arrive at a place where there is no way
we can make any forward progress while
still preserving the constraints that we
need to enforce we'll go ahead and
backtrack and try something else instead
so the very basic sketch of what
backtracking search looks like is it
looks like this function called
backtrack that takes us input and
assignment and a constraint satisfaction
problem so initially we don't have any
assigned variables so when we begin
backtracking search this assignment is
just going to be the empty assignment
with no variables inside of it but we'll
see later this is going to be a
recursive function
so backtrack takes us input the
assignment and the problem
if the assignment is complete meaning
all of the variables have been assigned
we just return that assignment that of
course won't be true initially because
we start with an empty assignment but
over time we might add things to that
assignment so if ever the assignment
actually is complete then we're done
then just go ahead and return that
assignment but otherwise there's some
work to be done
so what we'll need to do is Select an
unassigned variable for this particular
problem so we need to take the problem
look at the variables that have already
been assigned and pick a variable that
has not yet been assigned
and I'll go ahead and take that variable
and then I need to consider all of the
values in that variable's domain so
we'll go ahead and call this domain
values function we'll talk a little more
about that later that takes a variable
and just gives me back an ordered list
of all of the values in its domain so
I've taken a random unselected variable
I'm going to Loop over all the possible
values and the idea is let me just try
all of these values as possible values
for the variable
so if the value is consistent with the
assignment so far it doesn't violate any
of the constraints well then let's go
ahead and add variable equals value to
the assignment because it's so far
consistent and now let's recursively
call backtrack to try and make the rest
of the assignments also consistent so go
ahead and call Backtrack on this new
assignment that I've added this newest
the variable equals value to
and now I recursively call backtrack and
see what the result is and if the result
isn't a failure
well then let me just return that result
and otherwise what else could happen
well if it turns out the result was a
failure well then that means this value
was probably a bad choice for this
particular variable because when I
assigned this variable equal to that
value eventually down the road I ran
into a situation where I violated
constraints there was nothing more I
could do so now I'll remove variable
equals value from the assignment
effectively backtracking to say all
right that value didn't work let's try
another value instead
and then at the very end if we were
never able to return a complete
assignment we'll just go ahead and
return failure because that means that
none of the values worked for this
particular variable
this now is the idea for backtracking
search to take each of the variables up
try values for them and recursively try
backtracking search see if we can make
progress and if ever we run into a dead
end we run into a situation where there
is no possible value we can choose that
satisfies the constraints we return
failure and that propagates up and
eventually we make a different Choice by
going back and trying something else
instead
so let's put this algorithm into
practice let's actually try and use
backtracking search to solve this
problem now where I need to figure out
how to assign each of these courses to
an exam slot on Monday or Tuesday or
Wednesday in such a way that it
satisfies these constraints that each of
these edges mean those two classes
cannot have an exam on the same day so I
can start by just like starting at a
node it doesn't really matter which I
start with but in this case I'll just
start with a
and I'll ask a question like all right
let me Loop over the value from the
domain and maybe in this case I'll just
start with Monday and say all right
let's go ahead and assign a to Monday
we'll just go and order Monday Tuesday
Wednesday
and now let's consider node B all right
so I've made an assignment to a so I
recursively call backtrack with this new
part of the assignment now I'm looking
to pick another unassigned variable like
B and I'll say all right maybe I'll
start with Monday because that's the
very first value in B's domain
and I ask all right does Monday violate
any constraints and it turns out yes it
does it violates this constraint here
between A and B Because A and B are now
both on Monday and that doesn't work
because B can't be on the same day as a
so that doesn't work so we might Instead
try Tuesday try the next value in B's
domain and is that consistent with the
assignment so far well yeah be Tuesday a
Monday that is consistent so far because
they're not on the same day so that's
good now we can recursively call
backtrack try again pick another
unassigned variable something like d and
say all right let's go through its
possible values is Monday consistent
with this assignment well yes it is B
and D are on different days Monday
versus Tuesday and a and b are also on
different days Monday versus Tuesday so
that's fine so far too
we'll go ahead and try again maybe we'll
go to this variable here e say can we
make that consistent let's go through
the possible values we've recursively
called backtrack we might start with
Monday and say all right that's not
consistent because d and e now have
exams on the same day so we might try
Tuesday instead going to the next one
ask is that consistent well no it's not
because B and E those have exams on the
same day and so we try all right is
Wednesday consistent and it turns out
all right yes it is Wednesday is
consistent because d and e now have
exams on different days b and e now have
exams on different days all seems to be
well so far I recursively call backtrack
select another unassigned variable we'll
say maybe choose C this time and say all
right let's try the value values that c
could take on let's start with Monday
and it turns out that's not consistent
because now A and C both have exams on
the same day so I tried Tuesday and say
that's not consistent either because B
and C now have exams on the same day and
then I say all right let's go ahead and
try uh Wednesday but that's not
consistent either because c and e each
have exams in the same day too so now
we've gone through all of the possible
values for C Monday Tuesday and
Wednesday and none of them are
consistent there is no way we can have a
consistent assignment backtrack in this
case we'll return to failure
and so then we'd say all right we have
to backtrack back here well now for E
we've tried all of Monday Tuesday and
Wednesday and none of those work because
Wednesday which seemed to work turned
out to be a failure
so that means there's no possible way we
can assign e so that's a failure too we
have to go back up to D which means that
Monday assignment to D that must be raw
we must try something else so we can try
all right what if D is two What If
instead of Monday we try Tuesday Tuesday
it turns out is not consistent because B
and D now have an exam on the same day
but Wednesday as it turns out works
and now we can begin to make some
forward progress again we go back to e
and say all right which of these values
works Monday turns out to work by not
violating any constraints then we go up
to C now Monday doesn't work because it
violates a constraint violates two
actually uh Tuesday doesn't work because
it violates the constraint as well but
Wednesday does work then we can go to
the next variable F and say all right
does Monday work well no it violates a
constraint but Tuesday does work and
then finally we can look at the last
variable G recursively calling backtrack
one more time Monday is inconsistent
that violates the constraint Tuesday
also violates the constraint but
Wednesday that doesn't violate a
constraint
and so now at this point we recursively
call backtrack one last time we now have
a satisfactory assignment of all of the
variables and at this point we can say
that we are now done we have now been
able to successfully assign a variable
or value to each one of these variables
in such a way that we're not violating
any constraints we're going to go ahead
and have classes A and E have their
exams on Monday classes B and F can have
their exams on Tuesday and classes C D
and G can have their exams on Wednesday
and there's no violated constraints that
might come up there
so that then was a graphical look at how
this might work let's now take a look at
some code we could use to actually try
and solve this problem as well
so here I'll go ahead and go into the
scheduling directory
we're here now we'll start by looking at
schedule 0 dot pi
we're here I Define a list of variables
a b c d e f g those are all of the
different classes
then underneath that I Define my list of
constraints so constraint A and B that
is a constraint because they can't be on
the same day likewise A and C B and C so
on and so forth enforcing those exact
same constraints
and here then is what the backtracking
function might look like
first
if the assignment is complete if I've
made an assignment of every variable to
a value go ahead and just return that
assignment
then we'll select an unassigned variable
from that assignment
then for each of the possible values in
the domain Monday Tuesday Wednesday
let's go ahead and create a new
assignment that assigns the variable to
that value
I'll call this consistent function which
I'll show you in a moment that just
checks to make sure this new assignment
is consistent but if it is consistent
we'll go ahead and call backtrack to go
ahead and continue trying to run
backtracking search and as long as the
result is not none meaning it wasn't a
failure we can go ahead and return that
result but if we make it through all the
values and nothing works
then it is a failure there's no solution
we go ahead and return none here
what do these functions do select
unassigned variable is just going to
choose a variable not yet assigned so
it's going to Loop over all the
variables and if it's not already
assigned we'll go ahead and just return
that variable
and what does the consistent function do
well the consistent function goes
through all the constraints and if we
have a situation where we've assigned
both of those values to variables but
they are the same well then that is a
violation of the constraint in which
case will return false but if nothing is
inconsistent then the assignment is
consistent and will return true
and then all the program does is it
calls Backtrack on an empty assignment
an empty dictionary that has no variable
assigned to no values yet save that
inside a solution and then print out
that solution so by running this now I
can run python
schedule0 dot pi and what I get as a
result of that is an assignment of all
these variables to values and turns out
we assign a to Monday as we would expect
B to Tuesday C to Wednesday exactly the
same type of thing we were talking about
before an assignment of each of these
variables two values that doesn't
violate any constraints
and I had to do a fair amount of work in
order to implement this idea myself I
had to write the backtrack function that
went ahead and went through this process
of recursively trying to do this
backtracking search but it turns out the
constraint satisfaction problems are so
popular that there exist many libraries
that already implement this type of idea
again as with before the specific
library is not as important as the fact
that libraries do exist this is just one
example of a python constraint Library
where now
rather than having to do all the work
from scratch inside of schedule 1. Pi
I'm just taking advantage of a library
that implements a lot of these ideas
already so here I create a new problem
add variables to it with particular
domains I add a whole bunch of these
individual constraints where I call add
constraint and pass in a function
describing what the constraint is and
the constraint basically says the
function that takes two variables X and
Y and makes sure that X is not equal to
Y enforcing the idea that these two
classes cannot have exams on the same
day
and then for any constraint satisfaction
problem I can call get solutions to get
all the solutions to that problem and
then for each of those Solutions print
out what that solution happens to be and
if I run python schedule 1 dot pi and
I'll see they're actually a number of
different solutions that can be used to
solve the problem they're in fact six
different solutions assignments of
variables to values that will give me a
satisfactory answer to this constraint
and satisfaction problem
so this then was an implementation of a
very basic backtracking search method
where really we just went through each
of the variables picked one that wasn't
assigned tried the possible values the
variable could take on and then if it
was if it worked if it didn't violate
any constraints then we kept trying
other variables and if ever we hit a
dead end we had to backtrack But
ultimately we might be able to be a
little bit more intelligent about how we
do this in order to improve the
efficiency of how we solve these sorts
of problems and one thing we might
imagine trying to do is going back to
this idea of inference using the
knowledge we know to be able to draw
conclusions in order to make the rest of
the problem-solving process a little bit
easier
and let's now go back to where we got
stuck in this problem the first time
when we were solving this constraint
satisfaction problem we dealt with b and
then we went on to D and we went ahead
and just assigned D to Monday because
that seemed to work with the assignment
so far it didn't violate any constraints
but it turned out that later on that
choice turned out to be a bad one that
that choice wasn't consistent with the
rest of the values that we could take on
here
and the question is is there anything we
could do to avoid getting into a
situation like this avoid trying to go
down a path that's ultimately not going
to lead anywhere by taking advantage of
knowledge that we have initially and it
turns out we do have that kind of
knowledge we can look at just the
structure of this graph so far and we
can say that right now C's domain for
example contains values Monday Tuesday
and Wednesday and based on those values
we can say that this graph is not Arc
consistent recall that Arc consistency
is all about making sure that for every
possible value for a particular node
that there is some other value that we
are able to choose and as we can see
here Monday and Tuesday are not going to
be possible values that we can choose
for C they're not going to be consistent
with a node like B for example because B
is equal to Tuesday which means that c
cannot be Tuesday and because a is equal
to Monday C also cannot be Monday
so using that information by making C
Arc consistent with A and B we could
remove Monday and Tuesday from C's
domain and just leave C with Wednesday
for example
and if we continued to try and enforce
art consistency we'd see there are some
other conclusions we can draw as well we
see that B's only option is Tuesday and
C's only option is Wednesday and so if
we want to make e Arc consistent well e
can't be Tuesday because that wouldn't
be R consistent with b and e can't be
Wednesday because that wouldn't be art
consistent with C so we can go ahead and
say e and just set that equal to Monday
for example and then we can begin to do
this process again and again that in
order to make D Arc consistent with b
and e then D would have to be Wednesday
that's the only possible option and
likewise we can make the same judgments
for f and g as well and it turns out
that without having to do any additional
search just by enforcing Arc consistency
we were able to actually figure out what
the assignment of all the variables
should be without needing to backtrack
at all and the way we did that is by
interleaving this search process and the
inference step by this step of trying to
enforce our consistency and the
algorithm to do this is often called
just the maintaining Arc consistency
algorithm which just enforces our
consistency every time we make a new
assignment of a value to an existing
variable so sometimes we can enforce our
consistency using that AC3 algorithm at
the very beginning of the problem before
we even begin searching in order to
limit the domain of the variables in
order to make it easier to search but we
can also take advantage of the
interleaving of enforcing art
consistency with search such that every
time in the search process we make a new
assignment we go ahead and enforce Arc
consistency as well to make sure that
we're just eliminating possible values
from domains whenever possible
and how do we do this well this is
really equivalent to just every time we
make a new assignment to a variable X
we'll go ahead and call our AC3
algorithm this algorithm that enforces
our consistency on a constraint
satisfaction problem and we go ahead and
call that starting it with a Q not of
all of the arcs which we did originally
but just of all of the arcs that we want
to make are consistent with x the thing
that we have just made an assignment to
so all arcs y x where Y is a neighbor of
X something that shares a constraint
with X for example
and by maintaining art consistency in
the backtracking search process we can
ultimately make our search process a
little bit more efficient and so this is
the revised version of this backtrack
function same as before the changes here
highlighted in yellow every time we add
a new variable equals value to our
assignment we'll go ahead and run this
inference procedure which might do a
number of different things but one thing
it could do is call the maintaining Arc
consistency algorithm to make sure we're
able to enforce our consistency on the
problem and we might be able to draw new
inferences as a result of that process
get new guarantees of this variable
needs to be equal to that value for
example that might happen one time it
might happen many times and so long as
those inferences are not a failure as
long as they don't lead to a situation
where there's no possible way to make
forward progress well then we can go
ahead and add those inferences those new
knowledge that new pieces of knowledge I
know about what variables should be
assigned to what values I can add those
to the assignment in order to more
quickly make forward progress by taking
advantage of information that I can just
deduce information I know based on the
rest of the structure of the constraint
satisfaction problem
and the only other change I'll need to
make now is if it turns out this value
doesn't work well then down here I'll go
ahead and need to remove not only
variable equals value but also any of
those inferences that I made remove that
from the assignment as well and so here
then we're often able to solve the
problem by backtracking less than we
might originally have needed to just by
taking advantage of the fact that every
time we make a new assignment of one
variable to one value that might reduce
the domains of other variables as well
and we can use that information to begin
to more quickly draw conclusions in
order to try and solve the problem more
efficiently as well
and it turns out there are other
heuristics we can use to try and improve
the efficiency of our search process as
well and it really boils down to a
couple of these functions that I've
talked about but we haven't really
talked about how they're working and one
of them is this function here select
unassigned variable where we're
selecting some variable in the
constraint satisfaction problem that has
not yet been assigned so far I've sort
of just been selecting variables random
just like picking one variable on one
undefined variable in order to decide
all right this is the variable that
we're going to assign next and then
going from there but it turns out that
by being a little bit intelligent by
following certain heuristics we might be
able to make the search process much
more efficient just by choosing very
carefully which variable we should
explore next
so some of those heuristics include the
minimum remaining values or mrv
heuristic which generally says that if I
have a choice between which variable I
should select I should select the
variable with the smallest domain the
variable that has the fewest number of
remaining values left with the idea
being if there are only two remaining
values left well I may as well like
prune one of them very quickly in order
to get to the other because one of those
two has got to be the solution if a
solution does exist
sometimes minimum remaining values might
not give a conclusive result if all the
nodes have the same number of remaining
values for example and in that case
another heuristic that can be helpful to
look at is the degree heuristic the
degree of a node is the number of nodes
that are attached to that node the
number of nodes that are constrained by
that particular node and if you imagine
which variable should I choose should I
choose a variable that has a high degree
that is connected to a lot of different
things or a variable with a low degree
that is not connected to a lot of
different things well it can often make
sense to choose the variable that has
the highest degree that is connected to
the most other nodes as the thing you
would search first why is that the case
well it's because by choosing a variable
with a high degree
that is immediately going to constrain
the rest of the variables more and it's
more likely to be able to eliminate
large sections of the state space that
you don't need to search through at all
so what could this actually look like
let's go back to this search problem
here in this particular case I've made
an assignment here I've made an
assignment here and the question is what
should I look at next
and according to the minimum remaining
value heuristic what I should choose is
the variable that has the fewest
remaining possible values and in this
case that's this node here node C that
only has one variable left in this
domain which in this case is Wednesday
which is a variable very reasonable
choice of a next assignment to make
because I know it's the only option for
example I know that the only possible
option for C is Wednesday so I may as
well make that assignment and then
potentially explore the rest of the
space after that
but meanwhile at the very start of the
problem when I didn't have any knowledge
of what nodes should have what values
yet I still had to pick what node should
be the first one that I try and assign a
value to and I arbitrarily just chose
the one in the top node a originally but
we can be more intelligent about that
we can look at this particular graph all
of them have domains of the same size
domain of size three so minimum
remaining values doesn't really help us
there but we might notice that node e
has the highest degree it is connected
to the most things and so perhaps it
makes sense to begin our search rather
than starting at node a at the very top
start with the node with the highest
degree start by searching from node e
because from there that's going to much
more easily allow us to enforce the
constraints that are nearby eliminating
large portions of the search space that
I might not need to search through and
in fact by starting with e we can
immediately then assign other variables
and following that we can actually
assign the rest of the variables without
needing to do any backtracking at all
even if I'm not using this inference
procedure just by starting with a node
that has a high degree that it's going
to very quickly restrict the possible
values that other nodes can take on
so that then is how we can go about
selecting an unassigned variable in a
particular order rather than randomly
picking a variable if we're a little bit
intelligent about how we choose it we
can make our search process much much
more efficient by making sure we don't
have to search through portions of the
search space that ultimately aren't
going to matter
the other variable we haven't really
talked about the other function here is
this domain values function this domain
values function that takes a variable
and gives me back a sequence of all of
the values inside of that variable's
domain
the naive way to approach it is what we
did before which is just go in order go
Monday then Tuesday then Wednesday but
the problem is that going in that order
might not be the most efficient order to
search in that sometimes it might be
more efficient to choose values that are
likely to be Solutions first and then go
to other values now how do you assess
whether a value is likelier to lead to a
solution or less likely to lead to a
solution well one thing you can take a
look at is how many
constraints get added how many things
get removed from domains as you make
this new assignment of a variable to
this particular value and the heuristic
we can use here is the least
constraining value heuristic which is
the idea that we should return variables
in order based on the number of choices
that are ruled out for neighboring
values and I want to start with the
least constraining value the value that
rules out the fewest possible options
and the idea there
is that if all I care about doing is
finding a solution if I start with a
value that rules out a lot of other
choices I'm ruling out a lot of
possibilities that maybe is going to
make it less likely that this particular
choice leads to a solution whereas on
the other hand if I have a variable and
I start by choosing a value that doesn't
rule out very much well then I still
have a lot of space where there might be
a solution that I could ultimately find
and this might seem a little bit
counterintuitive and a little bit at
odds with what we were talking about
before where I said when you're picking
a variable you should pick the variable
that is going to have the fewest
possible values remaining but here I
want to pick the value for the variable
that is the least constraining but the
general idea is that when I am picking a
variable I would like to prune large
portions of the search Space by just
choosing a variable that is going to
allow me to quickly eliminate possible
options
whereas here within a particular
variable as I'm considering values that
that variable could take on I would like
to just find a solution and so what I
want to do is ultimately choose a value
that still leaves open the possibility
of me finding a solution to be as likely
as possible by not ruling out many
options I leave open the possibility
that I can still find a solution without
needing to go back later and backtrack
so an example of that might be in this
particular situation here if I'm trying
to choose a variable for a value for
node C here that c is equal to either
Tuesday or Wednesday we know it can't be
Monday because it conflicts with this
domain here where we already know that a
is Monday so C must be Tuesday or
Wednesday
and the question is should I try Tuesday
first or should I try Wednesday first
and if I try Tuesday what gets ruled out
well one option gets ruled out here a
second option gets rolled out here and a
third option gets rolled out here so
choosing Tuesday would rule out three
possible options and what about choosing
Wednesday well choosing Wednesday would
rule out one option here and it would
rule out one option there and so I have
two choices I can choose Tuesday that
rules out three options or Wednesday
that rules out two options and according
to the least constraining value
heuristic what I should probably do is
go ahead and choose Wednesday the one
that rules out the fewest number of
possible options leaving open as many
chances as possible for me to eventually
find the solution inside of the state
space and ultimately if you continue
this process we will
find the solution an assignment of
variables two values that allows us to
give each of these exams each of these
classes an exam date that doesn't
conflict with anyone that happens to be
enrolled in two classes at the same time
so the big takeaway now with all of this
is that there are a number of different
ways we can formulate a problem the ways
we've looked at today are we can
formulate a problem as a local search
problem a problem where we're looking at
a current node and moving to a neighbor
based on whether that neighbor is better
or worse than the current node that we
are looking at we looked at formulating
problems as linear programs we're just
by putting things in terms of equations
and constraints we're able to solve
problems a little bit more efficiently
and we saw formulating a problem as a
constraint satisfaction problem creating
this graph of all of the constraints
that connect two variables that have
some constraint between them and using
that information to be able to figure
out what the solution should be
and so the takeaway of all of this now
is that if we have some problem in
artificial intelligence that we would
like to use AI to be able to solve them
whether that's trying to figure out
where hospitals should be you're trying
to solve the traveling salesman problem
trying to optimize Productions and costs
and whatnot or trying to figure out how
to satisfy certain constraints whether
that's in a Sudoku puzzle or whether
that's in trying to figure out how to
schedule exams through University or any
number of a wide variety of types of
problems if we can formulate that
problem as one of these sorts of
problems then we can use these known
algorithms these algorithms for
enforcing art consistency and
backtracking search these hill climbing
and simulated annealing algorithms these
Simplex algorithms and interior Point
algorithms that can be used to solve
linear programs that we can use those
techniques to begin to solve a whole
wide variety of problems all in this
world of optimization inside of
artificial intelligence this was an
introduction to artificial intelligence
with python for today we will see you
next time
[Music]
thank you
all right welcome back everyone to an
introduction to artificial intelligence
with python now so far in this class
we've used AI to solve a number of
different problems giving the AI
instructions for how to search for a
solution or how to satisfy certain
constraints in order to find its way
from some input point to some output
point in order to solve some sort of
problem today we're going to turn to the
world of learning in particular the idea
of machine learning which generally
refers to the idea where we are not
going to give the computer explicit
instructions for how to perform a task
but rather we are going to give the
computer access to information in the
form of data or patterns that it can
learn from and let the computer try and
figure out what those patterns are try
and understand that data to be able to
perform a task on its own now machine
learning comes in a number of different
forms and it's a very wide field so
today we'll explore some of the
foundational algorithms and ideas that
are behind a lot of the different areas
within machine learning and one of the
most popular is the idea of supervised
machine learning or just supervised
learning and supervised learning is a
particular type of task ask it refers to
the task where we give the computer
access to a data set where that data set
consists of input output Pairs and what
we would like the computer to do is we
would like our AI to be able to figure
out some function that Maps inputs to
outputs so we have a whole bunch of data
that generally consists of some kind of
input some evidence some information
that the computer will have access to
and we would like the computer based on
that input information to predict what
some output is going to be and we'll
give it some data so that the computer
can train its model on to begin to
understand how it is that this
information works and how it is that the
inputs and outputs relate to each other
but ultimately we hope that our computer
will be able to figure out some function
that given those inputs is able to get
those outputs there are a couple of
different tasks within supervised
learning the one we'll focus on and
start with is known as classification
and classification is the problem where
if I give you a whole bunch of inputs
you need to figure out some way to map
those inputs into discrete categories
where you can decide what those
categories are and it's the job of the
computer to predict what those
categories are going to be so that might
be for example I give you information
about a banknote like a US dollar and
I'm asking you to predict for me doesn't
belong to the category of authentic
banknotes or does it belong to the
category of counterfeit banknotes you
need to categorize the input and we want
to train the computer to figure out some
function to be able to do that
calculation
another example might be the case of
weather something we've talked about a
little bit so far in this class where we
would like to predict on a given day you
know is it going to rain on that day is
it going to be cloudy on that day and
before we've seen how we could do this
if we really give the computer all the
exact probabilities for you know if
these are the conditions what's the
probability of rain oftentimes we don't
have access to that information though
but what we do have access to is a whole
bunch of data so if we wanted to be able
to predict something like is it going to
rain or is it not going to rain we would
give the computer historical information
about days when it was raining and days
when it was not raining and ask the
computer to look for patterns in that
data so what might that data look like
well we could structure that data in a
table like this this might be what our
table looks like where for any
particular day going back we have
information about like that day's
humidity that day's air pressure and
then importantly we have a label
something where the human has said that
on this particular day it was raining or
it was not raining so you could fill in
this table with a whole bunch of data
and what makes this what we would call a
supervised learning exercise is that a
human has gone in and labeled each of
these data points said that on this day
when these were the values for the
humidity and pressure that day was a
rainy day and this day was a not rainy
day
and what we would like the computer to
be able to do then is to be able to
figure out given these inputs given like
the humidity and the pressure can the
computer predict what labels should be
associated with that day does that day
look more like it's going to be a day
that rains or does it look more like a
day when it's not going to rain
put a little bit more mathematically you
can think of this as a function that
takes two inputs the inputs being the
data points that our computer will have
access to things like humidity and
pressure so we could write a function f
that takes us input both humidity and
pressure and then the output is going to
be what category we would describe to
these particular input points what label
we would associate with that input so
we've seen a couple of example data
points here we're given this value for
humidity and this value for pressure we
predict is it going to rain or is it not
going to rain and that's information
that we just gathered from the world we
measured on various different days what
the humidity and pressure were we
observed whether or not we saw rain or
no rain on that particular day and this
function f is what we would like to
approximate now the computer and we
humans don't really know exactly how
this function f works it's probably
quite a complex function so what we're
going to do instead is attempt to
estimate it we would like to come up
with a hypothesis function h
which is going to try to approximate
what F does we want to come up with some
function H that will also take the same
inputs and will also produce an output
rain or no rain and ideally we'd like
these two functions to agree as much as
possible so the goal then of the
supervised learning classification tasks
is going to be to figure out what does
that function H look like how can we
begin to estimate given all of this
information all of this data what
category or what label should be
assigned to a particular data point so
where could you begin doing this well a
reasonable thing to do especially in
this situation I have two numerical
values is I could try to plot this on
like a on a graph that has two axes an
x-axis and a y-axis and in this case
we're just going to be using two
numerical values as input but these same
types of ideas scale as you add more and
more inputs as well we'll be plotting
things in two Dimensions but as we soon
see you could add more inputs and just
imagine things in multiple dimensions
and while we humans have trouble
conceptualizing anything really Beyond
three dimension at least visually a
computer has no problem with trying to
imagine things in many many more
Dimensions that for a computer each
Dimension is just some separate number
that it is keeping track of so it
wouldn't be unreasonable for a computer
to think in 10 Dimensions or 100
Dimensions to be able to try to solve a
problem but for now we've got two inputs
so we'll graph things along two axes an
x-axis which will here represent
humidity and y-axis which here
represents pressure
and what we might do is say let's take
all of the days that were raining and
just try to plot them on this graph and
see where they fall on this graph and
you know here might be all of the rainy
days where each rainy day is one of
these blue dots here that corresponds to
a particular value for humidity and a
particular value for pressure
and then I might do the same thing with
the days that were not raining say take
all the not rainy days figure out what
their values were for each of these two
inputs and go ahead and plot them on
this graph as well and I've here plotted
them in Red so blue here stands for a
rainy day red here stands for a not
rainy day and this then is the input
that my computer has access to all of
this input
and what I would like the computer to be
able to do is to train a model such that
if I'm ever presented with a new input
that doesn't have a label associated
with it something like this white dot
here I would like to predict given those
values for each of the two inputs should
we classify it as a blue dot a rainy day
or should we classify it as a red dot a
not rainy day
and if you're just looking at this
picture graphically trying to say all
right this white dot doesn't look like
it belongs to the blue category or does
it look like it belongs to the red
category I think most people would agree
that it probably belongs to the blue
category and why is that well it looks
like it's close to other blue dots and
that's not a very formal notion but it's
a notion that will formalize it in just
a moment but because it seems to be
close to like this blue dot here like
nothing else is closer to it then we
might say that it should be categorized
as blue it should fall into that
category of I think that day is going to
be a rainy day based on that input might
not be totally accurate but it's a
pretty good guess and this type of
algorithm is actually a very popular and
common machine learning algorithm known
as nearest neighbor classification it's
an algorithm for solving these
classification type problems and in
nearest neighbor classification it's
going to perform this algorithm what
it'll do is give it an input it will
choose the class of the nearest data
point to that input by class we just
here mean category like rain or no rain
counterfeit or not counterfeit and we
choose the category or the class based
on the nearest data point so given all
that data we just looked at is the
nearest data point a blue point or is it
a red point and depending on the answer
to that question we were able to make
some sort of judgment we were able to
say something like we think it's going
to be blue or we think it's going to be
red
so likewise we could apply this to other
data points that we encounter as well if
suddenly this data point comes about
well its nearest data is red so we would
go ahead and classify this as a red
Point not raining
things get a little bit trickier though
when you look at a point like this white
point over here and you ask the same
sort of question should it belong to the
category of Blue Points the rainy days
or should it belong to the category of
red points the not rainy days
now nearest neighbor classification
would say the way you solve this problem
is look at which point is nearest to
that point you look at this nearest
point and say it's red it's a not rainy
day and then therefore according to
nearest neighbor classification I would
say that this unlabeled Point well that
should also be read it should also be
classified as a not rainy day
but your intuition you know might think
that that's a reasonable judgment to
make that it's the closest thing is a
not rainy day so may as well guess that
it's not rainy day but it's probably
also reasonable to look at the bigger
picture of things and to say yes it is
true that the nearest point to it was a
red point but it's surrounded by a whole
bunch of other Blue Points so looking at
the bigger picture there's potentially
an argument to be made at this point
should actually be blue and with only
this data we actually don't know for
sure we are given some input something
we're trying to predict and we don't
necessarily know what the output is
going to be so in this case which one is
correct is difficult to say but
oftentimes considering more than just a
single neighbor considering multiple
neighbors can sometimes give us a better
result
and so there's a variant on the nearest
neighbor classification algorithm that
is known as the K nearest neighbor
classification algorithm where K is some
parameter some number that we choose for
how many neighbors are we going to look
at so one nearest neighbor
classification is what we saw before
just pick the one nearest neighbor and
use that category
but with K nearest neighbor
classification where K might be three or
five or seven to say look at the three
or five or seven closest neighbors
closest data points to that point Works
a little bit differently this algorithm
will give it an input choose the most
common class out of the K nearest data
points to that input so if we look at
the five nearest points and you know
three of them say it's raining and two
of them say it's not raining we'll go
with the three instead of the two
because each one effectively gets one
vote towards what they believe the
category ought to be and ultimately you
choose the category that has the most
votes as a consequence of that
so K nearest neighbor classification
fairly straightforward one to understand
intuitively you just like look at the
neighbors and figure out what the answer
might be and it turns out this can work
very very well for solving a whole
variety of different types of
classification problems but not every
model is going to work under every
situation and so one of the things we'll
take a look at today especially in the
context of supervised machine learning
is that there are a number of different
approaches to machine learning a number
of different algorithms that we can
apply all solving the same type of
problem all solving some kind of
classification problem where we want to
take inputs and organize it into
different categories and no one
algorithm is necessarily always going to
be better than some other algorithm they
each have their trade-offs and maybe
depending on the data one type of
algorithm is going to be better suited
to trying to model that information than
some other algorithm and so this is what
a lot of machine learning research ends
up being about that when you're trying
to apply machine learning techniques
you're often looking not just at one
particular algorithm but trying multiple
different algorithms trying to see what
is going to give you the best results
for trying to predict some function that
Maps inputs to outputs
so what then are the drawbacks of K
nearest neighbor classification well
there are a couple one might be that in
the naive Approach at least it could be
fairly slow to have to go through and
measure the distance between a point and
every single one of these points that
exists here now there are ways of trying
to get around that there are data
structures that can help to make it more
quickly to be able to find these
neighbors there are also techniques you
can use to try and prune some of this
data remove some of the data points so
that you're only left with the relevant
data points just to make it a little bit
easier but ultimately what we might like
to do is come up with another way of
trying to do this classification and one
way of trying to do the classification
was looking at like what are the
neighboring points but another way might
be to try to look at all of the data and
see if we can come up with some like
decision boundaries some boundary that
will separate the rainy days from the
not rainy days in the case of two
Dimensions we can do that by drawing a
line for example so what we might want
to try to do is just find some line find
some separator that divides the rain
days the Blue Points over here from the
not rainy days the red points over there
we're now trying a different approach in
contrast with the nearest neighbor
approach which just looked at local data
around the input data point that we
cared about now what we're doing is
trying to use a technique known as
linear regression to find some sort of
line that will separate the two halves
from each other now sometimes it'll
actually be possible to come up with
some line that perfectly separates all
the rainy days from the not rainy days
realistically though this is probably
cleaner than many data sets will
actually be oftentimes data is Messier
there are outliers there's random noise
that happens inside of a particular
system and what we'd like to do is still
be able to figure out what a line might
look like so in practice the data will
not always be linearly separable we're
linearly separable refers to some data
set where I could like draw a line just
to separate the two halves of it
perfectly instead you might have a
situation like this where there's some
rainy points that are on this side of
the line and some not rainy points that
are on outside of the line and there may
not be a line that perfectly separates
what path of the inputs from the other
half that perfectly separates all the
rainy days from the not rainy days but
we can still say that this line does a
pretty good job and we'll try to
formalize a little bit later what we
mean when we say something like this
line does a pretty good job of trying to
make that prediction but for now let's
just say we're looking for a line that
does as good of a job as we can at
trying to separate one category of
things from another category of things
so let's now try to formalize this a
little bit more mathematically we want
to come up with some sort of function
some way we can Define this line and our
inputs are things like humidity and
pressure in this case so our inputs we
might call X1 is going to be our
represent humidity and X2 is going to
represent pressure these are our inputs
that we are going to provide to our
machine learning algorithm and given
those inputs we would like for our model
to be able to predict some sort of
output and we're going to predict that
using our hypothesis function which we
called H our hypothesis function is
going to take as input X1 and X2
humidity and pressure in this case and
you can imagine if we didn't just have
two inputs we had three or four or five
inputs or more we could have this
hypothesis function take all of those as
input and we'll see examples of that a
little bit later as well
and now the question is what does this
hypothesis function do well it really
just needs to measure like is this data
point on one side of the boundary or is
it on the other side of the boundary and
how do we formalize that boundary well
the boundary is generally going to be a
linear combination of these input
variables at least in this particular
case so what we're trying to do when we
say linear combination is take each of
these inputs and multiply them by some
number that we're going to have to
figure out we'll generally call that
number a weight for how important should
these variables be in trying to
determine the answer so we'll weight
each of these variables with some weight
and we might add like a constant to it
just to try and make the function a
little bit different and the result we
just need to compare like is it greater
than zero or is it less than zero to say
it doesn't belong on one side of the
line or the other side of the line and
so what that mathematical expression
might look like is this
we would take each of my variables X1
and X2 multiply them by some weight I
don't yet know what that weight is but
it's going to be some number weight 1
and weight two and maybe we just want to
add some other weight 0 to it because
the function might require us to shift
the entire value up or down by a certain
amount and then we just compare if we do
all this map is it greater than or equal
to zero if so we might categorize that
data point as a rainy day and otherwise
we might say no rain
so the key here then is that this
expression is how we are going to
calculate whether it's a rainy day or
not we're going to do a bunch of math
where we take each of the variables
multiply them by a weight maybe add an
extra weight to it see if the result is
greater than or equal to zero and using
that result of that expression we're
able to determine whether it's raining
or not raining this expression here is
in this case going to refer to just some
line if you were to plot that
graphically it would just be some line
and what the line actually looks like
depends upon these weights X1 and X2 are
the inputs but these weights are really
would determine the shape of that line
the slope of that line and what that
line actually looks like
so we then would like to figure out what
these weights should be we can choose
whatever weights we want but we want to
choose weights in such a way that if you
pass in a rainy day's humidity and
pressure then you end up with a result
that is greater than or equal to zero
and we would like it such that if we
passed in to our hypothesis function not
rainy days input then the output that we
get should be not written
so before we get there let's try and
formalize this a little bit more
mathematically just to get a sense for
how it is that you'll often see this if
you ever go further into supervised
machine learning and explore this idea
one thing is that generally for these
categories we'll sometimes just use the
names of the categories like rain and
not rain often mathematically if we're
trying to do comparisons between these
things it's easier just to deal in the
world of numbers so we could just say
one and zero one for reigning zero for
not raining so we do all this math and
if the result is greater than or equal
to zero we'll go ahead and say our
hypothesis function outputs 1 meaning
reigning and otherwise it outputs zero
meaning not raining and oftentimes this
type of expression will instead Express
using Vector mathematics and all a
vector is if you're not familiar with
the term is it refers to a sequence of
numerical values you could represent
that in Python using like a list of
numerical values or a tuple with
numerical values
and here we have a couple of sequences
of numerical values one of our vectors
one of our sequences of numerical values
are all of these individual weights w0
W1 and W2 so we could construct what
we'll call a weight vector and we'll see
why this is useful in a moment called W
generally represented using a bold face
W that is just a sequence of these three
weights weight zero weight one and wait
two
and to be able to calculate based on
those weights whether we think a day is
raining or not raining we're going to
multiply each of those weights by one of
our input variables that W2 this weight
is going to be multiplied by input
variable X2 W1 is going to be multiplied
by input variable X1 and w0 well it's
not being multiplied by anything but to
make sure the vectors are the same
length and we'll see why that's useful
in just a second we'll just go ahead and
say w0 is being multiplied by one
because you can multiply by something by
1 and you end up getting the exact same
number so in addition to the weight
Vector W we'll also have an input Vector
that we'll call X that has three values
one again because we're just multiplying
to be Zero by one eventually and then X1
and X2
so here then we've represented two
distinct vectors a vector of Weights
that we need to somehow learn the goal
of our machine learning algorithm is to
learn what this weight Vector is
supposed to be we could choose any
arbitrary set of numbers and it would
produce a function that tries to predict
rain or not rain but it probably
wouldn't be very good what we want to do
is come up with a good choice of these
weights so that we're able to do the
accurate predictions
and then this input Vector represents a
particular input to the function a data
point for which we would like to
estimate is that day a rainy day or is
that day a not rainy day and so that's
going to vary just depending on what
input is provided to our function what
it is that we are trying to estimate and
then to do the calculation we want to
calculate this expression here and it
turns out that expression is what we
would call the dot product of these two
vectors the dot product of two vectors
just means taking each of the terms from
the vectors and multiplying them
together w0 multiply it by one W one
multiply it by X1 W2 multiplied by X2
and that's why these vectors need to be
the same length and then we just add all
of the results together so the dot
product of dot product of w and X our
weight vector and our input Vector
that's just going to be w0 times 1 or
just W 0 plus W1 times X1 multiplying
these two terms together plus W2 times
X2 multiplying those terms together
so we have our weight Vector which we
need to figure out we need our machine
learning algorithm to figure out what
the weights should be we have the input
Vector representing the data point that
we're trying to predict a category for
predict a label for and we're able to do
that calculation by taking this dot
product which you'll often see
represented in Vector form but if you
haven't seen vectors before you can
think of it as identical to just this
mathematical expression just doing the
multiplication adding the results
together and then seeing whether the
result is greater than or equal to zero
or not this expression here is identical
to the expression that we're calculating
to see whether or not that answer is
greater than or equal to zero in this
case and so for that reason you'll often
see the hypothesis function written as
something like this a simpler
representation where the hypothesis
takes as input some input Vector X some
humidity and pressure for some day and
we want to predict an output like rain
or no rain or one or zero if we choose
to represent things numerically and the
way we do that
is by taking the dot product of the
weight and our input if it's greater
than or equal to zero we'll go ahead and
say the output is one otherwise the
output is going to be zero and this
hypothesis we say is parameterized by
the weights depending on what weights we
choose we'll end up getting a different
hypothesis if we choose the weights
randomly we're probably not going to get
a very good hypothesis function we'll
get a one or a zero but it's probably
not accurately going to reflect whether
we think a day is going to be rainy or
not rainy but if we choose the way it's
right we can often do a pretty good job
of trying to estimate whether we think
the output of the function should be a
one or a zero and so the question then
is how to figure out what these weights
should be how to be able to tune those
parameters and there are a number of
ways you can do that one of the most
common is known as the perceptron
learning Rule and we'll see more of this
later but the idea of the perceptron
learning Rule and we're not going to get
too deep into the mathematics we'll
mostly just introduce it more
conceptually is to say that given some
data point that we would like to learn
from some data point that has an input X
and an output Y where Y is like one for
rain or zero for not rain then we're
going to update the weights and we'll
look at the formula in just a moment but
the big picture idea is that we can
start with random weights but then learn
from the data like take the data points
one at a time and for each one of the
data points figure out all right what
parameters do we need to change inside
of the weights in order to better match
that input point and so that is the
value of having access to a lot of data
in the supervised machine learning
algorithm is that you take each of the
data points and maybe look at the
multiple times and constantly try and
figure out whether you need to shift
your weights in order to better create
some weight Vector that is able to
correctly or more accurately try to
estimate what the output should be
whether we think it's going to be
raining or whether we think it's not
going to be ran in so what does that
weight update look like without going
into too much of the mathematics we're
going to update each of the weights to
be the result of the original weight
plus some additional expression and to
understand this expression why well why
is what the actual output is and
hypothesis of X the input that's going
to be what we thought the input was and
so I can replace this by saying like
what the actual value was minus what our
estimate was and based on the difference
between the actual value and what our
estimate was we might want to change our
hypothesis change the way that we do
that estimation
if the actual value in the estimate were
the same thing meaning we were correctly
able to predict what category this data
point belonged to well then actual value
minus estimate that's just going to be
zero which means this whole term on the
right hand side goes to be zero and the
weight doesn't change weight I where I
is like weight one or weight two or
weight 0 weight I just stays at weight I
and none of the weights change if we
were able to correctly predict what
category the input belonged to
but if our hypothesis didn't correctly
predict what category the input belonged
to well then maybe then we need to make
some changes adjust the weights so that
we're better able to predict this kind
of data point in the future and what is
the way we might do that
well if the actual value was bigger than
the estimate
then and for now we'll go ahead and
assume that these X's are positive
values then if the actual value is
bigger than the estimate well that means
we need to increase the weight in order
to make it such that the output is
bigger and therefore we're more likely
to get to the right actual value and so
if the actual value is bigger than the
estimate then actual value minus
estimate that'll be a positive number
and so you imagine we're just adding
some positive number to the weight just
to increase it ever so slightly and
likewise the inverse case is true that
if the actual value was less than the
estimate the actual value was Zero but
we estimated one meaning it actually was
not raining but we predicted it was
going to be raining well then we want to
decrease the value of the weight because
then in that case we want to try and
lower the total value of computing that
dot product in order to make it less
likely that we would predict that it
would actually be raining so no need to
get too deep into the mathematics of
that but the general idea is that every
time we encounter some data point we can
adjust these weights accordingly to try
and make the weights better line up with
the actual data that we have access to
and you can repeat this process with
data point after data point until
eventually hopefully your algorithm
converges to some set of Weights that do
a pretty good job of trying to figure
out whether a day is going to be rainy
or not raining and just as a final point
about this particular equation this
value Alpha here is generally what we'll
call the Learning rate it's just some
parameters some number we choose for how
quickly we're actually going to be
updating these weight values that if
Alpha is bigger then we're going to
update these weight values by a lot and
if Alpha is smaller then we'll update
the weight values by less and you can
choose a value of alpha depending on the
problem different values might suit the
situation better or worse than others
so after all of that after we've done
this training process of take all this
data and using this learning rule look
at all the pieces of data and use each
piece of data as an indication to us of
do the weights stay the same do we
increase the weights do we decrease the
weights and if so by how much what you
end up with is effectively a threshold
function and we can look at what the
threshold function looks like like this
on the x-axis here we have the output of
that function taking the weight taking
the dot product of it with the input
and on the y-axis we have what the
output is going to be zero which in this
case represented like not raining and
one which in this case represented
raining and the way that our hypothesis
function works is it calculates this
value and if it's greater than zero or
greater than some threshold value then
we declare that it's a rainy day and
otherwise we declare that it's a not
rainy day and this then graphically is
what that function looks like that
initially when the value of this dot
product is small it's not raining it's
not raining it's not raining but as soon
as it crosses that threshold we suddenly
say okay now it's raining now it's
raining not now it's raining and the way
to interpret this kind of representation
is that anything on this side of the
line that would be the category of data
points where we say yes it's raining
anything that falls on this side of the
line are the data points where we would
say it's not raining and again we want
to choose some value for the weights
that results in a function that does a
pretty good job of trying to do this
estimation
but one tricky thing with this type of
hard threshold is that it only leaves
two possible outcomes right we plug in
some data as input and the output we get
is raining or not raining and there's no
room for anywhere in between and maybe
that's what you want maybe all you want
is given some data point you would like
to be able to classify it into one or
two or more of these various different
categories
but it might also be the case that you
care about knowing how strong that
prediction is for example so if we go
back to this instance here where we have
rainy days on this side of the line not
rainy days on that side of the line
you might imagine that let's look now at
these two white data points this data
point here that we would like to predict
a label or a category for and this data
point over here that we would also like
to predict a label or a category for it
seems likely that you could pretty
confidently say that this data point
that should be a rainy day seems close
to the other rainy days if we're going
by the nearest neighbor strategy it's on
this side of the line if we're going by
the strategy of just saying you know
which side of the line does it fall on
by figuring out what those weights
should be and if we're using the line
strategy of just which side of the line
does it follow on which side of this
decision boundary Well we'd also say
that this point here is also a rainy day
because it falls on the side of the line
that corresponds to rainy days
but it's likely that even in this case
we would know that we don't feel nearly
as confident about this data point on
the left as compared to this data point
on the right now for this one on the
right we can feel very confident that
yes it's a rainy day this one you know
it's pretty close to the line if we're
judging just by distance and so you
might be less sure
but our threshold function doesn't allow
for a notion of less short or more sure
about something it's what we would call
a hard threshold it's once you've
crossed this line then immediately we
say yes this is going to be a rainy day
anywhere before it we're going to say
it's not a rainy day and that may not be
helpful in a number of cases one this is
not a particularly easy function to deal
with if you guys you get deeper into the
world of machine learning and are trying
to do things like taking derivatives of
these curves this type of function makes
things challenging but the other
challenge is that we don't really have
any notion of gradation between things
we don't have a notion of yes this is a
very strongly strong belief that it's
going to be raining as opposed to you
know it's probably more likely than not
that it's going to be raining but maybe
not totally sure about that either
so what we can do by taking advantage of
a technique known as logistic regression
is instead of using this hard threshold
type of function we can use instead a
logistic function something we might
call a soft threshold and that's going
to transform this into looking something
a little more like this something that
more nicely curves and as a result the
possible output values are no longer
just 0 and 1 0 for not raining one for
raining but you can actually get any
real numbered value between zero and one
that if you're way over on this side
then you get a value of zero okay it's
not going to be raining and we're pretty
sure about that and if you're over on
this side you get a value of one like
yes we're very sure that it's going to
be raining but in between you could get
some real numbered value where a value
like 0.7 might mean you know we think
it's going to rain it's more probable
that it's going to rain than not based
on the data but we're not as confident
of some of the other data points might
be so one of the advantages of the soft
threshold is that it allows us to have
an output that could be some real number
the potentially reflects some sort of
probability the likelihood that we think
that this particular data point belongs
to that particular category
and there are some other nice
mathematical properties of that as well
so that then is two different approaches
to trying to solve this type of
classification problem one is this
nearest neighbor type of approach where
you just take a data point and look at
the data points that are nearby to try
and estimate what category we think it
belongs to
and the other approach is the approach
of saying all right let's just try and
use linear regression figure out what
these weights should be adjust the
weights in order to figure out what line
or what decision boundary is going to
best separate these two categories
turns out that another popular approach
a very popular approach if you just have
a data set and you want to start trying
to do some learning on it is what we
call the support Vector machine we're
not going to go too much into the
mathematics of the support Vector
machine but we'll at least explore it
graphically to see what it is that it
looks like and the idea or the
motivation behind the support Vector
machine is the idea that there are
actually a lot of different lines that
we could draw a lot of different
decision boundaries that we could draw
to separate two groups so if for example
I had the red data points over here and
the blue data points over here one
possible line I could draw is a line
like this that this line here would
separate the red points from the blue
points and it does so perfectly all the
red points are on one side of the line
all the blue points are on the other
side of the line
but this should probably make you a
little bit nervous if you come up with a
model and the model comes up with a line
that looks like this and the reason why
is that you worry about how well it's
going to generalize to other data points
that are not necessarily in the data set
that we have access to for example if
there was a point that fell like right
here for example on the right side of
the line well then based on that we
might want to guess that it is in fact a
red point but it falls on the side of
the line where instead we would estimate
that it's a blue point instead and So
based on that this line is probably not
a great choice just because it is so
close to these various data points we
might instead prefer like a diagonal
line that just goes diagonally through
the data set like we've seen before but
there too there's a lot of diagonal
lines that we could draw as well for
example I could draw this diagonal line
here which also successfully separates
all the red points from all of the blue
points from the perspective of something
like a just trying to figure out some
setting of Weights that allows us to
predict the correct output this line
will predict the correct output for this
particular set of data every single time
because the red points are on one side
the blue points are on the other but yet
again you should probably be a little
nervous because this line is so close to
these red points even though we're able
to correctly predict on the input data
if there was a point that fell you know
somewhere in this general area our
algorithm this model would say that yeah
we think it's a blue point when in
actuality it might belong to the red
category instead just because it looks
like it's close to the other red points
what we really want to be able to say
given this data how can you generalize
this as best as possible is to come up
with a line like this that seems like
the intuitive line to draw and the
reason why it's intuitive is because it
seems to be as far apart as possible
from the red data and the blue data so
that if we generalize a little bit and
assume that maybe we have some points
that are different from the input but
still slightly further away we can still
say that something on this side probably
read something on that side probably
blue and we can make those judgments
that way
and that is what support Vector machines
are designed to do they're designed to
try and find what we call the maximum
margin separator where the maximum
margin separator is just some boundary
that maximizes the distance between the
groups of points rather than come up
with some boundary that's very close to
one set or the other where in the case
before we wouldn't have cared as long as
we're categorizing the input well that
seems all we need to do the support the
support Vector machine will try and find
this maximum margin separator some way
of trying to maximize that particular
distance and it does so by finding what
we call the support vectors which are
the vectors that are closest to the line
and trying to maximize the distance
between the line and those particular
points and it works that way in two
Dimensions it also works in higher
Dimensions where we're not looking for
some line that separates the two data
points but instead looking for what we
generally call a hyperplane some
decision boundary effectively that
separates one set of data from the other
set of data and this ability of support
Vector machines to work in higher
Dimensions actually has a number of
other applications as well but one is
that it helpfully deals with cases where
data may not be linearly separable so we
talked about linear separability before
this idea that you can take data and
just draw a line or some linear
combination of the inputs that allows us
to perfectly separate the two sets from
each other there are some data sets that
are not linearly separable and some word
even too you would not be able to find a
good line at all that would try to do
that kind of Separation something like
this for example
or if you imagine here are the red
points and the Blue Points around it if
you try to find a line that divides the
red points from the Blue Points it's
actually going to be difficult if not
impossible to do that any line you
choose well if you draw a line here then
you ignore all of these Blue Points that
should actually be blue and not red
anywhere else you draw a line there's
going to be a lot of error a lot of
mistakes a lot of what we'll soon call
loss to that line that you draw a lot of
points that you're going to categorize
incorrectly what we really want is to be
able to find better decision boundary
that may not be just a straight line
through this two-dimensional space and
what support Vector machines can do is
they can begin to operate in higher
dimensions and be able to find some
other decision boundary like the circle
in this case that actually is able to
separate uh one of these sets of data
from the other set of data a lot better
so oftentimes in data sets where the
data is not linearly separable support
Vector machines by working in higher
Dimensions can actually figure out a way
to solve that kind of problem
effectively
so that then three different approaches
to trying to solve these sorts of
problems we're seeing support Vector
machines and we've seen trying to use
linear regression and the perceptron
learning rule to be able to figure out
how to categorize inputs and outputs we
see in the nearest neighbor approach no
one necessarily better than any other
again it's going to depend on the data
set the information you have access to
it's going to depend on what the
function looks like that you're
ultimately trying to predict and this is
where a lot of research and
experimentation can be involved in
trying to figure out how it is to best
perform that kind of estimation
but classification is only one of the
tasks that you might encounter in
supervised machine learning because in
classification what we're trying to
predict is some discrete category we're
trying to predict red or blue rain or
not rain authentic or counterfeit
but sometimes what we want to predict is
a real numbered value and for that we
have a related problem not
classification but instead known as
regression and regression is the
supervised learning problem where we try
and learn a function mapping inputs to
Output the same as before but instead of
the outputs being discrete categories
things like rain or not rain in a
regression problem the output values are
generally continuous values some real
number that we would like to predict
this happens all the time as well you
might imagine that a company might take
this approach if it's trying to figure
out for instance what the effect of its
advertising is like how do advertising
dollars spent translate into sales for
the company's product for example and so
they might like to try to predict some
function that takes us input the amount
of money spent on advertising and here
we're just going to use one input but
again you could scale this up to many
more inputs as well if you have a lot of
different kinds of data you have access
to and the goal is to learn a function
that given this amount of spending on
Advertising we're going to get this
amount in sales and you might judge
based on having access to a whole bunch
of data like for every past month here's
how much we spent on advertising and
here is what sales were and we would
like to predict some sort of hypothesis
function
that again given the amount spent on
Advertising can predict in this case
some real number some number estimate of
how much uh sales we expect that company
to do in this month or in this quarter
or whatever unit of time we're choosing
to measure things in
and so again the approach to solving
this type of problem we could try using
a linear regression type approach where
we take this data and we just plot it on
the x-axis we have advertising that are
spent on the y-axis we have sales and we
might just want to try and draw a line
that does a pretty good job of trying to
estimate this relationship between
advertising and sales and in this case
unlike before we're not trying to
separate the data points into discrete
categories but instead in this case
we're just trying to find a line that
approximates this relationship between
advertising and sales so that if we want
to figure out what the estimated sales
are for a particular advertising budget
you just look it up in this line figure
out for this amount of advertising we
would have this amount of sales and just
try and make the estimate that way and
so you can try and come up with a line
again figuring out how to modify the
weights using various different
techniques to try and make it so this
line fits as well as possible
so with all of these approaches then to
trying to solve machine learning style
problems the question becomes how do we
evaluate these approaches how do we
evaluate the various different
hypotheses that we could come up with
because each of these algorithms will
give us some sort of hypothesis some
function that Maps inputs to outputs and
we want to know how well does that
function work and you can think of
evaluating these hypotheses and trying
to get a better hypothesis as kind of
like an optimization problem in an
optimization problem if you've recall
from before
we were either trying to maximize some
objective function by trying to find
a global maximum or we were trying to
minimize some cost function by trying to
find some Global minimum and in the case
of evaluating these hypotheses one thing
we might say is that this cost function
the thing we're trying to minimize we
might be trying to minimize what we
would call a loss function and what a
loss function is is a function that is
going to estimate for us how poorly our
function performs more formally it's
like a loss of utility by whenever we
predict something that is wrong that is
a loss of utility that's going to add to
the output of our loss function
and you could come up with any loss
function that you want just some
mathematical way of estimating you know
given each of these data points given
what the actual output is and given what
our projected output is our estimate you
could calculate some sort of numerical
loss for it but there are a couple of
popular loss functions that are worth
discussing just so that you've seen them
before
when it comes to discrete categories
things like rain or not rain counterfeit
or not counterfeit one approach is the
zero one loss function and the way that
works is for each of the data points
our loss function takes as input what
the actual output is like whether it was
actually raining or not raining and
takes a prediction into account did we
predict given this data point that it
was ran in or not raining and if the
actual value equals the prediction well
then the zero one loss function will
just say the loss is zero there was no
loss of utility because we were able to
predict correctly
and otherwise if the actual value was
not the same thing as what we predicted
well then in that case our loss is one
we lost something lost some utility
because what we predicted was the output
of the function was not what it actually
was and the goal then in a situation
like this would be to come up with some
hypothesis that minimizes the total
empirical loss the total amount that
we've lost if you add up for all these
data points what the actual output is
and what your hypothesis would have
predicted
so in this case for example if we go
back to classifying days as raining or
not raining and we came up with this
decision boundary how would we evaluate
this decision boundary how much better
is it than drawing the line here or
Drawing the Line there well we could
take each of the input data points and
each input data point has a label
whether it was raining or whether it was
not raining and we could compare it to
the prediction whether we predicted it
would be raining or not raining and
assign it a numerical value as a result
so for example these points over here
they were all rainy days and we
predicted they would be raining because
they fall on the bottom side of the line
so they have a loss of zero nothing lost
from those situations and likewise same
is true for some of these points over
here where it was not raining and we
predicted it would not be raining either
where we do have loss are points like
this point here and that point there
where we predicted that it would not be
raining but in actuality it's a blue
point it was rated or likewise here we
predicted that it would be raining but
in actuality it's a red point it was not
written and so as a result we
miscategorized these data points that we
were trying to train on
and as a result there's some loss here
one loss here there here and there for a
total loss of four for example in this
case and that might be how we would
estimate or how we would say that this
line is better than a line that goes
somewhere else or a line that's further
down because this line might minimize
the loss there's no way to do better
than just these four points of loss if
you're just drawing a straight line
through our space
so the zero one loss function checks did
we get it right did we get it wrong if
we got it right the loss is zero nothing
lost if we got it wrong then our loss
function for that data point says one
and we add up all of those losses across
all of our data points to get some sort
of empirical loss how much we have lost
across all of these original data points
that our algorithm had access to
there are other forms of loss as well
that work especially well when we deal
with more real valued cases cases like
the mapping between advertising budget
and amount that we do in sales for
example because in that case you care
not just that you get the number exactly
right but you care how close you were to
the actual value if the actual value if
you did like twenty eight hundred
dollars in sales and you predicted that
you would do twenty nine hundred dollars
in sales you know maybe that's pretty
good that's much better than if you had
predicted you do a thousand dollars in
sales for example and so we would like
our loss function to be able to take
that into account as well take apart
take into account not just whether the
actual value and the expected value are
exactly the same but also take into
account how far apart they were
and so for that one approach is what we
call L1 loss L1 loss doesn't just look
at whether actual and predicted or equal
to each other
but we take the absolute value of the
actual value minus the predicted value
in other words we just ask how far apart
were the actual and predicted values and
we sum that up across all of the data
points to be able to get what our answer
ultimately is
so what might this actually look like
for our data set well if we go back to
this representation where we had
advertising along the x-axis sales along
the y-axis our line was our prediction
our estimate for any given amount of
advertising what we predicted sales was
going to be and our L1 loss is just how
far apart vertically along the sales
axis our prediction was from each of the
data points so we could figure out
exactly how far apart our prediction was
from each of the data points and figure
out as a result of that what our loss is
overall for this particular hypothesis
just by adding up all of these various
different individual losses for each of
these data points and our goal then is
to try and minimize that loss to try and
come up
with some line that minimizes what the
utility loss is by judging how far away
our estimate amount of sales is from the
actual amount of sales and turns out
there are other loss functions as well
one that's quite popular is the L2 loss
the L2 loss instead of just using the
absolute value like how far away the
actual value is from the predicted value
it uses the square of actual minus
predicted so how far apart are the
actual and predicted value and it
squares that value effectively
penalizing much more harshly anything
that is a worse prediction so you
imagine if you have two data points that
you predict as being you know one value
away from their actual value as opposed
to one data point that you predict as
being two away from its actual value the
L2 loss function will more harshly
penalize that one that is two away
because it's going to square however
much the differences between the actual
value and the predicted value and
depending on the situation you might
want to choose a loss function depending
on what you care about minimum if you
really care about minimizing the error
on more outlier cases then you might
want to consider something like this but
if you've got a lot of outliers and you
don't necessarily care about modeling
them then maybe an L1 loss function is
preferable but there are trade-offs here
that you need to decide based on a
particular set of data
but what you do run the risk of with any
of these loss functions with anything
that we're trying to do is a problem
known as overfitting and overfitting is
a big problem you can encounter in
machine learning which happens anytime a
model fits too closely with a data set
and as a result fails to generalize we
would like our model to be able to
accurately predict
data and inputs and output pairs for the
data that we have access to but the
reason we wanted to do so is because we
want our model to generalize well to
data that we haven't seen before I would
like to take data from the past year of
whether it was raining and not raining
and used that data to generalize it
towards the future to say in the future
is it going to be raining or not raining
or if I have a whole bunch of data on
what counterfeit and not counterfeit US
dollar bills look like
in the past when people have encountered
them I'd like to train a computer to be
able to in the future generalize
to other dollar bills that I might see
as well and the problem with overfitting
is that if you try and tie yourself too
closely to the data set that you're
training your model on you can end up
not generalizing very well so what does
this look like well we might imagine the
rainy day and not raining day example
again from here where the Blue Points
indicate rainy days and the red points
indicate not rainy days and we decided
that we felt pretty comfortable with
drawing a line like this as the decision
boundary between rainy days and not
rainy days so we can pretty comfortably
say that points on this side more likely
to be rainy days points on that side
more likely to be not rainy days but the
loss the empirical loss isn't zero in
this particular case because we didn't
categorize everything perfectly
there was this one outlier this one day
that it wasn't raining but yet our model
Still Still predicts that it is raining
but that doesn't necessarily mean our
model is bad it just means the model
isn't 100 accurate
if you really wanted to try and find a
hypothesis that resulted in minimizing
the loss you could come up with a
different decision boundary it wouldn't
be a line but it would look something
like this like this decision boundary
does separate all of the red points from
all of the Blue Points because the red
points fall on this side of this
decision boundary the Blue Points fall
on the other side of the decision
boundary but this we would probably
argue is not as good of a prediction
even though it seems to be more accurate
based on all of the available training
data that we have for training this
machine learning model we might say that
it's probably not going to generalize
well that if there were other data
points like here and there we might
still want to consider those to be rainy
days because we think this was probably
just an outlier so if the only thing you
care about is minimizing the loss on the
data you have available to you you run
the risk of overfitting and this can
happen in the classification case it can
also happen
in the regression case that here we
predicted what we thought was a pretty
good line relating advertising to sales
trying to predict what sales were going
to be for a given amount of advertising
but I could come up with a line that
does a better job of predicting the
training data and it would be something
that looks like this just you know
connecting all of the various different
data points and now there's no loss at
all now I've perfectly predicted given
any advertising what sales are and for
all the data available to me it's going
to be accurate but it's probably not
going to generalize very well I have
over fit my model on the training data
that is available to me and so in
general we want to avoid overfitting
we'd like strategies to make sure that
we haven't overfit our model to a
particular data set and there are a
number of ways that you could try to do
this one way is by examining what it is
that we're optimizing for in an
optimization problem all we do is we say
you know there is some cost and I want
to minimize that cost
and so far we've defined that cost
function the cost of a hypothesis just
as being equal to the empirical loss of
that hypothesis like how far away are
the actual data points the outputs away
from what I predicted them to be based
on that particular hypothesis and if all
you're trying to do is minimize cost
meaning minimizing the loss in this case
then the result is going to be that you
might overfit that to minimize cost
you're going to try and find a way to
perfectly match all the input data and
that might happen as a result of
overfitting on that particular input
data
so in order to address this you could
add something to the cost function what
counts as cost will not just loss but
also some measure of the complexity of
the hypothesis where the complexity of
the hypothesis is something that you
would need to Define for you know how
complicated does our line look this is
sort of an Occam's razor style approach
where we want to give preference to a
simpler decision boundary like a
straight line for example some simpler
curve as opposed to something far more
complex that might represent the
training data better but might not
generalize as well will generally say
that a simpler solution is probably the
better solution and probably the one
that is more likely to generalize well
to other inputs
so we measure what the loss is but we
also measure the complexity and now that
all gets taken into account when we
consider the overall cost that yes
something might have less loss if it
better predicts the training data but if
it's much more complex it still might
not be the best option that we have and
we need to come up with some balance
between loss and complexity and for that
reason you'll often see this represented
as multiplying the complexity by some
parameter that we have to choose
parameter Lambda in this case where
we're saying you know if Lambda has a
greater value then we really want to
penalize more complex hypotheses whereas
if Lambda is smaller we're going to
penalize more complex hypotheses a
little bit and it's up to the machine
learning programmer to decide where they
want to set that value of Lambda for how
much do I want to penalize a more
complex hypothesis that might fit the
data a little better and again there's
no one right answer to a lot of these
things but depending on the data set
depending on the data you have available
to you and the problem you're trying to
solve your choice of these parameters
may vary and you may need to experiment
a little bit to figure out what the
right choice of that is ultimately going
to be
this process then of considering not
only loss but also some measure of the
complexity is known as regularization
regularization is the process of
penalizing a hypothesis that is more
complex in order to favor a simpler
hypothesis that is more likely to
generalize well more likely to be able
to apply to other situations that are
dealing with other input points unlike
the ones that we've necessarily seen
before so oftentimes you'll see us add
some regularizing term to what we're
trying to minimize in order to avoid
this problem of overfitting
now another way of making sure we don't
overfit is to run some experiments and
to see whether or not we are able to
generalize our model that we've created
to other data sets as well and it's for
that reason that oftentimes when you're
doing a machine learning experiment when
you've got some data and you want to try
and come up with some function that
predicts given some input what the
output is going to be you don't
necessarily want to do your training on
all of the data you have available to
you that you could employ a method known
as holdout cross-validation wherein
holdout cross-validation we split up our
data we split up our data into a
training set and a testing set the
training set is the set of data that
we're going to use to train our machine
learning model
and the testing set is the set of data
that we are going to use in order to
test to see how well our machine
learning model actually performed
so the learning happens on the training
set we figure out what the parameters
should be we figure out what the right
model is and then we see all right now
that we've trained the model see how
well it does of predicting things inside
of the testing set some set of data that
we haven't seen before and the hope then
is that we're going to be able to
predict the testing set pretty well if
we're able to generalize based on the
training data that's available to us if
we've overfit the training data though
and we're not able to generalize well
then when we look at the testing set
it's likely going to be the case that
we're not going to predict things in the
testing set nearly as effectively
so this is one method of
cross-validation validating to make sure
that the work we have done is actually
going to generalize to other data sets
as well and there are other statistical
techniques we can use as well one of the
downsides of this just hold out cross
validation is if you say I just like
split it 50 50. I train using 50 of the
data and tests using the other 50 or you
could choose other percentages as well
is that there's a fair amount of data
that I am now not using to train that I
might be able to get a better model as a
result for example
so one approach is known as k-fold
cross-validation in k-fold
cross-validation rather than just divide
things into two sets and run one
experiment we divide things into K
different sets so maybe I divide things
up into 10 different sets and then run
10 different experiments so if I split
up my data into 10 different sets of
data then what I'll do is each time for
each of my 10 experiments I will hold
out one of those sets of data where I'll
say let me train my model on these nine
sets and then test to see how well it
predicts on set number 10. and then pick
another set of nine sets to train on and
then test it on the other one that I
held out where each time I train the
model on everything minus the one set
that I'm holding out and then test to
see how well our model performs on the
test that I did hold out and what you
end up getting is like 10 different
results 10 different answers for how
accurately our model worked and
oftentimes you could just like take the
average of those 10 to get an
approximation for how well we think our
model performs overall but the key idea
is separating the training data from the
testing data because you want to test
your model on data that is different
from what you trained the model on
because the training you want to avoid
overfitting you want to be able to
generalize and the way you test whether
you're able to generalize them is by
looking at some data that you haven't
seen before and seeing how well we're
actually able to perform
and so if we want to actually Implement
any of these techniques inside of a
programming language like python number
of ways we could do that we could write
this from scratch on our own but there
are libraries out there that allow us to
take advantage of existing
implementations of these algorithms that
we can use the same types of algorithms
in a lot of different situations and so
there's a library very popular one known
as scikit-learn which allows us in
Python to be able to very quickly get
set up with a lot of these different
machine learning models that this
library has already written an algorithm
for nearest neighbor classification for
doing perceptron learning for doing a
bunch of other types of inference and
supervised learning that we haven't yet
talked about but using it we can begin
to try actually testing how these
methods work and how accurately they
perform
so let's go ahead and take a look at one
approach of trying to solve this type of
problem all right so I'm first going to
pull up
banknotes.csv which is a whole bunch of
data provided by UC Irvine which is
information about various different
banknotes that people took pictures of
various different banknotes and measured
various different properties of those
banknotes and in particular some human
categorized each of those banknotes as
either a counterfeit banknote or as not
counterfeit and so what you're looking
at here is each row represents one
banknote this is formatted as a CSV
spreadsheet we're just comma separated
values separating each of these various
different fields we have four different
input values for each of these data
points just information some measurement
that was made on the banknote and what
those measurements exactly are aren't as
important as the fact that we do have
access to this data but more importantly
we have access for each of these data
points to a label where zero indicates
something like this was not a
counterfeit Bill meaning it was an
authentic Bill and a data point labeled
one means that it is a counterfeit bill
at least according to the human
researcher who labeled this particular
data so we have a whole bunch of data
representing a whole bunch of different
data points Each of which has these
various different measurements that were
made on that particular Bill and Each of
which has an output value 0 or 1 0
meaning it was a genuine Bill one
meaning it was a counterfeit Bill and
what we would like to do is use
supervised learning to begin to predict
or model some sort of function that can
take these four values as input and
predict what the output would be we want
our learning algorithm to find some sort
of pattern that is able to predict based
on these measurements something you
could measure just by taking a photo of
a bill predict whether that bill is
authentic or whether that bill is
counterfeit
and so how can we do that well I'm first
going to open up
banknote00.pi and see how it is that we
do this
I'm first importing a lot of things from
scikit-learn but importantly I'm going
to set my model equal to the perceptron
model which is one of those models that
we talked about before we're just going
to try and figure out some setting of
Weights that is able to divide our data
into two different groups
then I'm going to go ahead and read data
in for my file from banknotes.csv and
basically for every row I'm going to
separate that row into the first four
values of that row which is the evidence
for that row and then the label where if
the if the final column in that row is a
zero the label is authentic and
otherwise it's going to be counterfeit
so I'm effectively reading data in from
the CSV file dividing into a whole bunch
of rows where each row has some evidence
those four input values that are going
to be inputs to my hypothesis function
and then the label the output whether it
is authentic or counterfeit that is the
thing that I am then trying to predict
so the next step is that I would like to
split up my data set into a training set
and a testing set some set of data that
I would like to train my machine
learning model on and some set of data
that I would like to use to test that
model see how well it performed so what
I'll do is I'll go ahead and figure out
length of the data how many data points
do I have I'll go ahead and take half of
them save that number as a number called
holdout that is how many items I'm going
to hold out for my data set to save for
the testing phase I'll randomly Shuffle
the data so it's in some random order
and then I'll say my testing set will be
all of the data up to the holdout so
I'll take hold up many data items and
that will be my testing set my training
data will be everything else the
information that I'm going to train my
model on
and then I'll say I need to divide my
training data into two different sets I
need to divide it into my X values where
X here represents the inputs so the X
values the X values that I'm going to
train on are basically for every Row in
my training set I'm going to get the
evidence for that row those four values
where it's basically a vector of four
numbers where that is going to be all of
the input and then I need the Y values
what are the outputs that I want to
learn from the labels that belong to
each of these various different input
points well that's going to be the same
thing for each row in the training data
but this time I take that row and get
what its label is whether it is
authentic or counterfeit so I end up
with one list of all of these vectors of
my input data and one list which follows
the same order but as all of the labels
that correspond with each of those
vectors and then to train my model which
in this case is just this perceptron
model
I just call model.fit pass in the
training data and what the labels for
those training data are and scikit-learn
will take care of fitting the model
we'll do the entire algorithm for me and
then when it's done I can then test to
see how well that model performed so I
can say let me get all of these input
vectors for what I want to test on so
for each row in my testing data set go
ahead and get the evidence and the Y
values those are what the actual values
were for each of the rows in the testing
data set what the actual label is but
then I'm going to generate some
predictions I'm going to use this model
and try and predict based on the testing
vectors I want to predict what the
output is and my goal then is to now
compare y testing with predictions I
want to see how well my predictions
based on the model actually reflect what
the Y values were what the output is
that were actually labeled because I now
have this label data I can assess how
well the algorithm worked
and so now I can just compute how well
we did I'm going to this ZIP function
basically just lets me look through two
different lists one one by one at the
same time so for each actual value and
for each predicted value if the actual
is the same thing as what I predicted
I'll go ahead and increment the counter
by one otherwise I'll increment my
incorrect counter by one and so at the
end I can print out here the results
here's how many I got right here's how
many I got wrong and here was my overall
accuracy for example
so I can go ahead and run this I can run
python banknote0.pi
and it's going to train on half the data
set and then test on half the data set
and here are the results for my
perceptron model in this case it
correctly was able to classify
679 bills as correctly eyes are
authentic or counterfeit and incorrectly
classified seven of them for an overall
accuracy of close to 99 accurate so on
this particular data set using this
perceptron model we were able to predict
very well what the output was going to
be
and we can try different models too that
scikit learn makes it very easy just to
swap out one model for another model
so instead of the perceptron model I can
use the support Vector machine using the
SVC otherwise known as a support Vector
classifier using a support Vector
machine to classify things into two
different groups
and now see all right how well does this
perform
and right this time we were able to
correctly predict 682 when incorrectly
predicted for for accuracy of 99.4
percent and we could even try the K
Neighbors classifier
as the model instead and this takes a
parameter and neighbors for how many
neighbors do you want to look at let's
just look at one neighbor the one
nearest neighbor and use that to predict
go ahead and run this as well
and it looks like based on the K
neighbors classifier looking at just one
neighbor we were able to correctly
classify 685 data points incorrectly
classified one
maybe let's try three neighbors instead
instead of just using one neighbor do
more of a k nearest the neighbors
approach where I look at the three
nearest neighbors and see how that
performs and that one in this case seems
to have gotten a hundred percent of all
of the
predictions correctly described as
either authentic banknotes or as
counterfeit Bank notes and you know we
could run these experiments multiple
times because I'm randomly reorganizing
the data every time we're technically
training these on slightly different
data sets and so you might want to run
multiple experiments to really see how
well they're actually going to perform
but in short they all perform very well
and while some of them perform slightly
better than others here that might not
always be the case for every data set
but you can begin to test now by very
quickly putting together these machine
learning models using scikit-learn to be
able to train on some training set and
then test on some testing set as well
and this splitting up into training
groups and testing groups and testing
happens so often that scikit-learn has
functions built in for trying to do it I
did it all by hand just now but if we
take a look at banknotes one
we take advantage of some other features
that exist in scikit-learn where we can
really simplify a lot of our logic that
there is a function built into
scikit-learn called train test split
which will automatically split data into
a training group and a testing group I
just have to say What proportion should
be in the testing group something like
0.5 half the data inside the testing
group then I can fit the model on the
trading data make the predictions on the
testing data and then just count up and
scikit-learn has some nice methods for
just counting up how many times are
testing data match the predictions how
many times our testing data didn't match
the predictions so very quickly you can
write programs with not all that many
lines of code it's maybe like 40 lines
of code to get through all of these
predictions and then as a result see how
well we're able to do so these types of
libraries can allow us without really
knowing the implementation details of
these algorithms to be able to use the
algorithms in a very practical way to be
able to solve these types of problems
so that then was supervised learning
this task of given a whole set of data
some input output pairs we would like to
learn some function that Maps those
inputs to those outputs but turns out
there are other forms of learning as
well and another popular type of machine
learning especially nowadays is known as
reinforcement learning and the idea of
reinforcement learning is rather than
just being given a whole data set at the
beginning of input output paired
reinforcement learning is all about
learning from experience in
reinforcement learning our agents
whether it's like a physical robot
that's trying to make actions in the
world or just some virtual agent that is
a program running somewhere our agent is
going to be given a set of Rewards or
punishments in the form of like
numerical values but you can think of
them as reward or punishment and based
on that it learns what actions to take
in the future that our agent our AI will
be put in some sort of environment it
will make some actions and based on the
actions that it makes it learns
something it either gets a reward when
it does something well it gets a
punishment when it does something poorly
and it learns what to do or what not to
do in the future based on those
individual experiences and so what this
will often look like is it will often
start with some agent some AI which
might again be a physical robot if
you're imagining a physical robot moving
around but it can also just be a program
and our agent is situated in their
environment where the environment is
where they're going to make their
actions and it's what's going to give
them Rewards or punishments for various
actions that they're in
so for example the environment is going
to start off by putting our agent inside
of a state our agent has some state that
in a game might be the state of the game
that the agent is playing in a world
that the agent is exploring might be
some position inside of a grid
representing the world that they're
exploring but the agent is in some sort
of state and in that state the agent
needs to choose to take an action the
agent likely has multiple actions they
can choose from but they pick an action
so they may they take an action in a
particular State and as a result of that
the agent will generally get two things
in response as we model them the agent
gets a new state that they find
themselves in after being in this state
taking one action they end up in some
other state
and they're also given some sort of
numerical reward positive meaning reward
meaning it was a good thing negative
generally meaning they did something bad
they received some sort of punishment
and that is all the information the
agent has it's told what state it's in
it makes some sort of action and based
on that it ends up in another state and
it ends up getting some particular
reward and it needs to learn based on
that information what actions to begin
to take in the future if you could
imagine generalizing this to a lot of
different situations this is oftentimes
how you train if you've ever seen those
robots that are now able to like walk
around sort of the way humans do it
would be quite difficult to program the
robot in exactly the right way to get it
to walk the way humans do you could
instead train it through reinforcement
learning give it some sort of numerical
reward every time it does something good
like take steps forward and punish it
every time it does something bad like
fall over and then let the AI just learn
based on that sequence of rewards based
on trying to take various different
actions you can begin to have the agent
learn what to do in the future and what
not to do
so in order to begin to formalize this
the first thing we need to do is
formalize this notion of what we mean
about States and actions and rewards
like what does this world look like and
oftentimes we'll formulate this world as
what's known as a Markov decision
process similar in spirit to Markov
chains which you might recall from
before but a Markov decision process is
a model that we can use for decision
making for an agent trying to make
decisions in its environment and it's a
model that allows us to represent the
various different states that an agent
can be in the various different actions
that they can take and also what the
reward is for taking one action as
opposed to another action
so what then does it actually look like
well if you recall a Markov chain from
before A Markov chain looked a little
something like this where we had a whole
bunch of these individual states and
each state immediately transitioned to
another state based on some probability
distribution we saw this in the context
of the weather before where if it was
sunny we said with some probability
it'll be sunny the next day with some
other probability it'll be rainy for
example
but we could also Imagine generalizing
this it's not just sun and rain anymore
we just have these states where one
state leads to another state According
to some probability distribution but in
this original model there was no agent
that had any control over this process
it was just entirely probability based
where with some probability we moved to
this next state but maybe it's going to
be some other state with some other
probability what we'll now have is the
ability for the agent in the state to
choose from a set of actions where maybe
instead of just one path forward they
have three different choices of actions
that each lead down different paths and
even this is a bit of an
oversimplification because in each of
these states you might imagine more
branching points where there are more
decisions that can be taken as well so
we've extended the Markov chain
to say that from a state you now have
available action choices and each of
those actions might be associated with
its own probability distribution of
going to various different states
then in addition We'll add another
extension
where anytime you move from a state
taking an action going into this other
state we can associate a reward with
that outcome saying either R is positive
meaning some positive a word or R is
negative meaning there was some sort of
punishment and this then is what will
consider to be a Markov decision process
that a markup decision process has some
initial set of states of states in the
world that we can be in we have some set
of actions that given a state I can say
what are the actions that are available
to me in that state an action that I can
choose from
then we have some transition model the
transition model before just said that
given my current state what is the
probability that I end up in that next
state or this other state the transition
model now has effectively two things
we're conditioning on we're saying given
that I'm in this state and that I take
this action what's the probability that
I end up in this next state
now maybe we live in a very
deterministic World in this Markov
decision process we're given a state and
given an action we know for sure what
next state will end up in but maybe
there's some Randomness in the world
that when you take interstate and you
take an action you might not always end
up in the exact same state there might
be some probabilities involved there as
well the Markov decision process can
handle both of those possible cases
and then finally we have a reward
function generally called r that in this
case says what is the reward for being
in this state taking this action and
then getting to S Prime this next state
so I'm in this original state I take
this action I get to this next state
what is the reward for doing that
process you can add up these rewards
every time you take an action to get the
total amount of rewards that an agent
might get
from interacting in a particular
environment modeled using this markup
decision process so what might this
actually look like in practice well
let's just create a little simulated
World here where I have this agent that
is just trying to navigate its way this
agent is this yellow dot here like a
robot in the world trying to navigate
its way through this grid and ultimately
it's trying to find its way to the goal
and if it gets to the green goal then
it's going to get some sort of reward
but then we might also have some you
know red squares that are places where
you get some sort of punishment some bad
place where we don't want the agent to
go and if it ends up in the Red Square
then our agent is going to get some sort
of punishment as a result of that but
the agent originally doesn't know all of
these details it doesn't know that these
states are associated with punishments
but maybe it does know that this state
is associated with reward maybe it
doesn't but it just needs to sort of
interact with the environment to try and
figure out what to do and what not to do
so the first thing the agent might do is
given no additional information if it
doesn't know what the punishments are it
doesn't know where the rewards are it
just might try and take an action and it
takes an action and ends up realizing
that it got some sort of punishment and
so what does it learn from that
experience well it might learn that when
you're in this state in the future don't
take the action move to the right that
that is a bad action to take that in the
future if you ever find yourself back in
the state don't take this action of
going to the right when you're in this
particular State because that leads to
punishment that might be the intuition
it leaves and so you could try doing
other actions you move up all right that
didn't lead to any immediate rewards
maybe try something else then maybe try
something else and all right now you
found that you've got another punishment
and so you learn something from that
experience so the next time you do this
whole process you know that if you ever
end up in this Square you shouldn't take
the down action because being in this
state and taking that action ultimately
leads to
some sort of punishment a negative
reward in other words and this process
repeats it you might imagine just
letting our agent explore the world
learning over time what states tend to
correspond with poor actions and
learning over time what states
correspond with poor actions until
eventually if it tries enough things
randomly it might find that eventually
when you get to this state if you take
the up action in this state it might
find that you actually get a reward from
that and what it can learn from that is
that if you're in this state you should
take the up action because that leads to
a reward and over time you can also
learn that if you're in this state you
should take the left action because that
leads to the state that also lets you
eventually get to the reward so you
begin to learn over time not only which
actions are good in particular States
but also which actions are bad such that
once you know with some sequence of good
actions that leads you to some sort of
reward our agent can just follow those
instructions follow the experience that
it has learned we didn't tell the agent
what the goal was we didn't tell the
agent where the punishments were but the
agent can begin to learn from this
experience and learn to begin to perform
these sorts of tasks better in the
future
and so let's now try to formalize this
idea formalize the idea that we would
like to be able to learn in this state
taking this action is that a good thing
or a bad thing there are lots of
different models for reinforcement
learning we're just going to look at one
of them today and the one that we're
going to look at is a method known as Q
learning and what Q learning is all
about is about learning a function a
function q that takes inputs s and a
where s is a state and a is an action
that you take in that state and what Q
is this Q function is going to do is it
is going to estimate the value how much
reward will I get from taking this
action in the state
originally we don't know what this Q
function should be but over time based
on experience based on trying things out
and seeing what the result is I would
like to try and learn what Q of fa is
for any particular State and any
particular action that I might take in
that state so what is the approach well
the approach originally is we'll start
with qsa equal to zero for all states s
and for all actions a that initially
before I've ever started anything before
I've had any experiences I don't know
the value of taking any action in any
given state so I'm going to assume that
the value is just zero all across the
board
but then as I interact with the world as
I experience Rewards or punishments or
maybe I go to a cell where I don't get
either reward or a punishment I want to
somehow update
my estimate of qsa I want to continually
update my estimate of qsa based on the
experiences and rewards and punishments
that I've received such that in the
future my knowledge of what actions are
good in what states will be better so
when we take an action and receive some
sort of reward I want to estimate the
new value of qsa and I estimate that
based on a couple of different things I
estimate it based on the reward that I'm
getting from taking this action and
getting into the next state but assuming
like the situation isn't over assuming
there are still future actions that I
might take as well I also need to take
into account the expected future rewards
that if you imagine an agent interacting
with the environment and sometimes
you'll take an action and get a reward
but then you can keep taking more
actions and get more rewards that these
both are relevant both the current
reward I'm getting from this current
step and also my future reward and it
might be the case that I'll want to take
a step that doesn't immediately lead to
a reward because later on down the line
I know it will lead to more rewards as
well so there's a balancing act between
current rewards that the agent
experiences and future rewards that the
agent experiences as well
and then we need to update qsa so we
estimate the value of qsa based on the
current reward and the expected future
rewards and then we need to update this
Q function to take into account this new
estimate now we already as we go through
this process we'll already have an
estimate for what we think the value is
now we have a new estimate and then
somehow we need to combine these two
estimates together and we'll look at
more formal ways that we can actually
begin to do that
so to actually show you what this
formula looks like here's the approach
we'll take with Q learning we're going
to again start with Q of sna being equal
to zero for all states and then every
time we take an action a in state s and
observer reward R we're going to update
our value our estimate for Q of sa and
the idea is that we're going to figure
out what the new Value Estimate is minus
what our existing Value Estimate is so
we have some preconceived notion for
what the value is for taking this action
in this state maybe our expectation is
we currently think the value is 10.
but then we're going to estimate what we
now think it's going to be maybe the new
Value Estimate is something like 20. so
there's a Delta of like 10 that our new
Value Estimate is 10 points higher than
what our current Value Estimate happens
to be
and so we have a couple of options here
we need to decide how much we want to
adjust our current expectation of what
the value is of taking this action in
this particular State and what that
difference is how much we add or
subtract from our existing notion of how
much that we expect the value to be is
dependent on this parameter Alpha also
called a learning rate and Alpha
represents in effect how much we value
new information compared to how much we
Value Old information an alpha value of
one means we really value new
information but if we have a new
estimate then it doesn't matter what our
old estimate is we're only going to
consider our new estimate because we
always just want to take into
consideration our new information so the
way that works is that if you imagine
Alpha being 1
well then we're taking the old value of
qsa and then adding one times the new
value minus the old value and that just
leaves us with the new value so when
Alpha is one all we take into
consideration is what our new estimate
happens to be
but over time as we go through a lot of
experiences we already have some
existing information we might have tried
taking this action nine times already
and now we just tried it a tenth time
and we don't only want to consider this
tent experience I also want to consider
the fact that my prior nine experiences
those were meaningful too and that's
data I don't necessarily want to lose
them and so this Alpha controls that
decision controls how important is the
new information zero would mean ignore
all the new information just keep this Q
value the same one means replace the old
information entirely with the new
information and somewhere in between
keep some sort of balance between these
two values
we can put this equation a little bit
more formally as well the old Value
Estimate is our old estimate for what
the value is of taking this action in a
particular State that's just Q of sna so
we have it once here and we're going to
add something to it we're going to add
Alpha times the new Value Estimate minus
the old Value Estimate but the old Value
Estimate we just look up by calling this
Q function
and what then is the new Value Estimate
based on this experience we have just
taken what is our new estimate for the
value of taking this action in this
particular State well it's going to be
composed of two parts it's going to be
composed of what reward did I just get
from taking this action in this state
and then it's going to be what can I
expect my future rewards to be from this
point forward so it's going to be
are some reward I'm getting right now
plus whatever I estimate I'm going to
get in the future and how do I estimate
what I'm going to get in the future well
it's a bit of a another call to this Q
function it's going to be take the
maximum across all possible actions I
could take next and say all right of all
of these possible actions I could take
which one is going to have the highest
reward so this then looks a little bit
complicated this is going to be our
notion for how we're going to perform
this kind of update then I have some
estimate some old estimate for what the
value is of taking this action in the
state and I'm going to update it based
on new information that I experienced
some reward I predict what my future
reward is going to be and using that I
update what what I estimate the reward
will be for taking this action in this
particular State and there are other
additions you might make to this
algorithm as well sometimes it might not
be the case that future rewards you want
to wait equally to current rewards maybe
you want an agent that values like
reward now over reward later and so
sometimes you can even add another term
in here some other parameter where you
discount future rewards and say future
rewards are not as valuable as rewards
immediately they're getting reward in
the current time step is better than
waiting a year and getting rewards later
but that's something up to the
programmer to decide what that parameter
ought to be
but the big picture idea of this entire
formula is to say that every time we
experience some new reward we take that
into account we update our estimate of
how good is this action and then in the
future we can make decisions based on
that algorithm once we have some good
estimate for every state and for every
action what the value is of taking that
action then we can do something like
Implement a greedy decision-making
policy that if I am in a state and I
want to know what action should I take
in that state well then I consider for
all of my possible actions what is the
value of Q essay what is my estimated
value of taking that action in that
state and I will just pick the action
that has the highest value
after I evaluate that expression
so I picked the action that has the
highest value and based on that that
tells me what action I should take at
any given state that I'm in I can just
readily say across all my actions this
action gives me the highest expected
value and so I'll go ahead and choose
that action as the action that I take as
well
but there is a downside to this kind of
approach and the downside comes up in a
situation like this where we know that
you know there is some solution that
gets me to the reward
and our agent has been able to figure
that out but it might not necessarily be
the best way or the fastest way if the
agent is allowed to explore a little bit
more it might find that it can get the
reward Faster by taking some other route
instead by going through this particular
path that is a faster way to get to
that ultimate goal and maybe we would
like for the agent to be able to figure
that out as well but if the agent always
takes the actions that it knows to be
best well when it gets to this
particular Square it doesn't know that
this is a good action because it's never
really tried it but it knows that going
down eventually leads its way to this
reward so it might learn in the future
that it should just always take this
route and it's never going to explore
and go along that route instead
so when reinforcement learning there's
this tension between exploration and
exploitation and exploitation generally
refers to using knowledge that the AI
already has the AI already knows that
this is a move that leads to reward so
we'll go ahead and use that move an
exploration is all about exploring other
actions that we may not have explored as
thoroughly before because maybe one of
these actions even if I don't know
anything about it might lead to better
rewards faster or to more rewards in the
future
and so an agent that only ever exploits
information and never explores might be
able to get reward but it might not
maximize its rewards because it doesn't
know what other possibilities are out
there possibilities they would only know
about by taking advantage of exploration
and so how can we try and address this
well one possible solution is known as
the Epsilon greedy algorithm where we
set Epsilon equal to how often we want
to just make a random move where
occasionally we will just make a random
move in order to say let's try to
explore and see what happens
and then the logic of the algorithm will
be with probability 1 minus Epsilon
choose the estimated best move
in a greedy case we'd always choose the
best move but an Epsilon greedy were
most of the time going to choose the
best move or sometimes going to choose
the best move but sometimes with
probability Epsilon we're going to
choose a random move instead
so every time we're faced with the
ability to take an action sometimes
we're going to choose the best move
sometimes we're just going to choose a
random move so this type of algorithm
then can be quite powerful in a
reinforcement learning context by not
always just choosing the best possible
move right now but sometimes especially
early on allowing yourself to make
random moves that allow you to explore
various different possible States and
actions more and maybe over time you
might decrease your value of Epsilon
more and more often choosing the best
move after you're more confident that
you've explored what all of the
possibilities actually are
so we can put this into practice and one
very common application of reinforcement
learning is in game plan that if you
want to teach an agent how to play a
game you just let the agent play the
game a whole bunch and then the reward
signal happens at the end of the game
when the game is over if our AI won the
game it gets a reward of like one for
example and if it lost the game it gets
a reward of negative one and from that
it begins to learn what actions are good
and what actions are bad you don't have
to tell the AI what's good and what's
bad but the AI figures it out based on
that reward winning the game is some
signal losing the game is some signal
and based on all of that it begins to
figure out what decisions it should
actually make
so one very simple game which you may
have played before is a game called Nim
and in the game of nim you've got a
whole bunch of objects in a whole bunch
of different piles where here I've
represented each pile as an individual
row so you've got one object in the
first pile three in the second pile five
and the third pile seven in the fourth
pile and the game of nim is a two player
game where players take turns removing
objects from piles and the rule is that
on any given turn you were allowed to
remove as many objects as you want from
any one of these piles any one of these
rows you have to remove at least one
object but you can remove as many as you
want from exactly one of the piles and
whoever takes the last object loses
so player one might like remove four
from this pile here player two might
remove four from this pile here so now
we've got four piles left one three one
and three player one might remove you
know the entirety of the second pile
player two if they're being strategic
might remove all uh might remove two
from the third pile now we've got three
piles left each with one object left
player one might remove one from one
pile player two removes one from the
other pile and now player one is left
with choosing this one object from the
last pile at which point player one
loses the game so fairly simple game
piles of objects any turn you choose how
many objects to remove from a pile
whoever removes the last object loses
and this is the type of game you could
encode into an AI fairly easily because
the states are really just four numbers
every state is just how many objects in
each of the four piles and the actions
are things like how many am I going to
remove from each one of these individual
piles
and the reward happens at the end that
if you were the player that had to
remove the last object then you get some
sort of punishment but if you were not
and the other player had to remove the
last object well then you get some sort
of reward so we could actually try and
show a demonstration of this that I've
implemented in AI to play the game of
nim
all right so here what we're going to do
is create an AI as a result of training
the AI on some number of games that the
AI is going to play against itself where
the idea is the AI will play games
against itself learn from each of those
experiences and learn what to do in the
future and then I the human will play
against the AI so initially we'll say
train zero times meaning we're not going
to let the AI play any practice games
against itself in order to learn from
its experiences we're just going to see
how well it plays
and it looks like there are four piles I
can choose how many I remove from any
one of the piles so maybe from pile
three I will remove five objects for
example
so now ai chose to take one item from
pile zero so I'm left with these piles
now for example and so here I could
choose maybe to say I would like to
remove from pile two I'll remove all
five of them for example
and so AI chose to take two away from
pile one now I'm left with one pile that
has one object one pile that has two
objects so from pile three I will remove
two objects and now I've left the I O
with no choice but to take that last one
until the game is over and I was able to
win but I did so because the AI was
really just playing randomly it didn't
have any prior experience that it was
using in order to make these sorts of
judgments now let me let the AI train
itself on like 10 000 games I'm going to
let the AI play 10 000 games of nim
against itself every time it wins or
loses it's going to learn from that
experience and learn in the future what
to do and what not to do so here then
I'll go ahead and run this again and now
you see the AI running through a whole
bunch of training games 10 000 training
games against itself and now it's going
to let me make these sorts of decisions
so now I'm going to play against the AI
maybe I'll remove one from pile three uh
and the AI took everything from pile
three so I'm left with three piles I'll
go ahead and from pile two maybe remove
three items
um and the AI removes one item from pile
zero I'm left with two piles Each of
which has two items in it I'll remove
one from pile one I guess
and the AI took two from pile two
leaving me with no choice but to take
one away from pile one so it seems like
after playing ten thousand games of nim
against itself the AI has learned
something about what states and what
actions tend to be good and has begun to
learn some sort of pattern for how to
predict what actions are going to be
good and what actions are going to be
bad in any given state
so reinforcement learning can be a very
powerful technique for achieving these
sorts of game playing agents agents that
are able to play a game well just by
learning from experience whether that's
playing against other people or by
playing against itself and learning from
those experiences as well now Nim is a
bit of an easy game to use reinforcement
learning for because there are so few
states there are only states that are as
many as how many different objects are
in each of these various different piles
you might imagine that it's going to be
harder if you think of a game like chess
or games where there are many many more
States and many many more actions that
you can imagine taking where it's not
going to be as easy to learn for every
state and for every action what the
value is going to be so oftentimes in
that case we can't necessarily learn
exactly what the value is for every
state and for every action but we can
approximate it so much as we saw with
Minimax so we could use a depth limiting
approach to stop calculating at a
certain point in time we can do a
similar type of approximation known as
function approximation in a
reinforcement learning context where
instead of learning a value of Q for
every state and every action we just
have some function that estimates what
the value is for taking this action in
this particular state that might be
based on various different features of
the state that the environment that the
agent happens to be in where you might
have to choose what those features
actually are but you can begin to learn
some patterns that generalize Beyond one
specific State and one specific action
that you can begin to learn if certain
features tend to be good things or bad
things reinforcement learning can allow
you using a very similar mechanism to
generalize Beyond one particular State
and say if this other state looks kind
of like this state then maybe the
similar types of actions that worked in
one state will also work in another
state as well and so this type of
approach can be quite helpful as you
begin to deal with reinforcement
learning that exists in larger and
larger State spaces where it's just not
feasible to explore all of the possible
states that could actually exist
so there then are two of the main
categories of reinforcement learning
supervised learning where you have
labeled input and output Pairs and
reinforcement learning where an agent
learns from Rewards or punishments that
it receives the third major category of
machine learning that we'll just touch
on briefly is known as unsupervised
learning and unsupervised learning
happens when we have data without any
additional feedback without labels that
in the supervised learning case all of
our data had labels we labeled a data
point with whether that was a rainy day
or a not rainy day and using those
labels we were able to infer what the
pattern was or we labeled data as a
counterfeit banknote or not a
counterfeit and using those labels we
were able to draw inferences and
patterns to figure out what does a
banknote look like versus not
in unsupervised learning we don't have
any access to any of those labels but we
still would like to learn some of those
patterns and one of the tasks that you
might want to perform in unsupervised
learning is something like clustering
where clustering is just a task of given
some set of objects organize it into
distinct clusters groups of objects that
are similar to one another and there's
lots of applications for clustering it
comes up in genetic research where you
might have a whole bunch of different
genes and you want to Cluster them into
similar genes if you're trying to
analyze across a population or across
species it comes up in an image if you
want to take all the pixels of an image
cluster them into different parts of the
image comes a lot a lot up in market
research if you want to divide your
consumers into different groups so you
know which groups to Target with certain
types of product advertisements for
example and a number of other contexts
as well in which clustering can be very
applicable one technique for clustering
is an algorithm known as K means
clustering and what K means clustering
is going to do is it is going to divide
all of our data points into K different
clusters and it's going to do so by
repeating this process of assigning
points to clusters and then moving
around those clusters at centers we're
going to define a cluster by its Center
the middle of the cluster and then
assign points to that cluster based on
which Center is closest to that point
and I'll show you an example of that now
here for example I have a whole bunch of
unlabeled data just various data points
that are in some sort of graphical space
and I would like to group them into
various different clusters but I don't
know how to do that originally and let's
say I want to put assign like three
clusters to this group and you have to
choose how many clusters you want in
k-means clustering that you could try
multiple and see how well those values
perform but I'll start just by randomly
picking some places to put the centers
of those clusters so maybe I have a blue
cluster a red cluster and a green
cluster and I'm going to start with the
centers of those clusters just being in
these three locations here and what K
means clustering tells us to do is once
I have the centers of the Clusters
assign every point to a cluster based on
which cluster Center it is closest to
so we end up with something like this
where all of these points are closer to
the blue cluster Center than any other
cluster Center
all of these points here are closer to
the green cluster Center than any other
cluster Center and then these two points
plus these points over here those are
all closest to the red cluster Center
instead
so here then is one possible assignment
of all these points to three different
clusters but it's not great that it
seems like in this red cluster these
points are kind of far apart in this
green cluster these points are kind of
far apart it might not be my ideal
choice of how I would cluster these
various different data points but K
means clustering is an iterative process
that after I do this there's a Next Step
which is that after I've assigned all of
the points to the cluster Center that it
is nearest to we are going to re-center
the Clusters meaning take the cluster
centers these diamond shapes here and
move them to the middle or the average
effectively of all of the points that
are in that cluster so we'll take this
blue point this blue Center and go ahead
and move it to the middle or to the
center of all of the points that were
assigned to the blue cluster moving it
slightly to the right in this case and
we'll do the same thing for red we'll
move the cluster Center to the middle of
all of these
points weighted by how many points there
are there are more points over here so
the red Center ends up moving a little
bit further that way and likewise for
the green center there are many more
points on this pla this side of the
green center so the green center ends up
being pulled a little bit further in
this direction
so we re-center all of the Clusters and
then we repeat the process we go ahead
and now reassign all of the points to
the cluster Center that they are now
closest to and now that we've moved
around the cluster centers these cluster
assignments might change that this point
originally was closer to the red cluster
Center but now it's actually closer to
the blue cluster Center same goes for
this point as well and these three
points that were originally closer to
the green cluster Center are now closer
to the red cluster Center instead
so we can reassign what colors or which
clusters each of these data points
belongs to and then repeat the process
again moving each of these cluster means
on the middles of the Clusters to the
mean the average of all of the other
points that happen to be there and
repeat the process again go ahead and
assign each of the points to the cluster
that they are closest to so once we
reach a point where we've assigned all
the points to clusters to the cluster
that they are nearest to and nothing
changed we've reached a sort of
equilibrium in this situation where no
points are changing their allegiance and
as a result we can declare this
algorithm is now over and we now have
some assignment of each of these points
into three different clusters and it
looks like we did a pretty good job of
trying to identify which points are more
similar to one another than they are to
points in other groups so we have the
green cluster down here this blue
cluster here and then this red cluster
over there as well and we did so without
any access to some labels to tell us
what these various different clusters
were we just used an algorithm in an
unsupervised sense without any of those
labels to figure out which points
belonged to which categories and again
lots of applications for this type of
clustering technique and there are many
more algorithms in each of these various
different fields within machine learning
supervised and reinforcement and
unsupervised but those are many of the
the big picture foundational ideas that
underlie a lot of these techniques where
these are the problems that we're trying
to solve and we try and solve those
problems using a number of different
methods of trying to take data and learn
patterns in that data whether that's
trying to find neighboring data points
that are similar or Trying to minimize
some sort of loss function or any number
of other techniques that allow us to
begin to try to solve these sorts of
problems that then was a look at some of
the principles that are at the
foundation of modern machine learning
this ability to take data and learn from
that data so that the computer can
perform a task even if they haven't
explicitly been given instructions in
order to do so next time we'll continue
this conversation about machine learning
looking at other techniques we can use
for solving these sorts of problems
we'll see you then
[Music]
thank you
all right welcome back everyone to an
introduction to artificial intelligence
with python now last time we took a look
at machine learning a set of techniques
that computers can use in order to take
a set of data and learn some patterns
inside of that data learn how to perform
a task even if we the programmers didn't
give the computer explicit instructions
for how to perform that task today we
transition to one of the most popular
techniques and tools within machine
learning that of neural networks and
neural networks were inspired as early
as the 1940s by researchers who were
thinking about how it is that humans
learn studying Neuroscience in the human
brain and trying to see whether or not
we could apply those same ideas to
computers as well and model Computer
Learning off of human learning so how is
the brain structured well very simply
put the brain is consists of a whole
bunch of neurons and those neurons are
connected to one another and communicate
with one another in some way in
particular if you think about the
structure of a biological neural network
something like this there are a couple
of Key properties that scientists
observed one was that these neurons are
connected to each other and receive
electrical signals from one another that
one neuron can propagate electrical
signals to another neuron
and another point is that neurons
process those input signals and then can
be activated that a neuron becomes
activated at a certain point and then
can propagate further signals onto
neurons in the future and so the
question then became could we take this
biological idea of how it is that humans
learn with brains and with neurons and
apply that to a machine as well in
effect designing an artificial neural
network or an an which will be a
mathematical model for learning that is
inspired by these biological neural
networks and what artificial neural
networks will allow us to do is they
will first be able to model some sort of
mathematical function every time you
look at a neural network which we'll see
more of later today each one of them is
really just some mathematical function
that is mapping certain inputs to
particular outputs based on the
structure of the network that depending
on where we place particular units
inside of the scenario Network that's
going to determine how it is that the
network is going to function
and in particular artificial neural
networks are going to lend themselves to
a way that we can learn what the
Network's parameters should be we'll see
more on that in just a moment but in
effect we want a model such that it is
easy for us to be able to write some
code that allows for the network to be
able to figure out how to model the
right mathematical function given a
particular set of input data so in order
to create our artificial neural network
instead of using biological neurons
we're just going to use what we're going
to call units units inside of a neural
network which we can represent kind of
like a node in a graph which will here
be represented just by a blue circle
like this and these artificial units
these artificial neurons can be
connected to one another so here for
instance we have two units that are
connected by this Edge inside of this
graph effectively
and so what we're going to do now is
think of this idea as some sort of
mapping from inputs to outputs so we
have one unit that is connected to
another unit that we might think of this
side as the input and that side of the
output and what we're trying to do then
is to figure out how to solve a problem
how to model some sort of mathematical
function and this might take the form of
something we saw last time which was
something like we have certain inputs
like variables X1 and X2 and given those
inputs we want to perform some sort of
task a task like predicting whether or
not it's going to rain and ideally we'd
like some way given these inputs X1 and
X2 which stand for some sort of
variables to do with the weather we
would like to be able to predict in this
case a Boolean classification is it
going to rain or is it not going to rain
and we did this last time by way of a
mathematical function we Define some
function H for our hypothesis function
that took us input X1 and X2 the two
inputs that we cared about processing in
order to determine whether we thought it
was going to rain or whether we thought
it was not going to rain the question
then becomes what does this hypothesis
function do in order to make that
determination and we decided last time
to use a linear combination of these
input variables to determine what the
output should be so our hypothesis
function was equal to something like
this weight 0 plus weight one times X1
plus weight 2 times X2 so what's going
on here is that X1 and X2 those are
input variables the inputs to this
hypothesis function and each of those
input variables is being multiplied by
some weight which is just some number so
X1 is being multiplied by weight one X2
is being multiplied by weight two and we
have this additional weight weight zero
that doesn't get multiplied by an input
variable at all that just serves to
either move the function up or move the
function's value down you can think of
this as either a weight that's just
multiplied by some dummy value like the
number one it's multiplied by one and so
it's not multiplied by anything or
sometimes you'll see in the literature
people call this variable weight zero a
bias so that you can think of these
variables as slightly different we have
weights that are multiplied by the input
and we separately add some bias to the
result as well you'll hear both of those
terminologies used when people talk
about neural networks and machine
learning
so in effect what we've done here is
that in order to define a hypothesis
function we just need to decide and
figure out what these weights should be
to determine what values to multiply by
our inputs to get some sort of result of
course at the end of this what we need
to do is make some sort of
classification like rainy or not rainy
and to do that we use some sort of
function so that Define some sort of
threshold and so we saw for instance the
step function which is defined as one if
the weight if the result of multiplying
the weights by the inputs is at least
zero otherwise it's zero and you can
think of this line down the middle as
kind of like a dotted line effectively
it stays at zero all the way up to one
point and then the function steps or
jumps up to one so it's zero before it
reaches some threshold and then it's one
after it reaches a particular threshold
and so this was one way we could Define
what we'll come to call an activation
function a function that determines when
it is this output becomes active changes
to a z one instead of being a zero but
we also saw that if we didn't just want
a purely binary classification we didn't
want purely one or zero but we wanted to
allow for some in-between real numbered
values we could use a different function
and there are a number of choices but
the one that we looked at was the
logistic sigmoid function that has sort
of an s-shaped curve where we could
represent this as a probability that
maybe somewhere in between the
probability of rain of something like
0.5 maybe a little bit later the
probability of rain is 0.8 and so rather
than just have a binary classification
of 0 or 1 we could allow for numbers
that are in between as well and it turns
out there are many other different types
of activation functions where an
activation function just takes the
output of multiplying the weights
together and adding that bias and then
figuring out what the actual output
should be another popular one is the
rectified linear unit otherwise known as
relu and the way that works is that it
just takes its input and takes the
maximum of that input and zero so if
it's positive it remains unchanged but
if it's zero if it's negative it goes
ahead and levels out at zero and there
are other activation functions that we
could choose as well but in short each
of these activation functions you can
just think of as a function that gets
applied to the result of all of this
computation we take some function G and
apply it to the result of all of that
calculation
and this then is what we saw last time
the way of defining some hypothesis
function that takes in inputs calculates
some linear combination of those inputs
and then passes it through some sort of
activation function to get our output
and this actually turns out to be the
model for the simplest of neural
networks that we're going to instead
represent this mathematical idea
graphically by using a structure like
this here then is a neural network that
has two inputs we can think of this is
X1 and this is X2 and then one output
which you can think of classifying
whether or not we think it's going to
rain or not rain for example in this
particular instance and so how exactly
does this model work well each of these
two inputs represents one of our input
variables X1 and X2 and notice that
these inputs are connected to this
output via these edges which are going
to be defined by their weights so these
edges each have a weight associated with
them weight one and wait two
and then this output unit what it's
going to do is it is going to calculate
an output based on those inputs and
based on those weights this output unit
is going to multiply all the inputs by
their weights add in this bias term
which you can think of as an extra w0
term that gets added into it and then we
pass it through an activation function
so this then is just a graphical way of
representing the same idea we saw last
time just mathematically and we're going
to call this a very simple neural
network and we'd like for this neural
network to be able to learn how to
calculate some function that we want
some function for the neural network to
learn and the neural network is going to
learn what should the values of w0 W1
and w2b what should the activation
function be in order to get the result
that we would expect
so we can actually take a look at an
example of this what then is a very
simple function that we might calculate
well if we recall back from when we were
looking at propositional logic one of
the simplest functions we looked at was
something like the or function that
takes two inputs X and Y and outputs one
otherwise known as true if either one of
the inputs or both of them are one and
outputs a zero if both of the inputs are
zero or false so this then is the or
function and this was the truth table
for the or function that as long as
either of the inputs are one the output
of the function is one and the only case
where the output is zero is where both
of the inputs are zero so the question
is how could we take this and train a
neural network to be able to learn this
particular function what would those
weights look like well we could do
something like this here's our neural
network
and I'll propose that in order to
calculate the or function we're going to
use a value of one for each of the
weights and we'll use a bias of negative
one and then we'll just use this step
function as our activation function how
then does this work well if I wanted to
calculate something like 0 or 0 which we
know to be zero because false or false
is false then what are we going to do
well our output unit is going to
calculate this input multiplied by the
weight 0 times 1 that's 0. same thing
here zero times one that's zero and
we'll add to that the bias minus one so
that'll give us a result of negative one
if we plot that on our activation
function negative one is here it's
before the threshold which means either
zero or one it's only one after the
threshold since negative 1 is before the
threshold the output that this unit
provides is going to be zero and that's
what we would expect it to be that 0 or
0 should be zero What If instead we had
had one or zero where this is the number
one well in this case in order to
calculate what the output is going to be
we again have to do this weighted sum
one times one that's one
zero times one that's zero some of that
so far is one
add negative 1 to that well then the
output is zero and if we plot 0 on the
step function zero ends up being here
it's just at the threshold and so the
output here is going to be one because
the output of one or zero that's one so
that's what we would expect as well and
just for one more example if I had one
or one what would the result be well one
times one is one one times one is one
the sum of those is two I add the bias
term to that I get the number one one
plotted on this graph is way over there
that's well beyond the threshold and so
this output is going to be one as well
the output is always zero or one
depending on whether or not we're past
the threshold and this neural network
then models the or function a very
simple function definitely but it still
is able to model it correctly if I give
it the inputs it will tell me what X1 or
X2 happens to be and you could imagine
trying to do this for other functions as
well a function like the and function
for instance
that takes two inputs and calculates
whether both X and Y are true so if x is
1 and Y is one then the output of X and
Y is one but in all the other cases the
output is zero how could we model that
inside of a neural network as well well
it turns out we could do it in the same
way except instead of negative one as
the bias we can use negative two as the
bias instead what does that end up
looking like well if I had one and one
that should be one because one true and
true is equal to true well I take one
times one that's one one times one is
one I get a total sum of two so far now
I add the bias of negative two and I get
the value 0 and 0 when I plotted on the
activation function is just past that
threshold and so the output is going to
be one
but if I add any other input for example
like 1 and 0 well the weighted sum of
these is one plus zero is going to be
one minus two is going to give us
negative one and negative 1 is not past
that threshold and so the output is
going to be zero
so those then are some very simple
functions that we can model using a
neural network that has two inputs and
one output where our goal is to be able
to figure out what those weights should
be in order to determine what the output
should be and you could imagine
generalizing this to calculate more
complex functions as well that maybe
given the humidity and the pressure we
want to calculate what's the probability
that it's going to rain for example or
we might want to do a regression style
problem we're given some amount of
advertising and given what month it is
maybe we want to predict what our
expected sales are going to be for that
particular month so you could imagine
these inputs and outputs being different
as well and it turns out that in some
problems we're not just going to have
two inputs and the nice thing about
these neural networks is that we can
compose multiple units together make our
networks more complex just by adding
more units into this particular neural
network so the network we've been
looking at has two inputs and one output
but we could just as easily say let's go
ahead and have three inputs in there or
have even more inputs where we could
arbitrarily decide however many inputs
there are to our problem all going to be
calculating some sort of output that we
care about figuring out the value of how
then does the math work for figuring out
that output well it's going to work in a
very similar way in the case of two
inputs we had two weights indicated by
these edges and we multiplied the
weights by the numbers adding this bias
term
and we'll do the same thing in the other
cases as well if I have three inputs
you'll imagine multiplying each of these
three inputs by each of these weights if
I had five inputs instead we're going to
do the same thing here I'm saying sum up
from one to five x I multiply by weight
I so take each of the five input
variables multiply them by their
corresponding weight and then add the
bias to that so this would be a case
where there are five inputs into this
neural network for example but there
could be more arbitrarily many nodes
that we want inside of this neural
network where each time we're just going
to sum up all of those input variables
multiplied by their weight and then add
the bias term at the very end and so
this allows us to be able to represent
problems that have even more inputs just
by growing the size of our neural
network
now the next question we might ask is a
question about how it is that we train
these neural networks in the case of the
or function and the and function they
were simple enough functions that I
could just tell you like here what the
weights should be and you could probably
reason through it yourself what the
weights should be in order to calculate
the output that you want but in general
with functions like predicting sales or
predicting whether or not it's going to
rain these are much trickier functions
to be able to figure out we would like
the computer to have some mechanism of
calculating what it is that the weights
should be how it is to set the weights
so that our neural network is able to
accurately model the function that we
care about trying to estimate and it
turns out that the strategy for doing
this inspired by the domain of calculus
is a technique called gradient descent
and what gradient descent is it is an
algorithm for minimizing loss when
you're training a neural network and
recall that loss refers to how bad our
hypothesis function happens to be that
we can Define certain loss functions and
we saw some examples of loss function
last time that just give us a number for
any particular hypothesis saying how
poorly does it model the data how many
examples does it get wrong how much how
are they worse or less bad as compared
to other hypothesis functions that we
might Define
and this loss function is just a
mathematical function and when you have
a mathematical function in calculus what
you could do is calculate something
known as the gradient which you can
think of as like a slope it's the
direction the loss function is moving at
any particular point and what it's going
to tell us is in which direction should
we be moving these weights in order to
minimize the amount of loss and so
generally speaking we won't get into the
calculus of it but the high level idea
for gradient descent is going to look
something like this if we want to train
a neural network we'll go ahead and
start just by choosing the weights
randomly just pick random weights for
all of the weights in the neural network
and then we'll use the input data that
we have access to in order to train the
network in order to figure out what the
weight should actually be so we'll
repeat this process again and again the
first step is we're going to calculate
the gradient based on all of the data
points we'll look at all the data and
figure out what the gradient is at the
place where we currently are for the
current setting of the weights which
means in which direction should we move
the weights in order to minimize the
total amount of loss in order to make
our solution better
and once we've calculated that gradient
which direction we should move in the
loss function well then we can just
update those weights according to the
gradient take a small step in the
direction of those weights in order to
try to make our solution a little bit
better and the size of the step that we
take that's going to vary and you can
choose that when you're training a
particular neural network but in short
the idea is going to be take all the
data points figure out based on those
data points in what direction the weight
should move and then move the weights
one small step in that direction and if
you repeat that process over and over
again adjusting the weights a little bit
at a time based on all the data points
eventually you should end up with a
pretty good solution to trying to solve
this sort of problem at least that's
what we would hope to happen
now if you look at this algorithm a good
question to ask anytime you're analyzing
an algorithm is what is going to be the
expensive part of doing the calculation
what's going to take a lot of work to
try to figure out what is going to be
expensive to calculate and in particular
in the case of gradient descent the
really expensive part is this all data
points part right here having to take
all of the data points and using all
those data points figure out what the
gradient is at this particular setting
of all of the weights because odds are
in a big machine learning problem where
you're trying to solve a big problem
with a lot of data you have a lot of
data points in order to calculate and
figuring out the gradient based on all
of those data points is going to be
expensive and you'll have to do it many
times so you'll likely repeat this
process again and again and again going
through all the data points taking one
small step over and over as you try and
figure out what the optimal setting of
those weights happens to be it turns out
that we would ideally like to be able to
train our neural networks faster to be
able to more quickly converge to some
sort of solution that is going to be a
good solution to the problem so in that
case there are alternatives to just
standard gradient descent which looks at
all of the data points at once we can
employ a method like stochastic gradient
descent which will randomly just choose
one data point at a time to calculate
the gradient based on instead of
calculating it based on all of the data
points so the idea there is that we have
some setting of the weights we pick a
data point and based on that one data
point we figure out in which direction
should we move all the weights and move
the weights in that small Direction then
take another data point and do that
again and repeat this process again and
again maybe looking at each of the data
points multiple times but each time only
using one data point to calculate the
gradient to calculate which direction we
should move in now just using one data
point instead of all of the data points
probably gives us a less accurate
estimate of what the gradient actually
is is but on the plus side it's going to
be much faster to be able to calculate
that we can much more quickly calculate
what the gradient is based on one data
point instead of calculating based on
all of the data points and having to do
all of that computational work again and
again so there are trade-offs here
between looking at all the data points
and just looking at one data point
and it turns out that a middle ground
that was also quite popular is a
technique called mini batch gradient
descent where the idea there is instead
of looking at all of the data versus
just a single point we instead divide
our data set up into small batches
groups of data points where you can
decide how big a particular batch is but
in short you're just going to look at a
small number of points at any given time
hopefully getting a more accurate
estimate of the gradient but also not
requiring all of the computational
effort needed to look at every single
one of these data points
so gradient descent then is this
technique that we can use in order to
train these neural networks in order to
figure out what the setting of all of
these weights should be if we want some
way to try and get an accurate notion of
how it is that this function should work
some way of modeling how to transform
the inputs into particular outputs now
so far the networks that we've taken a
look at have all been structured similar
to this we have some number of inputs
maybe two or three or five or more and
then we have one output that is just
predicting like rain or no rain or just
predicting one particular value but
often in machine learning problems we
don't just care about one output we
might care about an output that has
multiple different values associated
with it so in the same way that we could
take a neural network and add units to
the input layer we can likewise add
input or out outputs to the output layer
as well instead of just one output you
could imagine we have two outputs or we
could have like four outputs for example
where in each case as we add more inputs
or add more outputs
if we want to keep this network fully
connected between these two layers we
just need to add more weight that now
each of these input nodes has four
weights associated with each of the four
outputs and that's true for each of
these various different input nodes so
as we add nodes we add more weights in
order to make sure that each of the
inputs can somehow be connected to each
of the outputs so that each output value
can be calculated based on what the
value of the input happens to be
so what made a case be where we want
multiple different output values
well you might consider that in the case
of weather predicting for example we
might not just care whether it's raining
or not raining there might be multiple
different categories of weather that we
would like to categorize the weather
into with just a single output variable
we can do a binary classification like
rain or no rain for instance one or zero
but it doesn't allow us to do much more
than that with multiple output variables
I might be able to use each one to
predict something a little different
maybe I want to categorize the weather
into one of four different categories
something like is it going to be raining
or sunny or cloudy or snowy and I now
have four output variables that can be
used to represent maybe the probability
that it is rainy as opposed to sunny as
opposed to cloudy or as opposed to snowy
how then would this neural network work
well we have some input variables that
represent some data that we have
collected about the weather each of
those inputs gets multiplied by each of
these various different weights we have
more multiplications to do but these are
fairly quick mathematical operations to
perform
and then what we get is after passing
them through some sort of activation
function in the outputs we end up
getting some sort of number where that
number you might imagine you could
interpret it as like a probability like
a probability that it is one category as
opposed to another category so here
we're saying that based on the inputs we
think there is a 10 chance that it's
raining a 60 chance that it's sunny a 20
chance it's cloudy a 10 chance that it's
snowy and given that output if these
represent like a probability
distribution well then you could just
pick whichever one has the highest value
in this case sunny and say that well
most likely we think that this
categorization of inputs means that the
output should be snowy and or it should
be sunny and that is what we would
expect the weather to be in this
particular instance
and so this allows us to do these sort
of multi-class classifications where
instead of just having a binary
classification one or zero we can have
as many different categories as we want
and we can have our neural network
output these probabilities over which
categories are most more likely than
other categories and and using that data
we're able to draw some sort of
inference on what it is that we should
do so this was sort of the idea of
supervised machine learning I can give
the neural network a whole bunch of data
a whole bunch of input data
corresponding to some label some output
data like we know that it was raining on
this day we know that with sunny on that
day and using all of that data the
algorithm can use gradient descent to
figure out what all the weights should
be in order to create some sort of model
that hopefully allows us a way to
predict what we think the weather is
going to be
but neural networks have a lot of other
applications as well you could imagine
applying the same sort of idea to a
reinforcement learning sort of example
as well where you remember that in
reinforcement learning what we wanted to
do is train some sort of agent to learn
what action to take depending on what
state they currently happen to be in so
depending on the current state of the
world we wanted the agent to pick from
one of the available actions that is
available to them
and you might model that by having each
of these input variables represent some
information about the state some data
about what state our agent is currently
in and then the output for example could
be each of the various different actions
that our agent could take action one two
three and four and you might imagine
that this network would work in the same
way the based on these particular inputs
we go ahead and calculate values for
each of these outputs and those outputs
could model which action is better than
other actions and we could just choose
based on looking at those outputs which
action should we should take
and so these neural networks are very
broadly applicable that all they're
really doing is modeling some
mathematical function so anything that
we can frame as a mathematical function
something like classifying inputs into
various different categories or figuring
out based on some input State what
action we should take these are all
mathematical functions that we could
attempt to model by taking advantage of
this neural network structure and in
particular taking advantage of this
technique gradient descent that we can
use in order to figure out what the
weights should be in order to do this
sort of calculation
now how is it that you would go about
training a neural network that has
multiple outputs instead of just one
well with just a single output we could
see what the output for that value
should be and then you update all the
weights that corresponded to it and when
we have multiple outputs at least in
this particular case we can really think
of this as four separate neural networks
that really we just have one network
here that has these three inputs
corresponding with these three weights
corresponding to this one output value
and the same thing is true for this
output value this output value
effectively defines yet another neural
network that has these same three inputs
but a different set of Weights that
correspond to this output and likewise
this output has its own set of Weights
as well and same thing for the fourth
output two
and so if you wanted to train a neural
network that had four outputs instead of
just one in this case where the inputs
are directly connected to the outputs
you could really think of this as just
training for independent neural networks
we know what the outputs for each of
these four should be based on our input
data and using that data we can begin to
figure out what all of these individual
weights should be and maybe there's an
additional Step at the end to make sure
that we turn these values into a
probability distribution such that we
can interpret which one is better than
another or more likely than another as a
category or something like that
so this then seems like it does a pretty
good job of taking inputs and trying to
predict what outputs should be and we'll
see some real examples of this in just a
moment as well but it's important then
to think about what the limitations of
this sort of approach is of just taking
some linear combination of inputs and
passing it into some sort of activation
function and it turns out that when we
do this in the case of binary
classification of trying to predict like
does it belong to one category or
another
we can only predict things that are
linearly separable because we're taking
a linear combination of inputs and using
that to Define some decision boundary or
threshold then what we get is a
situation where if we have this set of
data we can predict like a line that
separates linearly the red points from
the Blue Points but a single unit that
is making a binary classification
otherwise known as a perceptron
can't deal with a situation like this
where we've seen this type of situation
before where there is no straight line
that just goes straight through the data
that will divide the red points away
from the Blue Points it's a more complex
decision boundary the decision boundary
somehow needs to capture him the things
inside of this circle and there isn't
really a line that will allow us to deal
with that
so this is the limitation of the
perceptron these units that just make
these binary decisions based on their
inputs then a single perceptron is only
capable of learning a linearly separable
decision boundary all it can do is
Define a line and sure it can give us
probabilities based on how close to that
decision boundary we are but it can only
really decide based on a linear decision
boundary and so this doesn't seem like
it's going to generalize well to
situations where real world data is
involved because real world data often
isn't linearly separable it often isn't
the case that we can just draw a line
through the data and be able to divide
it up into multiple groups so what then
is the solution to this well what was
proposed was the idea of a multi-layer
neural network that so far all the
neural networks we've seen have had a
set of inputs and a set of outputs and
the inputs are connected to those
outputs
but in a multi-layer neural network this
is going to be an artificial neural
network that has an input layer still it
has an output layer but also has one or
more hidden layers in between other
layers of artificial neurons or units
that are going to calculate their own
values as well so instead of a neural
network that looks like this with three
inputs and one output you might imagine
in the middle here injecting a hidden
layer something like this this is a
hidden layer that has four nodes you
could choose how many nodes or units end
up going into the hidden layer you can
have multiple hidden layers as well and
so now each of these inputs isn't
directly connected to the output each of
the inputs is connected to this hidden
layer and then all of the nodes in the
hidden layer those are connected to the
one output
and so this is just another step that we
can take towards calculating more
complex functions each of these hidden
units will calculate its output value
otherwise known as its activation based
on a linear combination of all the
inputs and once we have values for all
of these nodes as opposed to this just
being the output we do the same thing
again calculate the output for this node
based on multiplying each of the values
for these units by their weights as well
so in effect the way this works is we
start with inputs they get multiplied by
weights in order to calculate values for
the hidden nodes those get multiplied by
weights in order to figure out what the
ultimate output is going to be
and the advantage of layering things
like this is it gives us an ability to
model more complex functions that
instead of just having a single decision
boundary a single line dividing the red
points from the Blue Points each of
these hidden nodes can learn a different
decision boundary and we can combine
those decision boundaries to figure out
what the ultimate output is going to be
and as we begin to imagine more complex
situations you could imagine each of
these nodes learning some useful
property or learning some useful feature
of all of the inputs and US somehow
learning how to combine those features
together in order to get the output that
we actually want
now the natural question when we begin
to look at this now is to ask the
question of how do we train a neural
network that has hidden layers inside of
it and this turns out to initially be a
bit of a tricky question because the
input data that we are given is we are
given values for all of the inputs and
we're given what the value of the output
should be what the category is for
example but the input data doesn't tell
us what the values for all of these
nodes should be so we don't know how far
off each of these nodes actually is
because we're only given data for the
inputs and the outputs the reason this
is called a hidden layer is because the
data that is made available to us
doesn't tell us what the values for all
of these intermediate nodes should
actually be
and so the strategy people came up with
was to say that if you know what the
error or the loss is on the output node
well then based on what these weights
are if one of these weights is higher
than another you can calculate an
estimate for how much the error from
this node was due to this part of the
Hidden node or this part of the Hidden
layer or this part of the Hidden layer
based on the values of these weights in
effect saying that based on the error
from the output I can back propagate the
error and figure out an estimate for
what the error is for each of these
nodes in the hidden layer as well and
there's some more calculus here that we
won't get into the details of but the
idea of this algorithm is known as back
propagation it's an algorithm for
training a neural network with multiple
different hidden layers and the idea for
this the pseudocode for it will again be
if we want to run gradient descent with
back propagation we'll start with a
random choice of Weights as we did
before
and now we'll go ahead and repeat the
training process again and again but
what we're going to do each time is now
we're going to calculate the error for
the output layer first we know the
output and what it should be and we know
what we calculated so we can figure out
what the error there is
but then we're going to repeat for every
layer starting with the output layer
moving back into the hidden layer then
the hidden layer before that if there
are multiple hidden layers going back
all the way to the very first hidden
layer assuming they're multiple we're
going to propagate the error back one
layer whatever the error was from the
output figure out what the error should
be a layer before that based on what the
values of those weights are and then we
can update those weights
so graphically the way you might think
about this is that we first start with
the output we know what the output
should be we know what output we
calculated and based on that we can
figure out all right how do we need to
update those weights back propagating
the error to these nodes and using that
we can figure out how we should update
these weights and you might imagine if
there are multiple layers we could
repeat this process again and again to
begin to figure out how all of these
weights should be updated in this back
propagation algorithm is really the key
algorithm that makes neural networks
possible it makes it possible to take
these multi-level structures and be able
to train those structures depending on
what the values of these weights are in
order to figure out how it is that we
should go about updating those weights
in order to create some function that is
able to minimize the total amount of
loss to figure out some good setting of
the weights that will take the inputs
and translate it into the output that we
expect
and this works as we said not just for a
single hidden layer but you can imagine
multiple hidden layers where each hidden
layer we just Define however many nodes
we want where each of the nodes in one
layer we can connect to the nodes in the
next layer defining more and more
complex networks that are able to model
more and more complex types of functions
and so this type of network is what we
might call a deep neural network part of
a larger family
of deep learning algorithms if you've
ever heard that term and all deep
learning is about is it's using multiple
layers to be able to predict and be able
to model higher level features inside of
the input to be able to figure out what
the output should be and so a deep
neural network is just a neural network
that has multiple of these hidden layers
where we start at the input calculate
values for this layer then this layer
then this layer and then ultimately get
an output and this allows us to be able
to model more and more sophisticated
types of functions that each of these
layers can calculate something a little
bit different and we can combine that
information to figure out what the
output should be
of course as with any situation of
machine learning as we begin to make our
models more and more complex to model
more and more complex functions the risk
we run is something like overfitting and
we talked about overfitting last time in
the context of overfitting based on when
we were training our models to be able
to learn some sort of decision boundary
where overfitting happens when we fit
too closely to the training data and as
a result we don't generalize well to
other situations as well and one of the
risks we run with a far more complex
neural network that has many many
different nodes is that we might overfit
based on the input data we might grow
over reliant on certain nodes to
calculate things just purely based on
the input data that doesn't allow us to
generalize very well to the output and
there are a number of strategies for
dealing with overfitting but one of the
most popular in the context of neural
networks is a technique known as Dropout
and what Dropout does is it when we're
training the neural network what we'll
do in Dropout is temporarily remove
units temporarily remove these
artificial neurons from our Network
chosen at random and the goal here is to
prevent over-reliance on certain units
so what generally happens in overfitting
is that we begin to over rely on certain
units inside the neural network to be
able to tell us how to interpret the
input data what Dropout will do is
randomly remove some of these units in
order to reduce the chance that we over
rely on certain units to make our neural
network more robust to be able to handle
the situations even when we just drop
out particular neurons entirely
so the way that might work is we have a
network like this and as we're training
it when we go about trying to update the
weights the first time we'll just
randomly pick some percentage of the
nodes to drop out of the network it's as
if those nodes aren't there at all it's
as if the weights associated with those
nodes aren't there at all and we'll
train it this way then the next time we
update the weights we'll pick a
different set and just go ahead and
train that way and then again randomly
choose and train with other nodes that
have been dropped out as well
and the goal of that is that after the
training process if you train by
dropping out random nodes inside of this
neural network you hopefully end up with
a network it's a little bit more robust
that doesn't rely too heavily on any one
particular node but more generally
learns how to approximate a function in
general
so that then is a look at some of these
techniques that we can use in order to
implement a neural network to get at the
idea of taking this input passing it
through these various different layers
in order to produce some sort of output
and what we'd like to do now is take
those ideas and put them into code and
to do that there are a number of
different machine learning libraries
neural network libraries that we can use
that allow us to get access to someone's
implementation of back propagation and
all of these hidden layers and one of
the most popular developed by Google is
known as tensorflow a library that we
can use for quickly creating neural
networks and modeling them and running
them on some sample data to see what the
output is going to be and before we
actually start writing code we'll go
ahead and take a look at tensorflow's
playground which will be an opportunity
for us just to play around with this
idea of neural networks in different
layers just to get a sense for what it
is that we can do by taking advantage of
neural networks
so let's go ahead and go into
tensorflow's playground which you can go
to by visiting that URL from before and
what we're going to do now is we're
going to try and learn the decision
boundary for this particular output I
want to learn to separate the orange
points from the blue points and I'd like
to learn some sort of setting of Weights
inside of a neural network that will be
able to separate those from each other
the features we have access to are input
data are the x value and the Y value so
the two values along each of the two
axes and what I'll do now is I can set
particular parameters like what
activation function I would like to use
and I'll just go ahead and press play
and see what happens
and what happens here is that you'll see
that just by using these two input
features the x value and the Y value
with no hidden layers just take the
input X and Y values and figure out what
the decision boundary is our neural
network learns pretty quickly that in
order to divide these two points we
should just use this line this line acts
as a decision boundary that separates
this group of points from that group of
points and it does it very well you can
see up here what the losses the training
loss is zero meaning we were able to
perfectly model separating these two
points from each other inside of our
training data
so this was a fairly simple case of
trying to apply a neural network because
the data is very clean it's very nicely
linearly separable we can just draw a
line that separates all of those points
from each other let's now consider a
more complex case so I'll go ahead and
pause the simulation
and we'll go ahead and look at this data
set here this data set is a little bit
more complex now in this data set we
still have blue and orange points that
we'd like to separate from each other
but there's no single line that we can
draw that is going to be able to figure
out how to separate the blue from the
orange because the blue is located in
these two quadrants and the Orange is
located here and here it's a more
complex function to be able to learn so
let's see what happens if we just try
and predict based on those inputs the X
and Y coordinates what the output should
be
I'll press play
and what you'll notice is that we're not
really able to draw much of a conclusion
that we're not able to very cleanly see
how we should divide the orange points
from the Blue Points
and you don't see a very clean
separation there
so it seems like we don't have enough
sophistication inside of our Network to
be able to model something that is that
complex we need a better model for this
neural network and I'll do that by
adding a hidden layer
so now I have a hidden layer that has
two neurons inside of it so I have two
inputs that then go to two neurons
inside of a hidden layer that then go to
our output and now I'll press play
and what you'll notice here is that
we're able to do slightly better we're
able to now say all right these points
are definitely blue these points are
definitely orange we're still struggling
a little bit with these points up here
though and what we can do is we can see
for each of these hidden neurons what is
it exactly that these hidden neurons are
doing each hidden neuron is learning its
own decision boundary and we can see
what that boundary is this first neuron
is learning all right this line that
seems to separate some of the blue
points from the rest of the points
this other hidden neuron is learning
another line that seems to be separating
the orange points in the lower right
from the rest of the points so that's
why we're able to sort of figure out
these two areas in the bottom region but
we're still not able to perfectly
classify all of the points so let's go
ahead and
add another neuron now we've got three
neurons inside of our hidden layer and
see what we're able to learn now
all right well now we seem to be doing a
better job by learning three different
decision boundaries which each of the
three neurons inside of our hidden layer
we're able to much better figure out how
to separate these blue points from the
orange points and you can see what each
of these hidden neurons is learning each
one is learning a slightly different
decision boundary and then we're
combining those decision boundaries
together to figure out what the overall
output should be I mean we can try it
one more time by adding a fourth neuron
there
and try learning that and it seems like
now we can do even better trying to
separate the blue points from the orange
points but we were only able to do this
by adding a hidden layer by adding some
layer that is learning some other
boundaries and combining those
boundaries to determine the output and
the strength though the size and
thickness of these lines indicate how
high these weights are how important
each of these inputs is for making this
sort of calculation
and we can do maybe one more simulation
let's go ahead and try this on a data
set that looks like this
go ahead and get rid of the Hidden layer
here now we're trying to separate the
blue points from the orange points where
all the blue points are located again
inside of a circle effectively so we're
not going to be able to learn a line
notice I press play and we're really not
able to draw any sort of classification
at all because there is no line that
cleanly separates the blue points from
the orange points
so let's try to solve this by
introducing a hidden layer
I'll go ahead and press play
and all right with two neurons in a
hidden layer we're able to do a little
better because we effectively learn two
different decision boundaries we learn
this line here and we learn this line on
the right hand side and right now we're
just saying all right well if it's in
between we'll call it blue and if it's
outside we'll call it orange so not
great but certainly better than before
that we're learning one decision
boundary and another and based on those
we can figure out what the output should
be
but let's now go ahead and add a third
neuron and see what happens now I go
ahead and train it and now using three
different decision boundaries that are
learned by each of these hidden neurons
we're able to much more accurately model
this distinction between blue points and
orange points we're able to figure out
maybe with these three decision
boundaries combining them together you
can imagine figuring out what the output
should be and how to make that sort of
classification and so the goal here is
just to get a sense for having more
neurons in these hidden layers allows us
to learn more structure in the data
allows us to figure out what the
relevant and important decision
boundaries are and then using this back
propagation algorithm we're able to
figure out what the values of these
weights should be in order to train this
network to be able to classify one
category of points away from another
category of points instead and this is
ultimately what we're going to be trying
to do whenever we're training a neural
network
so let's go ahead and actually see an
example of this you'll recall from last
time that we had this banknotes file
that included information about
counterfeit banknotes as opposed to
authentic banknotes where I had like
four different values for each banknote
and then a categorization of whether
that banknote is considered to be
authentic or a counterfeit note and what
I wanted to do was based on that input
information figure out some function
that could calculate based on the input
information what category it belonged to
and what I've written here in
banknotes.pi is a neural network that
will learn just that a network that
learns based on all of the input whether
or not we should categorize a banknote
as authentic or as counterfeit
the first step is the same as what we
saw from last time I'm really just
reading the data in and getting it into
an appropriate format and so this is
where more of the like writing python
code on your own comes in in terms of
manipulating this data massaging the
data into a format that will be
understood by a machine learning library
like scikit-learn or like tensorflow
and so here I separate it into a
training and a testing set
and now what I'm doing down below is I'm
creating a neural network here I'm using
TF which stands for tensorflow up above
I said import tensorflow as TF TF just
an abbreviation that we'll often use so
we don't need to write out tensorflow
every time we want to use anything
inside of the library
I'm using
tf.caris Keras is an API a set of
functions that we can use in order to
manipulate neural networks inside of
tensorflow and it turns out there are
other machine learning libraries that
also use the Keras API but here I'm
saying all right go ahead and give me a
model that is a sequential Model A
sequential neural network meaning one
layer after another
and now I'm going to add to that model
what layers I want inside of my neural
network so here I'm saying model.add go
ahead and add a dense layer and when we
say a dense layer we mean a layer that
is just each of the nodes inside of the
layer is going to be connected to each
of the nodes from the previous layer so
we have a densely connected layer
this layer is going to have eight units
inside of it so it's going to be a
hidden layer inside of our neural
network with eight different units eight
artificial neurons Each of which might
learn something different and I just
sort of chose eight arbitrarily you
could choose a different number of
hidden layer hidden nodes inside of the
layer and if we as we saw before
depending on the number of units there
are inside of your hidden layer more
units means you can learn more complex
functions so maybe you can more
accurately model the training data but
it comes with the cost more units means
more weights that you need to figure out
how to update so it might be more
expensive to do that calculation and you
also run the risk of overfitting on the
data if you have too many units and you
learn to just overfit on the training
data that's not good either so there is
a balance and there's often a testing
process where you'll train on some data
and maybe validate how well you're doing
on a separate set of data often called a
validation set to see all right which
setting of parameters how many layers
should I have how many units should be
in each layer which one of those
performs the best on the validation set
so you can do some testing to figure out
what these hyper parameters so-called
should be equal to
next I specify what the input shape is
meaning all right what does my input
look like my input has four values and
so the input shape is just four because
we have four inputs and then I specify
what the activation function is and the
activation function again we can choose
there are a number of different
activation functions here I'm using relu
which you might recall from earlier
and then I'll add an output layer so I
have my hidden layer now I'm adding one
more layer that will just have one unit
because all I want to do is predict
something like counterfeit bill or
authentic bill so I just need a single
unit and the activation function I'm
going to use here is that sigmoid
activation function which again was that
s-shaped curve that just gave us like a
probability of what is the probability
that this is a counterfeit build as
opposed to an authentic bill
so that then is the structure of my
neural network sequential neural network
that has one hidden layer with eight
units inside of it and then one output
layer that just has a single unit inside
of it and I can choose how many units
there are I can choose the activation
function then I'm going to compile this
model
tensorflow gives you a choice of how you
would like to optimize the weights there
are various different algorithms for
doing that what type of loss function
you want to use again many different
options for doing that and then how I
want to evaluate my model well I care
about accuracy I care about like how
many of my points am I able to classify
correctly versus not correctly as
counterfeit or not counterfeit and I
would like it to report to me how
accurate my model is performing
then now that I've defined that model I
call model.fit to say go ahead and train
the model train it on all the training
data plus all of the training labels so
labels for each of those pieces of
training data and I'm saying run it for
20 epics meaning go ahead and go through
each of these training points 20 times
effectively go through the data 20 times
and keep trying to update the weights if
I did it for more I could train for even
longer and maybe get a more accurate
result
but then after I fitted on all the data
I'll go ahead and just test it I'll
evaluate my model using model.evaluate
built into tensorflow that is just going
to tell me how well do I perform on the
testing data so ultimately this is just
going to give me some numbers that tell
me how well we did in this particular
case
so now what I'm going to do is go into
banknotes and go ahead and run
banknotes.pi
and what's going to happen now is it's
going to read in all of that training
data it's going to generate a neural
network with a all my inputs my eight
hidden layers are eight hidden units
inside my layer and then an output unit
and now what it's doing is it's training
it's training 20 times and each time you
can see how my accuracy is increasing on
my training data it starts off the very
first time not very accurate but better
than random something like 79 of the
time it's able to accurately classify
one bill from another but as I keep
training notice this accuracy value
improves and improves and improves until
after I've trained through all the data
points 20 times it looks like my
accuracy is above 99 on the on the
training data and here's where I tested
it on a whole bunch of testing data
and it looks like in this case I was
also like 99.8 accurate
so just using that I was able to
generate a neural network that can
detect counterfeit bills from authentic
bills based on this input data 99.8
percent of the time at least based on
this particular testing data and I might
want to test it with more data as well
just to be confident about that but this
is really the value of using a machine
learning library like tensorflow and
there are others available for Python
and other languages as well then all I
have to do is Define the structure of
the network and Define the data that I'm
going to pass into the network and then
tensorflow runs the back propagation
algorithm for learning what all of those
weights should be for figuring out how
to train this neural network to be able
to accurately as accurately as possible
figure out what the output values should
be there as well
and so this then was a look at what it
is that neural networks can do just
using these sequences of layer after
layer after layer and you can begin to
imagine applying these to much more
General problems and one big problem in
Computing and artificial intelligence
more generally is the problem of
computer vision computer vision is all
about computational methods for
analyzing and understanding images that
you might have pictures that you want
the computer to figure out how to deal
with how to process those images and
figure out how to produce some sort of
useful result out of this you've seen
this in the context of social media
websites that are able to look at a
photo that contains a whole bunch of
faces and it's able to figure out what's
a picture of whom and label those and
tag them with appropriate people this is
becoming increasingly relevant as we
begin to discuss self-driving cars the
car these cars now have cameras and we
would like for the computer to have some
sort of algorithm that looks at the
image
and figures out like what color is the
light uh what cars are around us and in
what direction for example and so
computer vision is all about like taking
an image and figuring out what sort of
computation what sort of calculation we
can do with that image it's also
relevant in the context of something
like handwriting recognition this what
you're looking at is an example of the
mnist data set it's a big data set just
of handwritten digits that we could use
so ideally try and figure out how to
predict given someone's handwriting
given a photo of a digit that they have
drawn can you predict whether it's a
zero one two three four five six seven
eight or nine for example so this sort
of handwriting recognition is yet
another task that we might want to use
computer vision tasks and tools to be
able to apply it towards this might be a
task that we might care about
so how then can we use neural networks
to be able to solve a problem like this
well neural networks rely upon some sort
of input where that input is just
numerical data we have a whole bunch of
units where each one of them just
represents some sort of number and so in
the context of something like
handwriting recognition or in the
context of just an image you might
imagine that an image is really just a
grid of pixels grid of dots where each
dot has some sort of color
and in the context of something like
handwriting recognition you might
imagine that if you just fill in each of
these dots in a particular way you can
generate like a two or an eight for
example based on which dots happen to be
shaded in and which dots are not and we
can represent each of these pixel values
just using numbers so for a particular
pixel for example zero might represent
entirely black depending on how you're
representing color it's often common to
represent color values on a 0 to 255
range so that you can represent a color
using eight bits for a particular value
like how much white is in the image so
zero might represent all black
255 might represent entirely white as a
pixel and somewhere in between might
represent some shade of gray for example
but you might imagine not just having a
single slider that determines how much
white is in the image but if you had a
color image you might imagine three
different numerical values a red green
and blue value where the red value
controls how much red is in the image we
have one value for controlling how much
green is in the pixel and one value for
how much blue is in the pixel as well
and depending on how it is that you set
these values of red green and blue you
can get a different color and so any
pixel can really be represented in this
case by three numerical values a red
value a green value and a blue value
and if you take a whole bunch of these
pixels assemble them together inside of
a grid of pixels then you really just
have a whole bunch of numerical values
that you can use in order to perform
some sort of prediction task
and so what you might imagine doing is
using the same techniques we talked
about before just design a neural
network with a lot of inputs that for
each of the pixels we might have one or
three different inputs in the case of a
color image a different input that is
just connected to a deep neural network
for example in this deep neural network
might take all of the pixels inside of
the image of like what digit a person
Drew
and the output might be like 10 neurons
are classified as a zero or a one or a
two or a three or just tells us in some
way what that digit happens to be
now there are a couple of drawbacks to
this approach the first drawback to the
approach is just the size of this input
array that we have a whole bunch of
inputs if we have a big image then
there's a lot of different channels
we're looking at a lot of inputs and
therefore a lot of Weights that we have
to calculate
and a second problem is the fact that by
flattening everything into just this
structure of all the pixelism we've lost
access to a lot of the information about
the structure of the image that's
relevant that really when a person looks
at an image they're looking at you know
particular features of an image they're
looking at curves they're looking at
shapes they're looking at what things
can you identify in different regions of
the image and maybe put those things
together in order to get a better
picture of what the overall image is
about and by just turning it into pixel
values for each of the pixels sure you
might be able to learn that structure
but it might be challenging in order to
do so it might be helpful to take
advantage of the fact that you can use
properties of the image itself the fact
that it's structured in a particular way
to be able to improve the way that we
learn based on that image too so in
order to figure out how we can train our
neural networks to better be able to
deal with images we'll introduce a
couple of ideas a couple of algorithms
that we can apply that allow us to take
the image and extract some useful
information out of that image and the
first idea will produce is the notion of
image convolution and when image
convolution is all about is it's about
filtering an image sort of extracting
useful or relevant features out of the
image and the way we do that
is by applying a particular filter that
basically adds the value for every pixel
with the values for all of the
neighboring pixels to it according to
some sort of Kernel Matrix which we'll
see in a moment is going to allow us to
weight these pixels in various different
ways and the goal of image convolution
then is to extract some sort of
interesting or useful features out of an
image to be able to take a pixel and
based on its neighboring pixels maybe
predict some sort of valuable
information something like taking a
pixel and looking at its neighboring
pixels you might be able to predict
whether or not there's some sort of
curve inside the image or whether it's
forming the outline of a particular line
or a shape for example and that might be
useful
if you're trying to use all these
various different features to combine
them to say something meaningful about
an image as a whole so how then does
image convolution work well we start
with a kernel Matrix and the kernel
Matrix looks something like this and the
idea of this is that given a pixel that
will be the middle pixel we're going to
multiply each of the neighboring pixels
by these values in order to get some
sort of result by summing up all the
numbers together so if I take this
kernel which you can think of as like a
filter that I'm going to apply to the
image and let's say that I take this
image this is a 4x4 image we'll think of
it as just a black and white image where
each one it's just a single Pixel value
so somewhere between 0 and 255 for
example so we have a whole bunch of
individual pixel values like this and
what I'd like to do is apply this kernel
this filter so to speak to this image
and the way I'll do that is all right
the kernel is three by three you can
imagine a five by five kernel or a
larger kernel two
and I'll take it and just first apply it
to the first three by three section of
the image and what I'll do is I'll take
each of these pixel values and multiply
it by its corresponding value in the
filter Matrix and add all of the results
together
so here for example I'll say 10 times 0
plus 20 times negative 1 plus 30 times
zero so on and so forth doing all of
this calculation and at the end if I
take all these values multiply them by
their corresponding value in the kernel
add the results together for this
particular set of nine pixels I get the
value of 10 for example
and then what I'll do
is I'll slide this 3x3 grid effectively
over Slide the kernel by one to look at
the next three by three section here I'm
just sliding it over by one pixel but
you might imagine a different stride
length where maybe I jump by multiple
pixels at a time if you really wanted to
you have different options here but here
I'm just sliding over looking at the
next three by three section and I'll do
the same math 20 times 0 plus 30 times a
negative 1 plus 40 times 0 plus 20 times
negative one so on and so forth plus 30
times 5 and what I end up getting is the
number 20. then you can imagine shifting
over to this one doing the same thing
calculating like the number 40 for
example and then doing the same thing
here and calculating a value there as
well
and so what we have now is what we'll
call like a feature map we have taken
this kernel applied it to each of these
various different regions and what we
get is some representation of like a
filtered version of that image and so to
give a more concrete example of why it
is that this kind of thing could be
useful let's take this kernel Matrix for
example which is quite a famous one that
has an 8 in the middle and then all of
the neighboring pixels get a negative
one and let's imagine we wanted to apply
that to a three by three part of an
image that looks like this where all the
values are the same they're all 20 for
instance well in this case if you do 20
times 8 and then subtract 20 subtract 20
subtract 20 for each of the eight
neighbors well the result of that is you
just get that expression which comes out
to be zero you multiplied 20 by 8 but
then you subtracted 28 times according
to that particular kernel the result of
all that is just zero so the takeaway
here is that when a lot of the pixels
are the same value we end up getting a
value close to zero
if though we had something like this
20th along this first row then 50 is in
the second row and 50s in the third row
well then when you do this same kind of
math 20 times negative 1 20 times a
negative one so on and so forth then I
get a higher value a value like 90 in
this particular case and so the more
general idea here is that by applying
this kernel negative one's eight in the
middle and then negative ones what I get
is when this middle value is very
different from the neighboring values
like 50 is greater than these 20s then
you'll end up with a value higher than
zero like if this number is higher than
its neighbors you end up getting a
bigger output but if this neighborhood
is this value is the same as all of its
neighbors then you get a lower output
something like zero and it turns out
that this sort of filter can therefore
be used in something like detecting
edges in an image if I want to detect
like the boundaries between various
different objects inside of an image I
might use a filter like this which is
able to tell whether the value of this
pixel is different from the values of
the neighboring pixels if it's like
greater than the values of the pixels
that happen to surround it
and so we can use this in terms of image
filtering and so I'll show you an
example of that I have here in filter.pi
a file that uses Python's image library
or pil
to do some image filtering I go ahead
and open an image and then all I'm going
to do is apply a kernel to that image
it's going to be a three by three kernel
same kind of Kernel we saw before
and here is the kernel this is just a
list representation of the same Matrix
that I showed you a moment ago it's
negative one negative one negative one
the second row is negative one eight
negative one and the third row is all
negative ones and then at the end I'm
going to go ahead and show the filtered
image
so if for example I go into
convolution directory and I open up an
image like bridge.png this is what an
input image might look like just an
image of a bridge over a river
now I'm going to go ahead and run this
filter program on the bridge
and what I get is this image here just
by taking the original image and
applying that filter to each three by
three grid I've extracted all of the
boundaries all of the edges inside the
image that separate one part of the
image from another so here I've got a
representation of boundaries between
particular parts of the image and you
might imagine that if a machine learning
algorithm is trying to learn like what
an image is of a filter like this could
be pretty useful that maybe the the
machine learning algorithm doesn't care
about all of the details of the image it
just cares about certain useful features
it cares about particular shapes and are
able to help it determine that based on
the image this is going to be a bridge
for example and so this type of idea of
image convolution can allow us to apply
filters to images that allow us to
extract useful results out of those
images taking an image and extracting
its edges for example
and you might imagine many other filters
that could be applied to an image that
are able to extract particular values as
well and a filter might have separate
kernels for the red values the green
values and the blue values that are all
summed together at the end such that you
could have particular filters looking
for is there red in this part of the
image are there green in other parts of
the image you can begin to assemble
these relevant and useful filters that
are able to do these calculations as
well
so that then was the idea of image
convolution applying some sort of filter
to an image to be able to extract some
useful features out of that image but
all the while these images are still
pretty big like there's a lot of pixels
involved in the image and realistically
speaking if you've got a really big
image that poses a couple of problems
one it means a lot of input going into
the neural network but two it also means
that we really have to care about what's
in each particular pixel whereas
realistically we often as an like if
you're looking at an image you don't
care whether something is in one
particular pixel versus the pixel
immediately to the right of it they're
pretty close together you really just
care about whether there's a particular
feature in some region of the image and
maybe you don't care about exactly which
pixel it happens to be in and so there's
a Technique we can use known as pooling
and what pooling is is it means reducing
the size of an input by sampling from
regions inside of the input so we're
going to take a big image and turn it
into a smaller image by using pooling
and in particular one of the most
popular types of pooling is called Max
pooling and what Max pooling does is it
pools just by choosing the maximum value
in a particular region so for example
let's imagine I had this 4x4 image but I
wanted to reduce its Dimensions I wanted
to make it a smaller image so that I
have fewer inputs to work with well what
I could do is I could apply a two by two
Max pool where the idea would be that
I'm going to first look at this two by
two region and say what if the maximum
value in that region well it's the
number 50. so we'll go ahead and just
use the number 50.
and then we'll look at this two by two
region what is the maximum value here
it's 110 so that's going to be my value
likewise here the maximum value looks
like 20. go ahead and put that there
then for this last region the maximum
value was 40. so we'll go ahead and use
that and what I have now is a smaller
representation of this same original
image that I obtained just by fixing
picking the maximum value from each of
these regions so
again the advantage of here are now I
only have to deal with a two by two
input instead of a four by four and you
can imagine shrinking the size of an
image even more but in addition to that
I'm now able to make my analysis
independent of whether a particular
value was in this pixel or this pixel
like I don't care if the 50 was here or
here as long as it was generally in this
region I'll still get access to that
value so it makes our algorithms a
little bit more robust as well
so that then is pooling taking the size
of the image reducing it a little bit by
just sampling from particular regions
inside of the image and now we can put
all of these ideas together pooling
image convolution and neural networks
all together into another type of neural
network called a convolutional neural
network or a CNN which is a neural
network that uses this convolution step
usually in the context of analyzing an
image for example
and so the way that a convolutional
neural network works is that we start
with some sort of input image some grid
of pixels but rather than immediately
put that into the neural network layers
that we've seen before we'll start by
applying a convolution step where the
convolution step involves applying some
number of different image filters to our
original image in order to get what we
call a feature map the result of
applying some filter to an image and we
could do this once but in general we'll
do this multiple times getting a whole
bunch of different feature Maps Each of
which might extract some different
relevant feature out of the image some
different important characteristic of
the image that we might care about using
in order to calculate what the result
should be and in the same way that when
we when we train neural networks we can
train neural networks to learn the
weights between particular units inside
of the neural networks we can also train
neural networks to learn what those
filters should be what the values of the
filters should be in order to get the
most useful most relevant information
out of the original image just by
figuring out what setting of those
filter values the values inside of that
kernel results in minimizing the loss
function minimizing how poorly our
hypothesis actually performs in figuring
out the classification of a particular
image for example so we first applied
this convolution step get a whole bunch
of these various different feature Maps
but these feature maps are quite large
right there's a lot of pixel values that
happen to be here and so a logical next
step to take is a pooling step where
we've reduced the size of these images
by using Max pooling for example
extracting the maximum value from any
particular region there are other
pooling methods that exist as well
depending on the situation you could use
something like average pooling where
instead of taking the maximum value from
a region you take the average value from
a region which has its uses as well
but in effect what pooling will do is
it'll take these feature maps and reduce
their Dimension so that we end up with
smaller grids with fewer pixels and this
then is going to be easier for us to
deal with it's going to mean fewer
inputs that we have to worry about and
it's also going to mean we're more
resilient more robust against potential
movements of particular values just by
one pixel when ultimately we really
don't care about those one pixel
differences that might arise in the
original image
and now after we've done this pooling
step now we have a whole bunch of values
that we can then flatten out and just
put into a more traditional neural
network so we go ahead and flatten it
and then we end up with a traditional
neural network that has one input for
each of these values in each of these
resulting feature Maps after we do the
convolution and after we do the pooling
step
and so this then is the general
structure of a convolutional network we
begin with the image apply convolution
apply pooling flatten the results and
then put that into a more traditional
neural network that might itself have
hidden layers you can have deep
convolutional networks that have hidden
layers in between this flattened layer
and the eventual output to be able to
calculate various different features of
those values but this then can help us
to be able to use convolution and
pooling to use our knowledge about the
structure of an image to be able to get
better results to be able to train our
networks faster in order to better
capture particular parts of the image
and there's no reason necessarily why
you can only use these steps once in
fact in practice you'll often use
convolution and pooling multiple times
in multiple different steps see what you
might imagine doing is starting with an
image
first applying convolution to get a
whole bunch of maps then applying
pooling then applying convolution again
because these maps are still pretty big
you can apply convolution to try and
extract relevant features out of this
result then take those results apply
pooling in order to reduce their
dimensions and then take that and feed
it into a neural network that maybe has
fewer inputs so here I have two
different convolution and pooling steps
I do convolution and pooling once and
then I do convolution and pooling a
second time each time extracting useful
features from the layer before it each
time using pooling to reduce the
dimensions of what you're ultimately
looking at and the goal now of this sort
of model is that in each of these steps
you can begin to learn different types
of features of the original image that
maybe in the first step you learn very
low level features just learn and look
for features like edges and curves and
shapes because based on pixels and their
neighboring values you can figure out
all right what are the edges what are
the curves what are the various
different shapes that might be present
there
but then once you have a mapping that
just represents where the edges and
curves and shapes happen to be you can
imagine applying the same sort of
process again to begin to look for
higher level features look for objects
maybe look for people's eyes and facial
recognition for example maybe look for
more complex shapes like the curves on a
particular number if you're trying to
recognize a digit in a handwriting
recognition sort of scenario and then
after all of that now that you have
these results that represent these
higher level features you can pass them
into a neural network which is really
just a deep neural network that looks
like this where you might imagine making
a binary classification or classifying
into multiple categories or performing
various different tasks
on this sort of model so convolutional
neural networks can be quite powerful
and quite popular when it comes towards
trying to analyze images we don't
strictly need them we could have just
used a vanilla neural network that just
operates with layer after layer as we've
seen before but these convolutional
neural networks can be quite helpful in
particular because of the way they model
the way a human might look at an image
that instead of a human looking at every
single Pixel simultaneously and trying
to convolve all of them by multiplying
them together you might imagine that
what convolution is really doing is
looking at various different regions of
the image and extracting relevant
information and features out of those
parts of the image the same way that a
human might have visual receptors that
are looking at particular parts of what
they see and using those combining them
to figure out what meaning they can draw
from all of those various different
inputs
and so you might imagine applying this
to a situation like handwriting
recognition so we'll go ahead and see an
example of that now
where I'll go ahead and open up
handwriting.pi
again what we do here is we first import
tensorflow
and then tensorflow it turns out has a
few data sets that are built in built
into the library that you can just
immediately access and one of the most
famous data sets in machine learning is
the mnist data set which is just a data
set of a whole bunch of samples of
people's handwritten digits I showed you
a slide of that a little while ago
and what we can do is just immediately
access that data set which is built into
the library so that if I want to do
something like train on a whole bunch of
digits I can just use the data set that
it's provided to me of course if I had
my own data set of handwritten images I
can apply the same idea I'd first just
need to take those images and turn them
into like an array of pixels because
that's the way that these are going to
be formatted they're going to be
formatted as effectively an array of
individual pixels
now there's a bit of reshaping I need to
do just turning the data into a format
that I can put into my convolutional
neural network so this is doing things
like taking all the values and dividing
them by 255 if you remember these color
values tend to range from 0 to 255 so I
can divide them by 255 just to put them
into zero to one range which might be a
little bit easier to train on
and then doing various other
modifications to the data just to get it
into a nice usable format but here's the
interesting and important part here is
where I create the convolutional neural
network the CNN
where here I'm saying go ahead and use a
sequential model and before I could use
model.add to say add a layer add a layer
add a layer another way I could Define
it is just by passing as input to this
sequential neural network a list of all
of the layers that I want
and so here the very first layer in my
model is a convolution layer where I'm
first going to apply convolution to my
image I'm going to use 13 different
filters so my model is going to learn 32
rather 32 different filters that I would
like to learn on the input image where
each filter is going to be a three by
three kernel so we saw those three by
three kernels before where we could
multiply each value in a three by three
grid by value multiply it and add all
the results together so here I'm going
to learn 32 different of these three by
three filters
I can again specify my activation
function and I specify what my input
shape is my input shape in the banknotes
case was just four I had four inputs my
input shape here is going to be 28 comma
28 comma 1 because for each of these
handwritten digits it turns out that the
MNS data set organizes their data each
image is a 28 by 28 pixel grid so we're
gonna have a 28 by 28 pixel grid and
each one of those images only has one
channel value these handwritten digits
are just black and white so there's just
a single color value representing how
much black or how much white you might
imagine that in a color image if you
were doing this sort of thing you might
have three different channels a red a
green and a blue channel for example but
in the case of just handwriting
recognition recognizing a digit we're
just going to use a single value for
like shaded in or not shaded in and it
might range but it's just a single color
value
and that then is the very first layer of
our neural network a convolutional layer
that will take the input and learn a
whole bunch of different filters that we
can apply to the input to extract
meaningful features
next step is going to be a Max pooling
layer also built right into tensorflow
where this is going to be a layer that
is going to use a pool size of 2x2
meaning we're going to look at two by
two regions inside of the image and just
extract the maximum value again we've
seen why this can be helpful it'll help
to reduce the size of our input
once we've done that we'll go ahead and
flatten all of the units just into a
single layer that we can then pass into
the rest of the neural network and now
here's the rest of the neural network
here I'm saying let's add a hidden layer
to my neural network with 128 units so a
whole bunch of hidden units inside of
the Hidden layer and just to prevent
overfitting I can add a drop out to that
say you know what when you're training
randomly drop out half of the nodes from
this hidden layer just to make sure we
don't become over-reliant on any
particular node we begin to really
generalize and stop ourselves from
overfitting so tensorflow allows us just
by adding a single line to add Dropout
into our model as well such that when
it's training it will perform this
Dropout step in order to help make sure
that we don't over fit on this
particular data
and then finally I add an output layer
the output layer is going to have 10
units one for each category that I would
like to classify digits into so 0
through 9 10 different categories and
the activation function I'm going to use
here is called the softmax activation
function and in short with the softmax
activation function is going to do is
it's going to take the output and turn
it into a probability distribution so
ultimately it's going to tell me like
what did we estimate the probability is
that this is a 2 versus a 3 versus a 4
and so it will turn it into that
probability distribution for me
next up I'll go ahead and compile my
model and fit it on all of my training
data
and then I can evaluate how well the
neural network performs and then I've
added to my Python program if I've
provided a command line argument like
the name of a file I'm going to go ahead
and save the model to a file and so this
can be quite useful too once you've done
the training step which could take some
time in terms of taking all the time
going through the data running back
propagation with gradient descent to be
able to say all right how should we
adjust the weight to this particular
model you end up calculating values for
these weights calculating values for
these filters you'd like to remember
that information so you can use it later
and so tensorflow allows us to just save
a model to a file such that later if we
want to use the model we've learned use
the weights that we've learned to make
some sort of new prediction we can just
use the model that already exists
so what we're doing here is after we've
done all the calculation we go ahead and
save the model to a file such that we
can use it a little bit later so for
example if I go into
go into digits
I'm going to run handwriting.pi I won't
save it this time we'll just run it and
go ahead and see what happens what will
happen is we need to go through the
model in order to train on all of these
samples of handwritten digits so the
mnist data set gives us thousands and
thousands of sample handwritten digits
in this same format that we can use in
order to train and so now what you're
seeing is this training process and
unlike the banknotes case where there
was much much fewer data points the data
was very very simple here this data is
more complex and this training process
takes time and so this is another one of
those cases where when training neural
networks this is why computational power
is so important that you oftentimes you
see people wanting to use a
sophisticated gpus in order to more
efficiently be able to do this sort of
neural network training it also speaks
to the reason why more data can be
helpful The More Sample data points you
have the better you can begin to do this
training so here we're going through 60
000 different samples of handwritten
digits and I said gonna we're gonna go
through them 10 times so we're going to
go through the data set 10 times
training each time hopefully improving
Upon Our weights with every time we run
through this data set and we can see
over here on the right what the accuracy
is each time we go ahead and run this
model that the first time it looks like
we got an accuracy of about 92 percent
of the digits correct based on this
training set we increased that to 96 or
97 percent
and every time we run this we're going
to see hopefully the accuracy improve as
we continue to try and use that gradient
descent that process of trying to run
the algorithm to minimize the loss that
we get in order to more accurately
predict what the output should be and
what this process is doing is it's
learning not only the weights but it's
learning the features to use the kernel
Matrix to use when performing that
convolution step because this is a
convolutional neural network where I'm
first performing those convolutions and
then doing the more traditional neural
network structure this is going to learn
all of those individual steps as well
and so here we see the tensorflow
provides me with some very nice output
telling me about like how many seconds
are left with each of these training
runs that allows me to see just how well
we're doing so we'll go ahead and see
how this network performs it looks like
we've gone through the data set seven
times we're going through it in eighth
time now
and at this point the accuracy is pretty
high we saw we went from 92 percent up
to 97 now it looks like 98 and at this
point it seems like things are starting
to level out there's probably a limit to
how accurate we can ultimately be
without running the risk of overfitting
of course with enough nodes you would
just memorize the input and overfit upon
them but we'd like to avoid doing that
and Dropout will help us with this
but now we see we're almost done
finishing our training step
we're at 55 000. all right we finished
training and now it's going to go ahead
and test for us on 10 000 samples and it
looks like on the testing set we were
98.8 accurate so we ended up doing
pretty well it seems on this test on
this testing set to see you know how
accurately can we predict these
handwritten digits
and so what we could do then is actually
test it out I've written a program
called recognition.pi using pygame uh if
you pass it a model that's been trained
and I pre-trained an example model using
this input data
what we can do is see whether or not
we've been able to train this
convolutional neural network to be able
to predict handwriting for example so I
can try just like drawing a handwritten
digit I'll go ahead and draw like the
number two for example
so there's my number two again this is
messy if you try to imagine how would
you write a program with just like ifs
and thens to be able to do this sort of
calculation it would be tricky to do so
but hero plus classify and they're right
it seems it was able to correctly
classify that what I drew was the number
two go ahead and reset it try it again
we'll draw like an eight for example
so here is an eight
press classify and all right it predicts
the digit that I drew was an eight and
the key here is this really begins to
show the power of what the neural
network is doing somehow looking at
various different features of these
different pixels figuring out what the
relevant features are and figuring out
how to combine them to get a
classification and this would be a
difficult task to provide explicit
instructions to the computer on how to
do like to use a whole bunch of if thens
to process all these pixel values to
figure out what the handwritten digit is
like everyone's going to draw their
eights a little bit differently if I
drew the eight again it would look a
little bit different and yet ideally we
want to train a network to be robust
enough
so that it begins to learn these
patterns on its own all I said was here
is the structure of the network and here
is the data on which to train the
network and the network learning
algorithm just tries to figure out what
is the optimal set of Weights what is
the optimal set of filters to use in
order to be able to accurately classify
a digit into one category or another
it's going to show the power of these
sorts of convolutional neural networks
and so that then was a look and how we
can use convolutional neural networks to
begin to solve problems with really with
regards to computer vision the ability
to like take an image and begin to
analyze it and so this is the type of
analysis you might imagine that's
happening in self-driving cars that are
able to figure out what filters to apply
to an image to understand what it is
that the computer is looking at or the
same type of idea that might be applied
to facial recognition in social media to
be able to determine how to recognize
faces in an image as well you can
imagine a neural network that instead of
classifying into one of ten different 10
different digits could instead classify
like is this person a or is this person
B trying to tell those people apart just
based on convolution
and so now what we'll take a look at is
yet another type of neural network that
can be quite popular for certain types
of tasks but to do so we'll try to
generalize and think about our neural
network a little bit more abstractly
that here we have a sample deep neural
network where we have this input layer a
whole bunch of different hidden layers
that are performing certain types of
calculations
and then an output layer here that just
generates some sort of output that we
care about calculating
but we could imagine representing this a
little more simply like this here is
just a more abstract representation of
our neural network we have some input
that might be like a vector of a whole
bunch of different values as our input
that gets passed into a network that
performs some sort of calculation or
computation and that Network produces
some sort of output that output might be
a single value it might be a whole bunch
of different values but this is the
general structure of the neural networks
that we've seen there is some sort of
input
that gets fed into the network and using
that input the network calculates what
the output should be and this sort of
model for a neural network is what we
might call a feed forward neural network
feed forward neural networks have
connections only in One Direction they
move from one layer to the next layer to
the layer after that such that the
inputs pass through various different
hidden layers and then ultimately
produce some sort of output
so feed forward neural networks were
very helpful for solving these types of
classification problems that we saw
before we have a whole bunch of input we
want to learn what setting of Weights
will allow us to calculate the output
effectively but there are some
limitations on feed forward neural
networks that we'll see in a moment in
particular the input needs to be like of
a fixed shape like a fixed number of
neurons or in the input layer and
there's a fixed shape for the output
like a fixed number of neurons in the
output layer
and that has some limitations of its own
and a possible solution to this
and we'll see examples of the types of
problems we can solve with this in just
a second is instead of just a feed
forward neural network where there are
there only Connections In One Direction
from left to right effectively across
the network we could also Imagine a
recurrent neural network where a
recurrent neural network generates
output that gets fed back into itself as
input for future runs of that Network so
whereas in a traditional neural network
we have inputs that get fed into the
network that get fed into the output and
the only thing that determines the
output is based on the original input
and based on the calculation we do
inside of the network itself this goes
in contrast with a recurrent neural
network where in a recurrent neural
network you can imagine output from the
network feeding back to itself into the
network again as input for the next time
that you do the calculations inside of
the network what this allows is it
allows the network to maintain some sort
of state to store some sort of
information that can be used on future
runs of the network
the previously the network just to find
some weights and we passed inputs
through the network and it generated
outputs but the network wasn't saving
any information based on those inputs to
be able to remember for future
iterations or for future runs what a
recurrent neural network will let us do
is let the Network store information
that gets passed back in as input to the
network again the next time we try and
perform some sort of action and this is
particularly helpful when dealing with
sequences of data so we'll see a real
world example of this right now actually
Microsoft has developed an AI known as
the captionbot
and what the captionbot does is it says
I can understand the content of any
photograph and I'll try to describe it
as well as any human I'll analyze your
photo but I won't store it or share it
and so what Microsoft's captionbot seems
to be claiming to do is it can take an
image and figure out what's in the image
and just give us a caption to describe
it so let's try it out here for example
is an image of a Harvard Square it's
some people walking in front of one of
the buildings at Harvard Square I'll go
ahead and take the URL for that image
and I'll paste it into captionbot and
just press go
so captionbot is analyzing the image and
then it says I think it's a group of
people walking in front of a building
which seems amazing the AI is able to
look at this image and figure out what's
in the image and the important thing to
recognize here is that this is no longer
just a classification task we saw being
able to classify images with a
convolutional neural network where the
job was you know take the image and then
figure out is it a zero or a one or a
two or is it this person's face or that
person's face what seems to be happening
here is the input is an image and we
know how to get networks to take input
of images but the output is text like
it's a sentence it's a phrase like a
group of people walking in front of a
building
and this would seem to pose a challenge
for our more traditional feed forward
neural networks for the reason being
that in traditional neural networks we
just have a fixed size input and a fixed
size output there are a certain number
of neurons in the input to our neural
network and a certain number of outputs
for our neural network and then some
calculation that goes on in between but
the size of the inputs the number of
values in the input and the number of
values in the output those are always
going to be fixed based on the structure
of the neural network and that makes it
difficult to imagine how a neural
network could take an image like this
and say you know it's a group of people
walking in front of the building because
the output is text like it's a sequence
of words
now it might be possible for a neural
network to Output like one word one word
you could represent as like a vector of
values and you can imagine ways of doing
that next time we'll talk a little bit
more about AI as it relates to language
and language processing but a sequence
of words is much more challenging
because depending on the image you might
imagine the output is a different number
of words we could have sequences of
different lengths and somehow we still
want to be able to generate the
appropriate output
and so the strategy here is to use a
recurrent neural network a neural
network that can feed its own output
back into itself as input for the next
time and this allows us to do what we
call a one-to-many relationship for
inputs to outputs then in vanilla more
traditional neural networks these are
what we might consider to be one-to-one
neural networks you pass in one set of
values as input you get one vector of
values as the output
but in this case we want to pass in one
value as input the image and we want to
get a sequence many values as output
where each value is like one of these
words that gets produced by this
particular algorithm and so the way we
might do this is we might imagine
starting by providing input the image
into our neural network and the neural
network is going to generate output but
the output is not going to be the whole
sequence of words because we can't
represent the whole sequence of words
using just a fixed set of neurons
instead the output is just going to be
the first word we're going to train the
network to Output with the first word of
the caption should be and you could
imagine that Microsoft has trained this
by running a whole bunch of training
samples through the AI giving it a whole
bunch of pictures and what the
appropriate caption was and having the
AI begin to learn from that
but now because the network generates
output that can be fed back into itself
you could imagine the output of the
network being fed back into the same
network this here looks like a separate
network but it's really the same network
that's just getting different input that
this network's output gets fed back into
itself but it's going to generate
another output and that other output is
going to be like the second word in the
caption
and this recurrent neural network then
is this network is going to generate
other output that can be fed back into
itself to generate yet another word fed
back into itself to generate another
word and so recurrent neural networks
allow us to represent this sort of one
to many structure you provide one image
as input and the neural network can pass
data into the next run of the network
and then again and again such that you
could run the network multiple times
each time generating a different output
still based on that original input
and this is where recurrent neural
networks become particularly useful when
dealing with sequences of inputs or
outputs and my output is a sequence of
words and since I can't very easily
represent outputting an entire sequence
of words I'll instead output that
sequence one word at a time by allowing
my network to pass information about
what still needs to be said about the
photo into the next stage of running the
network so you could run the network
multiple times the same network with the
same weights just getting different
input each time first getting input from
the image and then getting input from
the network itself as additional
information about what additionally
needs to be given in a particular
caption for example
so this then is a one-to-many
relationship inside of a recurrent
neural network but it turns out there
are other models that we can use other
ways we can try and use recurrent neural
networks to be able to represent data
that might be stored in other forms as
well we saw how we could use neural
networks in order to analyze images in
the context of convolutional neural
networks that take an image figure out
various different properties of the
image and are able to draw some sort of
conclusion based on that
but you might imagine that something
like YouTube they need to be able to do
a lot of learning based on video they
need to look through videos to detect if
they're like copyright violations or
they need to be able to look through
videos to maybe identify what particular
items are inside of the video for
example and video you might imagine is
much more difficult to put it as input
to a neural network because whereas an
image you could just treat each pixel as
a different value videos or sequences
they're sequences of images and each
sequence might be of different length
and so it might be challenging to
represent that entire video as a single
Vector of values that you could pass in
to a neural network
and so here too recurrent neural
networks can be a valuable solution for
trying to solve this type of problem
then instead of just passing in a single
input into our neural network we could
pass in the input like one frame at a
time you might imagine first taking the
first frame of the video passing it into
the network and then maybe not having
the network output anything at all yet
let it take in another input and this
time pass it into the network but the
network gets information from the last
time we provided an input into the
network then we pass in a third input
and then a fourth input where each time
what the network gets is it gets the
most recent input like each frame of the
video
but it also gets information in the
network processed from all of the
previous iterations so on frame number
four you end up getting the input for
frame number four plus information the
network has calculated from the first
three frames and using all of that data
combined this recurrent neural network
can begin to learn how to extract
patterns from a sequence of data as well
and so you might imagine if you want to
classify a video into a number of
different genres like an educational
video or a music video or different
types of videos that's a classification
task where you want to take as input
each of the frames of the video and you
want to output something like what it is
what category that it happens to belong
to
and you can imagine doing this sort of
thing the sort of many to one learning
anytime your input is a sequence and so
input is a sequence in the context of
video it could be in the context of like
if someone has typed a message and you
want to be able to categorize that
message like if you're trying to take a
a movie review and trying to classify it
as is it a positive review or a negative
review that input is a sequence of words
and the output is a classification
positive or negative there too a
recurrent neural network might be
helpful for analyzing sequences of words
and they're quite popular when it comes
to dealing with language
could even be used for spoken language
as well that spoken language is you know
an audio waveform that can be segmented
into distinct chunks and each of those
could be passed in as an input into a
recurrent neural network to be able to
classify someone's voice for instance if
you want to do voice recognition to say
is this one person or is this another
here are also cases where you might want
this many to one architecture for a
recurrent neural network
and then as one final problem just to
take a look at in terms of what we can
do with these sorts of networks imagine
what like Google Translate is doing so
what Google Translate is doing is it's
taking some text written in one language
and converting it into text written in
some other language for example where
now this input is a sequence of data
it's a sequence of words and the output
is a sequence of words as well it's also
a sequence so here we want effectively
like a many-to-many relationship our
input is a sequence and our output is a
sequence as well and it's not quite
going to work to just say like take each
word in the input and translate it into
a word in the output
because ultimately different languages
put their words in different orders and
maybe one language uses two words for
something whereas another language only
uses one so we really want some way
to take this information this input
encode it somehow and use that encoding
to generate what the output ultimately
should be and this has been one of the
big advancements in automated
translation technology is the ability to
use the neural networks to do this
instead of older more traditional
methods and this is improved accuracy
dramatically and the way you might
imagine doing this is again using a
recurrent neural network with multiple
inputs and multiple outputs we start by
passing in all the input input goes into
the network another input like another
word goes into the network and we do
this multiple times like once for each
word in the input that I'm trying to
translate and only after all of that is
done does the network now start to
generate output like the first word of
the translated sentence and the next
word of the translated sentence so on
and so forth where each time the network
passes information to Itself by allowing
for this model of giving some sort of
state from one run in the network to the
next run assembling information about
all the inputs and then passing in
information about which part of the
output in order to generate next and
there are a number of different types of
these sorts of recurrent neural networks
one of the most popular is known as the
long short-term memory neural network
otherwise known as lstm but in general
these types of networks can be very very
powerful whenever we're dealing with
sequences whether those are sequences of
images or especially sequences of words
when it comes towards dealing with
natural language
and so that then were just some of the
different types of neural networks that
can be used to do all sorts of different
computations and these are incredibly
versatile tools that can be applied to a
number of different domains we only
looked at a couple of the most popular
types of neural networks from more
traditional feed forward neural networks
convolutional neural networks and
recurrent neural networks but there are
other types as well there are
adversarial networks where networks
compete with each other to try and be
able to generate new types of data as
well as other networks that can solve
other tasks based on what they happen to
be structured and adapted for and these
are very powerful Tools in machine
learning from being able to very easily
learn based on some set of input data
and to be able to therefore figure out
how to calculate some function from
inputs to outputs whether it's input to
some sort of classification like
analyzing an image and getting a digit
or machine translation where the input
is in one language and the output is in
another these tools have a lot of
applications for machine learning more
generally
next time we'll look at machine learning
and AI in particular in the context of
natural language we talked a little bit
about this today but looking at how it
is that our AI can begin to understand
natural language and can begin to be
able to analyze and do useful tasks with
regards to human language which turns
out to be a challenging and interesting
task so we'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everybody to our final
class in an introduction to artificial
intelligence with python now so far in
this class we've been taking problems
that we want to solve intelligently and
framing them in ways that computers are
going to be able to make sense of we've
been taking problems and framing them as
search problems or constraint
satisfaction problems or optimization
problems for example in essence we have
been trying to communicate about
problems in ways that our computer is
going to be able to understand today the
goal is going to be to get computers to
understand the way you and I communicate
naturally via our own natural languages
languages like English but natural
language contains a lot of nuance and
complexity that's going to make it
challenging for computers to be able to
understand so we'll need to explore
some new tools and some new techniques
to allow computers to make sense of
natural language so what is it exactly
that we're trying to get computers to do
well they all fall under this General
heading of natural language processing
getting computers to work with natural
language and these tasks include tasks
like automatic summarization given a
long text can we train the computer to
be able to come up with a shorter
representation of it information
extraction getting the computer to pull
out relevant facts or details out of
some text machine translation like
Google translate translating some text
from one language into another language
question answering if you've ever asked
a question to your phone or had a
conversation with an AI chat bot where
you provide some text to the computer
the computer is able to understand that
text and then generate some text in
response text classification where we
provide some text to the computer and
the computer assigns it a label positive
or negative inbox or spam for example
and there are several other kinds of
tasks that all fall under this heading
of natural language processing but
before we take a look at how the
computer might try to solve these kinds
of tasks it might be useful for us to
think about language in general what are
the kinds of challenges that we might
need to deal with as we start to think
about language and getting a computer to
be able to understand it so one part of
language that we'll need to consider is
the syntax of language syntax is all
about the structure of language language
is composed of individual words and
those words are composed together in
some kind of structured whole and if our
computer is going to be able to
understand language it's going to need
to understand something about that
structure so let's take a couple of
examples here for instance is a sentence
just before nine o'clock Sherlock Holmes
stepped briskly into the room that's
sentence is made up of words and those
words together form a structured whole
this is syntactically valid as a
sentence but we could take some of those
same words rearrange them and come up
with a sentence that is not
syntactically valid
here for example just before Sherlock
Holmes nine o'clock stepped briskly the
room is still composed of valid words
but they're not in any kind of logical
hole this is not a syntactically
well-formed sentence another interesting
challenge is that some sentences will
have multiple possible valid structures
here's a sentence for example I saw the
man on the mountain with a telescope and
here this is a valid sentence but it
actually has two different possible
structures that lend themselves to two
different interpretations and two
different meanings maybe I the one doing
the seeing and the one with the
telescope or maybe the man on the
mountain is the one with the telescope
and so natural language is ambiguous
sometimes the same sentence can be
interpreted in multiple ways and that's
something that we'll need to think about
as well and This lends itself to another
problem within language that we'll need
to think about which is semantics while
syntax is all about the structure of
language semantics is about the meaning
of language it's not enough for a
computer just to know that a sentence is
well structured if it doesn't know what
that sentence means and so semantics is
going to concern itself with the meaning
of words and the meaning of sentences so
if we go back to that same sentence as
before just before nine o'clock Sherlock
Holmes stepped briskly into the room
I could come up with another sentence
say the sentence a few minutes before
nine Sherlock Holmes walked quickly into
the room and those are two different
sentences with some of the words the
same and some of the words different but
the two sentences have essentially the
same meaning and so ideally whatever
model we build we'll be able to
understand that these two sentences
while different mean something very
similar some syntactically well-formed
sentences don't mean anything at all a
famous example from linguist Noam
Chomsky is the sentence colorless green
ideas of sleep furiously this is a
syntactically structurally well-formed
sentence we've got adjectives modifying
a noun ideas we've got a verb and an
adverb in the correct positions but when
taken as a whole the sentence doesn't
really mean anything and so if our
computers are going to be able to work
with natural language and perform tasks
in natural language processing these are
some concerns we'll need to think about
we'll need to be thinking about syntax
and we'll need to be thinking about
semantics so how could we go about
trying to teach a computer how to
understand the structure of natural
language well one approach we might take
is by starting by thinking about the
rules of natural language our natural
languages have rules in English for
example nouns tend to come before verbs
nouns can be modified by adjectives for
example and so if only we could
formalize those rules then we could give
those rules to a computer and the
computer would be able to make sense of
them and understand them and so let's
try to do exactly that we're going to
try to define a formal grammar we're a
formal grammar is some system of rules
for generating sentences in a language
this is going to be a rule-based
approach to natural language processing
we're going to give the computer some
rules that we know about language and
have the computer use those rules to
make sense of the structure of language
and there are a number of different
types of formal grammars each one of
them has slightly different use cases
but today we're going to focus
specifically on one kind of grammar
known as a context-free grammar so how
does the context-free grammar work well
here's a sentence that we might want a
computer to generate she saw the city
and we're going to call each of these
words a terminal symbol a terminal
symbol because once our computer has
generated the word there's nothing else
for it to generate once it's generated
the sentence the computer is done
we're going to associate each of these
terminal symbols with a non-terminal
symbol that generates it
so here we've got n which stands for
noun like she or city we've got v as a
non-terminal symbol which stands for a
verb and then we have D which stands for
determiner a determiner is a word like
the or a or an in English for example so
each of these non-terminal symbols can
generate the terminal symbols that we
ultimately care about generating but how
do we know or how does the computer know
which non-terminal symbols are
associated with which terminal symbols
well to do that we need some kind of
rule here are some what we call
rewriting rules that have a non-terminal
symbol on the left hand side of an arrow
and on the right side is what that
non-terminal symbol can be replaced with
so here we're saying the non-terminal
symbol n again which stands for noun
could be replaced by any of these
options separated by vertical bars n
could be replaced by she or city or car
or Harry D for determiner could be
replaced by the a or and and so forth
each of these non-terminal symbols could
be replaced by any of these words
we can also have non-terminal symbols
that are replaced by other non-terminal
symbols here's an interesting rule NP
Arrow n Bar D N so what does that mean
well NP stands for a noun phrase
sometimes when we have a noun phrase in
a sentence it's not just a single word
it could be multiple words and so here
we're saying a noun phrase could be just
a noun or it could be a determiner
followed by a noun so we might have a
noun phrase that's just a noun like she
that's a noun phrase or we could have a
noun phrase that's multiple words
something like the city also acts as a
noun phrase but in this case it's
composed of two words a determiner the
and a noun City
we could do the same for verb phrases a
verb phrase or VP might be just a verb
or it might be a verb followed by a noun
phrase so we could have a verb phrase
it's just a single word like the word
walked or we could have a verb phrase
that is an entire phrase something like
saw the city as an entire verb phrase a
sentence meanwhile we might then Define
as a noun phrase followed by a verb
phrase and so this would allow us to
generate a sentence like she saw the
city an entire sentence made up of a
noun phrase which is just the word she
and then a verb phrase which is saw the
city saw which is a verb and then the
city which itself is also a noun phrase
and so if we could give these rules to a
computer explaining to it what
non-terminal symbols could be replaced
by what other symbols then a computer
could take a sentence and begin to
understand the structure of that
sentence and so let's take a look at an
example of how we might do that and to
do that we're going to use a python
Library called nltk or the natural
language toolkit which we'll see a
couple of times today it contains a lot
of helpful features and functions that
we can use for trying to deal with and
process natural language so here we'll
take a look at how we can use nltk in
order to parse a context-free grammar so
let's go ahead and open up
cfg0.pi CFG standing for context free
grammar and what you'll see in this file
is that I first import nltk the natural
language toolkit and the first thing I
do is Define a context-free grammar
saying that a sentence is a noun phrase
followed by a verb phrase I'm defining
what a noun phrase is defining what a
verb phrase is and then giving some
examples of what I can do with these
non-terminal symbols D for determiner n
for noun and V for verb
we're going to use nltk to parse that
grammar then we'll ask the user for some
input in the form of a sentence and
split it into words
and then we'll use this context-free
grammar parser to try to parse that
sentence and print out the resulting
syntax tree so let's take a look at an
example
we'll go ahead and go into my CFG
directory and we'll run cfg0.pi
and here I'm asked to type in a sentence
let's say I type in she walked
and when I do that I see that she walked
is a valid sentence where she is a noun
phrase and walked is the corresponding
verb phrase I could try to do this with
more complex sentence too I could do
something like she saw the city
and here we see that she is the noun
phraser and then saw the city is the
entire verb phrase that makes up this
sentence
so that was a very simple grammar let's
take a look at a slightly more complex
grammar here is cfg1 dot Pi where a
sentence is still a noun phrase followed
by a verb phrase them but I've added
some other possible non-terminal symbols
too I have AAP for adjective phrase and
P P for prepositional phrase and we
specified that we could have an
adjective phrase before a noun phrase or
a prepositional phrase after a noun for
example
so lots of additional ways that we might
try to structure a sentence and
interpret in parse one of those
resulting sentences so let's see that
one in action we'll go ahead and run
cfg1 dot Pi with this new grammar and
we'll try a sentence like she saw the
wide Street
here Python's nltk is able to parse that
sentence and identify that she saw the
wide Street has this particular
structure a sentence with a noun phrase
and a verb phrase and where that verb
phrase has a noun phrase that within it
contains an adjective and so it's able
to get some sense for what the structure
of this language actually is
let's try another example let's say she
saw the dog with the binoculars and
we'll try that sentence
and here we get one possible syntax tree
she saw the dog with the binoculars but
notice that this sentence is actually a
little bit ambiguous in our own natural
language who has the binoculars is it
she who has the binoculars or the dog
who has the binocularism and nltk is
able to identify both possible
structures for the sentence in this case
the dog with the binoculars is an entire
noun phrase it's all underneath this NP
here so it's the dog that has the
binoculars but we also
got an alternative parse tree where the
dog is just the noun phrase and with the
binocularism is a prepositional phrase a
modifying saw so she saw the dog and she
used the binoculars in order to see the
dog as well so this allows us to get a
sense for the structure of natural
language but it relies on us writing all
of these rules and it would take a lot
of effort to write all of the rules for
any possible sentence that someone might
write or say in the English language
language is complicated and as a result
there are going to be some very complex
rules so what else might we try we might
try to take a statistical lens towards
approaching this problem of natural
language processing if we were able to
give the computer a lot of existing data
of sentences written in the English
language what could we try to learn from
that data well it might be difficult to
try and interpret long pieces of text
all at once so instead what we might
want to do is break up that longer text
into smaller pieces of information
instead in particular we might try to
create engrams out of a longer sequence
of text
an engram is just some contiguous
sequence of n items from a sample of
text it might be n characters in a row
or n words in a row for example so let's
take a passage from Sherlock Holmes and
let's look for all of the trigrams a
trigram is an engram where n is equal to
three so in this case we're looking for
sequences of three words in a row so the
trigrams here would be phrases like how
often have that's three words in a row
often have I is another trigram have I
said I said to said to you to you that
these are all trigrams sequences of
three words that appear in sequence
and if we could give the computer a
large Corpus of text and have it pull
out all of the trigrams in this case it
could get a sense for what sequences of
three words tend to appear next to each
other in our own natural language and as
a result get some sense for what the
structure of the language actually is
so let's take a look at an example of
that how can we use nltk to try to get
access to information about engrams
so here we're going to open up
engrams.pi and this is a Python program
that's going to load a corpus of data
just some text files into our computer's
memory and then we're going to use
nltk's engrams function which is going
to go through the Corpus of text pulling
out all of the engrams for a particular
value of N and then by using Python's
counter class
we're going to figure out what are the
most common engrams inside of this
entire Corpus of text
and we're going to need a data set in
order to do this and I've prepared a
data set of some of the stories of
Sherlock Holmes so it's just a bunch of
text files and a lot of words for it to
analyze and as a result we'll get a
sense for what sequences of two words or
three words that tend to be most common
in natural language
so let's give this a try we'll go into
my engrams directory and we'll run
engrams.pi we'll try an N value of 2 so
we're looking for sequences of two words
in a row and we'll use our Corpus of
stories from Sherlock Holmes
and when we run this program we get a
list of the most common engrams where n
is equal to two otherwise known as a
biggram so the most common one is of the
that's a sequence of two words that
appears quite frequently in natural
language then in the and it was these
are all common sequences of two words
that appear in a row
let's instead now try running n grams
with n equal to three let's get all of
the trigrams and see what we get and now
we see the most common trigrams are it
was a one of the I think that these are
all sequences of three words that appear
quite frequently and we were able to do
this essentially via a process known as
tokenization tokenization is the process
of splitting a sequence of characters
into pieces in this case we're splitting
a long sequence of text into individual
words and then looking at sequences of
those words to get a sense for the
structure of natural language so once
we've done this once we've done the
tokenization once we've built up our
Corpus of engrams what can we do with
that information well the one thing that
we might try is we could build a Markov
chain which you might recall from when
we talked about probability recall that
a Markov chain is some sequence of
values where we can predict one value
based on the values that came before it
and as a result if we know all of the
common n grams in the English language
what words tend to be associated with
what other words in sequence we can use
that to predict what word might come
next in a sequence of words and so we
could build a Markov chain for language
in order to try to generate natural
language that follows the same
statistical patterns as some input data
so let's take a look at that and build a
Markov chain for natural language and as
input I'm going to use the works of
William Shakespeare so here I have a
file shakespeare.text which is just
a bunch of the works of William
Shakespeare it's a long text file so
plenty of data to analyze it and here in
generator.pi I'm using a third-party
python library in order to do this
analysis
we're going to read in the sample of
text and then we're going to train a
Markov model based on that text and then
we're going to have the Markov chain
generate some sentences we're going to
generate a sentence that doesn't appear
in the original text but that follows
the same statistical patterns that's
generating it based on the engrams
trying to predict what word is likely to
come next that we would expect
based on those statistical patterns so
we'll go ahead and go into
our Markov directory run this generator
with the works of William Shakespeare's
input and what we're going to get are
five new sentences where these sentences
are not necessarily sentences from the
original input text itself but just that
follow the same statistical patterns
it's predicting what word is likely to
come next based on the input data that
we've seen and the types of words that
tend to appear in sequence there too and
so we're able to generate these
sentences
of course so far there's no guarantee
that any of the sentences that are
generated actually mean anything or make
any sense they just happen to follow the
statistical patterns that our computer
is already aware of so we'll return to
this issue of how to generate text in
perhaps a more accurate or more
meaningful way a little bit later so
let's now turn our attention to a
slightly different problem and that's
the problem of text classification text
classification is the problem where we
have some text and we want to put that
text into some kind of category we want
to apply some sort of label to that text
and this kind of problem shows up in a
wide variety of places a common place
might be your email inbox for example
you get an email and you want your
computer to be able to identify whether
the email belongs in your inbox or
whether it should be filtered out into
spam so we need to classify the text is
it a good email or is it spam another
common use case is sentiment analysis we
might want to know whether the sentiment
of some text is positive or negative and
so how might we do that this comes up in
situations like product reviews where we
might have a bunch of reviews for a
product on some website my grandson
loved it so much fun product broke after
a few days one of the best games I've
played in a long time and a kind of
cheap and flimsy not worth it here's
some example sentences that you might
see on a product review website and you
and I could pretty easily look at this
list of product reviews and decide which
ones are positive and which ones are
negative we might say the first one and
the third one those seem like positive
sentiment messages but the second one
and the fourth one seem like negative
sentiment messages but how did we know
that and how could we train a computer
to be able to figure that out as well
well you might have clued your eye in on
particular keywords where those
particular words tend to mean something
positive or negative so you might have
identified words like loved and fun and
best tend to be associated with positive
messages and words like broke and cheap
and flimsy tend to be associated with
negative messages so if only we could
train a computer to be able to learn
what words tend to be associated with
positive versus negative messages then
maybe we could train a computer to do
this kind of sentiment analysis as well
so we're going to try to do just that
we're going to use a model known as the
bag of words model which is a model that
represents text as just an unordered
collection of words for the purpose of
this model we're not going to worry
about the sequence and The Ordering of
The Words which word came first second
or third we're just going to treat the
text as a collection of words in no
particular order and we're losing
information there right the order of
words is important and we'll come back
to that a little bit later but for now
to simplify our model it'll help us
tremendously just to think about text as
some unordered collection of words
and in particular we're going to use the
bag of words model to build something
known as a naive Bayes classifier so
what is a naive-based classifier well
it's a tool that's going to allow us to
classify text based on Bayes rule again
which you might remember from when we
talked about probability Bayes rule says
that the probability of B given a is
equal to the probability of a given B
multiplied by the probability of B
divided by the probability of a
so how are we going to use this rule to
be able to analyze text well what are we
interested in we're interested in the
probability that a message has a
positive sentiment and the probability
that a message has a negative sentiment
which I'm here for Simplicity I'm going
to represent just with these emoji happy
face and frown face as positive and
negative sentiment
and so if I had a review something like
my grandson loved it then what I'm
interested in is not just the
probability that a message has positive
sentiment but the conditional
sentiment given that this is the message
my grandson loved it
how do I go about calculating this value
the probability that the message is
positive given that the review is this
sequence of words well here's where the
bag of words model comes in rather than
treat this review as a string of a
sequence of words in order we're just
going to treat it as an unordered
collection of words we're going to try
to calculate the probability that the
review is positive given that all of
these words my grandson loved it are in
the review in no particular order just
this unordered collection of words and
this is a conditional probability which
we can then apply Bayes rule to try to
make sense of
so according to Bayes rule this
conditional probability is equal to what
it's equal to the probability that all
of these four words are in the review
given that the review is positive
multiplied by the probability that the
review is positive divided by the
probability that all of these words
happen to be in the review
so this is the value now that we're
going to try to calculate now one thing
you might notice is that the denominator
here the probability that all of these
words appear in the review doesn't
actually depend on whether or not we're
looking at the positive sentiment or
negative sentiment case so we can
actually get rid of this denominator we
don't need to calculate it we can just
say that this probability is
proportional to the numerator and then
at the end we're going to need to
normalize the probability distribution
to make sure that all of the values sum
up to the value 1. so now how do we
calculate this value well this is the
probability of all of these words given
positive times probability of positive
and that by the definition of joint
probability is just one big joint
probability the probability that all of
these things are the case that it's a
positive review and that all four of
these words are in the review
but still it's not entirely obvious how
we calculate that value and here's where
we need to make one more assumption and
this is where the naive part of naive
Bayes comes in we're going to make the
assumption that all of the words are
independent of each other and by that I
mean that if the word grandson is in the
review that doesn't change the
probability that the word Love is in the
review or that the word it is in the
review for example and in practice this
assumption might not be true it's almost
certainly the case that the probability
of words do depend on each other but
it's going to simplify our analysis and
still give us reasonably good results
just to assume that the words are
independent of each other and they only
depend on whether
it's positive or negative you might for
example expect the word loved to appear
more often in a positive review than in
a negative review
so what does that mean well if we make
this assumption then we can say that
this value the probability we're
interested in is not directly
proportional to but it's naively
proportional to this value the
probability that the review is positive
times the probability that my is in the
review given that it's positive times
the probability the grandson is in the
review given that it's positive and so
on for the other two words that happen
to be in this review and now this value
which looks a little more complex is
actually a value that we can calculate
pretty easily
so how are we going to estimate the
probability that the review is positive
well if we have some training data some
example data of example reviews where
each one has already been labeled as
positive or negative then we can
estimate the probability that a review
is positive just by counting the number
of positive samples and dividing by the
total number of samples that we have in
our training data
and for the conditional probabilities
the probability of loved given that it's
positive well that's going to be the
number of positive samples with loved in
it divided by the total number of
positive samples so let's take a look at
an actual example to see how we could
try to calculate these values here I've
put together some sample data the way to
interpret the sample data is that based
on the training data 49 of the reviews
are positive 51 are negative and then
over here in this table we have some
conditional probabilities
we have if the review is positive then
there's a 30 chance that my appears in
him and a if the review is negative
there's a 20 chance that Maya appears in
it and based on our training data among
the positive reviews one percent of them
contain the word grandson and among the
negative reviews two percent contain the
word grandson
so using this data let's try to
calculate this value the value we're
interested in and to do that
we'll need to multiply all of these
values together the probability of
positive and then all of these positive
conditional probabilities and when we do
that we get some value
and then we can do the same thing for
the negative case we're going to do the
same thing take the probability that
it's negative multiply it by all of
these conditional probabilities and
we're going to get some other value
and now these values don't sum to one
they're not a probability distribution
yet but I can normalize them and get
some values and that tells me that we're
going to predict that my grandson loved
it we think there's a 68 chance
probability 0.68 that that is a positive
sentiment review and 0.32 probability
that it's a negative review
so what problems might we run into here
what could potentially go wrong when
doing this kind of analysis in order to
analyze whether text has a positive or
negative sentiment well a couple of
problems might arise one problem might
be what if the word grandson never
appears for any of the positive reviews
if that were the case then when we try
to calculate the value the probability
that we think the review is positive
we're going to multiply all these values
together and we're just going to get 0
for the positive case because we're all
going to ultimately multiply by that
zero value and so we're going to say
that we think there's no chance that the
review is positive because it contains
the word grandson and in our training
data we've never seen the word grandson
appear in a positive sentiment message
before and that's probably not the right
analysis because in cases of rare words
it might be the case that in nowhere in
our trading data did we ever see the
word grandson appear in a message that
has positive sentiment so what can we do
to solve this problem well one thing
we'll often do is some kind of additive
smoothing where we add some value Alpha
to each value in our distribution just
to smooth out the data a little bit and
a common form of this is LaPlace
smoothing where we add one to each value
in our distribution in essence we
pretend we've seen each value one more
time than we actually have if we've
never seen the word grandson for a
positive review we pretend we've seen it
once we've seen it once we pretend we've
seen it twice just to avoid the
possibility that we might multiply by
zero and as a result and get some
results we don't want in our analysis
so let's see what this looks like in
practice let's try to do some naive
Bayes classification in order to
classify text as either positive or
negative
we'll take a look at sentiment.pi and
what this is going to do is load some
sample data into memory some examples of
positive reviews and negative reviews
and then we're going to train a naive
Bayes classifier on all of this training
data
training data that includes all of the
words we see in positive reviews and all
of the words we see in negative reviews
and then we're going to try to classify
some input
and so we're going to do this based on a
corpus of data I have some example
positive reviews here some positive
reviews it was great so much fun for
example and then some negative reviews
not worth it kind of cheap these are
some examples of negative reviews
so now let's try to run this classifier
and see how it would classify particular
text as either positive or negative
we'll go ahead and run our
sentiment analysis on this Corpus
and we need to provide it with a review
so I'll say something like I enjoyed it
and we see that the classifier says
there's about a 0.92 probability that we
think that this particular review is
positive let's try something negative
we'll try kind of overpriced and we see
that there is a 0.96 probability now
that we think that this particular
review is negative and so our naive
Bayes classifier has learned what kinds
of words tend to appear in positive
reviews and what kinds of words tend to
appear in negative reviews and as a
result of that we've been able to design
a classifier that can predict whether a
particular review is positive or
negative
and so this definitely is a useful tool
that we can use to try and make some
predictions but we had to make some
assumptions in order to get there so
what if we want to now try to build some
more sophisticated models use some tools
from machine learning to try and take
better advantage of language data to be
able to draw more accurate conclusions
and solve new kinds of tasks and new
kinds of problems well we've seen a
couple of times now that when we want to
take some data and take some input put
it in a way that the computer is going
to be able to make sense of it can be
helpful to take that data and turn it
into numbers ultimately and so what we
might want to try to do is come up with
some word representation some way to
take a word and translate its meaning
into numbers because for example if we
wanted to use a neural network to be
able to process language give our
language to a neural network and have it
make some predictions or perform some
analysis there a neural network takes as
input and produces its output a vector
of values a vector of numbers and so
what we might want to do is take our
data and somehow take words and convert
them into some kind of numeric
representation
so how might we do that how might we
take words and turn them into numbers
let's take a look at an example here's a
sentence he wrote a book and let's say I
wanted to take each of those words and
turn it into a vector of values here's
one way I might do that we'll say he is
going to be a vector that has a 1 in the
first position and the rest of the
values are zero rote will have a one in
the second position and the rest of the
values are zero a has a one in the third
position with the rest of the value 0
and book has a one in the fourth
position with the rest of the value zero
so each of these words now has a
distinct Vector representation and this
is what we often call a one hot
representation a representation of the
meaning of a word as a vector with a
single one and all of the rest of the
values are zero and so when doing this
we now have a numeric representation for
every word and we could pass in those
Vector representations into a neural
network or other models that require
some kind of numeric data as input
but this one hot representation actually
has a couple of problems and it's not
ideal for a few reasons one reason is
here we're just looking at forwards but
if you imagine a vocabulary of thousands
of words or more these vectors are going
to get quite long in order to have a
distinct Vector for every possible word
in our vocabulary and as a result of
that these longer vectors are going to
be more difficult to deal with more
difficult to train and so forth and so
that might be a problem
another problem is a little bit more
subtle if we want to represent a word as
a vector and in particular the meaning
of a word as a vector then ideally it
should be the case that words that have
similar meanings should also have
similar Vector representations so that
they're close to each other together
inside a vector space but that's not
really going to be the case with these
one-hot representations because if we
take some similar words say the word
wrote and the word authored which means
similar things they have entirely
different Vector representations
likewise book and novel those two words
mean somewhat similar things but they
have entirely different Vector
representations because they each have a
one in some different position and so
that's not ideal either so what we might
be interested in instead is some kind of
distributed representation a distributed
representation is the representation of
the meaning of a word distributed across
multiple values instead of just being
one hot with a one in one position here
is what a distributed representation of
words might be each word is associated
with some Vector of values with the
meaning distributed across multiple
values ideally in such a way that
similar words have a similar Vector
representation
how are we going to come up with those
values where do those values come from
how can we Define the meaning of a word
in this distributed sequence of numbers
well to do that we're going to draw
inspiration from a quote from British
linguist J.R Firth who said You shall
know a word by the company it keeps in
other words we're going to define the
meaning of a word based on the words
that appear around it the context words
around it take for example this context
for blank he ate you might wonder what
words could reasonably fill in that
blank
well it might be words like breakfast or
lunch or dinner all of those could
reasonably fill in that blank and so
what we're going to say is because the
words breakfast and lunch and dinner
appear in a similar context that they
must have a similar meaning and that's
something our computer could understand
and try to learn a computer could look
at a big Corpus of text look at what
words tend to appear in similar context
to each other and use that to identify
which words have a similar meaning and
should therefore appear close to each
other inside a vector space
and so one common model for doing this
is known as the word to VEC model it's a
model for generating word vectors a
vector representation for Every Word by
looking at data and looking at the
context in which a word appears the idea
is going to be this if you start out
with all of the words just in some
random position in space and train it on
some training data what the word tevec
model will do is start to learn what
words appear in similar contexts and it
will move these vectors around in such a
way that hopefully words with similar
meanings breakfast lunch and dinner book
Memoir novel
will hopefully appear to be near to each
other as vectors as well
so let's now take a look at what word to
VEC might look like in practice when
implemented in code
what I have here inside of words dot
text is a pre-trained model where each
of these words has some Vector
representation trained by word to VEC
each of these words has some sequence of
values representing its meaning
hopefully in such a way that similar
words are represented by similar vectors
I also have this file vectors dot Pi
which is going to open up the words and
form them into a dictionary and we also
Define some useful functions like
distance to get the distance between two
word vectors and closest words to find
which words are nearby in terms of
having close vectors to each other
and so let's give this a try
we'll go ahead and open a python
interpreter
and
I'm going to import these vectors
and we might say all right what is the
vector representation of the word book
and we get this big long Vector that
represents the word book as a sequence
of values and this sequence of values by
itself is not all that meaningful but it
is Meaningful in the context of
comparing it to other vectors for other
words so we could use this distance
function which is going to get us the
distance between two word vectors and we
might say what is the distance between
the vector representation for the word
book and the vector representation
for the word novel
and we see that it's 0.34 you can kind
of interpret 0 as being really close
together and one being very far apart
and so now what is the distance between
book and let's say breakfast well book
and breakfast are more different from
each other than book and novel are so I
would hopefully expect the distance to
be larger and in fact it is 0.64
approximately these two words are
further away from each other
and what about now the distance between
let's say lunch and breakfast well
that's about 0.2 those are even closer
together they have a meaning that is
closer to each other
another interesting thing we might do
is calculate the closest words we might
say what are the closest words according
to word devec to the word book and let's
say let's get the 10 closest words what
are the 10 closest vectors to the vector
representation for the word book
and when we perform that analysis we get
this list of words the closest one is
book itself but we also have books
plural and then essay Memoir essays
Novella Anthology and so on all of these
words mean something similar to the word
book according to word to VEC at least
because they have a similar Vector
representation so it seems like we've
done a pretty good job of trying to
capture this kind of vector
representation of word meaning
one other interesting side effect of
word to VEC is that it's also able to
capture something about the
relationships between words as well
let's take a look at an example here for
instance are two words man and King and
these are each represented by word to
VEC as vectors so what might happen if I
subtracted one from the other calculated
the value King minus man
well that will be the vector that will
take us from man to King somehow
represent this relationship between the
vector representation of the word man
and the vector representation of the
word King and that's what this value
King minus man represents so what would
happen if I took the vector
representation of the word woman and
added that same value King minus man to
it what would we get as the closest word
to that for example well we could try it
let's go ahead and go back to our python
interpreter and give this a try
I could say what is the closest word to
the vector representation of the word
King minus the representation of the
word man plus the representation of the
word woman
and we see that the closest word is the
word Queen we somehow been able to
capture the relationship between King
and man and then when we apply it to the
word woman we get as the result the word
Queen
so word to VEC has been able to capture
not just the words and how they're
similar to each other but also something
about the relationships between words
and how those words are connected to
each other
so now that we have this Vector
representation of words what can we now
do with it now we can represent words as
numbers and so we might try to pass
those words as input to say a neural
network neural networks we've seen are
very powerful tools for identifying
patterns and making predictions recall
that a neural network you can think of
as all of these units but really what
the neural network is doing is taking
some input passing it into the network
and then producing some output and by
providing the neural network with
training data we're able to update the
weights inside of the network so that
the neural network can do a more
accurate job of translating those inputs
into those outputs and now that we can
represent words as numbers that could be
the input or output you could imagine
passing a word in as input to a neural
network and getting a word as output and
so when might that be useful one common
use for neural networks is in machine
translation when we want to translate
text from one language into another say
translate English into French by passing
English into the neural network and
getting some French output you might
imagine for instance that we could take
the English word for lamp pass it into
the neural network get the French word
for lampeth output
but in practice When We're translating
text from one language to another we're
usually not just interested in
translating a single word from one
language to another but a sequence say a
sentence or a paragraph of words here
for example is another paragraph again
taken from Sherlock Holmes written in
English and what I might want to do is
take that entire sentence pass it into
the neural network and get as output a
French translation of the same sentence
but recall that a neural Network's input
and output needs to be of some fixed
size and a sentence is not a fixed size
it's variable you might have shorter
sentences and you might have longer
sentences so somehow we need to solve
the problem of translating a sequence
into another sequence by means of a
neural network and that's going to be
true not only for machine translation
but also for other problems problems
like question answering if I want to
pass this input a question something
like what is the capital of
Massachusetts feed that as input into
the neural network I would hope that
what I would get if output is a sentence
like the capital is Boston again
translating some sequence into some
other sequence and if you've ever had a
conversation with an AI chat bot or have
ever asked your phone a question it
needs to do something like this it needs
to understand the sequence of words that
you the human provided as input and then
the computer needs to generate some
sequence of words as output so how can
we do this well one tool that we can use
is the recurrent neural network which we
took a look at last time which is a way
for us to provide a sequence of values
to a neural network by running the
neural network multiple times and each
time we run the neural network what
we're going to do is we're going to keep
track of some hidden State and that
hidden state is going to be passed from
one run of the neural network to the
next run of the neural network keeping
track of all of the relevant information
and so let's take a look at how we can
apply that to something like this and in
particular we're going to look at an
architecture known as an encoder decoder
architecture where we're going to encode
this question into some kind of hidden
State and then use a decoder to decode
that hidden State into the output that
we're interested in
so what's that going to look like we'll
start with the first word the word what
that goes into our neural network and
it's going to produce some hidden State
this is some information about the word
what that our neural network is going to
need to keep track of
then when the second word comes along
we're going to feed it into that same
encoder neural network but it's going to
get us input that hidden State as well
so we pass in the second word we also
get the information about the hidden
State and that's going to continue for
the other words in the input this is
going to produce a new hidden State and
so then when we get to the third word
the
that goes into the encoder it also gets
access to the hidden State and then it
produces a new hidden state that gets
passed into the next run when we use the
word capital and the same thing that's
going to repeat for the other words that
appear in the input so of Massachusetts
that produces one final piece of hidden
state
now somehow we need to Signal the fact
that we're done there's nothing left in
the input and we typically do this by
passing some kind of special token say
an end token into the neural network and
now the decoding process is going to
start we're going to generate the word
the
but in addition to generating the word
this decoder network is also going to
generate some kind of hidden state
and so what happens the next time well
to generate the next word it might be
helpful to know what the first word was
so we might pass the first word the back
into the decoder Network
it's going to get an input this hidden
State and it's going to generate the
next word capital
and that's also going to generate some
hidden State and we'll repeat that
passing Capital into the network to
generate the third word is and then one
more time in order to get the fourth
word Boston and at that point we're done
but how do we know we're done usually
we'll do this one more time past Boston
into the decoder Network and get an
output some n token to indicate that
that is the end of our input and so this
then is how we could use a recurrent
neural network to take some input encode
it into some hidden State and then use
that hidden state to decode it into the
output we're interested in to visualize
it in a slightly different way we have
some input sequence this is just some
sequence of words that input sequence
goes into the encoder which in this case
is a recurrent neural network generating
these hidden States along the way until
we generate some final hidden state at
which point we start the decoding
process again using a recurrent neural
network that's going to generate the
output sequence as well so we've got the
encoder which is encoding the
information about the input sequence
into this hidden State and then the
decoder which takes that hidden State
and uses it in order to generate the
output sequence
but there are some problems and for many
years this was the state of the art the
recurrent neural network and variance on
this approach were some of the best ways
we knew in order to perform tasks in
natural language processing but there
are some problems that we might want to
try to deal with and that have been
dealt with over the years to try and
improve upon this kind of model
and one problem you might notice happens
in this encoder stage we've taken this
input sequence the sequence of words and
encoded it all into this final piece of
hidden State and that final piece of
hidden State needs to contain all of the
information from the input sequence that
we need in order to generate the output
sequence
and while that's possible it becomes
increasingly difficult as the sequence
gets larger and larger for larger and
larger input sequences it's going to
become more and more difficult to store
all of the information we need about the
input inside this single hidden State
piece of context that's a lot of
information to pack into just a single
value it might be useful for us when
generating output to not just refer to
this one value but to all of the
previous hidden values that have been
generated by the encoder and so that
might be useful but how could we do that
we've got a lot of different values we
need to combine them somehow so you
could imagine adding them together
taking the average of them for example
but doing that would assume that all of
these pieces of hidden state are equally
important but that's not necessarily
true either some of these pieces of
hidden state are going to be more
important than others depending on what
were they most closely correspond to
this piece of hidden State very closely
corresponds to the first word of the
input sequence this one very closely
corresponds to the second word of the
input sequence for example and some of
those are going to be more important
than others to make matters more
complicated depending on which word of
the output sequence we're generating
different input words might be more or
less important and so what we really
want is some way to decide for ourselves
which of the input values are worth
paying attention to at what point in
time and this is the key idea behind a
mechanism known as attention attention
is all about letting us decide which
values are important to pay attention to
when generating in this case the next
word in our sequence
so let's take a look at an example of
that here's a sentence what is the
capital of Massachusetts same sentence
as before and let's imagine that we were
trying to answer that question by
generating tokens of output so what
would the output look like well it's
going to look like something like the
capitalism and let's say we're now
trying to generate this last word here
what is that last word how is the
computer going to figure it out well
what it's going to need to do is decide
which values it's going to pay attention
to and so the attention mechanism will
allow us to calculate some attention
scores for each word some value
corresponding to each word determining
how relevant is it for us to pay
attention to that word right now
and in this case when generating the
fourth word of the output sequence the
most important words to pay attention to
might be capital and Massachusetts for
example
that those words are going to be
particularly relevant and there are a
number of different mechanisms that have
been used in order to calculate these
attention scores it could be something
as simple as a DOT product to see how
similar two vectors are or we could
train an entire neural network to
calculate these attention scores but the
key idea is that during the training
process for our neural network we're
going to learn how to calculate these
attention scores our model is going to
learn what is important to pay attention
to in order to decide what the next word
should be
so the result of all of this calculating
these attention scores is that we can
calculate some value some value for each
input word determining how important is
it for us to pay attention to that
particular value and recall that each of
these input words is also associated
with one of these hidden State context
vectors capturing information about the
sentence up to that point but primarily
focused on that word in particular
and so what we can now do is if we have
all of these vectors and we have values
representing how important is it for us
to pay attention to those particular
vectors is we can take a weighted
average we can take all of these vectors
and multiply them by their attention
scores and add them up to get some new
Vector value which is going to represent
the context from the input but
specifically paying attention to the
words that we think are most important
and once we've done that that context
Vector can be fed into our decoder in
order to say that the word should be in
this case Boston
so attention is this very powerful tool
that allows any word when we're trying
to decode it to decide which words from
the input should we pay attention to in
order to determine what's important for
generating the next word of the output
and one of the first places this was
really used was in the field of machine
translation here's an example of a
diagram from the paper that introduced
this idea which was focused on trying to
translate English sentences into French
sentences so we have an input English
sentence up along the top and then along
the left side the output French
equivalent of that same sentence and
what you see in all of these squares are
the attention scores visualized where a
lighter Square indicates a higher
attention score
and what you'll notice is that there's a
strong correspondence between the French
word and the equivalent English word
that the French word for agreement is
really paying attention to the English
word for agreement in order to decide
what French words should be generated at
that point in time and sometimes you
might pay attention to multiple words if
you look at the French word for economic
that's primarily paying attention to the
English word for economic but also
paying attention to the English word for
European in this case too
and so retention scores are very easy to
visualize to get a sense for what is our
machine learning model really paying
attention to what information is it
using in order to determine what's
important and what's not in order to
determine what the ultimate output token
should be
and so when we combine the attention
mechanism with a recurrent neural
network we can get very powerful and
useful results where we're able to
generate an output sequence by paying
attention to the input sequence too but
there are other problems with this
approach of using a recurrent neural
network as well in particular notice
that every run of the neural network
depends on the output of the previous
step and that was important for getting
a sense for the sequence of words and
the ordering of those particular words
but we can't run this unit of the neural
network until after we've calculated the
hidden state from the run before it from
the previous input token and what that
means
it's very difficult to parallelize this
process that as the input sequence get
longer and longer we might want to use
parallelism to try and speed up this
process of training the neural network
and making sense of all of this language
data but it's difficult to do that and
it's slow to do that with a recurrent
neural network because all of it needs
to be performed in sequence and that's
become an increasing challenge as we've
started to get larger and larger
language models the more language data
that we have available to us to use to
train our machine learning models the
more accurate it can be the better
representation of language it can have
the better understanding it can have and
the better results that we can see and
so we've seen this growth of large
language models that are using larger
and larger data sets but as a result
they take longer and longer to train and
so this problem that recurrent neural
networks are not easy to parallelize has
become an increasing problem and as a
result of that that was one of the main
motivations for a different architecture
for thinking about how to deal with
natural language and that's known as the
Transformer architecture and this has
been a significant milestone in the
world of natural language processing for
really increasing how well we can
perform these kinds of natural language
processing tasks as well as how quickly
we can train a machine learning model to
be able to produce effective results
there are a number of different types of
Transformers in terms of how they work
but what we're going to take a look at
here is the basic architecture for how
one might work with a Transformer to get
a sense for what's involved and what
we're doing
so let's start with the model we were
looking at before specifically at this
encoder part of our encoder decoder
architecture where we used a recurrent
neural network to take this input
sequence and capture all of this
information about the hidden State and
the information we need to know about
that input sequence right now it all
needs to happen in this linear
progression but what the Transformer is
going to allow us to do is process each
of the words independently in a way
that's easy to parallelize rather than
have each word wait for some other word
each word is going to go through this
same neural network and produce some
kind of encoded representation of that
particular input word and all of this is
going to happen in parallel now it's
happening for all of the words at once
but we're really just going to focus on
what's Happening for one word to make it
clear but know that whatever you're
seeing happen for this one word is going
to happen for all of the other input
words too
so what's going on here well we start
with some input word that input word
goes into the neural network and the
output is hopefully some encoded
representation of the input word the
information we need to know about the
input word that's going to be relevant
to us as we're generating the output and
because we're doing this each word
independently it's easy to parallelize
we don't have to wait for the previous
word before we run this word through the
neural network
but what did we lose in this process by
trying to parallelize this whole thing
well we've lost all notion of word
ordering the order of words is important
the sentence Sherlock Holmes gave the
book to Watson has a different meaning
than Watson gave the book to Sherlock
Holmes and so we want to keep track of
that information about word position in
the recurrent neural network that
happened for us automatically because we
could run each word one at a time
through the neural network get the
hidden State pass it on to the next run
of the neural network but that's not the
case here with the Transformer where
each word is being processed independent
of all of the other ones
so what are we going to do to try to
solve that problem one thing we can do
is add some kind of positional encoding
to the input word the positional
encoding is some Vector that represents
the position of the word in the sentence
this is the first word the second word
the third word and so forth we're going
to add that to the input word
and the result of that is going to be a
vector that captures multiple pieces of
information it captures the input word
itself as well as where in the sentence
it appears the result of that is we can
pass the output of that addition the
addition of the input word and the
positional encoding into the neural
network that way the neural network
knows the word and where it appears in
the sentence and can use both of those
pieces of information to determine how
best to represent the meaning of that
word in the encoded representation at
the end of it
in addition to what we have here in
addition to the positional encoding and
this feed forward neural network we're
also going to add one additional
component which is going to be a
self-attention step this is going to be
a tension where we're paying attention
to the other input words because the
meaning or interpretation of an input
word might vary depending on the other
words and the input as well and so we're
going to allow each word in the input to
decide what other words in the input it
should pay attention to in order to
decide on its encoded representation and
that's going to allow us to get a better
encoded representation for each word
because words are defined by their
context by the words around them and how
they're used in that particular context
this kind of self-attention is so
valuable in fact that oftentimes the
Transformer will use multiple different
self-attention layers at the same time
to allow for this model to be able to
pay attention to multiple facets of the
input at the same time we call this
multi-headed attention where each
attention head can pay attention to
something different and as a result this
network can learn to pay attention to
many different parts of the input for
this input word all at the same time and
in the spirit of deep learning these two
steps this multi-headed self-attention
layer and this neural network layer that
itself can be repeated multiple times
too in order to get a deeper
representation in order to learn deeper
patterns within the input text and
ultimately get a better representation
of language in order to get useful and
coded representations of all of the
input words
and so this is the process that a
Transformer might use in order to take
an input word and get it as encoded
representation and the key idea is to
really rely on this attention step in
order to get information that's useful
in order to determine how to encode that
word
and that process is going to repeat for
all of the input words that are in the
input sequence we're going to take all
of the input words and encode them with
some kind of positional encoding feed
those into the self-attention and feed
forward neural networks in order to
ultimately get these encoded
representations of the words that's the
result of the encoder we get all of
these encoded representations that will
be useful to us when it comes time then
to try to decode all of this information
into the output sequence we're
interested in and again this might take
place in the context of machine
translation where the output is going to
be the same sentence in a different
language or it might be an answer to a
question in the case of an AI chatbot
for example and so now let's take a look
at how that decoder is going to work
ultimately it's going to have a very
similar structure anytime we're trying
to generate the next output word we need
to know what the previous output word is
as well as its positional encoding where
in the output sequence are we and we're
going to have these same steps
self-attention
because we might want an output word to
be able to pay attention to other words
in that same output as well as a neural
network and that might itself repeat
multiple times
but in this decoder we're going to add
one additional step we're going to add
an additional attention step where
instead of self-attention where the
output word is going to pay attention to
other output words in this step we're
going to allow the output word
to pay attention to the encoded
representations so recall that the
encoder is taking all of the input words
and transforming them into these encoded
representations of all of the input
words but it's going to be important for
us to be able to decide which of those
encoded representations we want to pay
attention to when generating any
particular token in the output sequence
and that's what this additional
attention step is going to allow us to
do it's saying that every time we're
generating a word of the output we can
pay attention to the other words in the
output because we might want to know
what are the words we've generated
previously and we want to pay attention
to some of them to decide what word is
going to be next in the sequence
but we also care about paying attention
to the input words too and we want the
ability to decide which of these encoded
representations of the input words are
going to be relevant in order for us to
generate the next step
and so these two pieces combined
together we have this encoder that takes
all of the input words and and produces
this encoded representation and we have
this decoder that is able to take the
previous output word pay attention to
that encoded input and then generate the
next output word and this is one of the
possible architectures we could use for
a Transformer with the key idea being
these attention steps that allow words
to pay attention to each other during
the training process here we can now
much more easily parallelize this
because we don't have to wait for all of
the words to happen in sequence and we
can learn how we should perform these
attention steps the model is able to
learn what is important to pay attention
to what things do I need to pay
attention to in order to be more
accurate at predicting what the output
word is
and this has proved to be a tremendously
effective model for conversational AI
agents for building machine translation
systems and there have been many
variants proposed on this model too some
Transformers only use an encoder some
only use a decoder some use some other
combination of these different
particular features but the key ideas
ultimately remain the same this real
focus on trying to pay attention to what
is most important and the world of
natural language processing is fast
growing and fast evolving year after
year we keep coming up with new models
that allow us to do an even better job
of Performing these natural language
related tasks all on the surface of
solving the tricky problem which is our
own natural language we've seen how the
syntax and semantics of our language is
ambiguous and introduces all of these
new challenges that we need to think
about if we're going to be able to
design AI agents that are able to work
with language effectively so as we think
about where we've been in this class all
of the different types of artificial
intelligence we've considered we've
looked at artificial intelligence in a
wide variety of different forms now we
started by taking a look at search
problems where we looked at how AI can
search for Solutions play games and find
the optimal decision to make we talked
about knowledge how AI can represent
information that it knows and use that
information to generate new knowledge as
well
then we looked at what AI can do when
it's less certain when it doesn't know
things for sure and we have to represent
things in terms of probability we then
took a look at optimization problems we
saw how a lot of problems in AI can be
boiled down to trying to maximize or
minimize some function and we looked at
strategies that AI can use in order to
do that kind of maximizing and
minimizing we then looked at the world
of machine learning learning from data
in order to figure out some patterns and
identify how to perform a task by
looking at the training data that we
have available to it and one of the most
powerful tools there was the neural
network the sequence of units whose
weights can be trained in order to allow
us to really effectively go from input
to output and predict how to get there
by learning these underlying patterns
and then today we took a look at
language itself trying to understand how
can we train the computer to be able to
understand our natural language to be
able to understand syntax and semantics
make sense of and generate natural
language which introduces a number of
interesting problems too and we've
really just scratched the surface of
artificial intelligence there's so much
interesting research and interesting new
techniques and algorithms and ideas
being introduced to try to solve these
types of problems so I hope you enjoyed
it this exploration into the world of
artificial intelligence a huge thanks to
all the courses teaching staff and
production team for making the class
possible this was an introduction to
artificial intelligence with python